heute in der Viertelstunde das heißt um
12 Uhr ist sie angekündigt die große
Debatte über den kanzleret das ist ja
immer so eine generalaussprache über die
Politik der Bundesregierung da heißt es
dann wahrscheinlich Scholz gegen März
diese Debatte werden wir gleich live
übertragen jetzt meldet sich aus dem
Feyer des Deutschen Bundestages aber
schon mein Kollege er schärfer mit
Gästen er hat
bittechön Hans Werner vielen Dank ja was
lange wert wird zumindest ob es gut wird
müssen wir abwarten haben wir ja noch
ein knappes Jahr Zeit um das zu bewerten
am Freitag wird der Bundeshaushalt 2024
endgültig verabschiedet hier im
Deutschen Bundestag abgerechnet und da
hat Hans Werner schon die richtigen
Andeutungen gemacht abgerechnet mit der
Politik der Bundesregierung wird
allerdings schon heute in der schon an
ange erwenden wollte ich eigentlich
sagen Generaldebatte des Deutschen
Bundestages und wie sich das gehört zu
general Debatte haben wir zwei
Generalsekretäre eingeladen um das schon
mal vorab ein bisschen zu diskutieren
ich freue mich dass heute Mittag ist ja
ganz ungewohnt für die für uns hier um
diese Zeit bei uns sind Kevin
küert und Karsten Linnemann und beide
sind praktischerweise auch
bundestagsabgeordnet den sonst würde das
ganze ja hier gar nicht klappen bevor
wir über die Generaldebatte reden
vielleicht einen ganz kurzen Blick noch
mal zurück auf die Gedenkstunde die wir
hier erlebt haben was war ihr
Eindruck das sind für mich als die
dritte Gedenkstunde hier gewesen und das
sind wahnsinnig ergreifende Momente dass
wir das Privileg haben Überlebenden der
choan überhaupt noch persönlich zuhören
zu dürfen in einer so empathischen und
zugewandten von Optimismus und ja und
Wärme geprägten Rede das empfinde ich
als ein großes Privileg allen die es
nicht gehört haben sei es nahgelegt sich
das danach noch mal anzuhören her
linemann was muss die Konsequenz sein
für politische Kommunikation für
politische Kultur wenn man eine solche
Veranstaltung erlebt hat
parteiübergreifend hart durchgreifen ich
meine ich für mich unfassbar dass die
Menschen nicht mehr Hebräisch auf der
Straße sprechen dass Kind dass Eltern
ihre Kinder nicht zur Schule schicken
aus Angst Studenten nicht mehr in die in
die Uni gehen Holocaust man mal hier mit
Polizeiketten abgesichert wird dass die
Kipper öffentlich nicht mehr getragen
wird ist unfassbar dass wir beide das
jetzt wieder erleben müssen und da
müssen wir parteiübergreifend hart und
konsequent gegen an da kommen wir noch
drauf wir gucken jetzt mal ein bisschen
auf den Haushalt ähm die Unzufriedenheit
mit dem Bundeskanzler die
Unzufriedenheit mit der Bundesregierung
ist auf quasi Rekordniveau ähm die
Vorsitzende einer noch recht jungen
Partei hat keine Hemmungen die
Bundesregierung als dümmste und
schlechteste Europas zu bezeichnen wie
wollen Sie mit diesem Haushalt zumindest
aus dem bewertungstief wieder rauskommen
na was uns gelungen ist mit diesem
Haushalt ist trotz einer schwierigen
Haushaltslage die erstmal unabhängig von
der Regierungskonstellation vorligt
trotzdem Schwerpunkte zu setzen
Schwerpunkte für mehr Investitionen bei
bezahlbaren wohnen beispielsweise für
mehr
Arbeitsmarktintegration von
Langzeiterwerbslosen aber auch von
Menschen die zu uns geflüchtet sind
Ukrainer beispielsweise glaube das sind
einige Themen schon mal an den man sehen
kann da richtet sich der Haushalt mit
seiner Schwerpunktsetzung an Themen die
allgemein im Land besprochen werden und
die auch allgemein für Unsicherheit und
Verärgerung tatsächlich sorgen wir haben
es auch geschafft wichtige Investitionen
Zukunftstechnologien
Halbleitertechnologie
batteriezellenproduktion und anderes
mehr erhalten zu können trotz und das
ist ja der Elefant im Raum trotz des
schwierigen Verfassungsgerichtsurteils
was wir im Herbst bekommen haben das ist
das dmokles Schwert was über den ganzen
Beratungen hing und auch für so viel
Ärger innen wie außen geführt hat Kevin
Könner verweist Herr Lindemann auf die
äußeren Umstände die bei diesem Haushalt
eine große Rolle gespielt haben sie die
Union ist was die Kritik an der
Bundesregierung angeht gar nicht so weit
weg in Teilen zumindest nicht wie Frau
Wagenknecht ich zitiere mal navigiert
planlos ziellos und die Menschen haben
das Gefühl schlecht regiert zu werden
das ist ja relativ ähnlich äh
wenn sie woll wenn sie könnten wie sie
wollten was würden sie akut anders
machen ja ich glaube die Menschen warten
jetzt einfach auch auf eine große Rede
des Bundeskanzlers wo es hingeht mit
Deutschland dieses klein klein glaube
ich führt dazu dass es keine
Planungssicherheit in Deutschland gibt
und das ist das Hauptproblem was mein
sie mit klein klein ja dass man jetzt
hier versucht den Haushalt irgendwie zu
retten und hier eine Schraube dreht und
da ist alles legitim alles richtig nur
die Menschen wissen nicht mehr das groß
Z ganze wo will dieses Land hin
eigentlich braucht es jetzt eine große
Rede des Bundeskanzlers fünf Punkte zehn
Punkte das sind die Punkte wo wir den
nächsten Jahren hin wollen und genau das
fehlt und das schafft eben nicht
Planungssicherheit sondern
planungsverlust aus der Fraktion aus der
Fraktion aus ihrer Fraktion Herr küit
war ja dieser Tage auch durchaus zu
vernehmen dass da mehr vom Bundeskanzler
erwartet wird was erwarten sie denn
persönlich von ihm heute in der
Aussprache die übrigens von Friedrich
Merz eröffnet werden wird das heiß der
Bundeskanzler kann dann auch darauf
reagieren das wird er auch tun es wird
eine Reaktion auch sein es wird ein
politisches Gespräch so wie es sich im
Plenum auch gehört über die
Fragen der Zeit sein was ich mir erwarte
und das ist auch in den letzten Wochen
noch mal deutlich geworden m ist nicht
dass die Bundesregierung oder der
Bundeskanzler so tut als könnte er wie
ein absoluter Herrscher einfach alles so
machen wie einzelne sich das wünschen
aber sehr wohl muss das Erklären von
politischen Prozessen warum so ein
Urteil wie das in Karlsruhe dann zu
Einsparung führt und warum man hier und
nicht dort spart das muss deutlich
besser vermittelt werden das was im
Dezember entstanden ist beispielhaft bei
den Landwirten im Land hatte ja nur zum
Teil mit den konkreten Sparvorschlägen
zu tun es hatte aber ganz viel damit zu
tun das ganze Bevölkerungsgruppen den
Eindruck gewonnen haben nicht gesehen zu
werden in ihren Bedürfnissen und ihrer
Lebenswirklichkeit ich glaube wir alle
in der Politik jeder wird ja irgendwann
auch mal wieder Verantwortung tragen tun
gut da drin das sehr ernst zu nehmen und
da empathischer vorzugehen als das zum
Teil der Fall war sie kriegen gleich
auch zwei Fragen hintereinander aber ich
muss an der Stelle einfach noch einfach
noch mal nachfragen die die
Bertelsmannstiftung hat ja vor einiger
Zeit schon festgestellt was tatsächlich
diese Koalition zustande gebracht hat im
Hinblick auf das was sie vor hatte warum
bringen sie das nach wie vor nicht wie
man beim Sport so schön sagt auf dem
Platz es sind neue Herausforderungen
dazu gekommen ich kann jetzt auch das
ich tu es ihnen nicht an aber ich könnte
jetzt natürlich tausend Sachen aufzählen
die wir durchgebracht haben wo wir uns
vi ist das vielleicht nicht insgesamt
der der der Fehler oder das Defizit dass
sie haben irgendwie bei der Darstellung
der Politik dass sie es halt vielleicht
doch nicht oft genug sagen oder auch der
Kanzler nicht oft genug
sagt was alle Umfragen uns deutlich
sagen und ja auch das der gesunde
Menschenverstand und wenn man Gespräche
in seinem in seinem Wahlkreis fühlt ist
ist ein Grauschleier der Ungewissheit
über der Gesellschaft der ist jetzt
nicht durch irgendeine Regierung
exklusiv gekommen sondern es sind
Veränderungsprozesse die auf uns
einwirken die lassen Menschen
verunsichert auf ihren Arbeitsplatz auf
ihr Wohnumfeld auf die internationale
Lage gucken und das kann man so richtig
solche Entscheidungen sind durch 12 €
Mindestlohn durch Ausweitung beim
Wohngeld oder anderes mehr nicht
ungeschehen machen und ich glaube
tatsächlich dass daher die Art wie wir
Politik erklären und wie wir miteinander
umgehen Regierung und Opposition aber
auch innerhalb der Regierungskoalition
dass das ganz entscheidend dafür ist ob
wieder ein Gefühl von Sicherheit stärker
im Land einkehrt oder ob das ausbleibt
wie denken Sie Herr lindann dass die
Bevölkerung wieder zufriedener wäre wenn
die
der Spitze einer
regierungstüe was würden Sie tun konkret
also schauen sich gleich die Rede an von
friedich Merz die wird etwas anders sein
will jetzt nicht zu viel vorwegnehmen
damit die
spanungin wird große größere Rede sein
und ein größerer Rahmen wird gesetzt
und ich sag mal wenn mehr als 50% der
Menschen in Deutschland sagen sie trauen
der Politik keine kometenz mehr zu dann
haben wir offenkundig alle ein Problem
und deswegen habe ich auch ein Interesse
daran dass es besser läuft und dass die
Demokratie nicht unter die Räder kommt
nicht die Institution da habe ich keine
Sorge vor das ist stark in Deutschland
aber dieser Abstand zwischen den
gewählten und den wählan und der muss
kleiner werden und dafür braucht es
einfach Halt und Orientierung und das
wird hoffentlich Friedrich Merz auch
heute geben es braucht einen Plan für
Deutschland und der Kanzler finde ich
hat keinen Plan und Friedrich Merz hat
einen Plan und dem wird er heute unter
anderem vorstellen aber auch in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten und darauf
konzentrieren wir uns jetzt wir
konzentrieren uns auf uns nicht nur
sagen was die Regierung falsch macht
sondern wir müssen als Union sagen was
wir besser machen und das ist jetzt die
marschrute das ist gut dass sie das
sagen denn der große Rahmen ist ja das
eine sagen Sie doch mal konkret was sie
tatsächlich anders machen würden in
dieser Situation jetzt also in dieser
auch weltpolitischen innenpolitischen
energiepolitischen etc und alles was
dazu
gehört also ich ich finde wir brauchen
einen zehn punktepl für Deutschland
einen Kanzler der sichellt ja ich würde
würde natürlich anfangen mit dem Thema
Sicherheit das ist das was uns alle
betrifft das Stichwort NATO auch
international das Deutschland dort eine
stärkere Rolle spielt auch Europa ich
würde weitermachen über das Thema
Migration dass wir verstanden haben dass
wir am Limit sind und dass wir einen
Kurswechsel brauchen und nur noch in
Drittstaaten Schutz geben und auch das
Verfahren durchführen und gleichzeitig
Kontingente schaffen damit nur noch
diejenigen kommen die wirklich Humanität
von uns benötigen ich würde drittens
dafür sorgen dass ich Leistung in diesem
Lande wieder lohnt ich würde die
Überstunde bei Vollzeit Steuer
freistellen ich würde viertens Fördern
und Fordern wieder einführen das
Bürgergeld in der Form abschaffen und
diejenigen die Unterstützung brauchen
weil sie nicht arbeiten können
vielleicht noch mehr geben als heute
alle anderen müssen arbeiten und ich
würde fünftens das gesellschaftsjahr
Einführen das würde diesem Lande gut tun
dass junge Menschen ob ähm im sozialen
Bereich ob bei der Bundeswehr oder im
Ausland ihren Dienst tun damit sich
milieös wieder treffen und der
Zusammenhalt in Deutschland gesichert
ist und die anderen fünf wenn die Sie
wahrscheinlich auch noch haben bespre
ich weiß ist mir ist mir schon ist mir
schon klar Herr küner hat an einem Tag
für heute wir haben gerade auch über die
Gedenkstunde hier gesprochen an einem
Tag wie heute sagt und weil Herr
Lindemann das Thema Migration
angesprochen hat an einem Tag wie heute
sagt ihr Parteivorsitzender noch mal es
müsste viel mehr abgeschoben werden als
das bislang der Fall gewesen ist ist das
an einem Tag wie heute schlau ich habe
diese interviewpassage nachdem ich erst
die tickermeldung wie wir es ja häufig
in unserem Alltag der Fall ist gelesen
habe habe ich die interviewpassage von
Lars klingber gelesen und hat einfach
etwas ausgesprochen was wir seit Wochen
und Monaten genauso sagen nämlich dass
zu einer konsequenten Migrationspolitik
nach der es ja gefragt wurden sowohl die
Durchsetzung von Recht im Bereich der
ausreisen dazu gehört wie auch die
Integration und das klare Bekenntnis zu
Deutschland als
Einwanderungsgesellschaft dass wir Fach
und Arbeitskräfte im Land brauchen dass
man Menschen die hier gut integriert
sind auch Perspektiven für diese
Integration aufzeigen muss dass der Pass
auch mit dazuehört wer hier lebt wer
hier arbeitet wer hier Kinder in die
Welt setzt wer hier Steuern zahlt der
soll auch mit allem was dazu gehört dazu
gehören können hatten wir ja kürzlich
hier im Bundestag sehr unterschiedliche
Auffassungen zu also insofern fand ich
das eine völlig angemessene Aussage die
viel unspektakulärer war als das was
kolportiert wird vielleicht ist der
Zeitpunkt einfach nur ein bisschen
sage ich mal unglücklich Herr man die
fünf Punkte die sie schon erwähnt haben
und die anderen fünf die sie noch nicht
erwähnt haben die wir wahrscheinlich
heute auch gar nicht schaffen die
erfordern Geld
es muss also in den Staatshaushalt was
rein
es gibt im Moment eine veritable
Diskussion über die Schuldenregel ob sie
so bleibt wie sie ist da sind sie sehr
dafür die FDP auch es gibt aber ein
Schreiben von mehr als 50 Unternehmern
die gesagt haben das ganze muss wie sie
sagen weiterentwickelt werden und jetzt
melden sich auch die Wirtschaftsweisen
und sagen es gebe viele Möglichkeiten
über die Schuldenregel noch mal
nachzudenken um Wohlstand zu sichern um
sich Sicherheit der Bevölkerung auch im
Grunde zu sichern damit die sich sicher
fühlt was Jobs angeht was Klimaschutz
angeht und viele andere Dinge was kommen
sie da nicht ins Grübeln nein nehmen mal
an wir lockern die Schulden Bremse so
dann werden neue staatliche Programme
wieder gemacht der Staat versucht hier
Geld zu geben hier was zu regulieren wir
sehen doch bei der wir sehen doch bei
der bei der Energiewende dass es so
nicht funktioniert Nummer ein Beispiel
dieses heizungsgesetz hat sehr viel
Unsicherheit gebracht in Deutschland
sehr teuer was ist es Jahr passiert herr
Schäfer wir haben noch nie so viele
Ölheizung und Gasheizung installiert und
verkauft wie im letzten Jahr wie seit
langem nicht mehr das ist doch nicht die
richtige Politik wir müssen den Rahmen
setzen als Politik damit es Freiheit
gibt für Unternehmen und für Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und gleichzeitig müssen wir
mit dem Geld vernünftig umgehen und
nicht immer versuchen neue Schulden zu
machen und Steuern zu erhöhen das ist
die Position der CDU aber über das
heizungsgesetz können wir könen wir ein
eigenes Gespräch sicher eine Menge Meng
aus dem Ruder
aber mE FRB das nicht denken wen
Wirtschaftsweise die n wirklich was
verstehen von demch und von dem Thema
wenn auch Unternehmen die eigentlich
Union und FDP tendentiell und
traditionell näher stehen Ihnen als der
SPD dass die sagen ihr müsst da was
machen ihr müsst da was ändern sonst
haben wir kriegen wir mittelfristig ein
riesen Problemem also die
wirtschaftsweiseen wollen ja die
Schuldenbremse nicht aufheben sie wollen
sie auch nicht bitte aber die anderen ja
auch nicht sondern es geht ja um
Veränderung es geht um
Lockerung 20 Milliarden machen in diesem
Jahr noch mehr an Schulden trotz
Schuldenbremse lasass uns doch mal über
Wachstum reden über über Zukunft und ich
bin mir sicher wenn ich diesen
Unternehmen sage die Politik hält sich
mal ein halbes Jahr zurück oder ein Jahr
mit bürokratiegesetzen und so weiter ist
denind das viel lieber als wenn wir
jetzt sagen wir nehmen wieder Geld für
irgendwelche Projekte ja aber Ken das
Leben ist ja am Ende dann doch immer
konkret und wir beschließen heute einen
Haushalt zu dem ihr sowohl vor dem
Karlsruher Urteil als auch danach in den
Bereinigungssitzung keine erungs Anträge
eingebracht hab nur ein paar
maßgabebeschlüsse ich habe aber von euch
in den Debatten hab da genau zugehört
auch gestern ganz viele Forderungen
gehört wo auch ihr findet trotz
Bekenntnis zur Schuldenbremse wie sie
ist dass mehr ausgegeben werden muss 10
Milliarden mehr für die Bundeswehr
standen zwischenzeitlich in Rede ihr
hättet wie übrigens wir auch gerne das
mehrwertsteuerprivileg bei der
Gastronomie sind glaube ich 3ieinhalb
Milliarden aufrecht erhalten gestern ist
beklagt worden dass nicht mehr in die
Forschung reingesteckt werden kann und
so weiter und so fort wenn dann aber
keine Gegenfinanzierung Vorschläge jetzt
im realen Haushalt nicht irgendwo in D
Jahren sondern jetzt im realen Haushalt
kommen dann frage ich mich ob ihr
vielleicht einfach noch nicht an dem
Punkt wieder seid stfähig zu sein für
Regierungsverantwortung weil so habe ich
das immer verstanden die führende
Oppositionsfraktion muss sich in der
Haushaltsdebatte so verhalten dass sie
morgen übernehmen könnte aber so habt
ihr euch hier gerade nicht aufgestellt
nein deswegen haben wir uns auch bei den
Änderungsanträgen zurückgehalten
übrigens gilt das auch für unser
Wahlprogramm das ist schon ein Punkt
dass wir jetzt nicht das Blaue vom
Himmel versprechen und sagen wir machen
beispielsweise jetzt noch eine dritte
mütterrente sondern dass wir uns da auch
selbst selbstdisziplinieren und sagen
wir haben einfach nicht mehr so viel
Geld für so viele Projekte und
gleichzeitig sollten wir aber auch mal
darüber nachdenken was wir machen damit
dieses Land mal wieder wächst wenn wir
im Durchschnitt so wachsen würden wie
die Europäische Union derzeit wächst h
wir pro Jahr 20 bis 30 Milliarden mehr
und jetzt müssen wir leider aufhören
obwohl wir natürlich locker noch
weitermachen könnten wissen wir von uns
allen drei natürlich ziemlich gut vielen
Dank dass Sie da gewesen sind heute
Mittag Kevin Kön schönen dan Karsten
Lindemann vielen Dank sie dürfen direkt
verschwinden
denn es geht in dieser Sekunde auch los
wir gucken in den Plenarsaal schon mal
rein Bundestagspräsidentin berbel B ist
auch schon da wird sicherlich ein
bisschen was zum Prozedere der nächsten
Tage hier sagen und dann die Sitzung
eröffnet und dann ge dir re und Kollegen
ich wünsche Ihnen einen wunderschönen
Tag die Sitzung ist
eröffnet
bevor wir beginnen begrüße ich zwei neue
Kolleginnen und einen Kollegen in
unserer Mitte für den ausgeschiedenen
Abgeordneten Armin Schwarz hat die
Kollegen Bettina Margarete Wiesmann die
Mitgliedschaft im deutschen Bundestag
erworben herzlich
willkommen für den ausgeschiedenen
Abgeordneten kW mansuri rückt der
Kollege Martin Rabanus nach herzlich
willkommen und für den ausgeschiedenen
abgeordnet Timon gremmels hat die
Kollegin Nadin Ruf die Mitgliedschaft im
deutschen Bundestag erworben herzlich
willkommen ich komme nun zur
Tagesordnung interfraktionell wurde
vereinbart am Freitag im Anschluss an
die Haushaltsberatungen die
Beschlussempfehlungen des ältesten Rates
zur Anerkennung und Rechtsstellung der
Gruppe die Linke und der Gruppe BSW
sowie einen Antrag zu den
Mitgliederzahlen in den Ausschüssen in
verbundener Beratung aufzusetzen ich
sehe dazu keinen Widerspruch dann können
wir so verfahren wir setzen nun die
Haushaltsberatung fort ich rufe auf den
Einzelplan 04 Bundeskanzler und
Bundeskanzleramt mit den
Beschlussempfehlungen des
Haushaltsausschusses auf Drucksachen
8604 und
8661 Berichterstattung haben die
Abgeordneten Otto Fricke Dennis Rode
Kerstin Radomski Andreas audretsch
Markus Bühl und dr Gesine lösch Sowi den
Einzelplan 22 unabhängiger Kontrollrat
mit den Beschlussempfehlung des
Haushaltsausschusses auf den Drucksachen
8661 und
8662 Berichterstattung haben die
Abgeordneten Franziska hoppermann Martin
Gerster Sven Christian Kindler Torsten
Herbst Wolfgang wiele und dr gesene
Lötsch wir werden später über den
Einzelplan 04 namentlich abstimmen für
die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von 210
Minuten vereinbart ich eröffne die
Aussprache und zuerst hat das Wort für
die CDU CSU Fraktion Friedrich
März
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es fällt
einigermaßen schwer nach dieser
Gedenkstunde heute morgen jetzt ganz
einfach zur Tagesordnung
überzugehen vielleicht darf ich damit
beginnen dass ich Ihnen Frau Präsidentin
aber auch unseren beiden Gästen die
heute morgen hier gesprochen haben Eva
cepesi und Marcel Reif noch einmal sehr
herzlich Dank sage für die bewegenden
Worte die sie gesprochen
haben und ich möchte ein weiteres Wort
des Dankes hinzufügen am Montag der
letzten Woche hat der französische
Staatspräsident Emmanuel
von dieser Stelle aus und zu Ehren
unseres verstorbenen Kollegen Wolfgang
Schäuble eine ich finde das darf man
auch heute noch einmal sagen eine
wirklich große Rede gehalten
Emmanuel macron hat uns Deutschen erneut
die Hand sehr weit ausgestreckt er hat
uns in seiner Rede geradezu
aufgefordert zusammen mit seinem Land
zusammen mit Frankreich
Führungsverantwortung in und für
Europa zu übernehmen und ein Blick auf
die aktuelle Lage in der Welt ein Blick
auf die Krisen und die Kriege mit denen
wir nun auch in das Jahr 2024
hineingehen zeigt uns Deutschland sollte
ja Deutschland muss diese ausgestreckte
Hand des französischen Staatspräsidenten
jetzt
ergreifen Deutschland muss gemeinsam mit
Frankreich neue Initiativen erarbeiten
um die Handlungsfähigkeit Europas unter
Beweis zu stellen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich möchte uns daran erinnern
dass die letzte große deutsche
Initiative für Europa aus dem Jahre 9
stammt also heute schon mehr als 35
Jahre alt ist im Zuge der
Wiedervereinigung unseres Landes legte
der damalige Außenminister Hans Diedrich
Genscher abgestimmt mit Frankreich ein
währungspolitisches Memorandum vor aus
dem dann gut 10 Jahre später die
Währungsunion
wurde die letzte große
industriepolitische Initiative für
Europa die aus Deutschland kam liegt
mittlerweile fast 60 Jahre
zurück es war im Jahr
1965 die Gründung der
Arbeitsgemeinschaft Airbus so hieß sie
damals zwischen Deutschland aus Frank
und Frankreich aus der dann wie wir alle
wissen der größte europäische Luft und
raumfahrtkonzern
wurde ich nenne diese Beispiel weil sie
zeigen die Zeit ist mehr als reif für
Vorschläge in ähnlicher Dimension und
mit vergleichbarer
Tragweite Vorschläge die vor allem von
Deutschland und Frankreich
auf den Weg gebracht werden
müssen und erlauben Sie mir dass ich
hinzufüge das wären auch Vorschläge die
uns Europäer vorbereiten auf einen
möglichen Wechsel im Weißen Haus in
Washington ich will zwei sehr konkrete
Beispiele nennen was früher die
Währungspolitik war muss heute im
Interesse Europas die Außen und die
Sicherheitspolitik sein Deutschland und
Frankreich müssen enger zusammenarbeiten
und auf dem Weg hin zu einer gemeinsamen
europäischen Verteidigungspolitik so
früh wie möglich andere Mitgliedstaaten
der Europäischen Union mit einbeziehen
nach dem Regierungswechsel in Polen vor
allem die neue polnische Regierung diese
gemeinsame Verteidigungspolitik meine
Damen und Herren muss von Anfang an die
Rüstungspolitik die Beschaffung und die
militärische Unterstützung der Ukraine
beinhalten
und was früher was früher die Luft und
Raumfahrtindustrie war müssen heute die
Unternehmen der digitalwirtschaft der
Telekommunikation und die Banken sein
Deutschland und Frankreich sollten so
bald wie möglich Verabredungen darüber
treffen wie denn in diesen und anderen
Sektoren wirklich
europäische weltweit wettbewerbsfähige
Unternehmen entstehen
könnten dazu muss das europäische
Kartellrecht geändert werden denn der
sogenannte relevante Markt für diese
Unternehmen ist längst nicht mehr allein
Europa oder schon gar nicht der einzelne
mitgliedstad stat sondern der globale
Markt auf dem europäische Unternehmen
wettbewerbsfähig sein müssen meine Damen
und Herren zu allen diesen strategischen
Fragen zu dieser strategischen
Neuausrichtung Europas sollte das Format
des weimara Dreiecks wiederbelebt werden
am besten mit einer sehr bald
ausgesprochenen Einladung der deutschen
Bundesregierung nach Weimar um von dort
D aus den Weg hin zu einer gemeinsamen
europäischen außen und
Sicherheitspolitik und auch hin zu einer
gemeinsamen europäischen
Industriepolitik zu
beschreiten
Deutschland Deutschland sollte diese
Aufgabe ein aus einer Position der
Stärke und der Verantwortung zugleich
übernehmen voraussetzung dafür ist dass
Deutschland seine Wachstumsschwäche
überwindet
diese Wachstumsschwäche meine Damen und
Herren hat ganz überwiegend strukturelle
Gründe und hängt zusammen mit
Standortbedingungen die in mehrfacher
Hinsicht unzureichend sind ich will es
auf einen ganz einfachen Nenner bringen
die Arbeitskosten in Deutschland sind zu
hoch die Bürokratielasten werden immer
drückender die Energieversorgung ist zu
einseitig auf Wind und Sonne
ausgerichtet und die Steuerlast der
Unternehmen ist im internationalen
Vergleich ebenfalls zu hoch
Spielräume Spielräume in den
öffentlichen Haushalten lassen sich
erzielen wenn Sozialleistungen unseres
Landes auf die konzentriert werden die
sie wirklich brauchen wenn die
Lohnzusatzkosten wieder bei 40%
gedeckelt werden und wenn die gesamte
Last der Transformation hin zur
Klimaneutralität unserer Volkswirtschaft
nicht allein über Subventionen aus den
staatlichen Haushalten finanziert
wird lassen Sie mich das etwas konkreter
machen wir sollten in Zukunft in der
Sozialpolitik wieder stärker
unterscheiden zwischen
beitragsfinanzierten
Lohnersatzleistungen und
steuerfinanzierten
Sozialleistungen
Lohnersatzleistungen für die die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
Beiträge gezahlt haben dienen der
Überbrückung einer begrenzten Zeit der
Arbeitslosigkeit bei gleichzeitigem
Erhalt des
Lebensstandards steuerfinanzierte
Sozialleistungen dienen der Gewährung
des Existenzminimums und eines Minimums
einer sozialen Teilhabe und nur wenn
zwischen Arbeitseinkommen und
Sozialleistungen ein hinreichend großer
Abstand besteht wird die
Leistungsbereitschaft der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer auch
hinreichend belohnt meine Damen und
Herren
deshalb deshalb ist das System
Bürgergeld das genaue Gegenteil von dem
was wir jetzt brauchen um diese
Leistungsbereitschaft unsere
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
wieder zu
fördern und meine Damen und Herren
dieser Befund wird durch empirische
Erhebungen bestätigt
wenn die Sozialpolitik so schreibt
Renate Köcher in der letzten Woche in
ihrer monatlichen Erhebung wenn die
Sozialpolitik zu einer Annäherung von
unterstützungs und Erwerbseinkommen
führt verliert sie an Vertrauen und
Unterstützung und zwar besonders in der
Mittelschicht und in den schwächeren
sozialen Schichten meine Damen und
Herren gerade von der
Sozialdemokratischen Partei Deutschlands
sie waren sie waren einmal die Partei
der Arbeiter und Arbeit der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer sie
sind heute eine Partei der
subventionierten Arbeitslosigkeit
geworden und nicht mehr eine Partei der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer wir sehen in unserem Land
die gleichen Fehlsteuerungen in einer
Energie und Klimapolitik die vor allem
auf umfangreiche Förderprogramme und auf
staatliche Subventionen S
der Weg hin zu einer klimaneutralen
Volkswirtschaft und zu der dafür
benötigten Infrastruktur lässt sich
nicht allein über öffentliche Haushalte
beschreiten dieses
Land unser Land meine Damen und Herren
braucht mutige aber realistische Ziele
unser Land wird den Wettbewerb auf der
Welt nur gewinnen wenn wir aufhören alle
anderen zu belehren und immer wieder
einen Sonderweg zu suchen
wir
brauchen wir brauchen
Wirkungsmechanismen über den Preis wie
mit der Bepreisung des
schadstoffausschusses und wir brauchen
in erheblichem Umfang wir brauchen in
erheblichem Umfang privates Kapital für
den Ausbau der Infrastruktur
insbesondere des benötigten
Leitungsnetzes und meine Damen und
Herren das alles ob sie das nun wollen
oder nicht geht nicht ohne einen ja die
Zwischenrufe
zeigen ja dass ich sie genau an der
Stelle erreiche wo Sie einfach die
größte Schwäche haben in ihrer gesamten
Argumentation meine Damen und Herren das
alles was ich hier gerade beschreibe
geht nicht ohne einen tieferen und einen
breiteren europäischen Kapitalmarkt und
auch dazu wird Frankreich zusammen mit
uns und anderen ohne Zweifel bereit sein
nun werden sie und ich höre es an ihren
Zwischenrufen spätestens an dieser
Stelle fragen was diese Themen denn mit
ihrer Koalition und ihrem heute hier zur
Abstimmung gestellten Bundeshaushalt zu
tun haben ich will Ihnen die Antwort
geben gar nichts gar nichts sie haben
gar nichts damit zu tun wir sind wir
sind nämlich meine Damen und
Herren wir sind nämlich in allen
wesentlichen Fragen der außen und
Sicherheitspolitik der Wirtschafts- und
Finanzpolitik der Arbeitsmarktpolitik
der innen und Rechtspolitik und nicht
zuletzt der Asyl und
Einwanderungspolitik vollkommen anderer
Meinung als sie und zwar nicht im Grund
nicht im Detail sondern im Grundsatz im
Grundsätzlichen und das ist ganz
einfach das ist ganz einfach der Grund
dafür dass wir darauf verzichtet haben
in den Haushaltsberatungen irgendwelche
Änderungsanträge zu stellen ja meine
Damen und Herren wir wissen doch wie das
geht wir stellen die Anträge sie lehnen
alle Anträge ab sie addieren die Summen
unserer Anträge und halten uns dann hier
im Deutschen Bundestag im Plenum vor wir
hätten noch höhere Ausgaben
vorgeschlagen das ist doch genau der
Wirkungsmechanismus den wir von ihnen
immer wieder hören wenn sie so nicht
verstehen dann will ich es ihnen etwas
salopper sagen wenn sie nein meine Damen
und Herren wenn Sie die Jacke unten
falsch einknöpfen dann diskutieren wir
nicht mit ihnen wie groß denn der Knopf
oben im letzten Loch sein sollte diese
Diskussion führen wir mit ihnen nicht
ganz einfach im
übrigen im
übrigen wir haben wir haben in den
letzten zwei Jahren immer wieder und so
gut wie in jeder Sitzungswoche unsere
Vorstellungen und unsere
Änderungsanträge hier im Deutschen
Bundestag eingebracht sie haben bis zum
heutigen Tag
ausnahmslos alle samt abgelehnt damit
hier kein Missverständnis entsteht das
ist ihr gutes Recht sie haben die
Mehrheit aber bitte ersparen sie sich
und uns doch in Zukunft ihre Aufrufe zur
Zusammenarbeit diese Aufrufe sind nichts
anderes als reine politische retorik
sparen Sie sich und uns die
Zeit und wenn sie es noch etwas genauer
haben wollen da wo wir Sie bitten wie in
der vorletzten Woche geschehen doch
einmal inneten und die ihre
Entscheidungen noch einmal zu
überdenken machen sie von ihrer Mehrheit
hier im Haus
kalschneuzig und rücksichtslos gebraucht
wie z.B beim Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht
oder wie wieder in dieser Woche beim
Wahlrecht meine Damen und Herren und den
deutschlandpakt Migration den haben wir
nicht gekündigt den haben sie
aufgekündigt die
Erfahrungen die Erfahrungen der letzten
zwei
Jahre zeigen dass sie an einer
wirklichen Zusammenarbeit bis mit uns
nicht wirklich und ernsthaft
interessiert sind im Gegenteil da wo wir
Ihnen wie beim Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr zugestimmt haben halten Sie
sich anschließend nicht an die mit ihnen
verabredeten
Vereinbarungen und
deshalb und deshalb meine Damen und
Herren sind wir auch sehr zurückhaltend
sehr zurückhaltend wenn es um weitere
Änderungen des Grundgesetzes geht ich
stelle Ihnen eine Zustimmung dazu heute
grundsätzlich nicht in Aussicht und ich
schließe eine Zustimmung meiner Fraktion
zu einer Aufweichung der Schuldenbremse
des Grundgesetzes heute von dieser
Stelle aus hier erneut aus damit können
sie nicht
rechnen
wir sagen stattdessen unserer
Bevölkerung die Aufgaben vor denen wir
stehen lassen sich lösen auch ohne
zusätzliche Abgaben und ohne neue
Schuld dazu müssen allerdings die
Prioritäten der Staatsausgaben neu
geordnet werden und meine Damen und
Herren ja ich tue das von dieser Stelle
aus noch vor der Sicherung unseres
Wohlstandes muss die Bewahrung unserer
Freiheit gegen alle Angriffe von innen
und von außen die absolute Priorität
haben nur in Freiheit lässt sich der
Friede sichern nur in Freiheit wird die
Ukraine überleben und nur in Freiheit
kommt auch der Staat Israel hoffentlich
eines Tages wieder zur Ruhe
Freiheit Freiheit und vor allem
Meinungsfreiheit und
Religionsfreiheit sind die für den
inneren Frieden in unserem Land dafür
gehen die Menschen in diesen Wochen in
vielen hundert Städten zu Tausenden in
Deutschland auf die Straße vor allem um
gegen Rechtsradikalismus und
Rechtspopulismus zu demonstrieren ja das
sie dabei nervös werden kann ich gut
verstehen wir begrüßen das ausdrücklich
wir begrüßen das
ausdrücklich denn das Treffen der AFD
und anderer Rechtsextremisten in der
Villa Adlon in potzdamm hat offenbar
doch einer größeren Zahl von Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern über den wahren Charakter
dieser Partei und ihrer Funktionäre die
Augen geöffnet meine Damen und
Herren das
erstarten das Erstarken und das
Anwachsen des Rechtsradikalismus in
Deutschland besorgt uns wie viele andere
hier im Haus und im Land insgesamt
wirklich sehr aber wir sollten weniger
Zeit mit Abscheu und Empörung verbringen
als vielmhr nach den tieferen Gründen zu
suchen warum wir in der Lage sind denn
meine Damen und Herren die Wählerinnen
und Wähler der AFD sind nicht alle
rechtsradikal aber sie sind alle
ziemlich
frustriert machen wir ein kurzes
Gedankenspiel stellen wir uns doch mal
einen kurzen Augenblick vor wir hätten
in Deutschland eine Regierung die
wenigstens die Ansprüche sind gar nicht
so hoch mittelmäßig gut regieren würde
und die im und die im langjährigen
Mittel in unserer Bevölkerung halbwegs
angesehen und respektiert wäde kann sich
irgendjemand hier im Haus vorstellen
dass die AFD unter solchen Umständen
innerhalb von 2 Jahren von 10 auf 20% in
Deutschland angewchst wachsen wäre meine
Damen und Herren das glauben vermutlich
doch noch nicht einmal sie von den
ampelfraktion die
Lösung
die Lösung des Problems besteht also
offensichtlich darin dass sie die dass
sie die Probleme unseres Landes lösen
dafür sind sie gewählt und dafür sitzen
sie in der Regierung meine Damen und
Herren aber von einer Lösung der
Probleme in Deutschland sind sie zu
Beginn des Jahres
2024 noch weiter entfernt als zum Ende
des Jahres 2023 vor allem sie kommen die
sie bekommen die flüchtlingskrise nicht
in den Griff die
Umsetzung die Umsetzung der Beschlüsse
mit den Ministerpräsidenten verläuft Z
und träge ich gebe ihn ein Beispiel
z.bpiel bei der Einführung der
Bezahlkarte meine Damen und Herren die
vor allem die vor allem an dem
systematischen Widerstand von SPD und
Grünen in Deutschland scheiter da wo sie
da wo
sie
da wo sie eingeführt wurde nämlich in
einigen Landkreisen auf Initiative der
dortigen Landräte singt die Zahl der
Asylbewerber über Nacht weil einer der
wesentlichen
aufenthaltsgründe nämlich der Bezug von
Bargeld plötzlich nicht mehr möglich ist
meine Damen und Herren so könnte es in
ganz Deutschland gehen wenn sie sich an
die Verabredungen halten würden die sie
mit dem
Ministerpräsidenten des ganzen Landes
mit allen
Ministerpräsidenten geschlossen haben
lassen Sie mich in diesem Zusammenhang
zur Klarstellung aber für unsere
Bundestagsfraktion und auch für die sie
beiden tragenden Parteien hier noch
einmal folgendes und sehr
unmissverständlich sagen mit uns gibt es
keine Rückkehr zum Nationalismus in
Europa die Europäische Union hat ihre
Stärken und ihre Schwächen aber sie ist
vor allem die Grundlage für Freiheit
Frieden und Wohlstand auf unserem
Kontinent gerade in Deutschland wir
werden nicht zulassen dass diese
Grundlage zerstört wird meine Damen und
Herren
und wir stehen wir stehen zur
transatlantischen wir stehen zur
transatlantischen Partnerschaft Putins
Russland ist kein Partner für uns
sondern der Feind auch unserer Freiheit
keiner politischen Gruppierung keiner
politischen Gruppierung die diese
fundamentalen Überzeugungen in Frage
gestellt werden wir unsere Hand reichen
an diesen Überzeugungen endet jeder
Kompromiss meine Damen und Herren und
ein letztes Wort zu Ihnen meine Damen
und Herren von der sogenannten
Alternative für Deutschland sie haben in
den letzten Tagen und Wochen ihr wahres
Gesicht gezeigt sie machen gezielt und
seit langer Zeit geplant gemeinsame
Sache mit mit Rechtsextremisten jedweder
Herkunft ihre Netzwerke umfassen ihre
netzwer umfassen identitäre Bewegungen
genauso wie sogenannte Reichsbürger
sogenannte Reichsbürger meine Damen und
Herren Fremdenfeindlichkeit
Antisemitismus und Nationalismus gehen
bei ihnen Hand in Hand ebenso wie enge
Beziehungen zur Russland und ein tief
sitzender antiamerikanischer Komplex
unsere Botschaft an sie die sie da
drüben ganz rechts sitzen ist klar und
eindeutig genug ist genug sie sind sie
sind sie sind nicht die sie sind nicht
die Alternative für Deutschland sie
wären der endgültige Abstieg für
Deutschland und zwar gar nicht mal nur
wirtschaftlich sondern vor allem
moralisch und diesem abstieb meine Damen
und Herren werden wir uns mit aller
Kraft die uns zur Verfügung stellt
entgegenstellen das Spiel bei ihnen geht
jetzt zu Ende herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Friedrich März der Vorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion im Deutschen Bundestag
Parteivorsitzender der CDU am Ende mit
ein mit Worten die ja in die Reihen der
AFD gerichtet hat und davor noch mal mit
einem starken Bekenntnis zu Europa und
mit dem Thema Europa und insbesondere
mit den deutschfanzös
mit der deutschfranzösischen
Zusammenarbeit hat er seine Rede ja auch
begonnen bevor er dann sehr ausführlich
sich beschäftigt hat mit der
wirtschaftlichen Lage in Deutschland und
welche Mittel und Maßnahmen aus Sicht
der Union jetzt nötig werden und er hat
im Grunde auch die vorübergehende
Zusammenarbeit mit der Koalition relativ
deutlich aufgekündigt und jetzt sind wir
gespannt was der Bundeskanzler dazu
sagt fr Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren Kollegen eva schppessi hat es uns
eben gesagt wer schweigt macht sich
mitschuldig die
Gedenkveranstaltung sie hat uns alle
nachdrücklich
beeindruckt aber sie hat uns auch einen
Auftrag mitgegeben dass wir jetzt nicht
schweigen wenn in diesem Land
Konferenzen stattfinden in Landhäuser wo
darüber beraten wird wie ein Teil der
Bevölkerung aus diesem Land
herausgebracht werden kann Remigration
als Stichwort das erinnert an die
dunkelsten Zeiten der deutschen
Geschichte und das ist nicht nur ein
Wort wie dann einige verharenlosen
versuchen sich das zurechtzulegen was
dort von ihnen selber diskutiert und
gesagt wird und von ihren Mitarbeit dann
mit geplant wird wir wissen dass es in
Landtagen jetzt von der AFD beantragt
wird und deshalb bin ich sehr froh
darüber dass so viele Bürgerin und
Bürger über alle Parteigrenzen hinweg
auch solche die sich überhaupt nicht
parteipolitisch verordnen gemeinsam in
Deutschlands Straßen zusammenkommen in
Kundgebung und für die Demokratie für
unser Grundgesetz und gegen das
Vergessen
demonstrieren
und das ist mir an dieser Stelle auch
ganz wichtig weil mir immer wieder und
viel zu oft jetzt bürgerinen und Bürger
unseres Landes Staatsangehörige Frauen
und Männer die seit Jahrzehnten hier
leben die ihren Kinder hier groß
geworden sind erzählen dass sie Angst
haben ob sie gemeint sind ob sie jetzt
das Land verlassen müssen und deshalb
finde ich braucht es an dieser Stelle
auch ein ganz klares Bekenntnis von uns
allen
wir stehen vor diesen Bürgern und
Bürgern sie müssen sich nicht fürchten
die Demokratie beschützt uns wie Eva es
heute gesagt
hat ich glaube dass es deshalb auch
wichtig ist dass wir anständig sind im
Umgang miteinander und dass
wir lachen sie el
Anstand ist ja jetzt nicht das
kernkompetenzanliegen der
AFD sondern es geht doch darum dass wir
auch dann klar machen worum es hier geht
um rechtsextreme Ansichten die wir nicht
akzeptieren können und deshalb finde ich
es immer immer Herr märz ein kleines ko
wenn in dieser Situation dann jeweils
auf den anderen gezeigt wird was die
Verantwortung dafür betrifft wir müssen
als Demokraten
zusammenstehen und es
wird und es wird der großen
Herausforderung nicht gerecht die wir
sehen wenn der rechte Populismus in den
USA so viel Unterstützung bekommt wenn
wir gesehen haben dass er Großbritannien
in ein ökonomisches Unglück gestürzt hat
mit dem brexit und wenn wir sehr klar
sehen dass so viele Regierungen in
Europa von Rechtspopulisten getragen
wden werden dass sie manchmal dabei sind
wir haben in Deutschland eine Aufgabe
für unserer Geschichte wir wollen als
Demokratin und Demokraten zeigen dass
wir diesen Trend stoppen und zwar
gemeinsam und es ist ja alles gesagt das
finde ich gehört doch zur Wahrheit dazu
es ist alles gesagt man soll alle
wörtlich nehmen auch die AFD sie meint
was man ihr unterstellt und zwar das
Schlimme und das ist glaube ich wirklich
die Wahrheit mit der wir uns
auseinandersetzen müssen plötzlich fällt
so ein Wort wie dexit und das ist die
größte
wohlstandsvernichtung die für Europa und
für Deutschland passieren könnte unser
Land hat wie kein anderes profitiert von
der Europäischen Union und der
Zusammenarbeit
dort deshalb Herr märz kann ich ihn
versichern
Emmanuel macron und ich sind verabredet
sehr sorgfältig
sehr sehr sorgfältig wie wir im
Einzelnen reagieren auf die möglichen
politischen Entwicklung die in der Welt
auf uns zukommen und auch für alle muss
klar sein wenn die Welt noch schwieriger
wird auch z.B durch das was an Wahlen in
den USA Ergebnis als W Ergebnis
dann muss die Europäische Union umso
stärker werden und Frankreich und
Deutschland müssen diese Aufgabe
wahrnehmen dass das auch tatsächlich
möglich
wird und natürlich zählt dazu dass wir
immer im Blick haben dass Europa das
stärkste nationale Interesse ist d wir
haben und das hat dann viele viele
Konsequenzen aber zu denen zählt auch
dass es manchmal nicht gut ist die
Politik eine Zeit lang nicht so
sorgfältig verfolgt zu haben wenn immer
die Beispiele wo es irgendwie noch was
war sehr sehr lange zurückliegen aber
ich finde das ist doch eine gute
Zusammenarbeit war die ich auch mit Frau
Merkel hatte als wir mit der
französischen Regierung gemeinsam dafür
gesorgt haben dass es möglich ist auf
die coronakrise zu reagieren mit einem
europäischen wiederaufbaufond die letzte
große europäische ini
nicht zurü nur ihre Beteiligung an
diesen politischen geschehissen die
liegt lange zurück und ich finde man
muss dann auch einmal stolz sein auf das
was eine eigene Regierungschefin
zustande gebracht hat es war richtig was
wir dort gemacht haben herrz vergessen
Sie es nicht reden sie nicht drüber
hinweg es war eine CDU Kanzlerin mit der
mir das gemeinsam
gelung sind wir dabei all das
aufzuarbeiten was in diesem Land liegen
geblieben ist und es ist sehr viel
liegen geblieben über viele Jahre über
sehr sehr sehr viele Jahre sind die
entscheidenden Weichen nicht gestellt
worden damit Deutschland eine
industrielle Zukunft haben kann und
deshalb deshalb Herr
MZ war ihre Frage berechtigt was hat
eigentlich diese Rede von ihnen mit dem
gegenwtig der gegenwtigen Lage zu tun
nichts da haben sie
recht aber die Frage muss man
erweitern was hat eigentlich ihr
politisches Programm mit der Zukunft
Deutschlands zu tun nichts das ist die
Antwort die wir darauf geen
müssen und nachdem sie
wirklich im Untergrundkampf und intensiv
dafür gesorgt haben dass ist keinen
Ausbau der Netze in deuts gibt nachdem
sie als CDU CSU Verantwortung dafür
haben dass der Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energie nicht vorangekommen ist nachdem
sie nichts geschafft haben für die
Erschaffung einer wasserstoffindustrie
und Struktur für Deutschland nachdem sie
es nicht hingekriegt haben dass
Investitionen in der Stahlindustrie in
der
Halbleiterindustrie in den
batteriefabriken in Deutschland
stattfinden finden alle diese Dinge
jetzt statt zi Jahre haben Tempo gemacht
wo Tempo notwendig war
und wenn
wir und wenn wir genau hingehört haben
bei dem was Sie gesagt haben dann haben
sie ja gar nichts gelernt all die
Wachstumsbremsen die sie für Deutschland
gezogen haben die wollen sie
wiederziehen haben sie hier angekündigt
wie kann man so die Zukunft Deutschlands
verspielen wollen wie sie das
ökonomischer Sachverstand Null das ist
die Wahrheit keine Perspektive für
Deutschland keine industrielle
Perspektive keine Perspektive für die
Arbeitsplätze und ich will ihn gerne
ergänzen sie reden damit das so klappt
an all dem vorbei was an Wirklichkeit
über Deutschland zu berichten ist und zu
dieser Wirklichkeit gehört in der Tat
dass wir zu kämpfen haben mit weltweiter
Wachstumsschwäche zu kämpfen haben mit
den Wachstumsbremsen der Vergangenheit
die wir gelöst haben dass wir aber auch
verzeichnen können Deutschland hat den
höchsten Beschäftigungsstand in der
Geschichte den wir jemals verzeichnet
haben noch nie waren so viele
Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitnehmer
erwerbstätig und wenn
sich wenn sich die Unternehmen in diesem
Lande vor etwas fürchten dann ist es
nicht wie vor 20 Jahren Arbeitslosigkeit
sondern dann ist es
arbeitskräfteangel das ist die
Herausforderung der Zukunft und diese
Regierung hat die Weichen dafür gestellt
dass wir etwas dagegen tun können mit
dem Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz und
mit dem neuen
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht all das ist
eine Perspektive für die Zukunft
Deutschlands
und darum haben wir dafür gesorgt dass
sich Arbeit in Deutschland endlich
wieder
lohnt mit dem Mindestlohn mit einem
Mindestlohn den sie immer wieder
bekämpfen weil wenn sie dafür reden dass
Arbeit sich lohnenl meinen sie 10 20 30
40% unserer Arbeitsbevölkerung die viel
zu wenig verdien nie mit wir brauchen
bessere Löhne und der Mindestlohn war
genau der Weg das auf einen guten Kurs
zu
bringen
und das gleiche Geld für die Frage der
Einkommensverhältnisse derjenigen die
wenig verdienen wir haben das gemacht
mit den Dingen die wir als Erleichterung
für diejenigen die etwas weniger als
2000 € verdienen gemacht haben bei den
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen mit dem
Wohngeld für Erwerbstätige und für
Rentnerinnen und Rentner mit der
Kindergelderhöhung und dem
Kinderzuschlag lauter Maßnahmen die das
Einkommen von Erwerbstätigen die leider
zu geringe Löhne haben verbessert wir
sind stolz auf diese gemeinsame
Leistung und wir haben auch das gehört
dazu mehrfach Steuern gesenkt für
Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitnehmer für
Erwerbstätige die selbstständig sind und
nicht so große Einkommen haben wir haben
Steuern gesenkt und die arbeitende Mitte
dieses Landes entlastet und ich sage ihn
hier diesen Kurs werden wir auch weiter
verfolgen
es ist aber gegen die
Zukunftsperspektive der Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer gegen diejenigen die jeden
Tag sich anstrengen wenn man ihnen dann
mitteilt das allerwichtigste was wir in
Deutschland machen wollen trotz stabiler
rentenfinanzen die wir gegenwärtig
verzeichnen können ist die Anhebung des
Renteneintrittsalters ergänzt noch durch
schöne laute reden über den Freizeitpark
Deutschland den wir angeblich bei der
großen Beschäftigungszahl die wir heute
haben ich finde diese Verunsicherung der
Lebensperspektive von Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmern die sie dort verbreiten
ist nicht in Ordnung und ich finde dass
es eine Beleidigung ist von fleißigen
Bürgern und Bürgern wenn man sagt sie
würden in einem Freizeitpark leben das
ist nicht in
Ordnung die altväterliche beschimpmpfung
von Arbeitnehmern und Arbeitnehmern die
ihren Alltag zu organisieren wollen mit
alle müssen mal mehr arbeiten sie
arbeiten ganz schön viel und ich finde
solche Belehrung haben sich die
fleißigen dieses Landes auch vom
Oppositionsführer nicht
verdient meine Damen und
Herren natürlich natürlich ist es
wichtig dass wir uns den Herausforderung
stellen die wir haben und eine davon ist
dass es angesprochen worden die
irreguläre
Migration und da haben
wir sehr viele sehr weitreichende
Entscheidung getroffen übrigens im
größten Einvernehmen mit den 16 Ländern
dreimal haben wir uns mit ihnen
getroffen im letzten Jahr und haben alle
Fragen abgearbeitet und dreimal
gemeinsame Beschlüsse gefasst ein
endgültiger Finanzierungsmechanismus für
aufsteigende und absteigende zahlen wir
haben ganz konkrete Maßnahmen vereinbart
die der Bund machen muss und er hat sie
alle mit den Gesetzen die wir jetzt in
diesem Januar beschlossen haben
geliefert und auf den Weg gebracht und
wir arbeiten daran dass es auch den
Ländern gelingt die Dinge voranzubringen
die sie übernommen haben kürzere
Asylverfahren schnellere Digitalisierung
der Ausländerbehörden und so weiter aber
wenn es dann so ist das ganz ohne ihr
Zutun die Länder mit dem Bund
vereinbaren dass wir eine Bezahlkarte
für
Asylbewerber einführen wenn jetzt die
Ausschreibung läuft und der
oppositionsförer liest offenbar nicht
mal Zeitung und kann daraus berichten
dass das der Fall ist und links auf dem
Weg dann ist irgendwas nicht richtig im
Lande der
Opposition ganz
offenbar lesen Sie nicht nur wenig
Zeitung sondern reden auch nicht mit den
CDU Ministerpräsidenten die hätten ih
das so beim Bier mal nebenbei sagen
können das wäre eine gute Sache gewesen
übrigens mit dem intensivierten Schutz
unserer
Außengrenzen mit dem Dingen die wir auf
den Weg gebracht haben gehen die Zahlen
jetzt auch zurück was die irreguläre
Migration betrifft und die Maßnahmen
über die ich eben geredet habe die sind
ja alle jetzt erst beschlossen werden
gerade gesetzt die kommen ja zu dem noch
dazu was jetzt auch in der Realität in
nächster Zeit wirken wird und dazu zählt
aus meiner Sicht übrigens auch der
jobtbo mit dem wir dafür Sorge tragen
dass die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge
nachdem sie die ganzen Sprachkurse
gemacht haben jetzt auch aktiv in den
Arbeitsmarkt vermittelt werden mit
wachsendem Erfolg und ich finde übrigens
auch dort ist es kein Beitrag zur
Solidarität mit der Ukraine wenn der
Oppositionsführer den hier Schutz
suchenden Ukrainerinnen und Ukrain
mitteilt dass wir ihn so entg ekommen
sind war wohl ein Fehler das haben sie
gemacht Herr mer das haben sie
gemacht aber ich will gerne einen Satz
hinzufügen ich habe ja bei dem einen
großen Thema ich will gleich noch drauf
kommen Tempo Tempo in Deutschland
versucht ein deutschlandpakt zustande zu
bringen und sie dazu zu bringen
mitzumachen was sie irgendwie nicht
richtig hingekriegt haben aber aber es
ist so dass sie dann sicher auf ein
Teilthema kurzzeitig konzentriert hatten
Migration und wir hatten darüber auch
gute Gespräche jedenfalls erinnere ich
mich an keins davon schlecht wir hatten
eins das war sehr
sorgfältig und in diesem Gespräch in
diesem Gespräch habe ich ihn erläutert
dass es schon quasi über viele Fragen
die ganz wichtig sind eine Verständigung
gibt mit den Chefs der Senats und
staatskanzlein und dass wir am folgenden
Montag wir trafen uns Freitag das wohl
mit den Minister Präsidentin und
Ministerpräsidenten vereinbaren werden
sie hatten überhaupt nichts dagegen
einzuwenden weil wir nämlich gesagt
haben darüber hinaus können wir ja noch
was machen und was erlebt die erstaunte
Öffentlichkeit kaum ist diese Einigung
mit den Ministerpräsidenten
beschlossen erklärt der erklärt der
Oppositionsführer ja dann war es das
wohl mit der Zusammenarbeit in der
Migration so eine hasenfüßigkeit vor der
eigenen anfordung davon laufen das habe
ich noch nicht erlebt Herr März so viel
feikeit vor der eigenen Courage habe ich
noch nie gesehen ich rel bis heute warum
sie davon gelaufen sind und ich glaube
es lag daran dass sie das schöne Thema
nicht loswerden wollten wir können alles
geliefert haben alles kann ordentlich
gemacht sein wir kriegen das in den
Griff gemeinsam mit den Ländern und den
Kommunen in Deutschland was die
irreguläre Migration und ihr managigment
betrifft aber dann können sie ja nicht
mehr sagen alles läuft schief und darum
sind sie weggelaufen das ist der Grund
warum sie für ein Kompromiss nicht mehr
weiter zur Verfügung stehen
überhaupt sind sie da ein ganz
besonderer Teilen jeden Tag gegen die
Bundesregierung aus ist ihr recht
ordentlich schwer unter die Gürtellinie
ist auch ihr Recht aber wenn sie dann
mal kritisiert werden dann sind sie eine
Mimose ich finde wer ein W Bo der soll
kein glaskin haben aber sie haben ein
ganz schönes Gastkind
Herr meine Damen und
Herren wir haben eine große wir haben
eine große Herausforderung angesichts
des russischen angriffskriegs auf die
Ukraine und der wird ja jetzt auch heute
Abend Brüssel nach den
trauerfeiligkeiten für Jacques delore
und morgen eine große Rolle spielen wir
müssen die Ukraine unterstützen in ihrem
Freiheitskampf um den es in der Tat geht
und es ist notwendig dass wir mit der
Unterstützung der Ukraine nicht
nachlassen das ist unsere Verpflichtung
für den Frieden in Europa und für die
Sicherheit in
Europa esst was die Ukrainer Ukrainer
geleistet haben vergessen wir nicht wie
viel von ihrem Territorium von Russland
schon erobert war und wie viel sie auch
wieder zurückerobert haben vergessen wir
nicht mit welcher beharlichkeit Sie sich
den unglaublichen Ansturm russischer
Truppen wo der russische Präsident den
Verlust eigener Soldaten nicht scheut in
größeren Ordnung die man kaum
auszusprechen mag und wo er nicht scheut
Material einzusetzen und alles zerstören
zu lassen um das Ziel das er hat
tatsächlich zu erreichen nämlich ein
Teil oder die ganze Ukraine zu erobern
und er hat damit das in Frage gestellt
was Willi Brand und Helmut Schmidt auf
den Weg gebracht haben mit KSZE und
heutiger OSZE mit der friedens- und
sicherheitsordnung in Europa die lautet
mit Gewalt dürfen keine Grenzen in
Europa mehr verschoben werden das muss
unser Prinzip
sein
in der ganzen Welt hat sich
rumgesprochen bald auch in Deutschland
wir sind der größte Unterstützer nach
den USA für die Ukraine auch was
militärische Unterstützung mit Waffen
betrifft und wir sind es mit dem
Haushalt über den wir hier beraten und
den plän für dieses Jahr auch in Europa
nach allem was wir wissen können ist es
mehr als die Hälfte was aus Deutschland
geleistet werden wird in diesem Jahr für
diesen wieder stand der Ukraine und
deshalb sage ich hier an dieser Stelle
ist es mir ganz wichtig dass wir eine
breitere europäische Unterstützung
hinbekommen es kann nicht alleine an
Deutschland hängen um noch einmal Helmut
Schmidt zu zitieren wir sind nur eine
Mittelmacht und wenn wir diejenigen
wären die das überwiegend machen müssen
dann ist es nicht genug für die Ukraine
wir wollen dass mehr Länder sich aktiv
beteiligen an der Unterstützung der
Ukraine
auch mit dem was sie dort
finanzieren ich sage das bewusst
nicht um andere
vorzuführen deshalb haben wir das auch
nicht getan dass wir da einzelne
öffentlich angesprochen haben weil wir
wollen ja das Gegenteil wir wollen ja
dass alle sagen okay wir strengen uns
noch einmal an und das hoffe ich wird
auch das Ergebnis der Beratung sein die
wir
heute und morgen beginnen aber
sicherlich in dieser Frage nicht
abschließen werden nur das will ich hier
gerne versichern wir werden unseren
großen Beitrag für dieses Jahr leisten
und wir werden alles dafür tun dass der
gemeinsame Beitrag Europas so groß ist
dass die Ukraine darauf bauen kann und
dass Putin nicht darauf rechnen kann
dass unsere Unterstützung irgendwann
nachlässt das darfer nicht
denken
ja ja es ist so derer hofft auf die
amerikanischen
Präsidentschaftswahlen der hofft auf das
ermüden in
Europa und wir wissen wie schwierig das
ist wenn wir in die USA gucken es wird
ist immer noch nicht gelungen dass der
amerikanische Präsident eine Zustimmung
im Kongress für seine Haushaltsmittel
bekommen hat die er für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine dieses Jahr
benötigt ich bin ganz zuversichtlich
dass er das schaffen
wird und wir werden alle unseren Beitrag
leisten mitzuhelfen zu überzeugen dass
das eine gemeinsame Sache für uns die
Freunde der Freiheit der Demokratie und
des Rechtsstaats ist die Ukraine nicht
alleine zu lassen aber man stelle sich
einmal kurz vor das gelingt nicht und
dann wäre Deutschland stand jetzt der
größte Unterstützer was Waffenlieferung
betrifft für die Ukraine weltweit
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde das ist
etwas wo wir international alles dafür
tun müssen dass dieser Zustand nicht
eintritt denn es wäre Hybris wenn wir
glaubten dass wir alleine es richten
können so ist es nicht wir brauchen
Gemeinsamkeit und
Solidarität übrigens gilt das auch für
die anderen Beschlüsse die jetzt in
Europa notwendig sind über den
europäischen Haushalt den wir jetzt
endlich beschließen wollen und in dem
ist ja auch eine Haushaltshilfe für die
Ukraine von 12 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr
für die nächsten Jahre vorgesehen es
geht also um sehr viel Unterstützung die
notwendig ist es geht um ein
zusammenstehen Europas in diesen Zeiten
und das will ich dann auch zum Schluss
im Hinblick auf unser gemeinsames Europa
sagen ja wir brauchen eine gemeinsame
Anstrengung dass Europa vorankommt und
wie ich es vielleicht für den einen oder
anderen überraschend unbedingt auf einem
SPD Parteitag gesagt
habe
wir brauchen die Banken und
kapitalmarktunion damit das vorangeht
und deshalb müssen wir ausd dem was wir
schon geschafft haben eine weitere
Initiative entfalten die
Mindestbesteuerung die wir in Europa
etabliert haben könnte doch auch der
Maßstab sein für eine einheitliche
gemeinsame
körperschaftsbasis
basiskörperschaftssteuer damit die
Banken europaweit unter fairen
Bedingungen Wettbewerb machen können das
wäre ein echter Fortschritt für Europa
und wir brauchen ihn dringend wir
brauchen ihn dringend denn tatsächlich
ist ein Teil des besseren
Wirtschaftswachstums der USA
zurückzuführen auf ihre Banken und
Kapitalmärkte die mehr in der Lage sind
das Wachstum der Wirtschaft ohne
öffentliche Subventionen zu begleiten
und groß zu investieren in Startups und
wachsende Unternehmen manchmal welche
die jahrelang trotz Milliarden Bewertung
keine Gewinne machen das ist etwas was
in Europa in gleicher Weise nicht
vorkommt und deshalb ist es unsere
gemeinsame Aufgabe dass wir diesen
dieses Hindernis für Wachstum und
Wohlstand in Europa beseitigen und die
Tatsache dass es dieses Jahr so viel um
Europa gehen muss die ist vielleicht ein
Anlass an diesem und allen anderen not
notwendigen Reform für ein starkes
souveränes Europa in einer
globalisierten Welt zu arbeiten schönen
Dank Sicherheit und Wohlstand
nur in der EU einigermaßen garantiert
sind aber auch an diesem Punkt Europa
eine klare Abgrenzung zu Friedrich Merz
seitens des Bundeskanzlers es habe mit
der damaligen bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat
er gesagt mehr europapolitische
Initiativen gegeben als die die März
aufgelistet habe ansonsten
erwartungsgemäß eine ganz andere Bilanz
als die des Oppositionsführers in der
Wirtschafts in der Arbeitsmarkt aber
auch in der
Migrationspolitik wo er unter anderem
auf Entscheidung gemeinsame Beschlüsse
mit den Ländern verwiesen hat und das
ganze so vorgetragen wie es zuletzt die
eigene Fraktion des Bundeskanzlers sehr
deutlich gefordert hatte nämlich
angriffslustig und leidenschaftlich
nächste Rednerin Alis Weidel aus der
AFD sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter her Bundeskanzler sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die beiden Vorredner
haben eindrucksvoll gezeigt dass es
ihnen an Ernsthaftigkeit für die wahren
Belange und Probleme der Bürger in
diesem Lande
fehlt
es
brennt es brennt in Deutschland und
diese Regierung aus überforderten
Fehlbesetzung und starsinnigen Ideologen
ist der
Brandstifter die geschundenen
Leistungsträger dieses Landes gehen auf
die
Straße Bauern Handwerker Mittelständler
Gastwirte Händler
Transportunternehmer sie protestieren
weiter weil sie nicht mehr können
verschwiegen von den
Medien dreiviertel der deutschen stehen
hinter den mittelstandsprotesten
dreiviertel wünschen sich ein Ende
dieser
Regierung sie ziehen eine Schneise der
Verwüstung durch dieses
Land aber statt zu korrigieren setzen
Sie sich an die
Spitze sposen der Kinderbuchautor sitzt
da Frau
esken setzen Sie sich an die Spitze
einer beispiellosen Verleumdungskampagne
wie gerade hier eindrucksvoll
geschildert gegen die
mittelstandsproteste und gegen die
Oppositionskraft auf die immer mehr
Bürger ihre Hoffnung setzen frei nach
dem Motto wird der Bürger unangenehm
bezeichne ihn als
rechtsextrem
ihre
hilfsstasi
Korrektiv eine der vielen
Nichtregierungsorganisation die von
ihrer Regierung mit reichlich Steuergeld
versorgt wird hat ihn dafür die Vorlage
geliefert mit unglaublichen Lügen
Verleumdung und übelster
Nachrede und die Chefin von
Korrektiv lügt vor sich hin sie hätte
das Wort Deportation nie benutzt soweit
ist es schon gekommen steuerfinanzierte
denonzination gegen eine
konkurrenzpartei sie schämen sich nicht
einmal sie schäme sich nicht einmal das
Demonstrationsrecht zu pervertieren ein
Freiheitsrecht der Bürger gegenüber dem
Staat und nicht umgekehrt statt den
Menschen zuzuhören die ihren not in die
Öffentlichkeit tragen demonstrier sie
selbst gegen die Opposition und sie
finden auch nichts dabei wenn auf
solchen Demos ganz offen
Mordaufrufe gegen Oppositionspolitiker
zur Schau gestellt werden
afdler töten steht dort und sie
klatschen
Beifall der
Bundespräsident bezeichnet AFD Wähler
als Ratten und die FDP
Spitzenkandidatin AFD Wähler als
Schmeißfliegen schämen sie sich schämen
sie sich in Grund und
Boden mit ihrer unsäglichen
steuerfinanzierten verleäumdungs und
rufmordkampagnen Spalten Sie dieses Land
und nur um sich an ihre eigene Macht zu
klammern die Reparatur der
Reparatur eines missglückten und
aufgeblähten Haushaltsentwurfs ist ein
Dokument ihrer Arroganz und ihres
Unvermögens sie reden vom Sparen aber
sie bürden die Lasten allein den Bürgern
auf die Stimmung bei den Unternehmen ist
am Boden die Ampel ist das größte
standortrisiko für
Deutschland mittelständische Unternehmen
werfen reihenweise das Handtuch und
ergreifen die Flucht die Liste der
Firmen die ztaus Stellen streichen oder
ins Ausland ver wir täglich länger
klangvolle Namen sind darauf von BSF
Bayer und Bosch über kontinental
Mercedes und Miele bis SAP und ZF
deindustrialisierungsminister habbeck
der bekanntlich Vaterlandsliebe steh zum
kotzenfand fordert die Unternehmen nun
zum Patriotismus auf Pleite zu gehen das
ist das Konzept dieser
Bundesregierung Deutschland steckt tief
in einer Rezession als einziges
Industrie Land schrumpft es und dafür
trägt weder Putin die Verantwortung noch
die Welt noch irgendeine
herbeifantasierte
weltklimakatastrophe diese unfähige
Regierung trägt als einzige die
Verantwortung für das Disaster in
unserem
Land und zwar mit ihrer zerstörerischen
Politik der künstlichen
Energieverknappung und
energieverteuerung des unablässigen
Drehens an steuerschrauben der
Verbotspolitik der Enteignung der
Geldverschwendung während sie den Leuten
das Mär vom reichen Land erzählen reich
ist in Deutschland nur der überfütterte
übergriffige Staat aber nicht der
Steuerzahler
hunderttausende Deutsche erhalten in
diesen Tagen ihre
Heizkostenabrechnung und Wissen of nicht
wie sie sie bezahlen sollen
Normalverdiener Rentner Familien
Mittelständler Freiberufler müssen sich
Jahr für Jahr mehr einschränken um noch
über die Runden zu kommen sie selbst
aber denken gar nicht daran sich
einzuschränken sie gönnen sich neue
Hubschrauber und Fuhrparks ihre
Kabinettsmitglieder geben Unsummen für
Friseure und Fotografen aus die
Außenministerin fliegt mit großem Tross
in peinliche Missionen weltweit während
der
Durchschnittsverdiener nicht weiß was er
sich überhaupt noch leisten kann und sie
halten an ihrem
protzkanzleramt für fast sage umschreibe
800 Millionen Euro fest der
gigantomanische sbau kostet allein fast
so viel wie das jährliche Sonderopfer
was sie den Bauern abverlangen wollen
sie haben den
Beamtenapparat in nur Z Jahren um rund
11500 Stellen aufgebläht schön für ihre
Günstlinge schlecht für die Steuerzahler
den der ganze Spaß 8 Milliarden Euro
kostet wo andere Regierung ihr
internationales Engagement überdenken
und zurückfahren dräen sie sich überall
auf mit dem deutschen Steuergeld die
eigenen Bauern bedrohen sie in der
Existenz um eine knappe Milliarde zu
sparen aber für unsinnige agrarprojekte
in der Welt geben sie weiter hunderte
Millionen Euro aus die vielzitierten
Radwege in Peru sind nur eines von
hunderten überflüssigen
Entwicklungshilfe Vorhaben die in der
Summe den Steuerzahler 33 Milliarden EUR
kosten für nichts nur für ihre NGO
Günstlinge Sie verpulbern dieses Geld
ohne Gegenleistung für
ökokühlschränke in Kolumbien
feministische Außenpolitik in Südafrika
für die Taliban in Afghanistan und für
Hamas Terroristen im Gaza selbst nach
Indien gehen Milliarden obwohl Indien
zum Mond fliegt während bei uns die
Infrastruktur zerfällt die Schulen
vergammeln und die Schüler teilweise
nicht mehr richtig lesen Schrei und Reen
könen gegen die Gesetze der Physik und
der Logik treiben sie das
planwirtschafts und subventionsmonster
Energiewende weiter voran in der
Energiepolitik ist Deutschland der
Geisterfahrer der Welt die Kosten
sprengen alle Dimension sie sind der
Hauptgrund für die
Haushaltskrise sie summieren sich auf
fast eine Billion Euro se ein mit wie
viel Nullen Herr habbeck wissen Sie
nicht das sind keine Investitionen in
die Zukunft das ist die teuerste
Zerstörung einer funktionierenden
Infrastruktur die die Welt je gesehen
hat und sie Fluten das Land weiter mit
illegalen Migranten jeder kann kommen
keiner muss gehen sie Bürgern im Akkord
neue Wähler verschaffen illegalen über
das chancenaufenthaltsrecht eine
scheinlegalität ihr
abschiebungsbeschleunigungsgesetz ist
ein
abschiebungsverhinderungsgesetz wenn der
Steuerzahler abgelehten Asylbewerbern
auch noch ein Anwalt bezahlen muss um
weiter gegen die überfällige Ausreise zu
prozessieren mit dieser Politik treiben
sie die Kommunen in die Verzweiflung
sprengen die Sozialsysteme verschärfen
die Wohnungsnot und untergraben die
innere Sicherheit aber vor allem sie
nehmen den Deutschen ihre Heimat
über 1000
Frauen werden jedes Jahr Opfer sexueller
Gewalt durch Zuwanderer 7000 seit dem
willkommensputsch der CDU-Kanzlerin von
2015 aber darüber schweigen sie darüber
schweigen auch die Medien unter dem
schwindeletikett Bürgergeld haben sie
ein
migrationsmagneten geschaffen dessen
Kosten längst außer Kontrolle sind das
nächste Haushaltsloch steht schon vor
der Tür sie lassen die Bürger im Stich
wo der Staat dringend gebraucht würde wo
bleibt die Entschädigung an die vielen
impfgeschädigten ihrer covidimpfung wo
bleibt die eigentlich wo bleibt
überhaupt die Aufarbeitung dieses ganzen
disasters wieder und wieder habe ich
hier aufgeführt was nötig ist um dieses
Land auf Vordermann zu bringen noch mal
Schließung und Kontrolle der Grenzen
Zurückweisung illegaler Einwanderer
Rückführung abgelehnter und krimineller
Asylbewerber und jener die kein
Aufenthaltsrecht haben das ist die
Durchsetzung von Recht und Gesetz nach
Jahren des herrschafts des Unrechts sie
wollen Abschiebung kriminalisieren das
haben wir gesehen in ihrer
Kampagne Stopp der Energiewende
Beschränkung der Staatsausgaben und
natürlich Streichung des Bürgergelds für
ausländische Staatsbürger die nie in die
Sozialkassen eingezahlt haben sach statt
Geldleistung ist die Divise aber
rationale Argumente erreichen sie schon
gar nicht mehr sie können Deutschland
nicht gut regieren und sie wollen es
nicht sie richten es Zug Grunde und ich
sag auch
warum weil sie ihr eigenes Land weil sie
Deutschland hassen diese Regierung hast
Deutschland akzeptieren sie wenigstens
die
Möglichkeit eines demokratischen
Machtwechsels und machen sie den Weg
frei für Neuwahlen ich bedanke
mich weel ist kovorsitzende der AFD
Fraktion und bei der ein und anderen
Zahl die sie hier in ihrem Beitrag
vorgetragen hat ist wie gewohnt Vorsicht
geboten insbesondere was die Zuordnung
angeht so mancher Zahl dass diese
Regierung das Land
passt ist allerdings darüber hinaus eine
ziemlich gewagte These um es mal
vorsichtig zu
formulieren und im Bundestag hat den
Vorsitz das Präsidium
hat jetzt BR Hasselmann ans Pult gerufen
die kovorsitzende der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren und
heute sage ich mal einmal ausnahmsweise
sie liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger auf den
Tribünen und denen die am Bildschirm
vielleicht unsere Debatte verfolgen wenn
es eines Beweises bedurft hätte warum es
Zeit ist dass in Nordhausen Eckernförde
Altenburg Frankfurt sonhofen Zwickau
Hamburg Bielefeld wningerrode Halle
Brandenburg Plauen gieen München
Regensburg Füssen Worms wolzenburg oder
Wismer oder Bautzen Menschen auf die
Straße gehen und sagen wir haben etwas
zu verteidigen nämlich nicht weniger als
unsere Demokratie unsere Freiheit und
unseren
Rechtsstaat dann die Rede von Alice
Weidel meine Damen und Herren wie viel
Verachtung wie viel Verachtung wie viel
Menschenfeindlichkeit wie viel
Gefährlichkeit und wie viel
Verächtlichmachung demokratischer
Institutionen waren hier gerade in 10
Minuten zu hören meine Damen und Herren
es ist unglaublich eine verunglipfung
der Opfer des SED
regims durch unsägliche Vergleiche in
einem freien Land von einer freien
Presse
die geklärt hat und rausgekriegt hat wie
tief die Verstrickung von
Rechtsextremismus
Bewegung AFD in sogenannten
Geheimtreffen in Potsdam war und der
fraktionsvorsitzend steht heute
wahrscheinlich das Wasser zum Hals weil
der zweite ihrer Mitarbeiter soll auch
in Potsdam gewesen sein ich wäre auch
nervös meine Damen und Herren wenn so
etwas passieren würde beim Geheimtreffen
war offenbar nicht nur ihr Roland
Hartwig sondern auch ein gewisser mörig
der vom Bundesvorstand der bezahlt wird
meine Damen und Herren es ist so sie
sind demokratisch gewählt diese AFD
Abgeordneten aber sie sind keine
Demokraten und das erkennen immer mehr
Menschen und deshalb braucht es die
inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung mit ihnen
sie führen dieses Land in ein rückwärts
in ein nie wieder was wir auf jeden Fall
verhindern werden als DemokratInnen und
Demokraten denn das sind wir Menschen
wie
evaesi und Marcel Reifs Vater schuldig
sag ich stellvertretend nach einem einer
so würdigen Gedenkstunde wie heute
morgen in der Eva sepeschi uns
aufgefordert hat gemeinsam und sie alle
auch an ihrer Stelle zu sagen nie wieder
ist jetzt
und RE gesagt hat sei ein Mensch wissen
wir ganz genau als DemokratInnen und
Demokraten und zwar von CDU CSU FDP
Grünen und SPD was unsere Arbeit ist
nämlich diese Demokratie zu verteidigen
mit allem was wir haben meine Damen und
Herren gegen die Feinde der
Demokratie und ich weiß dass sie nervös
sind ich weiß dass ihnen das Wasser bis
zum Hall steht drei ihrer Landesverbände
in denen unter anderem bald Wahlen sind
sind als rechtsextrem gesichert
rechtsextrem eingestuft meine Damen und
Herren lassen Sie sich nicht erzählen
sie hätten Rezepte Lösungen und Ideen
für die Zukunft ein Ausstieg aus der
Europäischen Union ein Ausstieg aus dem
Euro würde
nationalverarmung und eine
Deindustrialisierung in diesem Land
bedeuten meine Damen und Herren und zwar
für alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger das muss
jede und jeder wissen der oder die mit
der AFD sympathisiert und ich kenne den
Bundespräsidenten ich schätze den
Bundespräsidenten und niemals wird er
über die Wählerinnen und Wähler auch
einer solchen Partei wie ihrer gesagt
haben es seien Ratten ich finde es
ungeheuerlich dass sie einen solchen
Vorwurf in diesem Haus erheben meine
Damen und Herren und ich erwarte dass
sie das Zurücknehmen denn Sie können es
durch nichts belegen sie schaden damit
dem Ansehen der demokratischen
Institution und das muss man in aller
Klarheit zurückweisen meine Damen und
Herren weil die Lage aber so ist wie sie
ist meine ganz große
Bitte an Sie Herr März sie haben vorhin
gesagt sparen Sie sich Aufrufe zur
Zusammenarbeit
das werde weder ich tun noch die FDP
Bündnis 90 die Grünen noch die SPD denn
wir wissen dass in diesen Stunden
DemokratInnen und Demokraten aller
demokratischen Parteien gefordert sind
und ich möchte dass sie diese Haltung
auch einnehmen denn die Lage ist ernst
in diesem Land wir sparen uns diese
Aufrufe zur Zusammenarbeit nicht denn
sie sind notwendig und machen Sie sich
doch nicht so klein wir haben doch in
diesem Haus auch schon gezeigt dass es
geht um die Demokratie whrhafter zu
machen haben wir gemeinsam das die
Parteienfinanzierung verändert meine
Damen und Herren unlautere Wahlwerbung
ihre ganzen
parteispendensümpfe sind so klarer
darlegbar meine Damen und Herren da
haben wir ein Riegel vorgeschoben
gemeinsam mit Ihnen Herr März wir haben
gerade das Stiftungsgesetz geändert
damit einfach klar ist wir haben erstmal
eins geschaffen was einen klaren
Rechtsrahmen gibt meine Damen und Herren
dafür dass Stiftung auf dem Grund und
Boden dieser Verfassung stehen müssen
und das klar und deutlich geregelt ist
und zwar zusammen mit der sie tragenden
Bundestag Bundesregierung und unseren
Fraktionen und ihnen wir haben das
Disziplinarrecht geändert damit
rechtsextremen Umtrieben in Polizei und
Bundes W Einhalt geboten wird also tun
sie doch nicht so als würden wir hier
nicht zusammenarbeiten und diese
Zusammenarbeit ist auch notwendig
dringend notwendig in dieser Zeit und
ich sage ihn mal aus vielen Gesprächen
mit Bürgerinnen und Bürgern ob bei der
Kirche oder ihren CDU Kolleginnen und
Kollegen vor Ort ich weiß das ganz genau
dass sie sich alle wünschen dass
DemokratInnen und Demokraten jetzt
zusammenstehen das tun sie nämlich auch
V Ort in den Städten in den Gemeinden
und wir arbeiten in sehr
unterschiedlichen Konstellationen als
demokratische Kräfte in den Ländern
zusammen also treiben sie hier keinen
Spalt rein wo er nicht gebraucht wird
bzw gefährlich ist meine Damen und
Herren ich bedauere meine Damen und
Herren die Unsicherheit die nachd dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht
entstanden ist was den Haushalt angeht
wir wissen sehr genau dass wir lange
gebraucht haben um das Urteil
auszuwerten und die Schlüsse daraus
zuziiehen die notwendig waren dass das
in Wirtschaft Industrie Handwerk bei den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern auch für
Verunsicherung gesorgt hat aber diese
Woche entscheiden wir in der Sache über
einen Haushalt und wir haben das
hingekriegt trotz aller
Unterschiedlichkeit in den Auffassungen
die vielleicht zwischen FDP Bündnis 90
die Grünen und SPD und auch in der
Bundesregierung erten wir bringen diese
Woche einen Haushalt auf den Weg der für
Klarheit schafft und der einen Rahmen
gibt für die
Zukunftsinvestitionen die notwendig sind
für die soziale Gerechtigkeit und für
die Demokratie meine Damen und Herren
und das ist ein gutes Signal bei aller
Unterschiedlichkeit es verbindet uns
drei nämlich die Überzeugung auch wenn
es schwer war dass wir zusammen agieren
und dass wir hier gemeinsam für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für die Industrie
für das Handwerk und vor allen Dingen
für die zentralen Zukunftsfragen die
Bekämpfung der Klimakrise die notwendige
Transformation also das heißt die
Veränderung die soziale und ökologische
die notwendig ist weil wir uns nach 16
Jahren Stillstand sowas nicht mehr
leisten können meine Damen und Herren es
braucht Veränderung das ist mittlerweile
bis tief in die großen
Wirtschaftsunternehmen klar die lächzen
danach dass wir die Rahmenbedingungen
setzen ein einfaches weiter so Herr März
wie in der 90er Jahre Wirtschaftspolitik
ist nicht die Zukunft unseres Landes die
führt uns nach unten im bestcee bleibt
sie da stehen aber das können wir nicht
gebrauchen wir haben viel zu viele
Herausforderungen und tun Sie mir noch
einen
Gefallen sozialer Zusammenhalt das
soziale Miteinander und auch die
Verantwortung dieses
Parlamentes für die sozialen Fr en und
die Sicherheit von Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern beantwortet man nicht indem man
das Bürgergeld als subventionierte
Arbeitslosigkeit bezeichnen wissen Sie
eigentlich was sie Menschen gegenüber
damit machen das ist ein treten nach
unten eine Abwertung und das spüren
Menschen sie sollten das nicht tun denn
sie haben gemeinsam mit uns im Bundestag
und im Bundesrat mit allen dann
gemeinsam das Bürgergeld auf den Weg
gebracht und sich jetzt so billig aus
der Verantwortung zu schleichen das wird
doch Ihnen auch gar nicht gerecht in
ihrer Rolle mein Gott meine Damen und
Herren meine Damen und Herren sie tragen
Verantwortung wie wir für dieses
Bürgergeld für das Konzept weil sie
haben in beiden Kammern dem Bundesrat
und dem Bundestag zugestimmt und ich
rate einfach nur dazu tun sie nicht das
Gleiche was andere versuchen durch die
Abwertung von Menschen andere in eine
bessere Lage zu versetzen oder Leute
gegeneinander auszuspielen Olaf Scholz
hat gerade in seiner Rede darauf
hingewiesen wo waren Sie denn wo waren
sie als wir über den Mindestlohn
gesprochen haben wo sind sie wenn es um
Tariftreue geht alle
absicherungsfragen die notwendig sind
auch für die Zukunft ich höre nichts von
ihnen oder ist jetzt Steffen Kampeter
ihr neues altes Sprachrohr der zu allem
nur nein sagt weil er in der
Wirtschaftspolitik der 90er verhangen
geblieben ist gucken Sie sich den Aufruf
der Unternehmen der 50 die gerade sagen
wir haben eine Herausforderung es gibt
kein Stillstand oder zurück es gibt nur
ein nach vorn und wir brauchen die
Unterstützung dieser Bundesregierung und
dieses Parlamentes dafür notwendige
Investitionen anschübe für
Transformation auch wirklich stemmen zu
können niemand redet in diesen
Unternehmen davon dass wir sie auf Dauer
subventionieren sollen das ist doch
völliger Quatsch sie brauchen
verlässliche Rahmenbedingungen sie
brauchen anschübe für
Zukunftsinvestitionen und das ist es was
Sie brauchen und J sparen diese billigen
Zwischenrufe gerne guckt dir doch gucken
Sie sich doch tüssenstahl in Essen an
tüen in Essen an was ist denn mit dem
grünenstahl reden Sie doch mal mit den
Leuten ich habe doch gerade schon gesagt
reden Sie nicht nur mit Kampeter sondern
gehen Sie in die Unternehmen und reden
mit denen fragen Sie doch mal wie die
das sehen die Schütteln mit dem Kopf
wenn die ihre wirtschaftspolitischen
Vorstellungen hören und tut sie mir
einen Gefallen reden Sie dieses
wunderbare Land nicht so
schlecht viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger
die ich gerade erlebe auf den
Straßen die wollen in diesem Land leben
weil dieses Land für Sie Freiheit
bedeutet weil dieses Land bedeutet hier
sind sie aufgewachsen geboren oder
hierher gekommen weil sie hier eine
Arbeit gefunden haben und weil sie hier
ihre Familie gegründet haben weil ihre
Kinder hier zur Schule gehen und die
lieben dieses Land und E Einzelfall wird
es so sein dass der eine oder die andere
unter bestimmten Fragen leidet oder
unzufrieden ist und auch wir können
vieles besser machen da bin ich
überzeugt und wir müssen einiges besser
machen aber in dieser
plateit auf das was Menschen draußen von
uns erwarten in dieser Situation der
Demokratie so einfach und schlicht zu
antworten wird auch Ihnen nicht Gericht
wir sind alle zusammen gefordert
wirklich
gefordert unser Land Zukunft fest
zuumachen Sicherheit zu geben damit
diese notwendige
Veränderung auch gestaltet werden kann
dass wir niemanden zurücklassen in
dieser Situation und wir sind
gemeinsam verantwortet diese Demokratie
und den Rahmen dafür auch gemeinsam
fester und resilienter zu machen
wehrhafter in unserer Demokratie und da
fordere ich Sie auf Herr März nehmen Sie
Ihren Eingangspunkt nicht so ernst dass
sie keine Zusammenarbeit wollen ich
finde es wichtig wir alle geben als
demokratische Kräfte ein Signal aus dass
wir wissen was die Stunde geschlagen hat
und als DemokratInnen und Demokraten
nicht nur die Rede und Gegenrede suchen
sondern auch den Konsens denn der gehört
zu einer Demokratie
danke
brittelmann kvorsitzende der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen am Ende noch mal
mit einem Appell zusammenzuarbeiten ein
Appell Richtung Unionsfraktion und vor
allem in Richtung Friedrich März der in
seiner Rede ja einer generellen
Zusammenarbeit mit der Ampelkoalition
eine Absage erteilt hatte und sagt
Britta Hasselmann reden Sie dieses
wunderbare Land nicht schlecht der
nächste Redner in dieser Generaldebatte
zum Bundeshaushalt 24 ist der
Vorsitzender der FDP Fraktion Christian
D Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir erleben
gegenwärtig überall in Deutschland
Demonstration gegen Rechtsextremismus
mit beeindruckenden Teilnehmerzahlen ich
habe selbst an der Demonstration in
Bremen teilgenommen dort habe ich die
dort habe ich die Breite bürgerliche
Mitte unserer Gesellschaft angetroffen
ganz normale Menschen die sich Sorgen um
unsere freiheitliche Demokratie machen
wir haben heute Vormittag hier im
deutschen bundest Tag eine Gedenkstunde
für die Opfer des Nationalsozialismus
gehabt in einzigartiger Weise tragen wir
Deutsche Verantwortung für unsere
Geschichte und dafür jüdisches Leben
hier und überall sicher zu machen der
barbarischeer Angriff der Hamas auf
Israel unterstreicht diesen Auftrag und
ja auch manche Reaktion auf deutschen
Straßen meine Damen und Herren ich will
deshalb in aller Deutlichkeit sagen mich
bei der Kollegin Britt Hasselmann und
den Kollegen Friedrich Merz
auch für die Worte am Anfang ihrer reden
ich möchte eine Wahrheit heute
aussprechen dass die
AFD hier heute in einem demokratischen
Parlament sitzt und von Remigration
spricht ist geschichtsvergessen und
gruselig meine Damen und
Herren die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat eine
lange Migrationsgeschichte und verdankt
auch seinen wierau Bau und das ehemalige
das damalige Wirtschaftswunder verlangt
es Menschen die zu uns gekommen sind wir
sind ein weltoffenes Land Herr märz ist
es richtig ich teile die Ausführung das
Thema Migration Bedarf Recht und Ordnung
keine Frage aber gleichzeitig das Signal
heute aus dem Bundestag geht nach
Deutschland aus die demokratischen
Parteien der politischen Mitte sie
stehen zur Weltoffenheit für Menschen
die zu uns kommen und uns sich bei uns
integrieren wollen die ranklatzen en die
unser Land mit uns gemeinsam nach vorne
bringen wollen sie sind in Deutschland
herzlich willkommen liebe Kolleginen und
Kollegen und richtig ist auch dass die
allgemeinpolitische Debatte zweimal im
Jahr jetzt haben wir sie im letzten Jahr
gehabt im September jetzt im Januar
etwas verspätet ich komme darauf gleich
noch einmal zu sprechen es ist ein guter
Anlass über Grundsätze der Politik zu
sprechen und Herr Kollege März
weil sie das vorhin angesprochen haben
es ist gute parlamentarische Tradition
dass wir eben zweimal im Jahr die
allgemeinpolitische Debatte im Rahmen
der Beratungen zum Bundeshaushalt
durchführen deshalb ist es es ist
deshalb gut weil sich am konkreten
Handeln von Regierung und Opposition
ablesen lässt ob man willens und in der
Lage ist das rhetorisch vorgetragene
auch in konkrete Politik umzusetzen und
da lieber Kollege März liebe Kollegin
Kollegen der CDU CSU weil sie selbst
angesprochen haben da ist die Antwort im
Bezug auf ihre Fraktion leider null sie
kritisieren hier am Pult rauf und runter
aber sind nicht in der Lage einen
einzigen Änderungsvorschlag zum
Bundeshaushalt 2024 zu machen das
spricht Bänd ein Fehler ein
fundamentaler strategischer Fehler den
sie heute begangen haben aus meiner
Sicht ein fundamentaler Fehler
wenn Sie Herr März wenn Sie selbst schon
keine Idee haben hätten sie doch
wenigstens die zahlreichen über 500
Änderungsanträge der FDP
Bundestagsfraktion aus der letzten
Wahlperiode stellen können viele haben
sie übrigens rhetorisch hier gerade
eingeführt und ich will sagen
zugegebenermaßen da ist nicht mehr so
viel übrig von den damaligen
Änderungsanträgen weil die meisten
Vorschläge die wir damals vorgetragen
hab heute in regierungshandel umgesetzt
werden im Deutschen Bundestag meine
Damen und Herren wir machen das real
aber Herr März der Grund warum ich das
anspreche und sage die
allgemeinpolitische Debatte findet im
Rahmen der Haushaltsberatung statt der
Grund warum ich das anspreche was sagt
es über ihre Partei aus die sich
richtigerweise anschickt auch in ferner
Zukunft einmal wieder
Regierungsverantwortung in Deutschland
zu übernehmen wenn sie nicht einmal zu
Oppositionszeiten in der Lage ist
konkrete Vorschläge zu machen reden ist
gut handeln ist besser selbst wenn
Anträge ab abgelehnt werden ich ermutige
sie machen sie
Oppositionsarbeit das ist ihr Job das
ist ihr
Job und ich habe das vorhin angedeutet
wir führen jetzt die abschließende
Beratung des Bundeshaushaltes im Januar
2024 statt wegen eines Urteils des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts vom 15
November es war wegweisend aus meiner
Sicht das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
die Schuldenbremse im Kern gestärkt und
Änderung an langjähriger stspraxis von
uns verlangt wesweisend war aber auch
die Art und Weise wie diese Koalition
mit den Folgen umgegangen ist wir können
heute feststellen dass wir das Urteil
des Verfassungsgerichts eins zu eins im
Bundeshaushalt umsetzen zugleich wird
dieser Bundeshaushalt der erste sein
seit 2019 der die Schuldenbremse wieder
vollumfänglich einhält das ist ein
Erfolg nicht nur dieser Regierung
sondern aller Steuerzahler Steuerzahler
in Deutschland liebe Kollegin Kollegen
aber wir können wir können da sehr gern
in die direkten Vergleich gehen wie
haben denn unionsgeführte Bundesländer
auf das haushaltsurteil reagiert gab es
da harte Verhandlung zur neu
Priorisierung von Staatsausgaben
Beispiel Berlin der Regierende
Bürgermeister Kai Wegner hält die
Schuldenbremse für Zitat gefährlich der
Berliner Rechnungshof hat die Pläne für
ein neues Klima Sondervermögen als
unvereinbar mit dem karlsoher Urteil
gebranntenmkt schläßig Holstein die
Koalition von Herrn Günther hat Ende
November eine außergewöhnliche
Notsituation für 2023 und 24
festgestellt und nimmt weiter
munterkredite auf als ob es das Urteil
nicht gegeben haben ich weiß es wird
richtigerweise auch über die
Schuldenbremse in diesem Haus
demokratisch gestritten aber ich will
mit einem Vorurteil aufhören es wird
behauptet die Schuldenbremse sei eine
Investitionsbremse doch der Haushalt
2024 er ist der Beweis dafür dass das
nicht der Fall ist denn trotz gehärtter
oder gerade wegen gehärtetter
Schuldenbremse bringen wir umfassende
Zukunftsinvestitionen auf den Weg diese
Koalition schafft es dass der
Bundeshaushalt
2024 eine fast
50% höhere Investitionsquote hat als das
2019 in Ihrer Verantwortung noch der
Fall war im Verkehrsbereich im
Verkehrsbereich wir
investieren in Schi in Strae Straße im
Vergleich zum letzten Jahr 40% mehr und
liebe Kollegin Kollegen der Union das
ist einerseits eine Leistung dieser
Koalition andererseits aber auch die
notwendige Antwort auf sagen wir es
offen eine katastrophale
Infrastruktur Infrastrukturpolitik der
Verkehrsminister Alexander Dobrind und
andreas Scheuer liebe Kollegen Kollegen
katastrophal was sie gemacht haben das
räumen wir jetzt auf das korrigieren
wir Fehler sich jahrelang nicht um die
deutschen Brücken gekümmert zu haben
sondern lieber sich mit einer
ausländermaut beschäftigt zu haben
zweitens
mit mit 12 Milliarden Euro mit 12
Milliarden Euro legen wir die Grundlage
für die aktienrente für das
generationkapital das ist einerseits
einer Leistung dieser Koalition
andererseits aber auch bitter notwendig
angesichts eines immer weiter steigenden
Bundeszuschuss in die gesetzliche
Rentenversicherung wir brauchen mehr
Kapital ung Herr März es war ein Fehler
dass sie in den langen CDU geführten
Bundesregierung in den langen Jahren mit
den überfälligen Einstieg in die
Kapitaldeckung unserer Rente nicht
angefangen haben das korrigieren wir
jetzt mit diesem Bundeshaushalt meine
Damen und Herren
und wir sorgen damit dass die
Steuerquote in Deutschland sinkt zum 1
Januar 2024 der Bundeskanzler hat es
vorhin angesprochen haben wir die
Arbeiten Mitte erneut bei der Lohn um
einkommenenssteuer um 15 Milliarden Euro
entlastet das ist einerseits eine
Leistung dieser Koalition andererseits
aber auch bitter notwendig angesetetzt
langjährigers steuerpolitischen
Stillstands in Deutschland und immer
weiter zunehmender Belastung der
arbeitenmitte in ihrer
Regierungsverantwortung um das in aller
Klarheit zu sagen ein Fehler den diese
Koalition jetzt korrigiert für die
arbeitende Mitte in unserem
Land
und
ich will das an dem Beispiel deutlich
sagen weil ich sie riefen vorhin bei der
Rede des Bundeskanzlers dazwischen er
würde reden wie ein Generalsekretär ich
habe den bererei gesessen ich finde
Generalsekretäre sind ganz wunderbare
Redner um das noch mal zu unterstreichen
aber ich will auf etwas anderes hinaus
ich habe nämlich gelesen was ihr
Generalsekretär in Bezug auf steuerliche
Reform in Deutschland gesagt hat er hat
gesagt man müsse bei der
einkommenenssteuer eine
Rechtsverschiebung des Tarifes machen um
die arbeitende Mitte zu entlasten genau
das tut diese Koalition ich habe mir die
GE Frage gestellt wenn sie solche Dinge
im Kopf haben warum bringen sie sowas
nicht in den Bundestag ein für sie sind
Steuersenkung immer nur Wahlkampfthema
nie Regierung und parlamentshandelt das
unterscheidet uns von Ihnen liebe
Kolleginen und
Kollegen und ich will einen weiteren
Punkt ansprechen das
statschancenprogramm was wir auch mit
diesem Bundeshaushalt absichern was
unsere Bundesbildungsministerin bertina
starkwatzinger auf den Weg bringt im
kommenden Jahr in den kommenden 10
Jahren 4000 Schwerpunktschulen mit
insgesamt 20 Milliarden Euro zu
unterstützen wir helfen damit eine
Millionen Kinder in unserem Land das ist
einerseits eine Leistung dieser
Koalition andererseits angesichts der
schlechten pisaergebnisse in unserem
Land aber auch bitter notwendig Herr
märz ist war ein Fehler dass das
Bildungsministerium in Deutschland
jahrelang von Durchsetzung schwachen
Bundesministerin ihrer Partei besetzt
worden ist das hat sich jetzt geändert
liebe Kollegin Kollegen und ich sag das
deshalb weil wir viel über
Zukunftschancen reden und ich bin
dankbar dass sich die Länder am Ende des
Tages bewegt haben hoffentlich bewegen
werden und genau dieses
statschancenprogramm zur Unterschrift
kommt aber es geht ja um mehr wer Recht
hat oder wer nicht hat in der
Bildungspolitik es geht um wesentlich
mehr es geht um die Chancen junger
Menschen es ist die
himmelschreidenste soziale
Ungerechtigkeit in Deutschland dass die
Chancen junger Menschen vom Elternhaus
abhängen das muss sich ändern jeder
junge Mensch hat eine Chance da geht's
nicht um soziale Unterstützung sondern
um faere Bildungschancen und das setzen
wir in dieser Koalition an liebe
Kollegin
Kollegen und her sie haben
richtigerweise über die wirtschaftliche
Situation in unserem Lande gesprochen
die herausfordernd ist das teile ich
ausdrücklich ich will hinzufügen manchen
Vorwurf lasse ich mir allerdings nicht
machen dass wir hinter dem
Scherbenhaufen den sie angerichtet haben
nicht schnell genug hinterherkehren aber
wir tun etwas beispielsweise die
Stromsteuer für das produzierende
Gewerbe um
96% gesenkt das
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz für Startups
der Bundeskanzler sprach davon wir haben
hier national das getan was notwendig
ist um unseren gründungsst Ort zu
stärken und schließlich mit dem Wachstum
chancengesetz entlasten wir die
Unternehmen in Deutschland und setzen
ein sehr wichtiges Signal für
Investitionsanreize und
Forschungsvorhaben in neue Technologien
und da verstehe ich nicht ihre Strategie
ich will das in aller Deutlichkeit sagen
bei genau dieser Zukunftsfrage der
Bundesfinanzminister hat in seiner Rede
bei der finanzpolitischen Debatte
gestern gesagt dass ihm der vorm redende
Kollege Matthias Middelberg aus meinem
geschätzten Heimatland nieder erschsen
vorkomme wie ein
Marsianer der vor 14 Tagen hier im
Deutschen Bundestag gelandet ist sich
umschaut was aus Deutschland geworden
ist wo die Probleme liegen dass zu wenig
in Infrastruktur investiert worden ist
in der Vergangenheit und die
wirtschaftlichen Herausforderung da sind
ich muss eines feststellen nach den
Debatten zu Einzelplänen am gestrigen
Tag und ihrer Rede am heutigen Vormittag
Herr Kollege März Herr
Bundesfinanzminister wir haben es nicht
mit einem einzelnen ma zu tun es ist
eine Invasion von Marian die wir hier
erleben die sich offensichtlich an
nichts aber auch gar nichts erinnern
können und jetzt nicht einmal in der
Lage sind das
wachstumschancengesetz durch den
Bundesrat zu bringen das wäre ihre
Aufgabe als CD und CSU diesen harten
Situation auch für die deutsche
Volkswirtschaft Liebe Kolleginen
Kollegen und deswegen und deswegen will
ich eines zum Schluss
sagenilang edenen Regeln über
Migrationspolitik gesprochen worden ist
ja ich habe gesagt mehr Recht und
Ordnung in der Durchsetzung und
gleichzeitig das ganze mit Weltoffenheit
verbinden deswegen haben wir das
Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz hier im
Bundestag beschlossen und das
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht noveliert aber
eines finde ich besonders spannend als
ich als Fraktionsvorsitzender der FDP im
letzten Oktober gesagt habe dass ich vor
den Ministerpräsidenten in der MPK am 6
November eine klare Zusage zur bezahlk
erwarte da war das Wort Bezahlkarte im
Wortschatz der Union noch gar nicht
verankert dass Sie sich jetzt hier
hinstellen und die Bezahlkarte hochleben
lassen ist ein Treppenwitz der
Geschichte ich bin und der Kanzler hat
gesagt dankbar dass endlich der klaren
Positionierung meiner Partei und dieser
Koalition beim Thema Bezahlkarte Folge
geleistet wird boris reinh hat erklärt
sie kommt in allen 16 Ländern das ist
ein gutes Signal zeigt übrigens dass
Deutschland insgesamt handlungsfähig ist
also bitte mehr Zeitung lesen dann sind
sie auch up to date bei ihren
Haushaltsreden Herr Merz ich danke
ihnen Christian dü der Vorsitzende der
FDP Fraktion und die Unionsfraktion und
da speziell deren Vorsitzender die
werden im Moment nicht so richtig
Freunde man hat es an verschiedenen
Stellen in seiner Rede gehört und unter
anderem hat er sich in seiner Replik auf
Friedrich merzer dessen Äußerung zum
Verzicht auf Änderungsanträge zum Haus
herausgepickter sei sag D ein
fundamentaler strategischer Fehler
Alexander dobrin für die CSU dieucaktion
zwei sehr ergreifende Schilderungen von
evaepesi und Marcel Reif gehört die uns
noch mal sehr deutlich gemacht haben was
die demokratische Mitte dieses Hauses
eint dass sich eben nicht wiederholt was
sich nicht wiederholen darf und dass wir
diese Demokratie gegen diejenigen
verteidigen müssen die sie angreifen und
da ist es in der Tat ein großartiges
Zeichen wenn in den vergangenen Tagen
und Wochen tausende Menschen in
Deutschland gegen den Rechtsextremismus
auf die Straße gegangen sind ein großes
Zeichen unserer lebendigen Demokratie
und sehr der Bundeskanzler sie haben
hier im Rednerpult vorhin gesagt wir
müssen als Demokraten zusammenstehen ja
wir m als Demokraten zusammenstehen aber
zu einer Demokratie gehört eben auch
eine Opposition in der Mitte dieses
Parlaments und der sollte man mit mehr
Respekt begegnen als sie das in ihrer
Erklärung hier gemacht
haben der Sinn von politik besteht nicht
ausschließlich im Ausdruck einer Haltung
sondern in der Bewältigung von Problemen
so jasp von alten
kurzem in seiner Zeitung ich stimme ihm
ausdrücklich zu es geht um die
Bewältigung von Problemen und sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler dass sie in
Anbetracht der Lage in der die Ampel
dieses Land gebracht hat heute kein
Stück Einsicht und Demut gezeigt haben
das ist wirklich der Gipfel der
Arroganz haben sie sichentlich die en
von gestern mal im Detail angeschaut
haben sie sich angeschaut was alle
Institute über Deutschland im Vergleich
zu Europa und der Welt zum Auszug
bringen es ist ein weiteres Schrumpfen
des vergangenen Jahres von
-0,3% festgestellt worden es gibt eine
pessimistische PR Prognose mit negativen
Wachstum für das Jahr
2024 und dann ist noch der
internationale währungsfor dazu gekommen
dass er Deutschland drastisch nach unten
abstuft wähend für die ganze Welt für
Europa für alle Industrienationen die
Prognosen nach oben gehen wird
Deutschland als einzige Industrienation
abgewertet die Kernaussage ist eindeutig
und klar Deutschland steckt in der
Rezession die Krise verfestet sich das
Land wird weiter abgehängt und die
Verantwortung liegt dafür bei der
ampelregierung und nirgendwo anders
meine Damen und
Herren
her Bundeskanzler sie haben in der
letzten Woche in der Zeitung die Zeit
formuliert wörtliches Zitat die
Koalition mutet sich angesichts der
großen Herausforderungen Konflikte zu
die Koalition mutet sich Konflikte zu
nein Herr Bundeskanzler es ist umgekehrt
nicht die Ampel mutet sich etwas zu
sondern die Ampel ist eine zubotung für
die Menschen in Deutschland das ist die
Wahrheit eine Zumutung für die Bauern
eine Zumutung für die Spediteure eine
Zumutung für die Gastronomen eine
Zumutung fürs Handwerk eine Zumutung für
den ländlichen Raum sie bieten in ihrem
Haushalt dazu auch überhaupt keine
Lösungen an hören Sie doch aufständig
dazwischenrufen sie sind einfach
schlichtweg nicht das Opfer dieser
Konflikte sie s der Urheber dieser
Konflikte die ich da gerade geschrieben
habe sie bieten keine Lösungen an
glauben Sie dass Sie mit 20 Milliarden
zusätzlichen Steuererhöhungen mit 40
Milliarden neuen Schulden irgendwas zur
Befriedung in diesem Land beitragen sie
haben sich vom Sparen komplett
verabschiedet sie haben sich schlichtweg
verabschiedet meine Damen und
Herren Gesetz mit Steuererhöhungen haben
sie die Polarisierung in diesem Land
weiter vorangetrieben und jetzt und
jetzt spricht der Finanzminister gestern
hier an diesem Rednerpult davon dass er
nicht mehr über einen Sparhaushalt
nachdenkt sondern über einen
gestaltungshaushalt meine Damen und
Herren sie sind keine Koalition der
Gestaltung sie sind eine Koalition der
Spaltung das sehen Sie auf
jedenag in diesem
Land und in diesem in dieser Situation
in der sie Deutschland gebracht haben
spricht der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister davon dass
Unternehmen mehr
standortpatriotismus zeigen sollten das
ist in der Tat ein beeindruckender
Versuch Ursache und Wirkung umzukehren
die Unternehmer sind nicht schld an der
schlechten Wirtschaftssituation sie sind
das Opfer ihrer schlechten
Wirtschaftspolitik so ist
es aber diejenigen von denen man mehr
standortpatriotismus erwarten müsste die
sitzen am
Kabinettstisch
standortpatriotismus würde heißen nicht
die deutschen Kernkraftwerke abschalten
und dann französische Kernenergie kaufen
standortpatriotismus würde bedeuten die
landwirtschaftliche Produktion im Land
zu erhalten anstatt sie abzuwirken
standortpatriotismus würde heißen den
Mittelstand zu entlasten anstatt die
Steuern zu erhöhen und
standortpatriotismus würde bedeuten die
Erbschaftssteuer zu regionalisieren
anstatt sie zu erhöhen und die Leute
damit zusätzlich zu belassen das wäre
standardpatriotismus in diesem
Land Geber sprechen davon dass die
Unternehmen das Vertrauen in die
Regierung verloren haben die igemetal
spricht davon dass es eine schleichende
Deindustrialisierung in diesem Land gibt
und sie Herr Bundeskanzler sprechen
davon dass sie alles dafür getan haben
dass sich Arbeit lohnt meine Damen und
Herren das ist der glatte Hohn gegenüber
denjenigen die heute das Gefühl haben
dass sich Arbeit in diesem Land nicht
mehr rentiert ihre Politik überfordert
schlichtg dieses
[Applaus]
Land die demotivierte Gesellschaft das
war ein Artikel der von Allensbach
veröffentlicht worden ist immer mehr
Menschen glauben dass sich schlichtweg
Arbeit nicht mehr lohnt und das sich
gerade Menschen mit mittlerem und den
kleinen Einkommen so äern gibt es doch
auch einen Grund dreiviertel der
Menschen sind der Überzeugung dass das
Bürgergeld davon abhalte in
Beschäftigung zu kommen dreiviertel
glauben dass das Bürgergeld
Beschäftigung verhindert ihr Bürgergeld
hat schlichtweg an Akzeptanz verloren
und ihr Bürgergeld sorgt dafür dass auch
Arbeit an Akzeptanz verliert weil die
Arbeitnehmer nicht mehr respektiert
werden von
ihnen
schauen Sie sich doch mal an was sie mit
diesem Bürgergeld entstanden ist es gibt
neue Rechnungen es gibt neue Rechnungen
die sagen würde sich eine Familie die
heute 2000 € 3000 € verdient auf den Weg
machen und mit weiteren 2000 € verdienen
wollen dann kämen sie gerade auf 32 €
mehr Netto so sieht doch kein
funktionierender Sozialstaat aus der die
Schwachen schützt nein so sieht ein
Sozialstaat aus der die
leistungsbereiten bestraft und das ist
die Realität mit ihrem
Bürgergeld Damen und Herren es gibt eine
ganze Menge zu kritisieren an dem was
diese Ampel mit ihrem
Haushaltsentwurf an Fehlern macht aber
sehr fr lassen an dieser Stelle sagen
ihre
Einlassung diese Regierung hasast
Deutschland die ist mit aller Schärfe
zurückzuweisen diese Regierung regiert
schlecht aber sie hasst dieses Land
nicht und ich sage Ihnen
das ja es wird nicht besser wenn sie es
wiederholen an dieser
Stelle wissen Sie ich gebe Ihnen hier
auch was mit auf den Weg sPD Grüne FDP
und CDU und CSU wir hassen auch dieses
Europa nicht wir hassen dieses Europa
nicht weil auch diese Europäische Union
der Garant für Demokratie für Freiheit
und für Wohlstand zwischen unseren
Partner Ländern ist und ich weiß ja
nicht ob es überhaupt noch jemand bei
Ihnen realisiert was in ihrer Partei
passiert wo haben Sie sich denn
eigentlich hingewegt von Lucke zu höcke
da stehen sie jetzt wo soll es denn
eigentlich weitergehen mit ihrer Partei
ich kann Ihnen sagen wenn einer aus
ihrer Fraktion aus ihrer Partei sagt
diese EU muss sterben dann ist er unser
schärfster Gegner wenn sie sagen das
brexit ist der Modell für Deutschland
dann sind Sie unser schärfster Gegner
sie arbeiten am Ruin dieses Landes und
das war sehr deutlich so zuagen und ich
kann ihn auch
nur ans Herz
legen sprechen Sie einfach weiter
darüber dass sie aus der Europäischen
Union aussteigen wollen dass sie den
Euro aufgeben wollen dass sie aus der
NATO aussteigen wollen und reden Sie
bitte auch weiter darüber dass sie sich
Putins rasischer Wirtschaftsunion
annähern wollen reden sie darüber dass
sie das freie Europa zerstören und sich
dem russischen Diktator anschließen
wollen sie sind nicht die Alternative
für Deutschland die Alternative die sie
anbütigen anbieten das ist die
Alternative der Unmündigkeit der unter
Unterwerfung der Unfreiheit das hat mit
Patriotismus nichts zu tun das ist
vaterlandsverrat was von ihnen hier
kommt
weitermachen
ja ist schwer zu ertragen die Wahrheit
ist an dieser Stelle sehr schwer zu
ertragen ich verstehe das sehr gete
Damen und
Herren will ihn nur Herr D für ihre Rede
den kleinen Hinweis geben sie haben
davon gesprochen
sie seien auf dem richtigen Weg ihre
umfrageerte haben sich von über 11% auf
3% entwickelt 8% Verlust wenn das der
richtige Weg ist dann ist das ein
Beispiel von autosubtition wie wir es
hier selten erlebt haben meine Damen und
Herren und sehr geehrte Frau Hasselmann
ich will ihnen das auch mit auf den Weg
geben sie haben hier formuliert in
Richtung von CDU und Jesu reden sie das
Land nicht schlecht ich sage Ihnen
regieren sie dieses Land nicht schlecht
Rechtsextremismus kann man auch nur dann
bekämpfen wenn man ihn nicht einfach nur
weg demonstriert oder verbieten will
sondern man muss ihn auch wegreieren und
da haben sie zurzeit noch Verantwortung
meine Damen und
Herren
Alexander Dobrind Vorsitzender der CSU
Landesgruppe über dies erster
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der CDU
CSU Fraktion mit viel und auch deftiger
Kritik an der Koalition aber auch mit
deutlichen Anmerkungen in Richtung der
AFD Fraktion nächster Redner rauf
Mützenich der Vorsitzende der SPD
Fraktion frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegin
und
Kollegen ich denke es ist gut wenn man
ein bisschen versucht diese Debatte auch
in einem Ton zu führen und ich muss auch
äh für die größte Fraktion in dieser
Koalition sagen ja in spannungsreichen
und aufwühlenden Zeiten ist es fast
unmöglich immer und überall Zuversicht
und Sicherheit zu stiften Kriege der
Wandel der internationalen Ordnung
wirtschaftliche Unsicherheiten und
politisches
abenteuertum liegen außerhalb unseres
Einflusses und ich muss es bekennen dass
wir aber durch unser Verhalten in der
Koalition manchmal Verdruss und
Besorgnis befördert haben ist fahrlässig
und das betrübt mich auch und wir haben
zugelassen dass unsere
Differenzen leider auch der Demokratie
als solcher zugeordnet wurden das muss
aufhören wir müssen anders arbeiten und
unseren Ansprüchen besser gerecht
werden
Grundsatzdebatten darf man auch in
dieser Koalition führen
Eigennutz Unhöflichkeit und besser
wisserei untereinander meine Damen und
Herren müssen dagegen
aufhören liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ich sag das ich sag das ja ich
glaube sie können das eben nicht sich
auch mal auf sich selbst zu beziehen das
ist glaube ich der Unterschied deswegen
sage ich ja in dieser Koalition und das
wussten wir von Anfang wir sind
unterschiedliche Parteien aber das
brauchen wir nicht jeden Tag zu betonen
wichtiger ist dass diese drei Parteien
zusammen gefunden haben weil sie wissen
dass Gesetze auch Kompromisse sind aber
am Ende legen wir die Planken wir
schaffen das Fundament für glasklare
Veränderungen in diesem Land weil das
eben in der Vergangenheit nicht gelungen
ist deswegen sage
ich kommit einer Bestimmung ist nicht
das Entscheidende sondern das
Entscheidende ist dass dieses Fundament
nicht wieder zurückgedreht werden kann
auch nicht von denen die die 90er Jahre
des letzten Jahrhunderts zurück wollen
das ist die Leistung und das ist der
Erfolg meine Damen und Herren dieser
Regierung und wir
brauchen wir brauchen
mehr von dieser möglichkeitspolitik und
wenn man das bedenkt und beachtet kann
man auch stolz auf das geschaffene sein
und es wird schwerlich möglich
vielleicht irgendwann für andere
politische Mehrheiten etwas
zurückzudrehen was diese Koalition
geschaffen hat und ich will mal sagen
das Recht auf Ausbildung das ist ein
fundamentaler Erfolg für die jungen
Menschen in diesem Land wenn sie keinen
Ausbildungsplatz finden
außerbetriebliche Bildung letztlich auch
hier zu bekommen Qualifizierungen und
Mindestlohn ein besseres Eltern und
Kindergeld Wohngeld Gesundheit und
Renten für die Menschen die
erwerbsgemindert sind das sind die
fundamentalen Entscheidungen die in
dieser Koalition getroffen worden sind
und genau das ist das Fundament für ein
soziales Deutschland wo auch wir
Sozialdemokratin und Sozialdemokraten
stolz drauf sind meine Damen und Herren
umso
mehr und das frage ich mich Herr Kollege
MZ wissen Sie eigentlich wenn Sie über
das Bürgergeld so reden mal unabhängig
davon dass sie und das haben wir ja
jetzt schon öfter auch festgestellt
zugestimmt haben und dem Mindeslohn
leider nicht wissen sie dass das
Bürgergeld von jedem fünften der in
Beschäftigung ist genutzt werden muss
weil das Gehalt das Einkommen zu gering
ist das sind Aufstocker wieso reden sie
über diese Menschen so dass ihnen das
Bürgergeld nicht
zusteht passt nicht zu einem
christlichen
Menschenbild und kranke Menschen die
eine Behinderung haben ein Handicap auch
die bekommen Bürgergeld weil sie eben
nicht in dieser Situation arbeiten
können so kann man nicht mit diesen
Menschen umgehen die auf ein Fundament
angewiesen sind nämlich einem sozialen
Netz was dieses Deutschland nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg schaffen wollte meine
Damen und
Herren und
deswegen haben Wort gehalten nicht nur
für diese fundamentalen Reformen die wir
in den letzten zwei Jahren auf den Weg
gebracht haben sondern eben in diesen
spannungsreichen und auffwühlenden
Zeiten genau das zu tun um Wort zu
halten was wir den Menschen auch
versprochen haben nämlich strukturbrüche
zu vermeiden durch starke
Haushaltspolitik dass wir es geschafft
haben existentielle sorgen den Menschen
auch in einer Situation zu geben am Ende
der Pandemie wo Russland die Ukraine
überfallen hat wo die Kriegsangst wächst
aber eben auch die sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen Herausforderung da
haben wir Halt gegeben und darauf können
wir doch auch stolz sein meine Damen und
Herren und ich finde gerade in diesen
Tagen wo wieder über Tarifpolitik
gesprochen wird Herr Bundeskanzler hat
die konstattierte Aktion eingeladen das
war gut mit den Gewerkschaften mit den
Arbeitgebern zu versuchen diese
strukturbrüche in unserem Land zu
vermeiden um gute Arbeitsplätze zu
erhalten und Investitionen
voranzubringen aber in dieser
konzertierten Aktion ist auch der
Grundstein für eine gute Tarifpolitik
gelegt worden weil nämlich und da hat
sich jede Gewerkschaft am Ende drauf
bezogen 3000€
äh Steu 3000 € Steuer und abgabenfi
gewesen ist das ist ein wichtiges
Zeichen gewesen und das zeigt dass
dieser Staat dass diese Regierung
Verantwortung trägt und das darf man
nicht schlecht reden in diesen Zeiten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ich sag das auch für eine Fraktion
die selbstbewusst ist manches was die
Regierung in ihrem Haushaltsentwurf auf
den Weg gebracht hat war auch für die
Mitglieder dieser Koalition für die
sozialdemokratische Fraktion
herausfordern das war nicht leicht weil
das ein oder andere doch in dem
Haushaltsentwurf stand das hat durchaus
zu sorgen das hat zu Verunsicherung in
den Wahlkreisen geführt und ich fand
manches was uns daf die Tür gekippt
wurde war schwer auch zu wieder zu
reparieren aber wir haben es geschafft
und das ist genau das was dieses
Parlament leistet was diese Koalition
leistet am Ende schaffen wir wieder
Vertrauen und es ist gelungen z.B im
Bereich des Sports im Bereich der
politischen Bildung bei der frei bei den
Freiwilligendiensten bei der
Migrationsberatung alles das haben wir
wieder korrigiert und auch die
Integration für den Arbeitsmarkt die
Qualifizierung das sind wichtige
Elemente gewesen die in diesem Haushalt
sich wiederfinden meine Damen und Herren
und es ist gut dass die Mitglieder
dieser Koalition auch deutliche
Korrekturen an diesem Haushalt
vorgenommen haben deswegen können wir
auch guten Gewissens heute diesem am
Freitag diesem Haushalt zustim meine
Damen und Herren und was der Unterschied
letztlich macht wir wenden uns den
Menschen zu ohne diese Abgeordneten wäre
es nicht möglich gewesen dass wir
endlich das Untersuchen worunter Kinder
und Jugendliche zu einem kleinen Teil
leiden aber was sie nach einer
coviderkrankung erleiden müssen jetzt
muss geklärt werden was können wir
diesen Kindern und Jugendlichen anbieten
das ist sozusagen ein Dienst am Menschen
am jungen Menschen genau diese Richtung
hat dies diese Koalition eingeschlagen
und der
Haushaltsgesetzgeber meine Damen und
Herren hat es korrigiert und vielleicht
mal
erinnernd an die heutige wirklich sehr
beeindruckende Holocaust Gedenkstunde
wir haben für jüdisches Leben noch mal
mehr Mittel bereitgestellt damit endlich
das aufhört was in dieses Land hätte nie
einziehen dürfen ein Antisemitismus der
sich gegen unsere jüdischen
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger richtet und
manchmal von den geistigen Brandstiftern
seit Jahren auch schon provoziert worden
ist meine Damen und Herren darauf bin
ich
stolz und wir haben wir haben diese
Dinge angepackt und deswegen können wir
uns auch besser erwähren den
Herausforderungen die diese
Demokratie die so schwer errichtet wurde
sich in diesen Tagen auch stellen muss
und die Voraussetzungen meine Damen und
Herren sind besser denn je Frau
Hasselmann hat hier vorgelesen in
welchen Gemeinden in welchen großen
Städten aber auch in den nächsten Tagen
Menschen sich nicht mehr mit diesem
geistigen Gehalt abfinden wollen in
diesem Land das ist wichtig aber es darf
nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
das sage ich auch bei diesen
Demonstrationen bleiben deswegen sage
ich zu allen die auf die Straße gehen
oder alle die sagen ich möchte
wiedersprechen gehen sie zu ihren
Nachbarn zu den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zu ihren Freunden und sagen den was es
bedeutet AFD zu wählen es geht nicht
darum zu sagen den die Wählerinnen und
Wähler anzuklagen sondern es geht darum
wie fahrlässig man sein würde wenn man
das
tut behinderte junge Menschen werden als
bel in diesem Land von her höcke
beschrieben und das werden nicht die
Ersten sein die eben auch in diese
Situation kommen sie wollen den
Mindestlohn abschaffen aber gleichzeitig
wollen sie die reichsten in diesem Land
entlasten sie sind gegen alle
Subventionen auch gegen die Subvention
für die Landwirte in diesem Land sie
wollen keine Subvention für gut und neue
Arbeitsplätze sie ruinieren das Land und
ich bin froh wenn diejenigen gegen sie
demonstrieren dass auch ihren Freunden
ihren Nachbarn und ihren Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sagen wir sind auf sie
angewiesen sein sie eine Stimme gegen
die Partei die dieses Land ruinieren
würde meine Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren und ich will zum Schluss auf
jeden Fall das ist wichtig auch noch mal
auf zwei grundsätzliche Fragen eingehen
die in den letzten Wochen auch die
öffentliche Diskussion beschäftigt haben
ich will etwas zum Kindergeld und zum
Kinderfreibetrag sagen wenn ich das mal
so offen von diesem reterpuls auch
erwähnen darf ich empfinde es als etwas
als ein trippenwitz der Geschichte dass
wir vor z Jahren es geschafft haben für
jedes Kind für jedes Kind 250 €
Kindergeld deutlich anzuh heben und erst
jetzt fällt das in der Diskussion auf
dass einige meinen jetzt geht es wieder
um den Kinderfreibetrag ich finde das
schade ich hätte mir letztlich anderes
gewünscht aber das ist auch an meine
Adresse an meine Adresse gerichtet aber
was ich sehr deutlich sagen will wir
haben es nicht nur getan weil jedes Kind
die gleiche Leistung erhalten muss
sondern wir haben es auch gemacht weil
im Koalitionsvertrag steht die Differenz
zwischen Kindergeld und Kinderfreibetrag
muss eingegrenzt werden und genau
deswegen haben wir das vor zwei Jahren
iner Koalition gemacht und ja ich geb zu
manche haben es nicht verstanden auch
als Vorleistung auf die
Kindergrundsicherung auch das war ein
wichtiges Element damals für die
Erhöhung des Kindergeldes aber ich werde
mich von diesem ich werde mich von
diesem Rednerpult gegen eins erwhren was
manche versuchen heute ich finde es
manchmal etwas perfide in die Diskussion
hin zu bringen als ob es eine
Verabredung gegeben hätte dass nach der
deutlichen Erhöhung des Kindergeldes
jetzt der Kinderfreibetrag dran ist ich
habe diese Verabredung nicht getroffen
und wir haben das unter den
Fraktionsvorsitzenden damals besprochen
und sie wissen genau Herr gesarei was
sie damals ja weil sie haben ja diese
Behauptung in die Welt gesetzt was Sie
für diesen Kinderfreibetrag auch
letztlich bekommen haben nämlich den
informations den inflations Ausgleich
für die besser verdienenden auch das
gehört meine Damen und Herren zur
Wahrheit mit dazu und ich finde eine
ordentliche Debatte muss dann auch
heißen wenn der Kinderfreibetrag
angepasst werden muss sage ich für meine
Fraktion dann muss auch das Kindergeld
erhöht werden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und Herr DM hat eine zweite
Sache angesprochen und die gehört in der
Tat zur politischen Grundsatzdebatte in
diesem Land mit dazu wie kann ein Land
was angewiesen ist auf einen modernen
auf einen aktiven auf einen starken
Staat wie kann dieser Staat in den
Umbrüchen am besten reagieren und da hat
meine Partei die Sozialdemokratische
Partei eine ganz Glas klare Antwort
gegeben auf der einen Seite muss die
Frage der ungleichen Vermögen der groß
Vermögen in diesem Land thematisiert
werden ich finde das ist da ist nichts
falsches dran es geht letztlich darum
die Solidarität auch der starken
Schultern in diesem Land immer wieder
anzusprechen und zum anderen geht es
darum wie konkurrieren wir mit den
Ländern auf der Welt die alles dafür tun
von uns
Industriearbeitsplätze abzuwerben mit
großen Investitionen mit letztlich
großen Investition Entscheidungen und da
finde ich muss die Antwort sein das kann
Deutschland genauso gut das muss in
Deutschland auch in nächster Zukunft
noch stärker sein weil sonst werden uns
die Industriearbeitsplätze ABH kommen
und die leihragenden sind die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer deswegen auch für dieses
Haushaltsjahr was wir am Ende der Woche
beschließen werden ich warne vor einem
Dilemma der Bundeskanzler hat hat
zurecht die große Unterstützung die
Deutschland von Anfang an der Ukraine
geleistet hat hervorgehoben und
appelliert an die europäischen Länder
Gleiches zu tun aber es gibt auch noch
etwas zweites an das man appellieren
muss wir dürfen nicht die notwendige
Unterstützung der Ukraine ausspielen
gegen andere notwendige Investitionen in
diesem Land beides gehört zusammen und
dafür bin ich für einen modernen und
letztlich auch starken stat meine Damen
und Herren und deswegen Herr März wenn
Sie bereit sind ich möchte sie als
Fraktionsvorsitzender darum bitten es
noch mal zu überlegen auch vor dem
Hintergrund ihrer Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidentinnen die da gesagt
haben auch die Länder wollen in Zukunft
starke Investition machen und wollen
sich im Primat der Politik nicht ein
wenn Sie bereit sind mit uns über eine
Reform der Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz
noch in dieser Legislaturperiode zu
reden sind wir davon offen ich lade Sie
dazu ein überlegen Sie sich Ihr nein
noch mal ich glaube dem Land meine Damen
und Herren würde es gut tun wir haben
einen guten Haushalt vorgelegt und es
gibt am Ende eine weitere gute Nachricht
die vorläufige Haushaltsführung endet
mit dieser
und geht zurück an die die vom Souverän
damit beauftragt wurden dieses Mandat
wer wir mit Kraft Vernunft und Verstand
zum Wohle unseres Landes ausüben vielen
Dank Rolf Mützen der Vorsitzende der SPD
Fraktion am Ende noch mal mit einem
Gesprächsangebot in Richtung Union und
friedrichz bezüglich der Schuldenregel
und deren Veränderung am Anfang hat er
eingestanden W die Koalition sich getan
hat im vergangenen Jahr und hat dann
aber doch in seiner Rede wieder darauf
hingewiesen dass eine weitere sagen mal
er nennt es Grundsatzdebatte aber andere
werden es als streitwerden auf diese
Koalition zukommt nämlich in Sachen
Kinder Freibetrag und
kindergeldtin für die
AF hier das Land ruinieren würden und
zwar das Zitat
dieterehmer uen in die Bundesregierung
verloren Zitat Ende und das sagte nich
der Arbeitgeber Präsident reiner Dulger
der fazz und muss sagen auch bei Ihnen
auf der Regierungsbank sollten
mittlerweile die Alarmsignale doch
längst angekommen sein wo bleibt
eigentlich Herr Bundeskanzler ihr
Respekt von dem sie ja im Wahlkampf so
viel gesprochen haben gegenüber den
Bauern und Bürgern die über Generationen
hinweg hier diesen Wirtschaftsmotor
Deutschland am Laufen gehalten haben und
wenn man kein Respekt hat und hat dann
liebt man dieses Land auch nicht und das
zeigen sie jeden Tag mit ihrer
Bundesregierung und es sind eben genau
die Menschen die uns alle hier gewählt
haben um eine Politik für Deutschland zu
machen sie machen Politik aber für wen
machen Sie eigentlich Politik Frau
Hasselmann für die Beratungsunternehmen
und die Millionen schweren Verträge im
Rahmen der Energiewende für ihre
Rüstungslobby für diese Menschen ist
Milliarden Euro an Geld da aber nicht
für die einfachen Bürger für diejenigen
die jeden Tag hart arbeiten und meine
Damen und Herren jeder Steuereuro muss
erstmal verdient werden erst dann können
wir hier darüber entscheiden wo er gut
investiert werden kann und ich kann nur
sagen dass ihre Schwerpunkte eben nicht
nachvollziehbar sind denn die Wirtschaft
Lage wirtschaftliche Lage in Deutschland
sie ist desolat dazu einige Eckpunkte
Deutschland ist der einzige G7 Staat
ohne Wirtschaftswachstum Deutschland ist
im Z Halbjahr 2023 in eine Rezession
gerutscht die Gründe dafür sind hohe
Energie kosten die grüne Transformation
und schlechte Standortbestimmungen die
Ernsthaftigkeit der Lage ist
offensichtlich warum reduzieren sie
selbst als Bundesregierung und auch das
ifointitut bereits die
wirtschaftswachstumserwartung für
2024 und ja jetzt kommen sie wieder mit
den internationalen Märkten und die
Kriege die wir leider wieder zu beklagen
haben zu diesen haben wir als
Alternative für Deutschland unsere
Position oft genug dargelegt wir
brauchen Frieden und wir wie auch die
Bürger wollen keinen Kampf mehr von
Systemen und von Ideologien und genau
diese Kriege sind eben nicht
verantwortlich dafür dass sie als
Bundesregierung die von Ihnen selbst
verursachten Standortnachteile weiter in
Kauf nehmen schauen sie endlich über den
Tellerrand hinaus auch wenn es
anstrengend ist und sicherlich für Sie
auch enttäuschend ist die Firmen wandern
ab oder wollen abwandern und wenn man
als Unternehmer ständig rote Zahlen
schreibt gibt es nicht die die
Möglichkeit mehr Ausgaben als Einnahmen
zu verursachen ein Unternehmer muss sich
auch an geltende Gesetze halten und kann
sie nicht einfach umgehen das kann nur
diese Bundesregierung indem sie die
Schuldenbremse die vor staatsverfolgung
schützen sein soll einfach aussetzt bei
dieser wirtschaftlichen Bilanz ist das
verantwortungslos und vor allen Dingen
staatsschädigend und wir haben es
gesehen im letzten Haushalt
verfassungswidrig was sie hier in diesem
Land betreiben
Werte Kollegen die deutsche Wirtschaft
lebt von Exporten und guten
wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen allen
Ländern darüber sind wir uns denke ich
in diesem Haus einig aber nun brechen
selbst die Exporte nach China und in die
USA ein wie kann sich eigentlich die
Arbeit für die Bürger überhaupt noch
lohnen wenn ihnen die Grundlage genommen
wird wie viele wollen sie in die
Alimentierung durch den Staat eigentlich
noch treiben für einige scheint sich
mittlerweile Erwerbsarbeit dank
Bürgergeld kaum noch zu lohnen und bei
all diesen Befunden senden sie als
ampelakteure weder Demut noch Einsicht
aus dafür treiben sie einen Spalt weiter
in die Gesellschaft und vor allen Dingen
sie drehen die Verantwortung um das ist
eigentlich der absolute Hammer den wir
aktuell hier erleben der
Bundesfinanzminister Linder sprach am
Wochenende davon das Programm der AFD
würde Deutschland wirtschaftlich
ruinieren und Herr Habig liegt nach die
AFD sei Gift für den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland sehen sie eigentlich nicht
wer das wirkliche Gift in die Land ist
das sehen die Bürger jeden Tag indem sie
ihre Rechnung nicht mehr bezahlen können
indem immer mehr Unternehmen pleite
gehen indem immer mehr Unternehmen
abwandern und immer mehr Bürger die Nase
gestrichen voll haben von den Bauern von
den Handwerkern und von Mittelstand in
diesem Land sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren und frelmann dann stellen sie
sich H hin und beten wieder das große
Lied der Demokratie nie wieder ist jetzt
da gebe ich ihn recht nie wieder ist
jetzt auch indem man staatskonforme
Medienhäuser quasi als zweite stasie
aufbaut und gegen die Opposition
einsetzt auch das ist nie wieder jetzt
das hatten wir alles schon und das
erinnert an die dunkelsten Zeiten
unserer Geschichte und wir sind nicht
nervös die einzigen die nervös sind das
sind sie und die SPD vor allem wenn ich
an die Wahlen dieses Jahr in Deutschland
denke an die Europawahl an die
Landtagswahl in Sachsen brandenbrück und
Thüringen sie bekommen die Quittung und
zwar vom Souverän vom deutschen Bürger
und darauf freue ich mich darauf freue
ich
mich hätten sie wirklich in dieser
ganzen Debatte und Kampagne mit
Korrektiv hätten sie diese Leute noch
mal recherchieren lassen bei kumex oder
bei nordstream da erwarten wir Ergebnis
hier im Parlament die sie immer noch
schuldig geblieben sind wer diese
Terrorakte durchgeführt hat genauso die
Geldverschwendung und bei diesen ganzen
Problemen die kumex verursacht hat in
diesem Sinne meine Damen und Herren
Werte Kollegen sage ich einst die
deutsche Wirtschaft lebt von den
Exporten und guten wirtschaftlichen
Beziehung und wir als AFD werden da uns
dafür wieder einsetzen dass Deutschland
als Wirtschaftsstandort attraktiv ist
und dass Deutschland vor allen Dingen
endlich wieder das verdient was es hat
eine ordentliche und vernünftige
Regierung vielen Dank
tin gruppaler Partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzender der AFD in der
Generaldebatte des Deutschen Bundestages
die seit äft und die auch noch
mindestens eine Stunde laufen wird und
hier sehr intensiv beobachtet wird von
vielen Gästen auf der Besuchertribüne
unter anderem haben wir vorhin gesehen
Gäste aus Würzburg Karnevalisten sind
hier von einem Traditionsverein die
demnächst richtig Fasching feiern aber
heute erstmal sich informieren Andreas a
Pult für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen einer der stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzend hab es glaube ich in
zwei reden heute hier gesehen in der
Rede von Frau Weidel in der Rede von
Herrn kropaler Feinde unserer liberalen
Demokratie die die Eckpfeiler unseres
Grundgesetzes die Freiheit und die
Gleichheit aller Menschen offen in Frage
stellen wir haben viel über das Treffen
in Potzdam gehört es braucht gar nicht
nur das weil wir es auch ansonsten sehr
sehr offensichtlich auf dem Tisch haben
20 bis 30% der Bevölkerung will Björn
höcke aus dem Land schaffen so hat er es
im dezember
2023 gesagt die Videos sind online jeder
kann es sehen jeder kann es wissen man
möchte man muss es nur wissen wollen und
um den Kampf um unsere Demokratie
erfolgreich führen zu können brauchen
wir alle in diesem Land wir brauchen als
erstes brauchen wir starke
Sicherheitsbehörden die zu hinschauen
die die zuschauen was passiert und
dokumentieren was los ist wir brauchen
weites Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler die herausarbeiten z.B
dass ihre Partei das Umfeld ihrer Partei
um konkret zu sein das Umfeld von
beratrix von Storch ganz konkret von
Russland finanziert wurde dreimal wurde
ich verklagt von dem Umfeld ihrer Partei
weil ich das offen sage dreimal haben
Gerichte es bestätigt dreimal haben sie
gesagt ich sage es zurecht ich sag's
hier noch mal sie das Umfeld ihrer
Partei wird finanziert von Oligarchen
aus Putins
Russland wir brauchen diese
Wissenschaftler wir brauchen aber auch
die freie Presse die aufdeckt was da los
ist bei Ihnen und dass sie genau das
hier wieder in Frage Gestellen zeigt wie
wichtig das ist wir brauchen die freie
Presse wenn sie sich mit rechtsextremen
treffen wenn Sie die Deportation von
Millionen von Menschen planen ganz
konkret durch deklinieren und wir
brauchen nicht zuletzt Hunderttausende
von Menschen auf den Straßen um
sicherzustellen dass Sie nicht die
deutungs Hoheit über unsere Gesellschaft
erlangen können deswegen bin ich so
dankbar über die Mitte der Gesellschaft
die sich aufgemacht hat genau das jetzt
auch ganz öffentlich deutlich zu machen
ich bin dankbar für 350 000 Menschen in
Berlin über 100.000 in Düsseldorf und in
Hamburg aber ich bin fast noch
beeindruckter
über 5000 Menschen in Düren über 4000
Menschen in Singen über 100 Menschen in
saahlfeld über die 500 Menschen in
Luckenwalde über die 400 Menschen in
all das sind Menschen die ganz klar
sagen wir stehen auf gegen diesen
Rechtsextremismus und dass sie es jetzt
versuchen als großstadtphänomen als von
der Regierung gesteuert darzustellen
zeigt wie viel Angst sie haben zeigt wie
nervös sie sind dass für sie jeden Tag
deutlicher wird dass das nicht weiter
akzeptiert wird und dass jeden Tag
deutlicher wird dass sie aufs ngste
zusammenarbeiten rechtsextreme
identitäre Leute aus der AFD und ih ihre
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
zusammen am Tisch zusammen planend das
was dieses Land Zug Grunde richten soll
das was wir heute morgen beklagt haben
was sie jetzt wieder ganz konkret planen
und ein zweiter Grund es gibt einen
zweiten Grund warum sie so nervös sind
weil eine These gebrochen wurde nämlich
dass die Rechtsextremen in diesem Land
die Mehrheit der Menschen stellen das
wollen sie weis machen das Gegenteil ist
bewiesen Hunderttausende gehen auf die
Straße um delich zu machen diese These
trifft nicht zu die Mehrheit unseres
Landes lehnt diesen Rechtsextremismus
entschieden ab heute sagen wir nie
wieder und wer sagt nie wieder der muss
wissen was damals war das ist die
Voraussetzung dafür deswegen haben wir
heute an die
Greultaten des Nationalsozialismus
erinnert und deswegen sorgen wir mit
diesem Haushalt mit dem was wir tun dass
in ganz Deutschland stetig daran
erinnert werden kann wir haben bereits
im letzten Jahr ein großes Paket über 80
Millionen Euro gepackt um die
kzgedenkstätten in Deutschland stärker
zu unterstützen und wir haben jetzt in
diesem Haushalt noch mal nachgelegt noch
mal Geld zur Verfügung gestellt so haben
wir z.B die Gedenkstätten Stätte
deutscher Widerstand die Stiftung
Denkmal für die ermordeten Juden Europas
die Stiftung niedersächsische
gedenkstätdten bergenbsen und andere mit
noch mal knapp 2 Millionen Euro gestärkt
weil wir wissen wie notwendig es ist
dass ich Menschen in ganz Deutschland
mit diesen Fragen
auseinandersetzen und wir stärken mit
dem was wir machen kulturelles Leben in
ganz Deutschland mit dem
amateurmusikfond von der blaskabelle
Kapelle bis zum Musikfest in ganz
Deutschland mit dem Festival förderfond
ebenfalls wir unterstützen weiter das
UNESCO welterbezeche Zollverein weil uns
diese Geschichte wichtig ist die
aufrecht zu erhalten und gleichzeitig
das Haus der Kulturen der Welt und das
Heimaten Festival weil dort
aufgearbeitet und gezeigt wird dass es
Heimat in Deutschland gibt und zwar im
Plural in Vielfalt weil wir alle
gemeinsam hier zusammen leben danke
ihnen Andreas aud audr pardon
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der
Fraktion m die Grünen in der
Generaldebatte und jetzt haben wir mal
zusammengerechnet die Redner die wir
hier im Moment auf der Liste haben da
kommen wir schon auf locker noch
Minuten aber
er in der FDP und der Generalsekretär
der Vortragen von Zahlen das haben wir
heute gesehen es geht in erster Linie um
die Politik die dahinter steht und diese
Politik muss immer im Einklang mit der
Realität im Land sein und wie sieht
diese Realität aus wir haben enorme
wirtschaftspolitische Herausforderung
wir haben enorme finanzpolitische
Herausforderung in unserem Land das
Thema Migration wird uns noch eine ganze
Weile beschäftigen und wir haben
zentrale außen und sicherheitspolitische
Fragen die wir noch in diesem Jahr
beantworten müssen es ist schon mehrmals
heute angesprochen was passiert wenn wir
Ende dieses Jahres oder Anfang nächsten
Jahres möglicherweise im Weißen Haus
einen anderen Präsidenten haben einen
Präsidenten der uns dann sagt
beispielsweise der Krieg in der Ukraine
kümmert euch lieber Europäer selbst
liebe Europäer kümmert euch selbst um
die Sicherheitsarchitektur in Europa das
hat ja nicht nur außen und
sicherheitspolitische folgen sondern
eine mögliche Präsidentschaft von Herrn
Trump hätte auch Handels und
wirtschaftspolitische folgen und
deswegen ist das auch außerordentlich
wichtig dass wir in Deutschland und
Europa auf diese Herausforderung
vorbereitet
sind wenn
wir wenn wir in dieser wirtschaftlich
schwierigen Situation ein starkes Land
bleiben wollen und den Wohlstand in
unserem Land bewahren und mehren wollen
dann müssen wir dringend den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland stärken
und Deutschland wieder fit für die
Zukunft machen der wirtschaftliche
Erfolg unseres Landes ist von zentraler
Bedeutung für unsere Zukunft meine Damen
und Herren und ich will ihnen das auch
an dieser Stelle ganz klar sagen wer wer
ökologische Transformation will wer
funktionierende sich wer funktionierende
soziale Sicherungssysteme will muss die
Rahmenbedingung dafür schaffen dass die
Menschen Unternehmen und ebe in unserem
Land in erster Linie entlastet werden
und nicht belastet
werden vielleicht hat es der ein oder
andere in der Politik auch vergessen
aber wir erinnern gerne daran es muss
erst erwirtschaftet werden bevor
überhaupt verteilt werden kann meine
Damen und
her und ich will die Gelegenheit nutzen
um auch zu verdeutlichen wie wichtig in
diesem Zusammenhang eine solide
Finanzpolitik ist wir haben heute
Inflation im Euroraum wir haben eine
andere Zinsentwicklung als noch vor
einigen Jahren
wir haben Krieg in Europa wer in dieser
schwierigen Situation eine
Schuldenpolitik will beschädigt den
Wirtschafts und Finanzstandort
Deutschland und macht einen großen
politischen
Fehler alles
muss alles muss heutzutage in
Deutschland nachhaltig sein das ist auch
gut so aber erstaunlicherweise wird
gerne in der Politik vergessen dass auch
Finanzpolitik nachhaltig sein muss das
heißt keine Belastungen für für die
Zukunft und ke Schuldenpolitik auf
Kosten künftiger Generation meine Damen
und
Herren wir dürfen keine Kosten keine
Schulden machen auf Kosten künftiger
Generation auf Schuldenbergen kann man
keine Zukunft bauen und er recht nicht
die Krisen dieser Zeit lösen und meine
Damen und Herren das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts hat
selbstverständlich einiges verändert
dieses Urteil bedeutet aber lieber Rolf
Mütze nicht nicht dass wir die
Schuldenbremse umgehen dieses Urteil
bedeutet auch nicht dass wir die
Schulden Bremse schleifen sondern dieses
Urteil bedeutet dass wir die
Schuldenbremse in diesem Land Stärken
lieber Rolf und das ist die zentrale
Botschaft des
Urteils und ich will dir das auch ganz
klar sagen lieber Rolf weil wir uns auch
sehr lange kennen und dich auch sehr
schätze aber es ist schon bemerkenswert
die Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse steht
auch so im Koalitionsvertrag
gelegentlich ist es auch gut sich den
Koalitionsvertrag anzuschauen und sich
hier hinzustellen und einfach Herrn März
Angebot zu machen über die Umgehung der
Schuldenbremse zu reden finde ich
bemerkenswert lieber
Rolf wir sind wir sind beide
reheinländer ich habe sehr viel
Verständnis für die Art des Humors hier
und von daher ist es alles in Ordnung
geschenkt alles geschenkt meine Damen
und Herren meine Damen und Herren ich
will ich will aber an dieser Stelle noch
mal eine Sache deutlich machen denn das
wird immer der Unterschied bleiben
zwischen uns wir haben ein anderes
Staatsverständnis als ihr und das ist
der Unterschied das ist der große
Unterschied für uns ist das Geld der
Steuers Steuerzahlers nicht eine
beliebige verteilungsmasse für uns ist
es übrigens auch nicht das Geld des
Staates sondern das Geld der Bürgerin
und Bürger und das ist der große
Unterschied und wenn wir sagen solide
Finanzpolitik und wenn wir sagen solide
Finanzpolitik dann heißt es in erster
Linie Respekt vor der Leistung der
Steuerzahlerin und Steuerzahler in
diesem Land das muss auch gelegentlich
wieder in diesem Haus deutlicher gesagt
werden meine Damen und Herren der
nächste Haushalt wird kommen die
nächsten intensive Debatten stehen auch
vor der Tür wir werden uns für die
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse einsetzen
und wir werden Steuererhöhungen
bekämpfen und vermeiden wir sind seit
vielen Jahren in Deutschland ein
hochsteuerland Ja wenn Sie mir das nicht
glauben ich kann Ihnen nur empfehlen
sich dort die die Tabellen der oszd
anzuschauen wir sind seit vielen Jahren
in Deutschland ein hochsteuerland in
diesem Land sind die Belastungen für die
Menschen für die Betriebe für die
Unternehmen außerordentlich hoch und wer
in dieser Situation eine Schuldenpolitik
macht macht nicht nur einen Fehler
sondern das ist gerade Gift für den
Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und ich will auch an der
Stelle noch einmal weil das ja auch eine
haushaltspolitische Debatte ist
der deutsche Staat hat keine
einnahmeprobleme das Problem sind die
Ausgaben meine Damen und Herren und da
müssen wir ran und wenn wir und wenn wir
über die Ausgaben reden dann müssen wir
selbstverständlich auch über das Thema
Haushaltskonsolidierung reden und ich
will euch noch eine Sache sagen wenn ich
schon hier vorne stehe wir werden auch
gemeinsam über die Zukunft des
Sozialstaates reden müssen denn das ist
eine zentrale Frage der sozialen
Gerechtigkeit in diesem Land der Moderne
funktionierende Sozialstaat darf nicht
nur gerecht sein gegenüber denjenigen
die die Hilfe brauchen sondern auch
gerecht sein gegenüber denjenigen die
die Hilfe finanzieren meine Damen und
Herren vielen
dankan jarai ist bundestagmglied im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss hat hier natürlich
eher in der Rolle des Generalsekretärs
seiner Partei gesprochen und das ist ja
hier die generelle Generaldebatte wo
normalerweise Opposition und Koalition
aufeinander prallen aber in den
vergangenen Minuten haben wir auch
festgestellt dass es innerhalb der
Koalition den einen oder anderen
Unterschied in der Auffassung zu
diversen Politikfeldern gibt ich sage
nur Schuldenregel da ist die FDP
ganzlich andere Auffassung als Grüne und
SPD und auch beim Thema Kinderfreibetrag
und Kindergeld das ist ein Thema das
Rolf Mütze nicht in diese Debatte
reingetragen hat wenn wir möglicherweise
auch noch den einen oder anderen
Widerspruch aus den reinen der FDP hören
vielleicht aber auch nicht K radomsk
spricht jetzt für die Fraktion CDU CSU
und sie ist die erste von mehreren
Mitgliedern des Haushaltsausschusses die
jetzt in der nächsten Zeit kommen W
beauftragten reicht im Bereich der
Kultur bleibt die Filmförderung ein
Sorgenkind die Filmindustrie fordert
seit 2022 eine dringend benötigte und
zudem versprochene Reform aber statt
eine Reform in Angriff zu nehmen wird
weiterhin an Symbolpolitik festgehalten
wie dem sogenannten green culture diese
Fokussierung auf symbolische Maßnahmen
lenkt von den eigentlichen
Herausforderungen ab die der
Kulturstandort Deutschland gegenwärtig
zu bewältigen hat der erste Leitfaden
aus dem Green culture desk zu
Theaterproduktion zeigt bereits was
Betreiber von Theaterbauten technisch
empfohlen wird es wird empfohlen auf
Bewegungsmelder und Zeitschalter für die
Beleuchtung umzusteigen bei Wärmepumpen
soll auf Luftwärmepumpen anstatt
Erdwärmepumpen umgestallt werden das
Dach soll begrünt werden Regenwasser
soll aufgefangen werden und auf
kondensationswasser soll geachtet werden
diese technischen Maßnahmen sind
sicherlich gut im Baubereich aufgehoben
aber sie haben tatsächlich überhaupt
nichts mit Kultur im engeren Sinne zu
tun und das große Ziel dieser
Regulierung scheint der gesamte
kulturelle Sektor zu sein wir haben
daher gefordert dass der Ansatz green
culture desk bei der Staatsministerin
gestrichen wird die Koalition hat das
abgelehnt nun zur Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für Migration
Flüchtlinge und Integration sowie
Antirassismus die Vielfalt ihrer
Aufgabenbereiche ist beeindruckend und
beeindruckend sind auch die Ausgaben für
die
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit
750.000 € für das kommende Jahr und nach
eigenen Angaben hat die Staatsministerin
im
Jahr 23 40% dieser Mittel für Social
Media Aktivitäten
genutzt schaut man sich das einmal
genauer an stellt man fest zwei bis drei
Posts pro Woche sind glaube ich eine
eher unterdurchschnittliche
Aktivität
auch es geht noch weiter auch bei der
Pressearbeit kann man die
Staatsministerin als ehermäßig aktiv
bezeichnen mit einer bis maximal zwei
Pressemitteilungen pro Monat im letzten
halben Jahr das und das bei einer
Staatsministerin die einen so wichtigen
und umfassenden Aufgabenbereich betreut
im Dezember fällt dann eine
Pressemitteilung mit dem Titel
kontrollquittung schafft mehr
Transparenz bei der Bundespolizei ins
Auge zur Erklärung für alle Anwesenden
künftig haben alle von der Bundespolizei
kontrollierten das Recht auf eine
sogenannte
kontrollquittung warum die Bundespolizei
kontrolliert beispielsweise in Zügen
Bahnhöfen oder an Flughäfen das schafft
nach Meinung der Staatsministerin
transparent gegen rassistische
Vorurteile und
Diskriminierung liebe Frau
Staatsministerin leider sind sie nicht
anwesend aber vielleicht können die
Kollegen aus dem Kanzleramt Ihnen das
mitteilen ich bin der Meinung dass
Rassismus entschuldigung wo ist sie also
schreien sie doch nicht so rein die ist
doch gar nicht anwesend so ich bin der
Meinung dass Rassismus und
Diskriminierung in diesem Land keinen
Platz haben dürfen die von ihn gelobte
kontrollquittung schafft keine
Transparenz sondern Bürokratie und
letzten Endes ein Misstrauen gegen die
Bundespolizei und wenn sie sich dann
auch noch rühmen eine wissenschaftliche
Evaluation für diese Maßnahme umgesetzt
zu haben dann muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen das ist schaufensterpolitik der
Sonderklasse wenn Sie selbst am Ende der
pressemisteilung nämlich feststellen die
meisten kontrollen finden gar nicht
durch die Bundespolizei statt sondern
durch die
Landespolizei und kommen wir am Ende ich
muss mich ja beeilen frau Präsidentin
zum Etat des Bundeskanzlers der mit 200
Millionen angesetzt ist und allein davon
die Hälfte sind für den Erweiterungsbau
des Kanzleramtes vorgesehen wir gehen
genau wie der Bundesrechnungshof davon
aus dass dieses Geld nicht reichen wird
und haben die Bundesregierung
aufgefordert den Erweiterungsbau zu
stoppen leider hat die Mehrheit im
Ausschuss dieses abgelehnt
zusammenfassend stelle ich fest die
Legislaturperiode ist zur Hälfte vorbei
sie setzen falsche Prioritäten bei
Investitionen und gesetzesentwrfen sie
haben den die Ernst der Lage nicht
erkannt deutschland braucht Reformen und
eine Bundesregierung die diese an vielen
Dank K Radomski aus der Unionsfraktion
hat die migrationsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung re all baliado waren
vermisst die hat aber über weite
Strecken diese Generaldebatte durchaus
verfolgt das müssen wir dann auch mal
kurz loswerden und hier geht's jetzt
weiter mit Achim Post ist
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der SPD
Fraktion da zuständig für den Bereich
Haushalt und außerdem ist er noch
Landesvorsitzender der SPD in
nordreinwestf Liebe Kolleginen und
Kollegen meine seh Damen und Herren es
ist gut dass wir in dieser Woche den
Haushalt beraten und beschließen und es
ist auch gut dass wir in diesem
Zusammenhang über unser Land reden über
Deutschland über die größte
Volkswirtschaft in Europa in Zeiten von
großen Herausforderungen und wir tun das
im Jahr des 75 geburtstags des
Grundgesetzes der besten Verfassung die
wir in diesem Land je hat hatten und
haben und wir tun das
angesichts beeindruckender
Demonstrationen im ganzen Land
Demonstrationen der Kollege D hat es
gesagt der Stärke für ein weltoffenes
und europäisches Deutschland wir tun das
angesichts von Demonstrationen der
Stärke die für Zuversicht und
Zusammenhalt kämpfen und wenn ich mal
nach rechts nach ganz rechts in diesem
Hause gucke schauen Sie sich um in
diesem Land in kleinen und den großen
Städten im Norden im Süden und Westen
und im Osten das ist Deutschland das ist
unsere Demokratie das ist die Mehrheit
das ist die Mitte liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und lassen Sie und lassen sie
uns lassen Sie uns über diese
haushaltswoche Reden liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen zu jeder haushaltswoche zu
jeder Plenardebatte gehört auch Streit
das auch gut so inhaltlicher Streit
zugespitzter Streit aber zur Demokratie
gehört auch die zweite Seite der
Medaille nämlich Kompromiss und Konsens
und deshalb der Kollege märz ist gerade
nicht mehr da ich bin und bleibe
zuversichtlich liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union dass wir da sie
auch dafür sind dass Wachstum in diesem
Land generiert wird ich bleibe
zuversichtlich dass wir was hinbekommen
beim Vermittlungsausschuss für das
wachstumschancengesetz wir sind s gar
nicht so weit davon entfernt wir sind
gar nicht so weit davon entfernt einen
Kompromiss zu erzielen also ich setze
darauf dass sie vernünftig sind
vernünftig bleiben und auch hier alles
dafür tun dass wir Wachstum in
Deutschland generieren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und ein zweiter Punkt sie
sind doch auch dafür dass die werhafte
Demokratie gestärkt wird ich habe keinen
Zweifel daran lassen Sie uns doch
zusammen darüber reden wie man das
höchste deutsche Gericht das
Bundesverfassungsgericht besser schützen
kann gegen Umtriebe von ganz rechts und
ich bin auch sicher dass Sie da auch
nicht einfach Nein sagen werden sondern
sich genau überlegen ob sie mitmachen
oder nicht ich setze darauf dass Sie
mitmachen und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn wir dabei sind wir alle
wollen starke Kommunen wir alle wollen
handlungsfähige Kommunen sie doch auch
ich habe gehört es gibt auch CDU
Bürgermeister und CDU Bürgermeisterin
und auch in der CSU gibt's viele
Bürgermeisterin die brauchen alle
finanzielle Mittel deshalb überlegen sie
noch mal ganz genau ob sie nicht
mitmachchen wollen beim altchulenf
lieber Kolleginnen und Kollegen und wenn
wir über diesen Haushalt reden muss man
über reden dieser Haushalt gibt
Sicherheit
Investitionssicherheit
rekordinvestitionen von über 70
Milliarden Euro liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und dieser Haushalt organisiert
soziale Sicherheit und der
Arbeitsminister wird bald einen
Vorschlag machen um das Rentenniveau zu
stabilisieren und zwar über einen
längeren Zeitraum das ist gut für
Deutschland das ist gut für die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner und das ist
auch gut für dieses
Land
und komm wir was ich vorhin gehört habe
von Seiten der AFD dass man sich
überlegt vielleicht sogar mehr aus der
Europäischen Union auszutreten dexit ist
das Wort ich empfehle nur einmal ganz
kurz einen Blick nach
Großbritannien von allen Versprechungen
die diejenigen die das Land rausgeführt
haben aus der Europäischen Union es gäbe
mehr Wohlstand es GBE ein stärkeres
Großbritannien es gebe mehr
Arbeitsplätze es gebe weniger Migranten
ist ein einziges versprechen ein
einziges in die Tat umgesetzt worden der
Pass ist wieder der Pass des Vereinigten
Königreiches der ist jetzt blau und
nicht mehr der Pass der Europäischen
Union der ist rot das ist das einzige
was sie umgesetzt haben und deshalb kann
ich nur sagen das ist ein Programm der
wohlstandsvernichtung der
arbeitsplatzvernichtung und würde
Deutschland in die Isolierung in
Deutschland und Europa und weltweit
führen Liebe Kollege und Kollegen
deshalb kann ich nur allen raten gucken
Sie genau hin was diese Partei
vorschlicht das geht so
nicht und letzter Punkt ich bin
zuversichtlich sicher und zwar bei allen
demokratischen Parteien bei der
Regierung bei den ampelfraktionen und
auch bei der größten
Oppositionsfraktion dass wir in diesem
wichtigen Jahr 2024 in einem Jahr der
Entscheidungen alles dafür tun werden
dass die Demokratie und Menschenfeinde
verlieren und dass die wehrhafte die
lebendige die tolerante die liberale
Demokratie in Deutschland gewinnen wird
in diesem Sinne alles Gute schönen
Dank der nächste Redner ist Martin Erwin
Renner für die AFD
[Applaus]
Fraktion ja hochverehrtes Präsidium ich
begrüße die demokratische Fraktion der
Alternative für Deutschland aber
natürlich auch alle anderen Fraktionen
hier im Hause vor allen die neue
Sozialistische Einheitspartei
Deutschlands die
nsed die sich hier so gerne als die
alleinigen Demokraten gerieren in
Wirklichkeit aber zueist gegenteilig
handeln wir sprechen über den Haushalt
der Bundes Beauftragten für Kultur und
Medien der dam ige Bundespräsident
Johannes Rau sagte im Mai 2003
richtigerweise wenn wir Kultur nur für
die Sahne auf dem Kuchen halten und
nicht für die Hefe im Teig dann
verstehen wir die Politik und unsere
Gesellschaft falsch der Mann hatte Recht
die Ampel und alle Parteien der neuen
Sozialistischen Einheitspartei
Deutschland verstehen unsere
Gesellschaft nicht nur falsch in
Wirklichkeit wollen sie eine neue
Gesellschaft mit dem neuen Menschen
schaffen ihre Politik bewirkt eine
Unkultur des Hasses der Entmenschlichung
und der Spaltung sie D defieren eine
demokratische Oppositionspartei als
extremistische Rattenfänger und
entwürdigen damit auch deren Wähler zu
Ratten oder auch zu Schmeißfliegen die
sich auf einen
Haufen
verdauungsendprodukte versammeln das ist
doch ziemlich Stck so eine Zuschreibung
selbst für einen Zimmermann oder
Zwietracht Misstrauen Argwohn Spaltung
Bespitzelung und Verdächtigung das ist
die Saat der linksgrünen bolche wen
Unkultur die auch mit den kulturetas der
vergangenen Jahre bestens aufgewachsen
ist nehmen wir exemplarisch die
chronisch linksdrehenden
schouraktivisten von Korrektiv die
wurden in Jahre
2023 mit
600 Euro aus der Staatskasse bezahlt
Bund und
NRW von diesem selbstendantten
Medienhaus hört man eigentlich nicht
viel und plötzlich kreieren Sie ein Spuk
und Gruselmärchen aufgegriffen und
aufgebauscht durch die klassischen
Mädchen bisschen framing bisschen was
hinzuerfunden und so weiter und die im
Endstadium ihres Niedergangs befindliche
ampelregierung dankte herzlich und rief
sofort ihre Steuergeld finanzierten
ökosozial ischen Apparatschik Apparate
zu Demonstrationen auf Horka wir haben
es gefunden den Stein der weißen und
wieder einmal das Totalversagen der
gebündelen mainstreammien die sich wie
morali Ban mit dieser Thematik
beschäftigt haben der über Jahrzehnte
üpig gemessete linksapparat der varia
wuchert in immer größeren Dimensionen
und verteidigt so seine errungene
kulturelle Hegemonie in unsere
Gesellschaft sie haben man sicher alle
Antonio grramschi gelesen der hat das
schon so beschrieben meine Damen und
Herren kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss ich
komm zum Schluss es ist hoch an der Zeit
dass alle diese Fördertöpfe im
Bundeshaushalt gestrichen werden und wir
von der Alternative für Deutschland
werden die spülmeister sein alerta
alerta AFD ist
da
martinenner war das hier für die AFD
Fraktion nächste Rednerin ist nun Paula
pierchotter sie sitzt im
Haushaltsausschuss hat in dieser Woche
also viel zu tun und ist Mitglied der
Grünen im
Bundestag sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen 2024 ist
auch das Jahr wichtiger Landtagswahlen
in Ostdeutschland und deswegen steigt
auch gerade wieder die Frequenz steiler
Thesen zu Ostdeutschland in den
deutschen Politik Podcast die vielleicht
nicht normalerweise bekannt sind für die
größte ostdeutschlandkpetenz und da
gab's neulich unter anderem so ein Satz
im Podcast Machtwechsel die
Bundesregierung versucht sich die
Stimmen in Ostdeutschland damit zu
kaufen dass sie den ostdeutschen teure
Arbeitsplätze hinstellt z.B in Magdeburg
mit Intel meine Damen und Herren nichts
könnte falscher sein und jeder der sowas
behauptet der hat sich weder mit
Ostdeutschland noch mit der
Notwendigkeit dieser strategischen
chipinvestitionen beschäftigt denn das
was ihn jeder Abgeordnete aus
Ostdeutschland der koalitionstragenden
Fraktion berichten wird können stimmen
kauman auch in Ostdeutschland für die
Demokratie nicht mit Mitteln aus dem
Bundeshaushalt sich einmal erkaufen aber
was man tatsächlich machen kann ist
anzuerkennen dass hier sich Magdeburg
und Dresden mit TSMC und Intel
durchgesetzt haben auch gegen
westdeutsche Standorte die sich beworben
haben und aufgrund der Verfügbarkeit z.B
von Flächen und den guten
Investitionsbedingungen von Ort sich
hier diese Standorte durchgesetzt haben
und die Bundesregierung das finanziert
weil es geostrategisch notwendig
und wer behauptet dass das wieder nur
ein subventionsgeschenk an ostdeutsche
wäre der verstätigt nicht nur Klischees
sondern der beleidigt und macht einmal
mehr ostdeutsche klein und das über 35
Jahre nach der deutschen
Wiedervereinigung und ich finde das
könnte jetzt wirklich mal zu Ende sein
auch in den großen deutschen Politik
Podcast meine Damen und
Herren was ihnen aber die Ostdeutschen
Abgeordneten der koalitionsrangen
Fraktion werden berichten können ist und
das erleben wir jeden Tag zu Hause bis
in die eigene Familie hinein
da wo Prosperität ist in Ostdeutschland
da wo zuzugstatt Wegzug stattfindet da
ist dann plötzlich auch nicht nur die
Lebenserwartung höher in Ostdeutschland
da sterben die Onkel auch in
Ostdeutschland nicht mit 65 am
Herzinfakt wie in anderen Regionen
Ostdeutschlands noch viel zu oft sondern
da ist auch die Zufriedenheit mit der
gelebten Praxis der Demokratie plötzlich
höher und dass wir uns deswegen dafür
einsetzen auch mit dem Bittel des
Bundeshaushalts dass wir noch mehr
Regionen in Ostdeutschland haben die
prosperieren das ist nicht nur gerecht
an angesichts der Geschichte das ist
auch die ureigenste Aufgabe jeder
Bundesregierung weil die Schaffung
gleichwertiger lebensverhältn ist die
Aufgabe jeder Bundesregierung und das
machen wir in diesem Bundeshaushalt
nicht nur mit Intel und TSMC nicht nur
mit der Unterstützung für Schwed und für
Leuner die wir übrigens jetzt im
parlamentarischen Verfahren noch mal
gerettet haben auch für die Forschung an
regenerativen Kraftstoffen lieben Dank
SEB Müller auch für die gute
Zusammenarbeit an der Stelle aber nicht
zuletzt auch mit der Absicherung des
Kemnitzer wasserstoffstandorts mit
zusätzlichen Geldern fürs
zukunftszentrum in Halle für deutsche
Einheit und natürlich auch mit dem neuen
Standort für die dati in Erft das sind
alles Punkte wie wir neue Regionen in
Ostdeutschland zu prosperierenden
Regionen machen wollen meine Damen und
Herren und das ist am Ende auch einfach
nur fair weil dieser Landesteil der
einfach so viel mehr Pech hatte als alle
anderen Landesteile und ind dem die
Bevölkerung jetzt noch Generationen
später für dieses Pech dieses Pech am
eigenen Leib spürt in Form von niedrig
Lebenserwartung in Form von niedrigerem
Wohlstand weil wir einfach alle
gemeinsam diese aufgab haben Jahrzehnte
später diese Ungleichheiten endlich
Stück für Stück abzubauen meine Damen
und
Herren es ist heute schon viel über die
aktuellen Demonstrationen gesagt worden
und wenn sie sich die Karte des
aktuellen demonstrationsgeschehens für
die starke Demokratie anschauen dann ist
das plötzlich eine der Karten wo sie die
ehemalige innerdeutsche Grenze nicht
mehr erkennen können und das ist neu das
ist neu selbst im Vergleich zu 2018 2018
sie erinnern sich die Ausschreitung in
chemnit Hase du bleibst hier da gab's
danach im September diese Demo wir sind
mehr in Chemnitz und da hat man den
Leuten vor Ort noch nicht zugetraut dass
sie alleine genug Leute auf die Straße
kriegen da kamen Leute aus ganz
Deutschland vor allenen auch Berlin wir
fuhren nach Chemnitz wir waren an dem
Tag mehr und am nächsten Tag waren wir
schon wieder nicht mehr mehr Leute in
Chemnitz und jetzt demonst demonstrieren
die Leute in Kemnitz genauso wie in
Braunschweig in Leipzig genauso wie in
Essling und in Berlin genauso wie in
Hamburg weil wir auf der einen Seite
endlich in Westdeutschland akzeptieren
dass es kein ostdeutsches
regionalproblem ist die Demokratie zu
verteidigen und weil wir in
Ostdeutschland genug Menschen haben die
sich jetzt trauen auf die Straße zu
gehen da ist Deutschland wieder ein
Stück weiter zusammengewachsen in den
letzten 5 Jahren und es ist ein extrem
großer Grund zur Freude meine Damen und
Herren viele von uns fragen sich warum
müssen wir eigentlich dafür auf die
Straße gehen sollt es in diesem Land
selbst in dem Landesteil wo die
Demokratie nur nicht mal 40 Jahre alt
ist sollte es nicht selbstverständlich
sein dass in diesem Land niemals wieder
jemand auf die Straße gehen muss gegen
Parteien mit
deportationsfantasien und da kann man
das Gefühl haben dass man eigentlich
nicht hier auf der Straße stehen sollte
aber ich möchte noch mal dran erinnern
wir können überhaupt nur auf der Straße
stehen wir können überhaupt nur für die
Demokratie demonstrieren weil in den
50ern in der alten Bundesrepublik
Menschen so klug und weise die
Demokratie aufgebaut haben und in
Ostdeutschland so mutig die SED Diktatur
zu Fall gebracht haben und deswegen ist
es auch ein großes Geschenk dass wir da
gemeinsam auf der Straße stehen
und kann besseres Gefühl geben wenn wir
diese Demonstration jetzt in den
nächsten Monaten weitertragen in Ost und
in West vielen Dank
seit auch für das nächste Wochenende
sind wieder viele
Demonstrationen angekündigt hier in
Berlin sollen schon 100000 Menschen sich
ang spricht nun der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der von beschrieben ist und das
selbst wie ich immer sage so ein
ultraess wie ich der vom linkener kommt
an der Stelle seinen Mitbürgern Vung
sagen kann seid weiter so neugierig
aufeinander und dann stellt ihr fest
dass bei allen Unterschieden ihr doch
gleicherweise deutsche Demokraten seid
das ist wichtig in unserer Gesellschaft
das müssen wir auch halten meine Damen
und Herren ich möchte dennoch als
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher der
versucht hat mit den beiden Kollegen in
dieser Koalition das hinzubekommen und
ich glaube es auch ganz kurz hinbekommen
hat noch mal auf ein paar Dinge
hinweisen bei diesem Haushalt der zeigt
was diese Koalition schaffen kann wenn
sie ja sich weniger streitet und wenn
sie am Ende nach schwierigen Vorgaben
Lösung findet wir halten die
Schuldenbremse ein wir setzen die
Vorgaben des Verfassungsgerichtes um die
Investitionsquote ist auf Rekordhöhe in
der letzten 10 Jahre wir sorgen sowohl
dafür dass die natoquote mit 2,1%
eingehalten wird wir sorgen dafür dass
bei der Entwicklungshilfe wir mit 0,63%
weit über dem EU-Durchschnitt sind weit
über dem was vergleichbare Länder machen
ja ich weiß da gibt es Leute die sagen
mich interessiert nicht was in anderen
Ländern passiert aber ich glaube wer in
dieser Zeit noch national alleine denkt
er muss auch aber national alleine denkt
der wird am Ende auch alleine bleiben
meine Damen und Herren wir bauen
Sondervermögen ab wir sorgen dafür an
der Stelle dass das was abgebaut wird
integriert wird in den Haushalt wir
helfen den Menschen im Aril trotz der
Tatsache dass uns das Verfassungsgericht
nicht mehr die Möglichkeit gibt wir
stoppen den personalaufwuchs übrigens
zum ersten Mal seit 2013 ein schellmwer
böses dabei denkt dass das an der FDP
liegt wir halten dabei zugleich das
soziale Niveau an der Stelle wir sorgen
aber auch gleichzeitig dafür dass
diejenigen die sich verweigern
entsprechend auch Konsequenzen fühlen
müssen all das tut diese Koalition
zugleich sinkt noch das sage ich mit
Freude darf ich mit Freude sagen die
Steuerquote und bei all den wird immer
gesagt aber bei euch selber macht er
nichts und da gebe ich den kleinen
kurzen Hinweis nur bei den
besucherfahrten die uns allen sehr
wichtig sind und die ja übrigens
zugleich eine Vermittlung von Demokratie
sind hat der Bundestag dann aber auch
gesagt ja wir kürzen bei uns zweieinhalb
Millionen und bei den besucherfahr des
Bundesrates die übrigens nicht die
Länder bezahlen sondern die der Bund
bezahlt kürzen wir auch um einhb das
heißt ja mag klein sein aber wir haben
auch immer geguckt wo betrifft es uns an
der Stelle und ich sage das auch
deutlich in dem nächsten Bundestag der
in dann etwas mehr als na ja zi Jahren
wer weiß mal gucken wie sich das alles
darstellt
kleiner sein wird werden wir auch dann
noch mal an der Frage ein wenig sparen
aber woran wir nicht sparen werden ist
an der Demokratie denn sie ist die Basis
dessen warum dieses Land mitten in
Europa funktionieren kann und Demokratie
ist etwas und da komme ich dann zur CDO
CSU der ein Fraktionsvorsitzender nicht
mehr da ist der ein zuständiger
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitz für
den Haushalt nicht mehr da ist ah der
Stefan nein ich meine den ich meine
nicht den CSU Kollegen ich meine schon
den denjenigen der hier als
hermittelberg uns erklärt hat wir würden
nicht sparen ich will als erstes der CDU
CSU doch mal sagen Demokratie ist
Diskurs Demokratie ist streiten um die
besseren Lösungen und wenn hier gesagt
wird von ihrem Fraktionsvorsitzenden wir
würden die Anträge ablehnen die Grünen
haben letzte Legislatur über 1500
Anträge im Haushaltsausschuss gestellt
wir über 2000 sie haben die immer
abgelehnt und doch haben wir sie jedes
Mal wiedergestellt und wo sind wir dann
gelandet in der Regierung und da wollen
sie doch auch wieder hin und sie wollen
doch nicht in Wirklichkeit mit leerrheit
hinkommen um dann nachher zu sagen oh es
tut uns alles Leid wir sind zufällig
wieder an die Regierung gekommen wir
haben vieles versprochen aber ist
eigentlich alles ganz anders eine solche
Opposition funktioniert nicht und dann
wird gesagt dann wird gesagt sagt sie
würden sparen ich werde das am Freitag
noch mal ausführen die ganze Liste ihrer
Leute die das All nicht darstellen ich
bleibe bei Ihnen bei dem Schweigen bei
Hamlet erster Aufzug zweite Szene doch
brich mein Herz den schweigen muss mein
Mund das tat Hamlet kund weil er nicht
nach Wittenberg gehen konnte herzlichen
Dank im Einzelplan 4 sind ja auch die
Ausgaben der Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für Kultur und Medien
enthalten dementsprechend tut hier ein
bisschen Zitierung aus Medien aus Medien
aus der Kultur gut und näch
red debattieren wir auch über den Etat
des ostbeauftragten warum eigentlich Ost
und West weil der Osten Deutschland noch
strukturelle Probleme hat und da möchte
ich mit einem Wort des Dankes beginnen
ein Wort des Dankes an die
Berichterstatter des
Haushaltsausschusses dass sie die
Möglichkeit gegeben haben dass die
schipfabriken in Tresen und Magdeburg
kommen und unter anderem die Möglichkeit
gegeben haben dass in demnächst grüner
Treibstoff für Flugzeuge hergestellt
wird herzlichen Dank
dafür und der WT ein Wort ist Dankes
gilt natürlich auch dass das
transformationszentrum auf den Weg
gebracht wird lieber Staatsminister
Schneider gewünscht hätten wir uns
natürlich am Anfang erst eine Debatte
über den Inhalt und dann über den
Architekturwettbewerb ich nehme aber
Wohlwollen zur Kenntnis dass am 13 märz
im Kulturausschuss über das
transformationszentrum sich unterhalten
wird und dann natürlich über den Inhalt
des transformationszentrums miteinander
gerungen wird das ist ein gutes Signal
und eine herzliche Einladung an alle 84
Millionen Menschen hier in Deutschland
kommen sie in den Osten unserer Republik
hier geht nicht nur die Sonne auf weil
wo wir sind es von und das werden wir
den nächsten Jahren auch
beweisen und da meine Redezeit knapp ist
möchte ich trotzdem noch einen Dank das
Wort ein Dankeswort sagen an den
Bundesrat der heute bedauerlicherweise
nicht mehr so gut vertreten ist denn der
Bundesrat hat eine
repräsentationslücke geschlossen
ostdeutsche sind in führungsriegen zu
wenig repräsentiert und der Bundesrat
hat bei der Besetzung einer
bundesverfassungsrichterstelle jemanden
eingesetzt und ernannt und gewählt der
an Karl markstadt geboren wurde und das
erhöht die Repräsentanz von ostdeutschen
und das ist so wichtig dass wir
miteinander zusammenwachsen herzlichen
Dank an den
Bundesrat aber natürlich gibt es und das
wäre ja zu schade nur Danke zu sagen wo
man auch die Regierung kritisieren muss
weil es zu lange dauert und lieber
Karsten Schneider ich würde mir ein
wenig mehr eran wünschen bei dem Thema
Ratifizierung des Geldes für die
Pipeline von für Schwed von Rostock nach
Schwed soll Geld fließen dieses Geld
muss ratifiziert werden Schwed muss
ausgelastet werden unser Vorschlag ist
sogar noch weitergehender wir brauchen
eine zweite Pipeline deswegen bisschen
mehr treif mit und diesen treif
mitnehmen damit auch die Kohle und
Struktur mit gleich retifiziert werden
damit wir vor der Europawahl endlich
auch da einen positiven Haken hinter
machen können dass der Osten weiter
Wachstumsregion bleibt meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren und damit der
Osten weiter Wachstumsregion bleibt lass
ich mal andere für mich sprechen im
Bundeskanzleramt ist ein Brief
eingegangen der Industrie und
Handelskammern aus Ostdeutschland indem
Sie fehlende Einbindung verschiedener
Interessen in den politischen Prozess
bemängeln stattdessen machen sich
eklatante Unterschiede zwischen Worten
und Taten der Bundesregierung breit
heißt es in dem Brief als Beispiel
führten sie den erklar um den
Bundeshaushalt Ende 2023 an außerdem
kritisierten sie fehlenden
Bürokratieabbau und Anreize für
Nichtarbeit all dies führe dazu dass die
internationale Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
Deutschlands leide so alle alle
Industrie und Handelskammern in
Ostdeutschland und das sollte uns ein
wegruf sein ein wegruf hier in diesem
Haus denn das kleine flänzchen was sich
gerade zeigt ist auch bedroht bedroht
durch die Politik ihrer Koalition
deswegen rufe ich Ihnen von diesem Platz
aus und zu kehren sie endlich um beim
Planungsrecht das kostet kein Geld wenn
eine ortsumfahung wie in Rosslau seit
über 30 Jahren geplant wird und nicht
gebaut wird dann macht das nicht nur die
Menschen frustriert sondern und es führt
auch zu kein Ergebnis kehren sie beim
Planungsrecht um kehren sie um beim
Thema Bürgergeld wir brauchen nicht
Bürgergeld wir brauchen Bürger in Arbeit
der Ministerpräsident aus Sachsen Anhalt
hat die Bürgerarbeit eingeführt eine
Million Menschen mehr in Arbeit aus
Bürgergeld entlastet unseren
Staatshaushalt und bringt zusätzliche
Einnahmen und insgesamt bis zu 30
Milliarden Euro kehren sie um beim
Bürgergeld kehren sie endlich um bei der
Energiewende es war ein Fehler die
Atomkraftwerke abzuschalten diese hätten
nach dem russischen Angriffskrieg
weiterlaufen müssen kehren sie um bei
der Energiewende und kehren sie um beim
heizungsgesetz sie belasten insbesondere
den ländlichen Raum in Ostdeutschland wo
die durch wo das Durchschnittseinkommen
bei unter 40% liegt kehren sie um im
heizungsgesetz denn dann sind Sie auf
dem richtigen Weg ansonsten haben die
Menschen das Gegenmodell auf dem
Wahlzettel im Sommer diesen Jahres und
das ist die CDU CSU meine Damen und
Herren vielen
danküller der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Unionsfraktion
mit deutlichen Forderungen an die
ampelregierung stellvertreten für die
SPD Fraktion spricht nun Sonja eichweder
die re politische Sprecherin ihrer
Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
werrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktion wir diskutieren
wahrlich in einer wichtigen Zeit für
unsere Demokratie und für unser Land es
ist angeklungen bei den Vorrednern wir
diskutieren h über den Haushalt wir
diskutieren aber in einem Jahr in dem
wir auch wichtige Landtagswahlen haben
in dem wir die Europawahl haben in dem
wir sehr sehr wichtige Kommunalwahlen
haben gerade auch bei uns in ostdeutsch
deswegen ist es doch gerade heute hier
in dieser Debatte sehr sehr wichtig
herauszustellen dass ich hinter dem
Haushalt hinter den einzelnen Zahlen
immer Personen immer Projekte verbergen
die dieses Land besser machen die diese
Demokratie stärken und die sich für
unsere Gesellschaft einsetzen werte
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen eben aus diesem Grund tut es
sehr sehr gut und viele Vorrednerinnen
und Vorredner sind darauf eingegangen
dass in den vergangenen W Wochen
100usende Bürgerinnen und Bürger auf der
Straße waren das wie die Kollegin Paula
potta gesagt hat man eben keine Grenze
zwischen Ost und West mehr sieht sondern
das auch bei mir im Wahlkreis in
Brandenburg in Brandenburg an der hafel
in rateno in klosterleninen balbelzig
oder in borgheide eben auch gerade im
ländlichen Raum viele Leute auf der
Straße waren und das ist auch in
Ostdeutschland die Mehrheit ist die hier
für unsere Demokratie streitet und sich
für unsere Demokratie einsetzt mit
vielen vielen Projekten im übrigen auch
mit vielen vielen Projekten die Ksten
Schneider als ostbeauftragter in dem
Projekt machen ausgezeichnet hat im
vergangenen Land das ist ein gutes
Projekt das ist gut für unsere
Demokratie das ist das gut für das
gesamte Land und das ist auch gerade gut
für uns in Ostdeutschland werte
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Mehrheit aufsteht es ist
wichtig dass an den Grundfesten unserer
Demokratie kein Zweifel gelassen wird
und es ist wichtig dass in demokratisch
gewählten Parlamenten eben auch
Demokraten sitzen und nicht solche die
die Demokratie missbrauchen um sie für
Menschen verachtende Zwecke zu nutzen
gerade nach dem Treffen der neuen
Rechten und von AFD Politikern in
Potsdam hinsichtlich der Frage der der
deportationspläne von Millionen von
mitbürgerinen und mit Bürger in unserem
Land müssen wir das deutlich machen
Menschenfeindlichkeit Hass Spaltung und
Ausgrenzung ist keine Meinung das ist
keine Option wir stellen uns hier gegen
und das und dass die AFD Fraktion im
Brandenburger Landtag gleich eine Woche
später einen Antrag gerade mit dem Thema
der deportationspläne und den Fragen von
Remigration gestellt hat ist doch auch
bezeichnend welch Geistes kindind sie
sind und deshalb ist es so gut dass eben
gegen diesen Hass der keine Alternative
für Deutschland ist so viele Leute auf
der Straße sind und deswegen ist es umso
wichtiger dass auch wir hier im Haus
darüber diskutieren wie wir unsere
Demokratie wie wir unseren Rechtsstaat
resilienter machen werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir gucken uns unsere Gesetze
an wir gucken nach wie wir beim
Verfassungsgericht und den anderen
Behörden in der exekutiven und in der
judikativen möglicherweise nachlegen
müssen damit eben gerade diejenigen die
verfassungspatrioten sind unsere
verfassungsschützen und
Verfassungsfeinde nicht unsere
Demokratie unterwandern werte
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen was mich aber sehr berührt hat
und was ich hier auch heute mit Ihnen
teilen möchte ist das am Samstag am 27
Januar eben am Holocaust Gedenktag
Holocaust den wir auch heute hier im
Hause gedenkt gedacht haben nahe dem Ort
in Brandenburg an der Hafe in dem 1941
die erste Gaskammer eingerichtet wurde
und 9000 Menschen weil sie krank oder
behindert waren ermordet wurden dass wir
eben nahe diesem Ort demonstriert haben
und dass die Leiterin der Gedenkstätte
dort umso deutlicher machte was nie
wieder bedeutet
dass wir hier eben unsere Pflicht haben
zu gedenken unsere Pflicht gegenüber der
Vergangenheit aber es ist auch eine
Sicherheit für die Zukunft für eine
bessere Zukunft und für unseren
rechtstat das machen wir in vielen
kleinen Städten in unserem Land eben
auch bei uns im Wahlkreis das machen wir
aber auch mit diesem Haushalt denn durch
diese Gedenkstätte fürühren Geiz die
selbst eine Beeinträchtigung haben und
zeigen weshalb es eben so wichtig ist
dass Demokratie Demokraten braucht dass
die gesamte Gesellschaft hier zusammen
auch profitiert und auch durch den
Bundeshaushalt mit vielen kleinen
Projekten gefördert wird Demokratie ist
greifbar Demokratie ist nahber jeder
kann mitmachen jeder soll wählen gehen
dann haben wir Bestand so schützen wir
unseren Rechtsstaat und das machen wir
mit diesem Bundeshaushalt vielen Dank
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen son ich wede eine Abgeordnete
die hier für Brandenburg im Bundestag
sitzt hat hier auch von ihren Eindrücken
der
Demonstrationen erzählt nächster Redner
ist Gottfried kurio für die AFD Fraktion
der innenpolitische Sprecher sehr
geehrte Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren der Kanzler sagte kürzlich die
EU-Wahl sei die Chance ein klares Votum
gegen Rechts abzugeben indem man
demokratische Parteien und nicht die
Rechten wählt das was der Kanzler und
andere sich da als Rettung der
Demokratie schön reden könnte
antidemokratischer nicht sein nicht
Extremismus wird bekämpft sondern alles
was nicht links ist dabei sind links und
rechts begrifflich gleichberechtigte
ganz normale Ausprägung von
Parteipolitik aber die Antidemokraten
wollen mal eben die Hälfte der
politischen Landschaft abräumen denn
argumentativ ist diese Regierung längst
komplett blank man wollte die AFD
inhaltlich stellen aber sie haben nichts
deshalb die verzweifelten Rufe nach
Parteiverbot nach Grundrecht Zug für
Oppositionspolitiker die kneblung
Oppositioneller Meinung soll es richten
Demokratie in Gefahr in der Tat meine
Damen und Herren dafür der
regierungsseitig zusammengerufene
Protest aus der Mitte der linksgrünen
Wählerschaft dafür all die Fahnen der
antifah der SPD der jusus die
schildermann sei Bund die Regenbogen
Fahnen linke Lobbygruppen gepampert mit
Staatsknete wie pervers ist das eine
Regierung ruft zu Demonstration gegen
die Opposition auf lässt erst die
Opposition verlumen und will dann deren
Wähler einch üchtern Hass und Hetze vom
linken straßensturm sollen es richten
zusammen gegen Rechts gegen rechte
Menschen angeblich für Vielfalt de facto
aber gerade gegen Meinungsvielfalt damit
gegen Meinungsfreiheit damit gegen die
essentielle Voraussetzung jeder
Demokratie Demokratien Gefahr in der Tat
meine Damen und Herren so soll auch die
ewige Leier vom Zusammenhalt natürlich
mit der Meinung der Regierung nur
Oppositionelle Meinungen diskreditieren
dafür wird die AFD Forderung nach
Rückführung eine staatspflicht die die
Regierung nicht erfüllen will
vorsätzlich politisch verleumdet alles
um die verheerende Regierungspolitik
einer inhaltlichen Diskussion zu
entziehen wer dagegen protestiert wie
Bauern Spediteure Handwerker der
Mittelstand soll nicht mehr gehört
werden wir aber geben weiter allen
Regierungskritikern eine Stimme
Demokratie in Gefahr nicht mit einer
vitalen AFD meine Damen und
[Applaus]
Herren der innenpolitische Sprecher der
AFD Fraktion für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
spricht nun Lamia kador sie ist
innenpolitische Sprecherin ihrer
Fraktion se fr Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Abgeordnete liebe Zuhörer und
Zuhörer ich glaube der AFD ist es nicht
gelungen das opfernarrativ ernsthaft
stark zu machen die haben sich eher
demaskiert aus meiner
Sicht die AFD und andere Nationalisten
völkische oder auch Rechtsextremisten
haben ja tatsächlich die Vorstellung sie
könnten bestimmen wer zu diesem Land
gehört und damit Deutscher ist wer und
wer nicht als ob gelten würde je rechter
desto mehr Deutungshoheit aber in einem
Rechtsstaat wird über Menschen nicht
gnädig der Daumen gehoben oder gesenkt
zu Gruppe der Menschen die deportiert
werden sollen gehören auch Menschen wie
ich und deshalb möchte ich hier
stellvertreten für Millionen von
Menschen Antworten ich bin Tochter
syrischer Einwanderer und Mutter
deutscher
Kinder
nein meine Damen und Herren wir lassen
uns nicht von der AFD sagen und darüber
entscheiden wer hier Deutscher ist und
wer hier leben darf oder nicht nein
tausende von Menschen sehen das übrigens
genauso und die sind nicht von uns
orchestriert oder von irgendjemanden die
haben genau das gleiche Bedürfnis wie
jeder anständige Bürger und Bürgerinnen
in diesem Staat und gehen fast täglich
seit fast dre Wochen auf die Straße und
dafür vielen Dank und das ist wirklich
großartig denn eins ist doch klar wer
deportieren will will Demokratie keinen
Rechtsstaat der will zurück in dunkle
Zeiten dieses Landes und wir kennen
diese dunklen Zeiten sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen fast 30%
unserer Bevölkerung haben eine
einwanderungsbiographie wenn AFD und
neue Rechte ernst machen könnten mit
ihren deportationsplänen es sind keine
Fantasien es sind Pläne das ist ein
Unterschied hätte dies katastrophale
Folgen für uns alle und das wäre das
Ende von Einigkeit Recht und Freiheit
und das lassen wir nicht zu und dem
schieben wir auch durch unseren Haushalt
trotz all widrigen Umstände einen Riegel
vor meine Damen und
Herren wir sorgen dafür dass diese
Demokratie die uns seit über 80 Jahren
Frieden beschert vor ihren Feinden im
Inneren wie im äußeren geschützt wird
fühlen Sie sich ruhig angesprochen wir
werden bald ein
demokratieördergesetz im Bundestag
verabschieden wir stärken die politische
Bildung und wir ordnen die Migration
indem wir für
Austausch wir ordnen Migration indem wir
für Ausgleich sorgen wir sehen die herus
aber eben auch die Chancen wir
unterstützen das bampf und die
migrationsverwaltung mit zusätzlichen
200 Millionen Euro und legen mit 95
Millionen Euro die Grundlagen für den
Ausbau des Ausländer zentralregisters
und wir hinterlegen Integrationskurse
und Migrationsberatung mit deutlich mehr
Geld meine Damen und Herren und noch
eins wer meint jetzt vor einem AKP
Ableger in Deutschland zu warnen und uns
als Regierung Ideologie vorzuwerfen der
hat eines nicht verstanden alle
demokratischen Parteien wir alle auch
wir wir ich wir sie sind in der
Verantwortung Politik für die ganze
Bevölkerung zu machen zumal
türkeisttimmige zum türkeistämige
Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit Nähe mit
politischer Nähe zuur AKP in Deutschland
die Union wählen würden wie eine Studie
der Konrad annauer Stiftung ja selbst
zeigt es zeugt also ein Stück weit von
verfehlter Integrationspolitik und
vielleicht auch mangelnden politischer
Adressierung dieser Menschen wenn sie
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der CDU
CSU die ihnen politisch zugeneigten
Menschen nicht für sich gewinnen können
und an eine Art deutschen abbleäger der
AKP verlieren meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginen und Kollegen ich komme
zum Schluss lassen Sie uns daher
ungeachtet des Ringens um die richtige
Haushaltspolitik diese großartige
Protestbewegung auf den Straßen
verstärken und das geht zuletzt habe ich
das selbst in Arlen Westfalen gemacht
Oberbürgermeister Berger hat neben mir
gestanden als grüne wir haben das nicht
parteipolitisch ausgeschlachtet ich
würde sagen das geht in diesem Sinne
möchte ich gerne heute den Appell mich
dem Appell anschließen von Marcel Reif
dem sein Vater ihn immer wieder
zugerufen hat ich glaube er ist heute
wichtiger den
je bleibt ein Mensch oder sei ein Mensch
vielen
Dank und die nächste Rednerin ist für
die FDP Fraktion anniko glowski
mer sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin sehr
froh in dieser emotionalen Debatte über
Kultur sprechen zu können denn es ist
uns gelungen dass dieser Bundeshaushalt
trotz enormer Herausforderung einen
klaren und starken Fokus auf unsere
demokratischen Werte setzt die wir
gerade jetzt das merken wir auch in
dieser Debatte gerade wieder mehr denn
je verteidigen müssen und ich sage als
Braunschweigerin danke für 20 000 die
gegen Rechts auf die Straße gegangen
sind und ich sage Danke für 1000
Menschen in der priegnit meiner alten
Heimat Haltung zeigen Zeichen setzen
darauf kommt es an in Zeiten in denen
ein nie wieder ist jetzt skandiert und
tatsächlich wieder in den Fokus gerückt
werden muss bin ich sehr froh über
dieses geeinte Signal der Koalition
Erinnerungskultur ist nicht nur ein
Blick zurück auf das was war um daraus
zu lernen erinnern ist Zukunft das was
uns hilft nach vorne zu blicken und zu
wissen was unsere Gesellschaft nie
wieder zulassen darf denn nie wieder ist
immer die letzten Jahre waren immer
wieder geprägt von kriesenbedingten
Sonderprogramm nun müssen wir aber
wieder in den haushaltspolitischen
Normalzustand zurückkehren und auch wenn
die Rahmenbedingungen herausfordern
haben wir als Koalition gerade auch für
die Kultur viel erreicht wir bauen die
Förderung der unverzichtbaren Arbeit der
Gedenkstätten aus die als leern und
erlebnisorte einen wichtigen Beitrag zur
Erinnerungskultur leisten wir fördern
mit 3,3 Millionen Euro eine kulturelle
Aufarbeitung zum Völkermord an den
Jesiden im Hinblick auf die immensen
Einflüsse aus desinformationsk Kampagnen
und Fake News stärken wir die Deutsche
Welle in ihrem Kampf gegen
Desinformation und Propaganda mit
zusätzlichen 10 Millionen Euro und
worüber ich mich sehr freue ist die
Entscheidung den Kulturpass nach seinem
großen Erfolg vorzuführen durch ihn ist
ein niedrigschwelliger Zugang zu Kultur
für junge Menschen möglich Jugendliche
die dadurch Kultur in ihrer Vielfalt
vielleicht zum ersten Mal selbstständig
erleben
können und was ich hier auf keinen Fall
unerwähnt lassen möchte ist die
Förderung der Games Branche ein
Herzensanliegen für dass ich mich
nachdrücklich eingesetzt habe und
einsetzen werde denn die Games haben
kreatives und innovatives Potenzial
welches sinnbildlich für die Kultur und
Kreativwirtschaft ist kommen Sie bitte
zum Schluss liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in einer Zeit die geprägt ist
von Krisen und Konflikten kann man nicht
of genug die Notwendigkeit
demokratischer Werte betonen und hierfür
brauchen wir die Kunst und Kultur mehr
denn je denn sie ist eine laute Stimme
der Demokratie ohne Kunst und Kultur ist
alles stumm und dazu dürfen wir es
niemals kommen lassen vielen Dank an
Nico glokowski mten war das hat an die
Bedeutung der Kultur erinnert ähnlich
hat es übrigens auch Staatsministerin
Claudia rot in der ersten Lesung zu
diesem Einzelplan gesagt und die
Bedeutung der Kultur für die Demokratie
betont Christiane schenderlein spricht
nun für die Unionsfraktion KLE und
Kollegen sobald die Bundesregierung nach
dem Grund ihrer forscherei gefragt wird
ist die oft die Antwort oft schnell und
simpel gefunden 16 Jahre CDU sie mich
die Halbzeit ihrer Regierung zum Anlass
nehmen um 16 Jahre unionsgeführte
Kulturpolitik zu rekapitulieren
Verdopplung des kulturhaushaltes auf
über 2 Milliarden Euro
unbürokratische und effektive
coronahilfen mittels neustadtkultur und
den Sonderform für Kulturveranstaltungen
Höhe von über viinhalb Milliarden Euro
und solide Finanzierung der
Filmförderung dem stellen wir
[Musik]
nun
dem stellen wir nun zwei Jahre
Kulturpolitik unter der ampelregierung
gegenüber der jahrzehntelange
überparteiliche Konsens dass an der
Kulturpolitik nicht gespart werden darf
ist aufgekündigt anstatt die Restmittel
von neustadtkultur für den
Kulturhaushalt 2024 zu nutzen geben Sie
diese 300 Millionen Euro ohne
Widerspruch an den Bundesfinanzminister
zurück dabei hätte dieses Geld unserer
deutschen Kulturland
gut getan
unsere unsere großen Kulturinstitutionen
darben die Stiftung Preußischer Kultur
besitzt ist unterfinanziert beim Humbold
Forum wackelt der freie Eintritt dem
Bundesarchiv fehlt massiv Geld für die
Außenstellen des Jasi unterlagenarchivs
beim freiheits und Einheitsdenkmal gibt
es kurz vor Fertigstellung einen
Baustopp Finanzierung immer noch unklar
der energiefond für viele kleine
Kultureinrichtungen die ohne h mit
erheblichen Mehrkosten kämpfen
ausgelaufen sie kürzen beim
Denkmalschutz Sonderprogramm und der
kinoförderung überall fehlt angeblich
das Geld ganz aktuell liefern sie den
Treppenwitz der Haushaltsführung sie
streichen den Musikinstrumenten Preis in
Höhe von 60.000 € um ihren
Bundeshaushalt zu konsolidieren da weiß
man nicht ob man bei dieser Summe lachen
oder aufgrund der offenbar fehlenden
Wertschätzung für unsere Weinen
müsste nicht einmal ihre eigenen
versprechen können Sie einlösen die
Ampel und Frau Staatsministerin rot
persönlich haben zugesichert
Mindesthonorare für Solo selbständige
einzuführen auch hier ist seit dieser
Zeit nichts passiert dafür steigen die
Kosten beim Museum der Moderne
inzwischen auf 600 Millionen Euro durch
Mehrkosten für eine ökologische
Nachhaltigkeit am Bau dafür ist Geld da
auch für den Kulturpass für 18-Jährige
100 Millionen Euro es wird auf allen
Kanälen geworben ein Vorzeigeprojekt ja
aber mehr auch nicht und am schlimmsten
leidet die deutsche Filmbranche unter
ihrer Politik die filmverbände schließen
sich zusammen schreiben einen offenen
Brandbrief damit endlich die seit zwei
Jahren angekündigte Reform der
Filmförderung umgesetzt wird zur letzten
Berlinale haben sie ein acht Punkte
Programm vorgestellt und in zwei Wochen
ist wieder Berlin
bis jetzt liegt noch nichts vor noch nie
war der Filmstandort Deutschland so in
Gefahr wie heute es ist Halbzeit das
Ende ihrer Kulturpolitik ist in Sicht
die Ampel hat es bis heute nicht
geschafft auch nur einen gemeinsamen
Gesetzentwurf vorzulegen auch beim
staatsel Kultur nicht uns die Schuld für
ihr Versagen in die Schuhe zu schieben
ist ein reines Ablenkungsmanöver von
ihrer Untätigkeit und
Uneinigkeit
St statt ihrer regelmäßigen green
culture Konferenzen hätten wir von Ihnen
gern eine Äußerung zur fabattacke am
Brandenburger Tor
vernommen was man positiv bewerten kann
sind hingegen ihre Worte zum bitteren
Schweigen der Kulturbranche nach dem 7
Oktober und gegen Antisemitismus im
Kulturbetrieb wir sagen deutlich
Kultureinrichtungen oder Kulturprojekte
die mit öffentlichen Geldern finanziert
werden dürfen Antisemiten keine Bühne
bieten wir
brauchen wir brauchen eine einheitliche
Regelung die Dokumenta wirft bereits
ihre Schatten voraus und an Herren
Kollegen Grundel an dieser Stelle wenn
sie als politischer Mandatsträger im
Zusammenhang mit einer
antisemitismusklausel von einer
Einschränkung der Kunstfreiheit sprechen
dann vergiften sie den politischen
Diskurs und spielen den Extremisten in
die Karten wenn sie als Vertreter der
Grünen mittlerweile schon ökologische
Standards zur Voraussetzung von
Fördergeldern machen da muss auch erst
recht gelten keine Steuermittel für
Antisemiten der
Kulturausschuss der Kulturausschuss des
Deutschen Bundestages wird in der
Sitzung am 21 Februar sich mit diesem
Thema befassen wir erwarten hier
Klarheit wir wollen ein vielfältiges
jüdisches Leben in unserem Land ohne
Angst und Gewalt
Christiane schenderlein verurteilt hier
den Antisemitismus sie ist auch noch mal
auf den Kulturpass
eingegangen den hatte sie schon zuvor
als Kü bezeichnet der sich gewidmet
werden kann wenn die Pflicht erfüllt ist
für die SPD Fraktion ist die nächste
Rednerin Wiebke Ester frau Präsidentin
meine Damen und Herren wir haben einen
Haushalt den haben wir zusammen
verhandelt das waren wahrlich keine
einfachen Verhandlungen aber ehrlich
gesagt sind ja auch die Umstände unter
denen wir diesen Haushalt verhandelt
haben schwierig und damit meine ich
nicht nur und gar nicht mal in erster
Linie das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes denn wir
werden in diesem Haushalt ich glaube in
jedem Einzelplan noch Auswirkung der
coronapandemie finden die
Berücksichtigung finden möchte ich
möchte ein Beispiel rausen über 100
Millionen fast 200 Millionen Euro
stellen wir ein für die long covid
Forschung eine Nachwirkung der
coronapandemie die wir der wir jetzt
begegnen der Angriffskrieg Putins über
die Ukraine an die Ukraine läuft
weiterhin und wir haben mit dem
Sondervermögen das inzwischen zu zwei
Drittel gesichert ist in diesem Haushalt
auch sehr stark abgebildet wie sehr wir
uns um die äußere Sicherung halten und
der steigende
Handlungsbedarf gegen den Klimawandel
der mit Sicherheit auch damit
zusammenhängt dass ich zitiere Olaf
Scholz zu Beginn dieser Debatte sehr
viel liegen geblieben ist dass wir eben
so einen hohen Investitionsbedarf hat
diesen Handlungsdruck den begegnen wir
weil wir uns jetzt auch trauen im
Gegensatz zu der großen Koalition vorher
dass wir beim Thema Verkehr und beim
Thema wohn da wo der CO2 auschraus am
größten ist jetzt auch mit Maßnahmen
politisch
steuern und meine Damen und Herren darum
ist es gut dass dieser Haushalt eine
steigende Investitionsquote hat das
brauchen wir es ist eben sehr viel los
liegen geblieben aber wir brauchen eben
auch die Debatte über die Schuldenbremse
und ich freue mich sehr dass der
Sachverständigen Rat sehr deutlich
gemacht hat dass auch er inzwischen der
Auffassung ist dass wir noch mehr
Investitionen brauchen dass wir diese
Ausnahmesituation diese multiplen Krisen
die wir haben auch damit begegnen müssen
dass die neuverschildungsquote nach dem
BIP angehoben werden müssen denn am Ende
ist es doch so es wird keinem einzigen
Kind irgendetwas nutzen wenn wir die
Verschuldungsquote um ein 2 oder 3%
Punkte schneller senken dafür aber das
Bildungssystem marote gespart ist und es
wird auch keinem Unternehmer etwas
nutzen wenn das Schienenverkehr der
Schienen System so marode ist dass die
Lieferungen über den güterfehr dort
nicht zuverlässig ankommen und es wird
auch keinem Arbeitnehmer und keine
Arbeitnehmerin irgendetwas nutzen wenn
sie nicht im Homeoffice arbeiten kann
weil der glasphaserausbau so sehr stockt
und darum ist für uns klar darum ists
für uns klar sein wir müssen über die
Investitionen die notwendig sind die bei
denen es darum geht dass wir gestalten
wollen für dieses Land reden und da
gehört nach diesem
Bundesverfassungsgericht auch eine
offenebatte über die Schuldenbremse dazu
meine Damen und Herren wir bilden in
diesem Haus halt auch ab das Motto dass
Demokratie nicht für umsonst zu haben
ist Demokratie kostet und darum haben
wir beispielsweise und es ist sichtbar
geworden nach dem so Schwier so
barbarischen Überfall der Hamas auf
Israel wie groß in unserer Gesellschaft
das antisemitismusprem ist es ist aber
noch viel erschreckender deutlich
geworden wie
rechtsextreme konkrete konkrete Pläne
zur Deportation zur Remigration haben
und wie gefährdet unsere Demokratie mit
systematischen Plänen in die auch
zutiefst die AFD verstrickt
ist vorlegen und darum bin ich so froh
dass so viele Menschen in diesen Tagen
auf die Straße gehen und Flagge zeigen
und diese Demonstrationen sind enorm
wichtig diese Demonstrationen können
aber immer nur ein kleiner Baustein sein
sie können nur ein erster Schritt sein
der Schritt den die Bevölkerung den die
Menschen draußen auf der Straße machen
wir in diesem Haus haben die Aufgabe und
da werden wir gerecht einen finanziellen
Rahmen für politische Bildung wir haben
alle Kürzungen dort zurückgenommen für
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhen Halt und
für Demokratieförderung für den Kampf
gegen Antisemitismus als finanziellen
Rahmen zusammenzusetzen und sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der AFD nein aus der
AFD brauche ich keine
Zwischenfrage und wir werden diesen
finanziellen Rahmen und die Proteste die
wir jetzt auf der Straße haben in dem
ganzen Jahr 2024 zusammenbinden müssen
zwei Bausteine der dritte Baustein der
dazu kommt ist dass wir aktiv als
Politikerinnen und Politiker aber eben
auch alle Menschen die auf der Straße
waren und noch viel mehr aktiv
widersprechen müssen wenn sie am
Arbeitsplatz wenn sie in der
Nachbarschaft wenn sie in der Familie
antidemokratische Äußerungen hören wenn
sie antisemitische rassistische außerung
wenn sie Diskriminierung hören das ist
die Aufgabe der wir uns 2024 das ganze
Jahr alle DemokratInnen und Demokraten
gemeinsam stellen müssen weil es
notwendig ist das ist das traurige aber
ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir das
hinbekommen weil wir damit die AFD die
ganz rechts außen und diejenigen die
Hass und Spaltung sehen etwas
entgegensetzen werden und am Ende werden
wir mehr sein wir werden stärker sein
und wir werden es auch länger
durchhalten herzlichen Dank wieb Geester
war das für die SPD Fraktion und bis
Anfang dezemember gab es hier im
Bundestag noch eine Linksfraktion dann
hat sie sich allerdings aufgelöst nach
demem Abgeordnete um Sarah Wagenknecht
aus der Partei ausgetreten sind Pardon
und jetzt gibt es hier eine
Kurzintervention aus der AFD Fraktion
der anderen Parteien von neuen Rechten
und der AFD äh die Rede und Bezug nehmen
Sie auf das sogenannte Geheimtreffen
jetzt mal abgesehen davon dass dort nie
von Deputation gesprochen wde und so
weiter und so fort was sie hier
wahrheitswidrig behaupten was sie hier
weahheitsbedrig behaupten aber ich
möchte sie ich wollte sie eigentlich nur
fragen auch sie z.B kann ich nachher
Fragen aber eigentlich frage ich Sie sie
sagen reden immer von Rechtsextremen und
der AFD von neuen Rechten und der AFD
und jetzt frage ich Sie sie wissen ja
sicherlich dass auch CDU Politiker an
diesem Treffen teilgenommen haben und wo
verorden sie jetzt die CDU Politiker
also wo verstecken sie sie sind jetzt
die CDU Politiker die neuen Rechten oder
also wie muss ich das verstehen also
letztendlich wie gesagt cduptiker waren
dabei das vergessen sie bloß immer zu
erwähnen und wo verorten sie die
cdupitiker sind jetzt Teil der neuen
Rechten weil sie die sonst nicht
erwähnen vielen Dank für die
Antwort die Kurzintervention von Ksten
Hilse war das wollen sie antworten ja
ich antworte gerne und will als erstes
betonen dass ich sehr froh bin dass in
so vielen Reden angesprochen wurde
welche Gefahr von den rechtsextrem in
diesem Land inzwischen ausgeht dass wir
uns alle in den demokratischen Parteien
dafür bedankt haben dass so viele
Menschen auf die stße gehen und dass wir
froh sein können dass es eine freie
Presse und ein recherchenetzwerk
Korrektiv gibt die das aufgedeckt haben
und was ich feststellen muss dazu ist
dass all diejenigen nach den Recherchen
die wir kennen all diejenigen die bei
diesem Treffen waren Verfassungsfeinde
sind all diejenigen die bei diesem
Treffen sind tragen die Verantwortung
für diese menschenfeindlichen Pläne die
dort gestaltet worden sind und die
Grenze zwischen DemokratInnen und
Demokraten verläuft dort wo diejenigen
sich davon distanzieren die sagen dass
das nicht in Ordnung ist und der
wesentliche Unterschied zwischen der
Union und der AFD um das auch ganz klar
zu benennen ist aber dass sie eine
Programmatik in der gesamten Partei
haben die Menschen verachtend ist dass
sie als Ziel als parteipolitisches Ziel
Menschenverachtung Rassismus und
Diskriminierung ausgegeben haben und das
werden wir als alle demokratischen
Parteien in diesem Bundestag bekämpfen
da bin ich mir
sicher
soweit noch die Erwiderung und dietm
Bartsch macht sich jetzt auf dem Weg zum
Rednerpult ich hatte es eben gesagt die
Fraktion DIE LINKE gibt es nicht mehr
dimar B ist dementsprechend
fraktionsloser Abgeordnete das könnte
sich am Freitag ändern da dürfte der
Bundestag die Linke und auch das Bündnis
SAR Wagenknecht als Gruppe
Anerkennen der Linken ganz herzlich
bedanken für die Organisation der
heutigen Gedenkveranstaltung und ich
will mich auch sehr besonders bei Eva
cpesi und auch bei Marcel Reif bedanken
das waren hervorragende reden und ich
würde mir wünschen dass sie in jeder
Schulklasse einmal angehört werden und
dass darüber gesprochen wird das wäre
für unser Land meines Erachtens sehr
wichtig meine Damen und Herren lassen
Sie mich zunächst daran erinnern warum
wir heute überhaupt zum Haushalt für das
laufende Jahr diskutieren das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die
trixsereien der Ampel ausgebremst
verfassungswidrig war das Urteil das ist
die größte Klatsche für eine Regierung
die es überhaupt geben kann darauf will
ich noch mal verweisen und meine Damen
und Herren im Gegensatz zu vielen Reden
zu vielen Reden die heute gehalten
worden sind ist die Situation im Lande
dramatisch das Brutto Inlandsprodukt ist
im vergangenen Jahr um
0,3% zurückgegangen in keiner anderen
OECD Nation ist das so gewesen die
Inflationen die übrigens in diesem Jahr
fürs erste Quartal auch ein Minus
prognostiziert die Inflation war im
letzten Jahr im Durchschnitt bei 5,9 9%
das ist eine Katastrophe nicht annährend
bei den 2% die Zielrichtung der EZB
waren das ist doch eine wirkliche
Katastrophe die Lage wir befinden uns in
einer Rezession und das muss
ausgesprochen werden und mit dieser
Rezension dafür haben viele die
Verantwortung und wenn der Bundeskanzler
sagt die Stimmung im Land ist unruhig da
hat er schlicht Unrecht es brodelt im
Land das ist die Situation meine Damen
und Herren und natürlich ist es korrekt
auch von der Ampel auf die 16 Jahre
von Angela Merkel zu verweisen aber eins
will ich denn den lieben
Sozialdemokraten und Sozialdemokraten
doch sagen in den letzten 26 Jahren
haben 22 Jahre sie mit Verantwortung in
der Regierung getragen da können sie
doch nicht so tun als wenn die jetzige
Situation mit ihnen nichts zu tun hab
das ist doch nicht der Fall meine Damen
und Herren gerade in stürmischen Zeiten
brauchst eine Bundesregierung die in
Haushalt vorlegt der das Land und den
sozialen Zusammenhalt stärkt und der auf
die Zukunft schaut aber sie tun genau
das Gegenteil sie legen eine
belastungsorje für die Mehrheit im Land
vor sie verteuern den ohnehin schon
teuren Alltag für viele Menschen in
diesem Land und sie versuchen uns hier
und den bürgerinen und Bürgern xvu zu
machen das ist doch alles nicht wahr was
sie hier sagen mein der Bund
Bundesfinanzminister der jetzt auch
nicht mehr da ist obwohl hier eine
Haushaltsberatung ist der sagt
anlässlich der richtigen und der
friedlichen bauernproteste alle müssen
einen Beitrag leisten wenn wir keine
allgemeinen Steuererhöhung wollen das
sind zwei Unwahrheiten in einem Satz die
Wahrheit ist doch sie schonen sich und
sie schonen den Geldadel und natürlich
steigen die allgemeinsteuern ob das die
Mehrwertsteuer heizen tanken essen gehen
Schulessen vieles wird teurer damit sie
ihre Haushaltslöcher stopfen das ist die
Wahrheit alle leisten einen Beitrag nein
eben nicht alle werden sie den
Landwirten nur über den agrariesel in
diesem Jahr 176 Millionen aus den Rippen
schneiden wollen haben sie für mehr als
200 Millionen Helikopter gekauft
luxusubschrauber für die Regierung das
ist doch unangemessen wie kommen sie
eigentlich auf die Idee in dieser
Situation in dieser Situation die
Ausgaben für das fürs Kanzleramt nicht
auf den Prüfstand zu setzen eine
Milliarde wird das am Ende werden wir
haben jetzt schon die größte
Regierungszentrale der Welt und da soll
die Fläche noch mal verdoppelt werden
also denken Sie doch mal darüber nach
alle nein eben da wird genau nicht
gespart und dann haben Sie noch die
hutpe dass sie wirklich
11500 neue Beamtin und Beamte einstellen
die Mehrkosten sind 7 Milliarden will
nur ein Beispiel sagen Frau Geiwitz Frau
Geiwitz ist ja die die für 400.000 neue
Sozialwohnung das wird ja nicht annäht
nicht mal die Hälfte wird erreicht aber
bei den Beamten und Beamten da gibt es
ein Plus von
130% das ist die Wahrheit ihre Aufgaben
die lösen sie nicht aber sich
selbstbedienen die Bundesregierung ist
unter der Ampel zu einem selbstbedien en
verkommen das ist die Wahrheit meine
Damen und Herren sie agieren vielfach
wie der Vorstand der Deutschen waren für
unsere Leute muss zu allererst gesorgt
werden will mal noch mal dran erinnern
3000 €
Inflationsausgleich für Minister
1000ende neue Mitarbeiter was kost die
Welt ist offensichtlich ihr Motto nein
das geht so nicht meine Damen und Herren
und sehr
geehr wissen sie der ist ja nicht da
wissen Sie was die höchste Subvention
nach ihrem eigenen Bericht die höchste
Subvention in Deutschland ist das ist
nach ihrem eigenen Bericht sind das die
Ausnahmen für großerben denn je größer
das Vermögen die vererbt werden desto
niedriger die Steuerlast nach ihrem
eigenen Bericht 4,5 Milliarden Euro
kostet das aber das stört sie nicht Herr
Lindner ist der Vermögensverwalter des
Geldadels meine Damen und Herren das ist
die Wahrheit sie schützen sie schützen
diese Subventionen und holen sich das
Geld lieber bei den Bauern und bei der
arbeitenden Bevölkerung was ist
eigentlich mit dem Respekt von dem der
Bundeskanzler im Wahlkampf gesprochen
hat gewah geworden ja rolf mützenig hat
vorhin völlig zurecht auf das Thema
Kindergeld ma verwiesen also was ist da
eigentlich los ich meine da lese ich
dann dass Herr Lindner meint dass sie
der dass er den Top Verdiener noch mehr
Taler zuschussen Schussen müsste m nicht
hat ja hier gesagt das findet nicht
statt na ich bin ja sehr gespannt was da
wird bin ja sehr gespannt was da wird
richtig wäre Kindergeld für alle
auszahlen und den Freibetrag streichen
das wäre richtig das wäre Gere und das
wäre auch eine Lösung meine Damen und
Herren auch Politiker tragen natürlich
und müssen nicht alles wissen bei allen
Themen das doch völlig klar aber bei
Rente ist so ein Thema was dann doch
sehr viele berührt 21 Millionen Menschen
in unserem Land sind da betroffen und da
liegt es leider nicht die Rente
durchschnittlich bei irgendwas bei 2000
€ und das hat ja Ricard lang unlängst
erzählt das trifft übrigens für
Bundestagsabgeordnete vor zu nach 8
Jahren ohne dass wir ein Cent eingezahlt
haben vielleicht gibt's da auch ein
Problem aber für rentnergil nach 45
Jahren durchgängiger Arbeit bekommen sie
ca 1500 € das ist die Realität die
sollte man als abgeordnet kennen und
dann kommt auch noch die Rentensteuer
fast jeder zweite Rentner hat laut
statistischenem Bundesamt weniger als
1250 € Nettoeinkommen und sie wollen die
Rentner in diesem Jahr mit 3,5% noch mal
abspeisen das ist wieder
Einkommensverlust Reallohnverlust das
ist die Wahrheit das vierte Jahr infolge
weniger im portmane und das in der
stärksten Volkswirtschaft Europas ist
denn das normal unser rentniveau liegt
10% unter dem EU-Durchschnitt in der
stärksten Volkswirtschaft da ist was
nicht in Ordnung da braucht's eine
Generalüberholung meine Damen und Herren
ich will nur einen kleinen Mosaikstein
noch sagen machen Sie doch den Weg frei
damit endlich wir alle wir alle
Abgeordnete verpflichtend in die
Rentenkasse einzahlen wir hatten in der
letzten Legislatur eine Diskussion da
waren sozial alleraten dafür da waren
grüne dafür warum machen wir das nicht
das könnte man doch mal machen am Ende
brauchen wir einen Übergang zu einer
Rentenkasse wo alle einzahlen das wäre
dringend notwendig meine Damen und
Herren wir haben in drei ostdeutschen
Bundesländern im herbstwahlen ich finde
es sehr ermutigend um das auch deutlich
zu sagen dass hunderte für die
Demokratie und für Menschenrechte auf
die Straße gegangen sind aber zur
Wahrheit gehört eben leider auch dass
die selbsternannte
fortschrittskoalition mit ihrem Streit
mit ihrer katastrophalen Kommunikation
mit Ihren gebrochenen Wahlversprechen
diejenigen gestärkt hat die unser
Zusammenleben offen Frage stellen das
muss ausgesprochen werden meine Damen
und Herren sie sind ungewollt zu einer
Werbeagentur für die geworden das können
Sie nicht wollen das können Sie nicht
wollen und ich hoffe dass sie das
Verändern gucken sich doch ihren eigenen
Koalitionsvertrag an kinders
Grundsicherung was ist daraus geworden
Null klimageld klimageld was ist daraus
geworden auch nichts das ist doch im
Kern das ist doch so wenn Christian
Linder sagt möchte das nicht dann kommt
das nicht mein letzter Satz
ist der dass der Haushalt wirklich eine
horrorrechnung für on Normalverbraucher
ist wenn sie nicht real Umsteuern dann
wird so wie iner Deutschen Bahn und dann
kann das Land entgleisen meine Damen und
Herren herzlichen
Dank di B war das noch Fraktions und
gruppenlos das wird sich wie gesagt
eventuell am Freitag ändern für die
Grünen spricht nun Erhard Grundel
sehr verhrte frau Präsidentin ösus meine
Damen und Herren
Erinnerungskultur ist kein
Freifahrtschein der auf Erledigung zielt
es geht um einen Prozess der uns
begleitet wir leben in einer
Einwanderungsgesellschaft in der viele
Menschen auch die die hier geboren sind
unsere Geschichte nicht wirklich kennen
es geht darum neue Wege zu finden die
nationalsozialistische Vergangenheit
Deutschlands auch im europäischen
Kontext in ihrer Bedeutung für die
Gegenwart und Zukunft wachzuhalten und
es geht darum dass diese Arbeit
nachhaltig wirken kann und wir sie im
Haushalt entsprechend finanziell
ausstatten Erinnerungskultur ist keine
drogkulisse sondern ein Versprechen an
uns alle an eine menschenfreundliche
Zukunft eine Zukunft in der Artikel 1
unserer Verfassung fest in den Köpfen
und Herzen der deutschen Bevölkerung
verankert ist Sie hier rechts
außen ist die Würde des Menschen eben
nicht unantassbar die Würde des Menschen
ist ihnen egal wenn dieser Mensch durch
irgendetwas nicht in ihr vom stacheldrah
eingerahmtes kleinkariertes Weltbild
passt spätestens seit Potzdam wissen wir
sie sind Feinde unserer Verfassung
Feinde unserer Demokratie denn für sie
sind Menschen nicht gleich sondern mit
George Orell formuliert einige sind
gleicher als andere wer dazu gehört das
wollen sie definieren aber das kann ich
Ihnen versprechen wir werden verhindern
dass sie hier Menschen aussortieren dass
sie hier Menschen vertreiben wir das
sind die Bürgerinnen und Bürger auf der
Straße das sind die Parlamente in diesem
Land und darum wird es keinen
Schlussstrich unter die
Erinnerungskultur geben denn sie weistß
auf die Mechanismen hin die zu
Faschismus und zur Herrschaft der
leutechinder geführt haben wir alle
wissen die Nationalsozialisten haben
sich in Deutschland nicht an die Macht
geputscht ihnen wurde durch die
Unfähigkeit der DemokratInnen und
Demokraten vereinzuh Handeln der Weg
erst geebnet was uns heute aber bei
aller Unterschiedlichkeit ein und das
haben die vielen vielen Menschen auf den
Demos der Zivilgesellschaft in den
vergangenen Tagen gezeigt ist dass wir
heute gemeinsam unsere Demokratie
verteidigen wir brauchen uns die
Demokratie nicht zurückzuholen wir haben
sie und wir wissen wem wir sie ganz
bestimmt nicht überlassen dürfen mit
Blick auf diese Demonstrationen gegen
den Rechtsextremismus in unserem Land ja
auch in niederbeinen und ich bin stolz
in landzut Passau Straubing deckendorf
und Regen fällt mir eine Zeile von Lana
Del Ray ein Hoffnung zu haben mag
gefährlich sein aber ich habe sie vielen
Dank nach Hamlet nun ein Zitat
von also hier eine große Bandbreite der
die sich hier zeigt in dieser Debatte
nächster Redner ist tostenfrei für die
[Applaus]
Unionsfraktion sehr verehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich bin ziemlich sicher wenn
man später einmal auf die Kanzlerschaft
von Olaf Scholz schauen wird dann wird
diese Krise um den Nachtragshaushalt
2023 und den Bundeshaushalt
2024 eine zesur sein eine zesur deshalb
weil in diesem Moment viele Menschen
auch den Glauben daran verloren haben
dass dieser Bundeskanzler die Probleme
und ihre Lösung vom Ende her denken es
ist angesprochen worden in dieser
Debatte das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts vom 15
November des letzten Jahres das war kein
unvermeidliches Naturereignis dass da
über diese Koalition und unser Land
hinweggekommen ist sondern diese
Ergebnis dieses Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts war durchaus
erwartbar es gab diese
verfassungsrechtlichen Zweifel die sind
von vielen geäußert worden vor allen
Dingen auch vom
Bundesrechnungshof aber der
Bundeskanzler war derjenige der seine
Politik durchgezogen hat wieder
jeglicher Ratschläge und der am Ende des
Land in das die Situation gebracht hat
in der wir heute sind
und
wenn man sich dann mal die Folgen
anschaut dann sieht man ja auch kann man
in den letzten zwei Monaten sehr schön
sehen dass diese Bundesregierung auf
dieses Urteil überhaupt nicht
vorbereitet war überhaupt nicht es gab
kein Plan B sie haben lange gebraucht
bis sie sich einigermaßen sortiert haben
und als es dann im 13 dezember war es
glaube ich die
Koalitionsspitzen sich zusammengesetzt
haben zu einem
Grundsatzbeschluss da hat nur wenige
Stunden gedauert ich glaube keine
24 als sich zunächst einmal der Minister
aus dem Kabinett der fachlich zuständig
ist davon distanziert hat dann drei
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der SPD dann einer der
Verhandlungsführer der Vorsitzende der
FDP und was man an der Stelle sehen kann
ist dass die Autorität des
Bundeskanzlers schmilzt wie Eis in der
Sonne schmilzt wie Eis in der Sonne und
ich sag deshalb ween man angesichts der
gewaltigen Herausforderungen die sich ja
nicht nur in diesem Haushalt abbilden
sondern die sich in unserem Land jeden
Tag zeigen eigentlich einen
Bundeskanzler bräuchte mit Autorität der
in der Lage ist das Land zu führen und
damit auch schwierige und kritische
Entscheidungen durchzusetzen und ich
will das mal anhand von drei großen
Themen beleuchten erstens die Außen und
Sicherheitspolitik die Gefahren die uns
drohen und die Frage wie wir in der Lage
sind uns gegen diese Gefahren von außen
zu schützen und da muss man sagen dass
dieser Bundeshaushalt keine Antworten
gibt auf die Herausforderungen die wir
haben ganz im Gegenteil es gab so einen
Moment drei Tage nach dem russischen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine als der
Bundeskanzler hier an diesem Pult seine
Rede zur Zeitenwende gehalten hat da
konnte man den Eindruck haben dieser
Bundeskanzler hat die Situation
begriffen und ist bereit die richtigen
Schlussfolgerungen daraus zu ziehen er
hat hier an diesem Pult gesagt dass ab
jetzt 2% der Wirtschaftsleistung unseres
Landes für die Bundeswehr zur Verfügung
stehen würde er hat gesagt dass es
darüber hinaus ein schuldenfinanziertes
Sondervermögen in der Größenordnung von
100 Milliarden Euro geben soll um große
Waffensysteme zu beschaffen und heute
muss man sagen der Bundeskanzler hat
sein Versprechen gebrochen er hat sein
Versprechen gebrochen wenn wir hier über
einen Verteidigungsetat diskutieren der
sich überhaupt nicht verändert hat
gegenüber den Vorjahren der bei 50
Milliarden Euro steheneblieben ist der
im Grunde genommen nur durch die
Zuflüsse aus dem Sondervermögen die
Ziele einigermaßen erreichen kann wenn
es darum geht dass nach der
Grundgesetzänderung im Grunde genommen
nicht große Waffensysteme beschafft
worden sind und werden sondern
einfachste
Ausrüstungsgegenstände für die
Bundeswehr dann hat er nicht nur sein
Versprechen gebrochen sondern dann wird
er den Herausforderungen die wir haben
überhaupt nicht
gerecht und wenn man jetzt nur drüber
sprechen würde dass es mit dem Geld so
eine Sache ist dann frage ich mich
anicht angesichts dieser
dahinschmelzenden Autorität natürlich
auch wie die anderen großen Probleme
bewältigt werden sollen wenn es
beispielsweise darum geht dass wir es
derzeit nicht schaffen die stärke der
Bundeswehr um 20.000 Personen auf
203000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten
anwachsen zu lassen wenn wir darüber
diskutieren dass wir die Wehrpflicht
wieder aktivieren müssten wenn wir
darüber diskutieren dass erstmals
Ausländer Wehrdienst Dienst in der
Bundeswehr leisten soll dann sind es
gewaltige Entscheidungen die
langfristige Konzeptionen revidieren
würden und dann bräuchte es dafür einen
Bundeskanzler mit Autorität um das
tatsächlich bewerkstelligen zu können
und wenn man sich die Wirtschaftspolitik
anschaut dann muss ich wirklich eine
Anleihe nehmen an Dietmar bsch der die
Lage so analysiert hat wie sie ist und
im Bundeskanzler wenn er da wäre müsste
man zurufen nehmen Sie Ihre rosarote
Brille ab wir haben das doch heute in
seiner Haushaltsrede wieder erlebt es
ist doch schier unglaublich wie man die
Lage in unserem Land gesund beten kann
und ich will Ihnen mal eine
das hat nichts damit zu tun dass man sie
schlecht redet sonder es hat damit zu
tun dass man die Lage analysiert wie sie
ist um auf dieser Basis die richtigen
Entscheidungen für Besserung zu
erreichen und wer beispielsweise noch im
März letzten Jahres behauptet dass die
Investition in den Klimaschutz zu einem
Wirtschaftswachstum wie im
Nachkriegsdeutschland führen würde und
heute sind wir die einzige
Industrienation der Welt mit einer
schrumpfenden Wirtschaft
-0,3% im letzten Jahr dieses Jahr
vielleicht ein Plus von 0,5 oder 0,6%
bei einer Weltwirtschaft die um 3%
wächst da muss man doch sagen die
Vorschläge haben wir in der Debatte doch
elendlich lange
gemacht dann sage ich Ihnen Frau Eser
wenn Sie das mögen dann muss man
Bürokratie abbauen da muss man Steuern
senken dann muss man die Preise für für
Strom für Gas für Energie senken wir
sagen es ihnen doch andauernd dann muss
man Arbeit wieder lohnend machen da muss
man für Gerechtigkeit sorgen eigentlich
doch ihre Themen ihre Themen und wenn
sie das nicht realisieren können dann
zeigt es eben einfach dass sie sich die
Welt so malen wie sie Ihnen gefällt aber
es hat eben mit der Realität nichts zu
tun und deshalb muss man auf dieser
Grundlage also Entschuldigung Frau est
wenn sie nicht zuhören dann ist es Ihr
Problem und sie brauchen uns im Übrigen
nicht nur in dieser Debatte hier zuhören
sondern wir haben die ganz konkreten äge
in den Fachausschüssen und auch hier im
Plenum des Deutschen Bundestages in den
vergangenen Z Jahren gemacht unser
Fraktionsvorsitzender vorhin darauf
eingegangen wir haben zu jedem Thema
konkrete Vorschläge gemacht die sie
ausnahmslos abgelehnt haben wir übrigens
unterstützen die Dinge die vernünftig
und wirkungsvoll sind und das bringt
mich zum dritten und letzten Thema das
ist die Bewältigung der migrationskrise
hier bei uns im Land und das hat ja der
Bundeskanzler in seiner Haushaltsrede
auch angesprochen und er hat
angesprochen dass wir die ausgestreckte
Hand nicht ergriffen hätten hat davon
gesprochen dass wir nicht bereit wären
gemeinsam diese Herausforderungen zu
lösen das ist falsch wir waren und wir
sind immer bereit die Hand dort zu
reichen wo ihre Politik dazu führt dass
die Verhältnisse bei uns im Land besser
werden aber das was sie vorschlagen
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage aus
Bundes die grün
bittechön
Herr frei sie haben gerade betont dass
Sie Projekte Sie sie für sinnvoll
erachten unterstützen im Einzelplan 60
werden unter anderem
7,5 Milliarden Euro für die robuste
Unterstützung der Ukraine zur Verfügung
gestellt im Haushaltsausschuss hat sich
ihre Fraktion dazu enthalten wie
bewerten sie
das
also Herr
Kollege wir reden hier über einen
Einzelplan im ganzen und nicht über
konkrete Entscheidungen nein das muss
man schon nein das muss man schon
unterscheiden wissen Sie wir haben ja
hier im Bundestag auch auch in der
letzten Sitzungswoche eine ganze Reihe
von Anträgen auch im Zusammenhang mit
dem von Ihnen angesprochenen Thema
gestellt beispielsweise die Lieferung
von Taurus
Marschflugkörpern die komplette
Koalition hat gegenestimmt also wir
haben weder in Reden noch in Anträgen
noch in Beschlussfassungen je einen
Zweifel daran gelassen dass wir bereit
sind die Ukraine in ihrem Abwehr und
Verteidigungskampf aber auch im Kampf
für Freiheit in Europa so zu
unterstützen wie es notwendig ist und
deshalb ist es gerade ein gutes Beispiel
wo man sagen kann das ist etwas wenn sie
es genauso sehen und große Teile der der
Koalition tun das ja auch sie
tatsächlich auf unsere Unterstützung
bauen können warum haben sie
jetzt und deshalb meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren wir haben in der
letzten Woche ich fahre dort fort wo ich
stehen geblieben bin haben wir in der
letzten Woche beispielsweise ein
rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz hier
verabschiedet ja wir hätten das
unterstützt da waren ja auch ganz gute
Ansätze drin sie sind aber selber davon
ausgegangen dass mit diesem Gesetz und
deswegen ist es der Name eigentlich ein
Euphemismus gerade mal 600 zusätzliche
Rückführungen im Jahr erreicht werden
können und die grüne Fraktion hat es
dazu noch geschafft zwischen dem
Kabinettsbeschluss undter Verabschiedung
hier im Bundestag dieses ohnehin schon
magere Gesetz weiter zu verschlechtern
und da muss ich ihnen einfach sagen wir
stehen nicht dazu bereit als Feigenblatt
für ihre Politik wenn wir davon ausgehen
müssen dass ihre Politik nicht zu guten
Ergebnis in unserem Land führen dann
dürfen wir dem auch nicht folgen und wir
haben es heute in der Rede von der Frau
Hasselmann gehört wie sie versucht hat
uns in Haftung zu nehmen für die
Entscheidung für das Bürgergeld ich
komme zum Schluss frau Präsidentin und
es ist ein gutes Beispiel wir haben
versucht das Bestmögliche für unser Land
zu erreichen die schlimmsten Auswüchse
zu verhindern und die Folge ist dann
dass sie so tun als wäre das unser
Gesetz das ist es mit nichten nicht ich
würde im Gegensatz sagen die
Möglichkeiten dazu haben dann werden wir
dieses Gesetz wieder abschaffen vielen
Dank am Wochenende hat sich die neue
Partei Bündnis Sara
Wagenknecht zum ersten Mal getroffen und
für diese Partei allerdings noch
fraktionslos spricht nun Sarah
Wagenknecht geht hier aus der gleichen
Ecke sage ich mal des Parlaments hervor
wie auch die Linke sitzt die sind noch
relativ zusammen wenn auch nun zwei ver
Parteien
offiziell frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Bundesregierung scheint wild
entschlossen die Zeiten endgültig zu
beenden in denen unser Land für seine
starke Industrie für seinen
erfolgreichen Mittelstand für seine
Erfindungen für seine gut ausgebildeten
Arbeitnehmer und für seine
zurückhaltende
Außenpolitik Inter national geachtet und
vielleicht sogar beneidet wurde statt
Antworten offerieren sie den Bürger
Ausreden und statt Konzepte
Schönfärberei das haben wir vorhin auch
vor allem in der Rede des Kanzlers noch
mal ausführlich gehört und wenn sie
dafür wenn sie dafür Zorn und Empörung
ernten dann gehen Sie auf die Straße und
demonstrieren heldenhaft gegen die
Ergebnisse ihrer eigenen Politik sie
sollten sich lieber fragen was ihre
Verantwortung da dafür ist dass die AFD
sich verdoppelt hat und immer stärker
wird ja wir leben wir leben in einer
Zeit der Kriege und wir leben in einer
Zeit der Krise und trotzdem wächst in
anderen Ländern die Wirtschaft Energie
ist bezahlbar Wohnungen werden gebaut
Rentnerin und Rentner können
einigermaßen von ihren Renten leben die
Migration ist niedriger und in der
Schule lernen die Kinder sogar relativ
korrekt Rechnen und Schreiben es ist
nicht Schuld der Welt sondern es ist ihr
Versagen dass das alles in Deutschland
heute anders ist
Gas Gas kostet in den USA aktuell ein
Viertel dessen was Unternehmen in
Deutschland bezahlen und beiden stellt
jetzt durch Kappung der
exportkapazitäten sicher dass diese
Preisdifferenz auch in Zukunft
fortbesteht Strom ist bei uns teurer als
anderswo und sie genehmigen den
Netzbetreibern noch eine saftige
renditerhöhung oben drauf tanken und
heizen ist für viele kaum noch bezahlbar
und sie sorgen mit höheren CO2 Preisen
und Mehrwertsteuererhöhungen für den
nächsten Preisschub das ist doch alles
absolut rücksichtslos und wäre während
andere Länder sich aus der Finanzierung
des ukrainekrieges zurückziehen bezahlt
Deutschland inzwischen mehr als die
Hälfte aller Waffenlieferungen aus
Europa und wenn es nach Herrn märz und
nach den Waffen beeisterten Grünen und
liberalen geht dann liefern wir
demnächst sogar taurusraket mit denen
selenski dann Moskau angreifen kann und
bringen unser eigenes Land in große
Gefahr was für ein Wahnsinn immer mehr
Waffen für einen nicht gewinnbaren Krieg
aber Kürzungen bei Renten bei Gesundheit
und Bildung wie abgehoben wie
gleichgültig gegenüber den sorgen
normaler Bürger müssen Politiker sein
die solche Entscheidungen treffen senken
Sie die Energiepreise bevor es zu spät
ist indem wir Rohstoffe wieder dort
kaufen wo sie am preiswertesten sind so
wie andere Länder das auch machen
kümmern sie sich um mehr Lehrer um
höhere Löhne und wieder echte
Aufstiegschancen statt weiter die
fleißigen zu enteignen und sich dann
über Fachkräftemangel und fehlende
Arbeitsmotivation zu beklagen der
Spiegel sieht ihr Kabinett inzwischen
auf
dschungelcampniveau GL die Bürger bin
gleich zu Ende die Bürger wären froh
wenn der ampelspug auch noch wenige Tage
dauern würde und wenn sie auch bei Ihnen
die Macht hätten jeden Tag die
schlimmste niet rauszuwählen vielen
Dank SAR wagenlecht war das und der
nächste Redner ist Helge lind er ist
Sprecher für Kultur und
Medien für die SPD
Fraktionen bin ich
nicht frau Präsidentin Liebe Kolleginen
und
Kollegen Liebe Union liebe Frau Dr
schenderlein ihre ja ziemlich
kleinkarrierten gerade zu
apokalyptischen Vision vom Untergang von
Kunst und Kultur in Deutschland die
halten weder einem faktcheck und ich
empfehle da unter anderen die Herren
Frick und Rode zu Unterstützung ein
weder einem faktensteck Stand noch
werden sie dem Ernst der Lage ehrlich
gesagt auch nur im
ansatzgerecht und wenn man dann wie
sie im Ausschuss von Kultur und Medien
im Deutschen Bundestag vor aller Ohren
fast schon zum Fremdschämen das
Staatsziel Kultur mig macht und dann
hier uns vorwurft wir würden das Stats
die Kultur nicht einbringen dann wird
man nur egerecht den schönen deutschen
Wort
scheinheilig ich möchte mich aber an
diesem Tag auf das Wesentliche
konzentrieren wir erleben nämlich und
das betrifft auch viele die tätig sind
im Bereich von Kunst Kultur und Medien
einen regelrechten Kulturkampf von
rechts außen der nämlich darin besteht
nicht ertragen zu wollen dass
Institutionen sich öffnen dass wir uns
um Kolonialismus kümmern dass die
Gesellschaft dieses Landes so vielfältig
se ich sich auch im Bereich von Kunst
und Kultur abbildet und wir können ihn
sagen dieser dieser Kulturkampf den sie
erklärt hat wird von uns angenommen und
er wird gewonnen für dieses Land für
dieses Land in der Breite und für alle
Menschen die zu diesem Land gehören und
nicht in Ihrem Sinne wenn man aber
diesen Punkt ernst nimmt kann man auch
nicht wie sie es tun Antisemitismus
instrumentalisieren denn das ist das
einzige was sie tun ih geht nicht um
Antisemitismus wir müssen aber ernsthaft
in dieser Minute über Antisemitismus im
Bereich von Kunst und Kultur in diesem
Land
reden es ist nämlich kein annehmbarer
und hinnehmbarer Zustand wenn Künstler
und Künstler einem und nicht nur Einzel
schreiben dass sie es nicht wagen sich
frei zu äußern und dass sie es z.B auch
nicht wagen in einem Kulturausschuss
offen zu sprechen weil sie dann keine
Chance haben künstlerisch weiter in
diesem Land tätig zu sein das ist nicht
etwas bei dem wir sagen können das
sollte es nicht geben das darf es nicht
geben und darüber müssen wir reden und
wir können eben auch
nicht hinnehmen so wichtig Diskurs über
Kunstfreiheit sind dass wir die
Kunstfreiheit von Jüdin und Juden in
diesem Land nicht ernst nehmen wir haben
heute gehört durch Eva schppesi und
Marcel Reif welche Schneisen der
Verwüstung von Traumatisierung Schmerz
Ausschluss und Verfolgung Vernichtung
von Juden und Juden in Familien
geschlagen haben deshalb müssen wir
aufschreien wenn es der Fall ist dass
die Kunstfreiheit von jüdischen Künstler
Künstler in diesem Land eben nicht
gewährleistet ist das ist die politische
Frage der wir un stellen müssen und das
sind die politischen Bedingungen die wir
zu schaffen haben Freiheit muss auch
immer die Freiheit der anderen sehen und
deshalb kann es nicht sein und das ist
mit diesem Haushalt zu beantworten auch
mit nächsten und mit unserer
bundeskultur kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss dass wir bei anderen Themen
immer selbstverständlich sagen und
zurecht gesellschaftliche Fragen sind zu
berücksichtigen bei der Kunst und Kultur
aber bei Jüden Juden sagen aber die
Kunstfreiheit nein es geht um die
Kunstfreiheit derer die jüdische
Perspektiven einbringen wollen der haben
wir gerecht zu Hörden und dieser
Verantwortung werden und müssen wir uns
stellen Helge lind und wir kommen zum
einzigen Abgeordneten der zwar jetzt
fraktionslos ist aber seit Anfang der
Legislaturperiode fraktionslos auf war
Stefan
seitler Kollegen nach großen Anstrengung
können wir nun abschließend den Haushalt
für 204 debattieren und ich möchte an
dieser Stelle zunächst danke sagen
infolge des als das
Bundesverfassungsgericht musste an
vielen Stellen gespart werden dass die
Position für unsere nationalen
Minderheiten etwa im Haushalt von Frau
rot davon nicht betroffen sind und für
die Zusammenarbeit dafür bin ich Ihnen
liebe Kollegin und Kollegen
ausgesprochen
dankbar gerade jetzt gerade jetzt ist
dies ein wichtiges Signal für kulturelle
Vielfalt und eine gesunde demokratische
Kultur in
Deutschland die Debatten um Einsparung
im Haushalt haben auch bei uns im Norden
die Gemüter bewegt erst soll bei unseren
Bauern gekürzt werden und dann werden
von einem Tag auf den anderen die
Fischer belastet so oder so es trifft
das Land bei uns an der Küste kommt dazu
dass viele weiter mit der Beseitigung
der Folgen der schweren
jahrhundertsturmflut im vergangenen
Oktober beschäftigt sind ich habe die
zerstörten Orte und das Leid dass das
Wasser der ostse verursacht hat selbst
erlebt auch in anderen Bundesländern
Niedersachsen Bremen Anhalt Thüringen
mussten die Menschen in den vergangenen
Wochen gegen Wassermassen kämpfen um
ihre Existenz zu retten wieder geht es
darum dass der Bund den Betroffenen
hilft als Norddeutscher ist für mich
klar dass wir solidarisch sein müssen
Teil unserer DNA ist es die Ärmel
hochzukrempeln anzupacken wenn Land
unter ist gerade weil Naturkatastrophen
durch den Klimawandel häufiger werden
müssen wir zusammenstehen das macht uns
aus Land als Land aus was aber nicht
geht ist Hilfen ankündigen und sie dann
zu versagen so wie es der Bundeskanzler
gemacht hat die Kritik wurde selbst von
der SPD laut mit diesem mal hü mal hot
verspielen wir das Vertrauen bei den
Leuten und was noch schlimmer und
schlicht ungerecht wäre in einem Fall zu
helfen und im anderen nicht das wäre
Gift für den sozialen Frieden angesichts
des Klimawandels ist es aus meiner Sicht
unerlässlich dass wir uns als Land
besser vorbereiten etwa indem die Leute
sich endlich umfassend gegen
Naturkatastrophen versichern können bis
DAH ist es für mich ein ot der
politischen Gerechtigkeit das Hilfen des
Bundes dort wo sie benötigt werden
verlässlich nach transparenten Kriterien
gewährt werden was diese Kriterien in
einzelnen sind darüber sollte aus meiner
Sicht nicht die Bundesregierung sondern
der Bundestag entscheiden vielen Dank
für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit stefan seitler war das
vom südschleswiik wählerverband und
damit kommen wir hier zur letzten
Rednerin in dieser Debatte zu Einzelplan
4 das ist die die Beauftragte der
Bundesregierung für
Menschenrechtspolitik und humanitäre
Hilfe Luise amsbergell für unsere
Demokratie und für ein vielfältiges Land
und ich finde gerade heute wo es um den
Kulturhaushalt geht ist es auch wichtig
dass wir nicht nur darüber reden was wir
nicht wollen sondern auch was wir wollen
und was wir mit unserer Kulturpolitik
auch ganz konkret fördern und deshalb
ist es so wichtig dass wir wenn es um
die Kulturpolitik geht nicht nur uns auf
die großen Bühnen und die zweifelsohne
hervorragende Hochkultur unseres Landes
beschränken sondern die vielfältige
Realität auch in der Förderpolitik
abbilden und ich bin sehr froh und der
kulturstaatsministerin Claudia rot aber
auch Finanzminister Lindner sehr sehr
dankbar für den Kulturpass und vor allen
Dingen dass wir ihn weiterführen denn
erstmalig gibt ein Förderinstrument die
freie Wahl was finanziell unterstützt
werden soll erstmalig wird nicht
vorgegeben sondern nachgefragt und das
ist schon eine kleine kulturpolitische
Revolution meine Damen und Herren
unsere
Kulturpolitik ist aber natürlich auch
auch Ausdruck dessen wo wir strukturelle
Probleme sehen und weil es noch immer zu
wenig Frauen auf und hinter den Bühnen
sind freue ich mich dass wir mit mewem
ein kleines aber sehr Wichtiges
mentoringpjekt für Frauen in der Musik
Wirtschaft finanzieren weil es sozusagen
auch eine Unterstützung im Bereich der
amateurmusik braucht haben wir mit dem
amateurmikfond das kulturelle Ehrenamt
gestärkt in der Stadt und auch auf dem
Land die Räume die Menschen zu
musizieren und für ihre
Professionalisierung auch brauchen
erstmals fördern wir die riesige
popkulturelle Festivalszene finde ich ja
wirklich das großartigste an diesem
Haushalt in unserem Land schon jetzt ist
dieser Fond um ein fünffaches
überzeichnet was für ein Erfolg und
liebe Claudia wirklich was für ein
klares Zeichen dafür dass wir hier genau
richtig lagen was die Bedarfe
angeht jetzt müssen wir die mittelzügig
entsperren denn für den kommenden Sommer
brauchen die Festivals
Planungssicherheit der schaltschutzfond
wird die Clubs in lärmkonflikten mit
investien in den Lärmschutz unterstützen
das ist ein weiteres Versprechen aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag dass wir jetzt
umsetzen aber meine Damen und Herren
wenn man über Kulturpolitik redet muss
man auch das erwähnen das Clubsterben
werden wir nicht mit Geld aufhalten
können das metov in Hamburg Destillery
in Leipzig Harry kleinen München einige
Clubs sterben laut manche leise und das
so ehrlich müssen wir sein würden wir in
der Hochkultur niemals zulassen Clubs
aber sind Kulturorte Schutzräume gerade
in dieser Zeit extrem wichtig Orte der
kreativen Entfaltung und des
Ausprobierens und deshalb braucht es
rechtlichen Rahmen Rahmenbedingungen die
das stärken und hier liegt natürlich die
Verantwortung in der Bau
nutzungsverordnung und der TA Lärm hier
sind wir als Regierungsfraktion das sage
ich auch so offen noch in der Pflicht
und hier müssen wir noch liefern aber
meine Damen und Herren ich habe das zu
Beginn gesagt Kulturpolitik ist
existenziell für unsere Gesellschaft
existentiell auch genau diese Räume und
Orte zu schützen denn Kultur ist
Ausdruck des menschlichen Daseins des
Menschseins am Ende und ich bin stolz
darauf dass wir es geschafft haben in
diesem Haushalt diesem Anliegen das auch
abzubilden ein Stück näher zu kommen
also vielen Dank auch für deine Arbeit
Claudia
und dafür dass du diese Vielfalt und vor
allen Dingen auch das Potenzial und die
kulturelle schaffenkraft Schaffenskraft
in unserem Land auch siehst das stärkst
und uns da als Parlament auch so eine
gute Leitlinie bist vielen
Dank ich schließe die Aussprache wir
kommen zur Abstimmung über den
Einzelplan 04 Bundeskanzler das war also
nun hier die Debatte zum Einzelplan des
Bundeskanzler
Bundeskanzleramt und die Abgeordneten
werden darüber jetzt namentlich
abstimmen in der westlobby so ist es ja
Usus und in dieser Debatte wurde ja auch
viel über die
Demonstrationen berichtet die sich gegen
Rechtsextremismus im Land entfacht haben
nachdem klar wurde dass in Potzdam
mehrere rechtsextreme sich getroffen
haben und auch aufd Politiker um über
die massenhafte Abschiebung von Menschen
zu diskutieren die entweder ein
Migrationshintergrund haben oder sich
z.B für eine offene Gesellschaft
einsetzen mit dabei war hier auch
die wir hier in der Debatte sehen eine
AFD Abgeordnete sie hat sich nun aber
nicht hier in der Debatte geäußert und
auch Nachfragen von Kollegen zu eben
diesem
Treffen auf die ist sie leider nicht
eingegangen hat aber der Süddeutschen
Zeitung ihre Teilnahme an dem Treffen
bestätigt also wir werden dort
wahrscheinlich noch in Zukunft mehr zu
hören auch das wurde hier in der Debatte
angekündigt begrüßt dass ja auch am
nächsten Wochenende wieder viele
Demonstrationen geplant werden und hier
um den Bundestag um das
reichsgebäude da soll es eine
Menschenkette geben um eben auch gegen
Rechtsextremismus zu
demonstrieren wir schauen jetzt auf den
nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt wir bleiben natürlich
im Haushalt 2024 und der nächste
Tagesordnungspunkt ist der Einzelplan
Auswärtiges Amt der dem Auswärtigen Amt
sollen 6,71 Milliarden Euro zugesprochen
werden das ist ein Minus von
768 Millionen Euro allerdings immerhin
noch mehr als ursprünglich im
Regierungsentwurf für dieses Ministerium
vorgesehen waren die
bundesaußenministerin Annalena berbock
hatte damals auch von schmerzhaften
Einsparungen gesprochen so wie es viele
Ministerinnen und Minister empfunden
haben als natürlich klar war das gespart
werden muss sie wird hier in der Debatte
auch sprechen allerdings lässt sie erst
einmal auch das machen einige
Ministerinnen und Minister hier erst
einmal eine Runde der Fraktionen
durchlaufen dann kann man schon mal
hören wohin so die Debatte geht und die
Abgeordneten gehen nun auf stehen nun
auf um abzustimmen die Außenpolitiker
bleiben natürlich noch hier um eben
dieser Debatte zu
lauschen erster Redner das können wir
schon mal sagen ist KST kör ob man im
Rechnungsprüfungsausschuss der sich als
erstes dazu äußern
wird ich eröffne die Aussprache das Wort
hat der Kollege Karsten Körber für die
CDU CSU
Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren die
Beratungen zum diesjährigen
Bundeshaushalt liefen diesmal anders als
jemals zuvor was im Haushaltsausschuss
aber auch innerhalb der
Regierungskoalition in den vergangenen
Wochen und Monaten zu erleben war lässt
einen bestenfalls irritiert
zurück die Art und Weise wie dieser
Prozess ablief hat der parlamentarischen
Demokratie und dem Vertrauen von
Menschen in Politik schweren Schaden
zugefügt und damit meine ich nicht den
Streit an sich der gehört zweifelsohne
dazu sondern ich meine vor allem den
Stil in welchem der Streit innerhalb der
Regierung ausgetragen wurde das
haushaltsaufstellungsverfahren war von
Beginn an vom Streit und der Uneinigkeit
innerhalb der Koalition gekennzeichnet
die Vorstellung der eckwerde wurde erst
verschoben dann komplett gestrichen der
Kabinettsbeschluss wurde dreimal
verschoben und dann erst beschlossen als
es gar nicht mehr anders ging und heute
wissen wir das war erst der Anfang denn
dann wurde es richtig schlimm mit dem
Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes vom 15
November wurde erstmals in der
Geschichte unseres Landes ein
Bundeshaushalt für nichtig erklärt und
nicht die Union und auch nicht das
Bundesverfassungsgericht ist schuld
daran dass der zweite nach agshaushalt
2021 verfassungswidrig ist es waren
allein die Taschenspielertricks der
Ampel die zum Urteil aus Karlsruhe
geführt
haben und es ist es ist schlechter Sel
dann zu versuchen andere für das eigene
Versagen verantwortlich zu machen am Tag
nach der Urteilsverkündung hat
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner zugegeben
dass er noch nicht überschauen könne
welche Auswirkungen das Urteil auf den
Haushalt haben wird das ist ehrlich und
überhaupt nicht zu beanstanden aber jede
vernünftige Regierung hätte doch an
dieser Stelle einen neuen
Regierungsentwurf vorlegen müssen
stattdessen trängte die Ampel darauf die
nur für einen Tag später angesetzte
Bereinigungssitzung doch durchzuziehen
das war der hilflose Versuch die
Tragweite des teils herunterz Spielen
nicht besonders souverän und auch kein
guter
Stil und auch im Inneren bei uns im
Bundestag fürht das Verhalten der
ampelmehrheit vor allem auch im
Haushaltsausschuss leider zu unnötigen
Verwerfungen und in letzter Konsequenz
auch zu einer Entwertung des Parlaments
nach der ersten Bereinigungssitzung ging
es dann am 18 Januar diesen Jahres in
die zweite bereitigungssitzung und
stetiger Begleiter war in diesem Prozess
wiederum sie ahnen es der schlechte Stil
dort hat die ampelmehrheit nach
Gutsherrenart entschieden welcher
Minister in den Ausschuss kommt und wer
nicht generell ist im Verhältnis
zwischen Regierung und Parlament da
einiges ins Rutschen geraten und liebe
ampelkollegen ich rufe Ihnen zu hören
sie auf sich zum handlang der Regierung
zu machen sie sind deren
Kontrollorgan her der hier die
verfahrensmehrheit auszunutzen weil man
Angst oder keine Lust auf kritische
Fragen hat ist ein Unding und es schadet
letzten Endes uns allen und auch sie
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin berbock
kann ich leider von dieser Kritik nicht
ausnehmen sie hielten es offenbar nicht
für nötig zu uns in den
Haushaltsausschuss zu kommen obwohl sie
an diesem Tag in Berlin und auch hier im
Plenum war da haben sie sich wirklich
falsch beraten
lassen jeder der es waren auch andere
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus dem
Kabinett nicht eingeladen sind aber
trotzdem in den Ausschuss gekommen wir
hätten uns jedenfalls sehr gefreut wenn
Sie das gemacht hätten zum et des
Auswärtigen Amtes der et liegt jetzt bei
6,7 Milliarden das sind so ca 10% unter
dem Ansatz des vergangenen Jahres das
Auswärtige Amt hat insgesamt einen
konsolidierungsbetrag von 200 Millionen
Euro geleistet für die humanitäre Hilfe
wo ursprünglich eine Erhöhung im
parlamentarischen Verfahren von 700
Millionen Euro vorgesehen wurde gehen
die 200 Millionen Weg jetzt sind wir
jetzt bei ein Plus von 500 Millionen
aber im wissen dass die Abrede zwischen
dem Auswärtigen Amt und dem
Bundesfinanzministerium gilt sollten
hier unabwendbare Bedarfe entstehen wird
das BMF auch zusätzliche Mittel
bereitstellen zum Schluss mit schlechten
Stil wird man die Wunden nicht heilen
die die Ampel inzwischen in unser Land
und unsere Gesellschaft gerissen hat und
ich wünsche mir von der Ampel dass sie
zu einem geordneten miteinander
zurückfinden und ich wünsche mir das im
Interesse unseres Landes vielen
Dank das Wort hat die Kollegin Jamila
Schäfer für die Fraktion Bündnis
90il Schäfer ist vorsitzend des
bundesfinanzierungsgremiume Kollegen und
Kollegen lieber Herr kber ich kann ja
guten ein paar Kritikpunkte auch an dem
Prozess gibt aber ganz ehrlich wir haben
als wir dieses Urteil erhalten haben
direkt darauf reagiert wir haben mehrere
Anhörungen gemacht im
Haushaltsausschuss wir haben die
Parlamentsrechte sogar gestärkt indem
wir z.B mehr Beteiligung bei den üpl
Beschlüssen eingeführt haben und wir
haben dann keinerlei Änderungsanträge
von ihnen gesehen und sich dann hier so
hinzustellen und diesen ganzen Prozess
in der in der Rede hauptsächlich zu
kritisieren finde ich dann schon ein
bisschen wenig ehrlich gesagt
und ich finde gut dass wir trotz dieses
Urteils jetzt einen sehr guten Haushalt
aufgestellt haben und dazu möchte ich
jetzt auch
sprechen ein paar allgemeine Bemerkungen
zur Außenpolitik bald jäht sich der
Anfang des russischen angriffskriegs auf
die Ukraine zum zweiten Mal unzähige
unschuldige Menschen sind seitdem
gestorben und es ist sehr gut und
wichtig dass wir die Ukraine militärisch
humanitär und finanziell stark
unterstützen und ich halte es auch für
wichtig diese unützung noch auszuweiten
denn wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass
Putin sich ermutigt fühlt noch weiter zu
eskalieren und
neben neben dem 24 Februar 2022 ist auch
der 7 Oktober 2023 ein Tag an dem die
Welt eine andere wurde auch mit Blick
auf den Krieg im Gaza stehen wir zurecht
auf der Seite des Völkerrechts und klar
zur Selbstverteidigung das bedeutet wir
stehen ein für die Sicherheit Israel und
für Israel Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung und wir
stehen und wir stehen für die Achtung
des humanitären Völkerrechts und deshalb
ist es auch so richtig und wichtig
anzumahnen dass die Z Zivilbevölkerung
im Gazastreifen noch besser geschützt
werden muss und dafür zu sorgen dass die
humanitäre Hilfe auch richtig ankommt
und zwar nicht bei der Hamas die die
Menschen als Schutzschild missbraucht
sondern bei der leidenden
Zivilbevölkerung und selbst ständlich
müssen die schwerwiegenden Vorwürfe
gegen die Mitarbeiter von unwra
aufgeklärt werden und zwar
lückenlos und selbstverständlich muss
humanitäre Hilfe in Gaza sichergestellt
werden die Menschenrechtslage dort zu
verbessern ist nämlich im Interesse der
Sicherheit Israels und auch im Interesse
einer langfristigen Stabilität in der
Region und jetzt komme ich zum Haushalt
das alles zeigt dass die
außenpolitischen Herausforderung immer
größer geworden sind und deshalb freut
es mich auch sehr dass es uns gelungen
ist im parlamentarischen Verfahren den
et noch um
552 Millionen Euro zu erhöhen auf 6,7
Milliarden Euro und gerade mit Blick auf
die weltweit zunehmenden Krisen übrigens
auch z.B in Regionen wie dem Horn von
Afrika ist die Erhöhung der humanitären
Hilfe um 500 Millionen Euro im Vergleich
zum Regierungsentwurf ein wichtiges
Zeichen und mit den Umschichtungen
parlamentarischen Verfahren haben wir
auch noch wichtige andere Akzente
gesetzt wir haben z.B die
Auslandsschulen gestärkt die
jugendaustausche ich freue mich aber
auch ganz besonders dass wir die
konzeptionellen Vorbereitungen für die
Anlaufstelle zur Rückgabe von Human
remains jetzt angehen das ist ein großer
Schritt um die Bestattung von Opfern von
kolonialverbrechen durch ihre
Angehörigen jetzt endlich nach so langer
Zeit zu ermöglichen und auch die
institutionelle Förderung von merics
also die mercato Institute für ke China
studies ist ein wichtiger Schritt um die
chinakompetenz der deutschen
Außenpolitik zu
stärken und damit wir auch in Zeiten
knapper Mittel die Auswirkung unserer
Mittel verstärken möchten wir das
zuwendungsrecht entbürokratisieren und
haben dafür auch einen maßgabebeschluss
auf den Weg
gebracht ich möchte mich am Ende meiner
Rede noch mal ganz ausdrücklich bedanken
für die vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit
mit meinen
mitberichterstatterkolleginnen und ich
bin froh dass wir den Einzelplan
gemeinsam im parlamentarischen Verfahren
so gut aufgestellt haben ich bedanke
mich auch bei unserer Ministerin und dem
Haus für die gute Zusammenarbeit und
bitte natürlich um die Zustimmung zum
Einzelplan 05 vielen
Dank bevor wir in der Debatte fortfahren
mache ich darauf aufmerksam dass die
Zeit zur Abgabe der Stimme zur
namentlichen Abstimmung um
16:22 Uhr abläuft sollten also noch auch
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Hause sein
die ihre Stimme noch nicht abgegeben
haben wäre jetzt ein guter
Zeitpunkt wir setzen die Debatte fort
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Dr Michael
espendiller für die AFD
[Applaus]
Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Kollegen liebe Zuschauer im
Saal und bei Youtube und natürlich liebe
Frau berbock einer meiner
lieblingsschlagzeilen in der letzten
Woche war russische Kampagne aufgedeckt
das Auswärtige Amt soll eine
Datenanalyse vorgenommen haben die
natürlich total vertraulich ist aber
ganz zufällig dem SPIEGEL vorliegt und
diese Datenanalyse kommt zu dem Schluss
dass über xtausendfach deutschsprachige
Tweets abgesetzt wurden die den Vorwurf
beinhalten die Bundesregierung
vernachlässige die eigene b völkerung um
die Ukraine zu unterstützen oh mein Gott
wie kommt man die denn da drauf da ist
man ja völlig schockiert oder aber man
ist informiert man muss nur den Bericht
des Finanzministeriums vom dezember 2023
lesen in dem steht dass Deutschland seit
Kriegsbeginn Gesamtausgaben in Höhe von
27,8 Milliarden Euro zu Gunsten der
Ukraine veranlasst hat und diese Zahlen
beinhalten noch nicht mal die deutschen
Beiträge für die EU-Programme also 27 ,8
Milliarden Euro das ist in etwa der
2024er ETA für das Auswärtige Amt das
Familienministerium und das
Landwirtschaftsministerium
zusammengerechnet aber für diese Ampel
des Grauens sind das vermutlich alles
nur Peanuts denn Strom kommt aus der
Steckdose Geld wächst auf den Bäumen und
Stylisten werden vom Steuerzahler
bezahlt apropos Steuerzahler während wir
hier zu Lande die Einkommen unserer
Bürger mit Steuersätzen zwischen 14 und
45% belast
gibt es in der Ukraine eine schlanke
Flat Text von 18% Einkommensteuer plus
1,5% Kriegssteuer das heißt der
durchschnittliche ukrainische Oligarch
zahlt prozentual weniger Steuern als die
meisten normalen Arbeitnehmer in
Deutschland vermutlich lief auch deshalb
die weihnachtliche Skisaison in der
Ukraine wieder recht gut in den Genuss
dieses Vergnügens kommen natürlich nur
diejenigen die es sich leisten können
und auf wundersame Weise nicht bei ihren
Leuten an der Front sind an der Front wo
ganze Generation von Ukrainern von ihrem
Präsidenten in den Tod geschickt werden
anstatt endlich
waffenstillstandsverhandlung zu starten
Herr Abgeordnete ich habe die Uhr
angehalten gestatten Sie eine Frage oder
Bemerkung des Abgeordneten F nein
danke auch das interessiert in der Ampel
natürlich keinen in Deutschland Flattern
der weil die Nebenkostenabrechnung für
Mieter in die Briefkästen die zum Teil
horrende Nachzahlung im stelligen
Bereich fordern man schätzt dass es
durchschnittlich 581 € Nachzahlung pro
Mieter gewesen sind Preistreiber Nummer
1 die Energiekosten nun werden die
Märchenerzähler der Regierung wieder
einwenden dass Putin Schuld an den hohen
Energiepreisen ist das ist aber nicht
die Wahrheit denn es ist die
Außenpolitik und die Energiepolitik der
Ampel und ihrer schwarzroten
Vorgängerregierung die uns das
eingebrockt
haben mir hat übrigens auch noch keiner
erklären können warum es jetzt so viel
besser ist abhängig vom amerikanischen
LNG zu sein statt vom russischen Gas an
der bösen Politik von Putin kann es ja
nicht liegen sonst dürfte die Regierung
auch keine energiedeals mit den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten machen
ich weiß ja nicht ob sie schon davon
gehört haben aber mit den Frauenrechten
dort sieht es nicht gut aus aber die
sind der Bundesregierung ganz
offensichtlich auch egal ebenso wie die
Menschenrechte der Israelis die von
ihren Hamas Nachbarn regelmäßig mit
Raketen beschlossen beschossen und aufs
barbarisen niedergemetzelt werden
immerhin unterstützt die Bundesregierung
seit Jahren das sogenannte Palästinenser
Hilfswerk und Rea mit Millionen
Beiträgen und seit Ewigkeiten gibt es
Belege dafür dass genau diese
Organisation die Terroristen der Hamas
unterstützt auf X haben wir dann am
Sonntag erfahren dürfen dass 12
Mitarbeiter sogar am um Überfall der
Hamas auf Israel am 7 Oktober letzten
Jahres beteiligt gewesen waren und genau
aus diesen längstbekkannten Gründen
fordert meine Fraktion seit Jahren immer
und immer wieder die an un einzustellen
und un komplett
aufzulösen doch es passiert immer wieder
das gleiche wenn die große mediale
Empörungswelle rollt werden die Zahlung
Medien wirksam eingefroren nur um sie
kurze Zeit später heimlich wieder
aufzunehmen und so unterstützt diese
Bundesregierung nicht nur Terroristen
und Mörder sondern z.B auch weiterhin
die Schlepper im Mittelmeer auch hier
haben wir übrigens die Streichung der
Mittel
beantragt und wenn wir einmal bei
Streichung sind wir haben auch beantragt
dass die Mittel für die politischen
Stiftungen im Etat des Auswärtigen Amtes
um 84 Millionen Euro gekürzt werden mit
diesem Geld betreiben sämtliche
Altparteien eine Art eigenes
botschaftsnetzwerk schauen sie mal auf
die Website z.B der Friedrich Naumann
Stiftung dort hat man weltweit Standorte
z.B in Manila Islamabad Lima Harare und
Tiflis und so ist das bei sämtlichen
Stiftung der Altparteien bis auf bei der
AFD natürlich aber die Frage ist doch
eigentlich muss der deutsche steuerzah
das Bezahlen unsere Antwort darauf ist
ganz Klip klar nein das muss er nicht
und indem wir uns diese Frage bei allen
Positionen des etas von Frau berbock
gestellt haben konnten wir
Einsparpotenzial in einer Gesamthöhe von
1,4 Milliarden Euro identifizieren damit
bräuchten wir
21,5% weniger Geld als diese Ampel des
Grauens und ganz ehrlich ich denke da
geht auch noch mehr vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
ich komme zurück zum Einzelplan
04 die Zeit für die namentliche
Abstimmung ist abgelaufen ich Frage
dennoch gibt es noch ein Mitglied des
Hauses welches seine Stimme nicht
abgegeben hat das ist nicht der Fall ich
schließe die Abstimmung und bitte die
Schriftführerin und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu beginnen das
der Abstimmung wir Ihnen später
bekanntgegeben und damit geht es dann
hier in der Debatte weiter wie papenck
ist die nächste Rednerin sie sitzt für
die SPD Fraktion im
Haushaltsausschuss sehrehte frau
Präsidentin sehrte Frau Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Besucherin und Besucher ich komme zurück
zur Sachlichkeit und zu Beratung let
wir haben h nämlich in den letzten
Wochen als ampelhaushälter die für den
et des
auswtigenamtes zuständig sind hinter den
Kulissen viel bewegt wir haben nicht nur
Zahlen umher geschoben oder den Rotstift
angesetzt sondern wir haben auch
intensiv darüber beraten wie wir
verfahren modernisieren und verschlanken
können genau damit haben wir auch in den
letzten beiden Jahren schon begonnen als
wir die vis digigitalisierung in unseren
Botschaften und Behörden auf den Weg
gebracht haben was genau meine ich damit
es geht hier um weniger Papierformulare
und dadurch weniger Aufwand für alle
Seiten beim Bundesamt für auswertige
Angelegenheiten funktioniert das bereits
sehr gut und genau da machen wir jetzt
weiter das Amt soll sich nämlich vor
allen um die Fachkräfte Einwanderung
kümmern und dass wir die dringend
brauchen da sind wir uns hier alle einig
liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und deshalblen wir hier weiter
indem wir unnötige Bürokratie
abbauen hier komme ich direkt zu den
kleinen
Nichtregierungsorganisationen für die
auch das Bundesamt zuständig ist diese
unabhängigen deutschen Organisationen
gehören zu den wichtigsten
zivilgesellschaftlichen Partnern unserer
Außenpolitik indem sie für uns Projekte
im Ausland durchführen helfen sie uns
Menschen in vielen Ländern weltweit zu
erreichen die Helferinnen und Helfer
kümmern sich um den Schutz der
Menschenrechten sie kümmern sich darum
dass die Auswirkung von Krieg
hungersnoten und dem Klimawandel
abgefedert werden für ihr großes
Engagement möchte ich Ihnen hier meinen
Dank
aussprechen bei diesen kleinen
Organisation fließt oft
unverhältnismäßig viel Zeit in die
Bearbeitung von unzähligigen Akten mit
dem Ergebnis dass auch der Aufwand für
unsere Verwaltung unverhältnismäßig hoch
ist unsere deutschen Regeln mit mit dem
wir hier manchmal schon an unsere
Grenzen stoßen funktionieren am anderen
Ende der Welt nicht versuchen Sie mal in
Mumbai nach einer Fahrt mit einem
tuktuck ein beförderungsnachweis zu
bekommen als jemand der schon oft in
Indien war kann ich Ihnen sagen das
funktioniert
nicht und deshalb haben wir jetzt solche
unsinnigen Regeln
abgeschafft warum weil sie in vielen
Teilen der Welt vollkommen praxisfern
sind und auch unsere Verwaltung
Mehrarbeit bescheren dafür haben wir uns
alle an einen Tisch gesetzt und mehrere
Runden gedreht und das hat sich auch
ausgezahlt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir sind zu vielen praktischen
Lösungen gekommen wie wir
selbstverständlich im Rahmen der
bundeshaushaltsordnung für effektivere
und effizientere Abläufe sorgen damit
entlasten
wir damit entlasten wir nämlich beide
Seiten die Verwaltung und die NGOs und
das wollen wir hier übermorgen im
Parlament beschließen
so und dass wir überflüssige Regeln
abschaffen das erwarten natürlich auch
alle anderen von uns und da kann ich
sagen es ist bei allen meinen Gesprächen
die ich in meinem Wahlkreis im
Nordwesten Brandenburgs führe immer ein
großes Thema alle wünschen sich
einfachere und praxistaugliche Prozesse
und deswegen ist es gut dass das
Bundesjustizministerium erst vor kurzem
ganz vor kurzen ein Gesetzentwurf für
ein viertes Bürokratie entlastungsgesetz
vorgelegt hat
wir
handeln jetzt möchte ich noch auf ein
anderes Thema zu sprechen kommen das uns
in unseren parlamentarischen Beratungen
sehr wichtig war nämlich unser
Verhältnis zu China und die Frage wie
wir uns in Zukunft gegenüber dem Land
aufstellen China ist unser wichtigster
Handelspartner noch vor den
USA deshalb hat die Volksrepublik für
unsere Wirtschaft einen besonderen
Stellenwert aber unser mit ihr verändert
sich immer mehr die Bundesregierung hat
dazu im letzten Jahr eine eigene
Strategie vorgelegt darin ist unter
anderem festgehalten welche Weichen wir
jetzt stellen wollen wir wollen
einerseits unsere wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit mit China auf einem hohen
Niveau halten andererseits wollen wir
Abhängigkeiten in kritischen Bereichen
reduzieren hier setzt auch das mercato
Institute V China studies an eine
unabhängige forschungseinricht
die Arbeit dieses Instituts stärken wir
jetzt mit diesem Haushalt
deutlich und dadurch bauen wir auch
unsere eigene China Expertise aus ein
gutes Ergebnis liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich möchte zum Schluss noch auf
die humanitäre Hilfe zu sprechen kommen
also das ist die unsere Soforthilfe für
Menschen in Not es ist eine gute
Nachricht dass es nicht zu den von der
Bundesregierung geplanten Kürzung bei
der ären Hilfe kommt was kommt sind 500
Millionen Euro zusätzlich die wir
ampelhaushälter auf den von der
Bundesregierung vorgelegten
Haushaltsentwurf 24
drauflegen das ist ein starkes Signal
das von uns als
Regierungskoalition hier im Parlament
ausgeht und es macht deutlich wie
wichtig uns die humanitäre Hilfe als
Teil unserer zivilen Krisenbewältigung
im Ausland
ist damit bleibt dieser Posten auch in
diesem Jahr ein Schwerpunkt im Haushalt
des Auswärtigen
Amtes alles in allem haben wir gute
Ergebnisse erzielt dafür mein Dank
gestatten Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung
aus der
aufdaktion ich komme zum Schluss mein
Dank gilt allen Kollegen im
Haushaltsausschuss in den
Fachausschüssen vielen Dank für diese
erfolgreichen Beratung danke
schön soweit wiebge
parkenbuck von der SPD Fraktion und Otto
Fricke haben wir heute schon gehört aber
als haushaltspolitischer Sprecher ist er
in der haushaltswoche natürlich sehr
gefragt also redet er nun auch wieder
für die FDP Fraktion meine lieben
Kolleginnen Kollegen am Anfang darf ich
diesmal Shakespeare setzen und zwar
lässt der Thomas Morus der übrigens wie
viele wissen der Schutzpatron der
Politiker ist sagen in jedem Land das
nicht das eure ist dort W
die Fremden und gute Außenpolitik muss
eigentlich dafür sorgen dass das
möglichst wenig passiert das nämlich
egal wo wir als Deutschland auftreten
wir nicht die Fremden sind meine D
Herren die Haushaltsberatungen sind hier
nicht einfach gewesen ja es ist auf
vieles hingewiesen worden aber Kollege
kber ich möchte dann doch noch eines mal
noch mal richtig stellen
hier die Außenministerin ist zur zweiten
Bereinigungssitzung bei der ersten war
sie ja dabei da sind do Fragen gestellt
worden sie ist deswegen nicht zu dieser
zweiten bereinungssitzung eingeladen
worden weil es keine wesentlichen
Veränderung gab und noch viel wichtiger
weil es seitens der CDU CSU auch nicht
nur einen Antrag inhaltlich gegeben
hätte über den wir als sie als
Opposition mit uns als Regierung dann
hätten reden können und dann zu sagen zu
nichts müsste eine Ministerin kommen das
wäre die Verschwendung von guter
Arbeitszeit meine Damen und
Herren meine Damen und Herren nein ich
rede nicht schön sondern ich glaube dass
die CD Fraktion immer noch nicht
verstanden hat dass Demokratie und
Parlament Diskurs heißt und das heißt
von allen Seiten Diskurs und sie
verweigern sich dem Diskurs und erkennen
dabei nicht dass sie sich dadurch selber
schlechter machen und damit auch das
Land das diesen Diskurs braucht das ist
ihr eigentliches Problem meine Damen und
Herren es ist von der Kollegin
papenbrouck und ich danke ihr genauso
wie der Kollegin Schäfer aber auch dem
hauptberichterstatter Körber im Rahmen
guter berichterstattergespräche sehr
sehr viel auch technisches verändert
worden und das halte ich auch für sehrh
sehr wichtig ich will ausdrücklich aber
noch mal darauf hinweisen Frau
Ministerin dass die Berichterstatter bei
der Frage wie man globale Minderausgaben
nutzt doch einige Grenzen aufgesetzt
haben und ich will hoffen dass das jetzt
ausreicht um klar zu machen dass wenn
man eineem Ministerium mehr Freiheiten
gibt Sie diese bitte aber auch
verantwortungsvoll nutzen werden und wir
werden uns das in den nächsten Monaten
auch genauer angucken dennoch will ich
ausdrücken noch mal sagen die auswärtige
Kultur und Bildungspolitik ist kein
Steinbruch für eine globale
Minderausgabe und wenn wir bei götee
auch weiterhin den Prozess wie ich
glaube gemeinsam verfolgen dann geht es
uns auch da nicht darum Auswärtige
Kulturpolitik abzubrechen es geht uns
darum sie besser zu machen zu sehen wo
wir sie richtig Gewichten können und ich
will das ausdrücklich noch mal sagen es
ist deutsche Auswärtige Kulturpolitik
und es ist nicht eine allgemeine wir
gucken mal was in anderen Ländern an
Kultur da ist das ist die Aufgabe von
Goethe und darauf glaube ich müssen wir
auch sehr sehr viel Wert legen und ich
sage das auch und das müssen wir dann
auch sehen wenn in Zukunft
möglicherweise Veränderung bei Goethe
noch auf uns zukommen werden meine Damen
und Herren ein zweiter Punkt die Frage
was wir sonst noch alles gemacht haben
wir haben uns und das darf ich dann
sagen beim Thema Ukraine auch um unser
partnerparlament in der Ukraine
gekümmert dass wir aus diesem Etat mit
1,8 Millionen unterstützen und auch da
gilt wieder ein Land wie die Ukraine das
zu uns in Europa gehören will das auch
zur EU gehören will worüber man
sicherlich diskutieren kann wann wie und
auf welchem Basis das von uns aus als
nationales Parlament zu unterstützen
sollte unsere ureigene Aufgabe sein und
ich glaube dass wir auch damit noch eine
gute Tat als Berichterstatter getan
haben
schließlich schließlich will ich aber
auch noch auf einen Punkt hinweisen die
Vereinfachung des zuwendungsrechtes die
ja angesprochen worden ist wo einige so
ein bisschen gelächelt haben das ist
aber doch genau das wodrunter wir leiden
wir wollen doch dass unsere Politik
funktioniert nun mag man sagen in der
Opposition wir wollen es eigentlich
nicht aber wenn man dann wieder
vielleicht irgendwann an der Regierung
ist dann will man doch auch dass es
funktioniert und deswegen kann ich nur
darum bitten Bürokratie kommt oft auf
falschverstandener
kontrollnotwendigkeit die aber dann am
Ende nur noch in berichtsnotwendigkeit
endet weil am Ende gar niemand mehr da
ist um es zu kontrollieren das haben wir
hier gut gemacht auch die Frage Anträge
nicht mehr immer nur auf Deutsch stellen
zu müssen ich glaube ein Auswärtiges Amt
kann es durch das gesamte Amt schaffen
dass man da auch alles auf Englisch
beantragen kann wenn es für diejenigen e
einfache ist statt immer noch offizielle
teure Übersetzung notwendig zu machen
und schließlich darf
ich alle die noch Lust haben irgendwann
mal Sachen zu lesen auf den Paragraphen
8a des Haushaltsgesetzes hinweisen wo
wir neu eingeführt haben sorgfalls und
Prüfpflichten bei Leistungen des Bundes
die nicht zur Finanzierung
terroristischer Aktivitäten eingesetzt
werden dürfen und nicht an Empfänger
gewährt werden dürfen die terroristische
Vereinigung sind oder terroristische
Vereinigung unterstützen und das sage
ich im Rahmen der Debatte mit unwah hier
ist noch mehr möglich wir haben ja einen
Kompromiss geschlossen aber ich sage
deutlich wenn wir von deutschen
Unternehmen im Rahmen der Lieferkette
ethische Verantwortung erwarten dann
erwarte ich auch von denigen denen wir
Steuerzahlergeld geben dass sie bei der
Frage wohin das Geld am Ende geht
genauso aufpassen wie ein Mittelständler
ist in Deutschland muss meine Damen und
Herren das alles gesagt haben glaube ich
dass wir hier einen Einzelplan haben mit
dem wir am Ende vieles erreichen können
und mit dem wir auch das sage ich ganz
deutlich in anderen Ländern zeigen
können dass wir eben nicht fremde
sondern Freunde sind herzlichen
Dank aus dem et des auswtigen Amts
werden auch die Gothe Institut
finanziert und da soll nun gespart
werden von 158 Instituten sollen neun
geschlossen werden Ergebnis der
namentlichen
Schlussabstimmung zum Einzelplan 04
Geschäftsbereich des Bundeskanzlers und
des Bundeskanzleramts bekannt abgegebene
Stimmkarten
679 mit ja haben
386 Abgeordnete gestimmt mit Nein
stimmten 293
niemand hat sich enthalten der
Einzelplan 04 ist angenommen und damit
also der Etat des
Kanzleramts Ausgaben in Höhe von 3,87
Milliarden Euro sind für 2024
vorgesehen und damit kommen wir wieder
zum Bereich auswärtiges Jürgen hart
spricht als nächstes für die
Unionsfraktion und
Kollegen ich möchte Eingehen auf die
Vorrednerinnen und Papenbrock da ist
über die humanitäre Hilfe geredet worden
die Kollegin Schäfer hat sich dazu
verstiegen zu sagen die würde um 500
Millionen erhöht ich möchte darauf
hinweisen dass die Bundesregierung die
humanitäre Hilfe um 900 Millionen kürzen
wollte der Haushaltsausschuss hat davon
500 Millionen zurückgenommen es bleibt
aber ein Minus von 400 Millionen Euro
bei der humanitären Hilfe und wenn die
Kollegin Papenbrock sagt die humanitäre
Hilfe sei ein Schwerpunkt dieses
Haushaltes dann sage ich der Haushalt
ist insgesamt mit - 10% gegen dem
Vorjahr absolut zu dürftig ausgestattet
und humanitäre Hilfe wird sogar noch
größer gekürzt als der Durchschnitt
dieses Haushalts also bitte überprüfen
Sie Ihre Aussagen die humanitäre Hilfe
wird gekürzt während wir jeden Tag im
Fernsehen sehen und den Zeitung lesen
dass das Elend in der Welt zunimmt das
ist eine Ungemessene Reaktion auf die
Situation offichtig ist der auswärtige
et als weiches Ziel identifiziert worden
den Kanzleramt den Finanzministerium den
- 10% in einem Politikbereich in der
alle in Deutschland parteiübergreifend
und in der Bevölkerung sagen wir müssen
in außen und Sicherheit einen
Schwerpunkt setzen das ist ein
Widerspruch ich möchte aber auf die
aktuellen Herausforderung der
Außenpolitik eingehen und an dieser
Stelle auch für die CDU CS Fraktion
anmerken dass wir das Engagement der
Außenministerin und anderer Minister der
Regierung für Israel und bei den
Bemühungen um Minderung der folgen und
der Leiden des hamasanschlags auf die
Israelis und der gegenwärtigen Situation
dass wir das anerkennen dass wir die
Arbeit die da reingesteckt wird schätzen
und dass wir auch jetzt nicht anstehen
in klein klein der Frage nachzugehen ob
das Gespräch und die Reise jetzt richtig
oder falsch war das wird man am Ende des
Tages erst sagen können und die
Bemühungen sind offensichtlich ich habe
allerdings an der Außenpolitik der
Bundesregierung einiges auszusetzen und
zwar glaube ich dass der 7 oktober für
die nah und mittelostpolitik auch eine
Zeitenwende gewesen ist und das über die
Frage wie wir jetzt im Blick auf
Geiselbefreiung und im Blick auf Frieden
zwischen Israel und den Palästinensern
und in der Region insgesamt angehen dass
wir zu kurz springen wenn wir uns nicht
auch die Frage stellen ob in einigen
anderen wichtigen Politikfeldern neue
Weichen weichen neugestellt werden
müssen und da sehe ich an erster Linie
die
iranpitik der 7 oktober hat uns vor
Augen geführt dass letztlich der größte
Spoiler der größte Störer des Friedens
in der Region der Iran ist mit seinen
Proxis mit seinen Stellvertreter
Terrororganisationen Hamas die sogar vom
Iran Waffen und Munition bekommen hat
hutis im Jemen die die jemenitische
Regierung unter Druck gesetzt haben die
das Land transalieren und die jetzt auch
Handelsschiffe im Roten Meer angreifen
und natürlich die hisbolla im Libanon
die das Land in geielhaft genommen hat
und Israel bedroht und wenn wir den 7
Oktober nicht zum Anlass nehmen unsere
Iranpolitik zu ändern dann springen wir
zu
kurz die Iranpolitik gegenüber einem
Land das wöchentlich politische
Gefangene hinrichtet ich erwarte dass
die Bundesregierung nicht nur die
Revolutionären Garden als
Terrororganisation listet damit wir Ihre
wirtschaftliche Betätigung in
Deutschland Europa austrocknen können
sondern dass sie auch ganz konkret mit
listungsmaßnahmen gegenüber
regimangehörigen mit Ausweisung von
Diplomaten reagiert wenn wie vor wenigen
Tagen geschehen und zwischen den Jahren
geschehen politische Gefangene im Iran
hingerichtet
werden ich sehe eine weitere
Notwendigkeit einer solchen neuen
Weichenstellung in der Politik gegenüber
der arabischen Welt wir haben damals
schon lange mit dem SPD Außenminister
Heiko mas gestritten über die Frage wie
unterstützen wir eigentlich
Saudi-Arabien und V bei ihrem Kampf
gegen die die hutis im Jemen
wir haben mit spitzen Fingern das Thema
angefasst weil uns die Art und Weise wie
die Saudis agiert haben und die va weil
uns das nicht gefallen hat jetzt ist das
Ergebnis dass die huti weiter erstarkt
sind und dass wir nun gezwungen sind
selbst etwas zu unternehmen mit einem
Mittelmeer mit einem Mandat im Roten
Meer was uns ja in der übernächsten
Woche vermutlich ins Haus steht und das
dritte ist dass wir gegenüber unwahr wie
ich finde eine andere Politik brauchen
Derin lasch hat heute morgen im
Ausschuss darauf hingewiesen bereit vor
20 Jahren gab es einen
Untersuchungsausschuss der des
Europaparlament bisdem ervorsaß dass ich
mit der unwah und Unregelmäßigkeiten bei
unwra beim Palästinenser
flüchtltingsilzberg auseinandergesetzt
hat alle 5 Jahre bereden wir das ich
glaube wir brauchen einen kompletten
neuen Anfang bei der unwahr wenn wir
überhaupt jemals dort wieder Geld
hingeben können und deswegen fürchte ich
dass Herr Lazzarini als
generalalkommissar dieses Amt nicht
weiter ausüben sollte sondern dass der
Neuanfang glaubwürdig mit ein anderen
Person verbunden werden
muss in wie weit in Zukunft das un
Palästinenser hilfswer Gelder bekommen
wird das wird sich noch zeigen die
Vorwürfe müssen ja nun erst einmal
geprüft werden und Annalena berbur
spricht nun selber die
bundesaußenministerin wurde hier schon
angesprochen in mehreren
reden frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen manchmal glaube ich die Welt
hat uns Frauen vergessen das war der
erste bei meinem Gespräch im
Flüchtlingslager im
Südsudan zu Fuß hat sie die Wüste
durchquert mit ihren Kindern auf dem
Rücken wie 1,7 Millionen Menschen
fliehend vor einem brutalen Krieg in
Sudan die Frau neben ihr musste bei
dieser Flucht miterleben wie ihre
Tochter von Kämpfern mehrfach
vergewaltigt
wurde und ich habe während dieser Reise
auch von einigen Stimmen aus Deutschland
gehört darum sollen wir uns auch jetzt
noch kümmern ich sage deutlich
ja nicht nur weil es unsere humanitäre
Pflicht ist sondern auch weil es in
unserem eigenen Sicherheitsinteresse ist
dass der Krieg im Südsudan dass der
Krieg im Sudan und die
Auseinandersetzung in Südsudan nicht
noch mehr Nachbarländer ins Chaos
stürzen der Krieg im Nahen Osten die hui
Raketen überm Roten Meer Krisen an Orten
die uns mal fern erschienen sind sie
betreffen uns heute unmittelbar daher
ist
das Wegschauen daher ist das nicht
hinschauen keine Option
hinschauen dazu sein wenn andere uns
brauchen dass ist in diesen Tagen harte
Sicherheitspolitik so wie andere da
waren auch fern von uns als wir Europäer
sie seit dem 24 februar für unsere
Sicherheit brauchten Deutschlands
Verlässlichkeit ist in diesen Zeiten mit
unsere wichtigste
Währung zu dieser Verlässlichkeit zählt
auch unsere Rolle als zweitgrößter
internationaler Geber und ich bin den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus dem
Haushaltsausschuss sehr dankbar auch den
Kollegen von der demokratischen
Opposition der Union sehr dankbar dass
sie die humanitäre Hilfe hier weiter
gestärkt haben weil ja
Entschuldigung gestatten Sie eine Frage
oder Bemerkung der Abgeordneten
Vogler frler
Vogler nach links
ja mir nie passiert in meinen zwei
Jahren als
Ministerin ja vielen vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin dass sie meine
Zwischenbemerkung Zwischenfrage zulassen
vielen Dank auch frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin sie haben gerade darüber
gesprochen wie wichtig das ist dass
Deutschland als verlässlicher Partner in
der Welt anerkannt ist und ich kann ihn
da als Linke auch nur zustimmen
Verlässlichkeit ist natürlich ein
wichtiges Element der
Außenpolitik umso mehr hat es mich
befremdet dass sie auf die Vorwürfe
gegenüber unr Mitarbeitern damit
reagiert hab haben
dass sie gleich die angekündigt haben
die Zuwendung an das palästinensische
Hilfswerk zu streichen
ich halte das für außerordentlich
problematisch denn natürlich müssen wir
sehr genau hinschauen
wenn Vorwürfe erhoben werden dass
Mitarbeiter dieser Organisation an den
schrecklichen Angriffen in Israel
beteiligt gewesen sind dass sie sich
Terrorgruppen angeschlossen haben und
vielleicht sogar Mittel der Organisation
genutzt haben um an diesem Massaker teil
zunhmen aber eine Organisation mit fast
30.000 Mitarbeitern die nicht nur die
Menschen im Gazastreifen versorgt
sondern die für se für 6 Millionen
Menschen in Syrien im Libanon in
Jordanien in der Westbank und in Gaza
und in
Ostjerusalem die wichtigste humanitäre
und Entwicklungshilfe
leistet und die sie Selb von der sie
selber noch vor z Jahren gesagt haben
dass sie chronisch unter finanziert sei
und unbedingt verlässliche Unterstützung
brauche diese ganze Organisation in
Kollektivhaftung zu nehmen für die
Vergehen von einzelnen Mitarbeitern das
halte ich für falsch und ich würde Sie
bitten das zu
überdenken ja das wäre der zweite Teil
meiner Rede gewesen deswegen einmal
vorne weg gesagt und dann komme ich aber
genau zu dem Teil hier auch in meiner
Rede vorne weg gesagt Sie haben es ja
bereits unterstrichen wenn wir über
unvra reden haben wir unvra Gaza auf der
einen Seite und die Tätigkeit von unvra
in etlichen anderen Ländern auch noch
darüber haben wir intensiv heute auch im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss diskutiert und ich
bin auch an dieser Stelle allen Kollegen
sehr sehr dankbar den ampelfraktion und
auch der Union sehr dankbar dass alle
das sehr differenziert betrachten das
tue ich auch an dieser Stelle dass wir
nämlich wissen dass unwra seit
Ewigkeiten ein Konstrukt ist weil es
eben keine Selbstverwaltung vor Ort
geben kann für Gaza aber auch in den
anderen Ländern wie Jordanien z.B wo wir
in der Vergangenheit unsere Gelder auch
immer weiter erhöht haben haben um die
Situation gerade auch von Kindern in
Schulen deutlich zu verbessern wir haben
auch da gemeinsam mit dem Auswärtigen
Ausschuss gemeinsam mit dem
Finanzausschuss bei der Überprüfung
unserer Gelder die wir kontinuierlich
gemacht haben und Otto Fricker hat drauf
hingewiesen auch noch mal dann in der
Überprüfung der humanitären Hilfe
Veränderung erreichen können mit Blick
z.B auch auf die Schulbücher auch da
bitte ich alle Kolleginnen und Kollegen
bei Fakten immer zu schauen von wann
diese Beschreibungen sind weil es
offensichtlich Reform Bedarf gibt auf
der anderen stite muss man feststellen
dass wir derzeit mitten in einem
furchtbaren Kriegssituation sind und
dass wir mit Blick auf unwah eben vor
der Situation stehen dass sie derzeit
der wichtigste um nicht zu sagen fast
der alleinige Versorger in Gaza ist weil
alle anderen Organisationen wo wir noch
viel mehr humanitäre Hilfe mit abwickeln
wie z.B das World Food program wie z.B
die Weltgesundheitsorganisation wie z.B
uniceef wie wie z.B das Internationale
Komitee des Roten Kreuzes in Gaza
derzeit so gut wie nicht mehr aktiv sein
können über 200 humanitäre Helfer sind
bereits umgekommen deswegen sind die
unrstrukturen derzeit die einzigen die
dort überhaupt noch in Ansätzen oder
fast die einzigen Hilfe verteilen können
deswegen ist es nicht so wie Sie es
gerade wiedergegeben haben dass wir
gesagt haben einfach so Kaen wir jetzt
alles ich bitte auch an der Stelle meine
Äußerung genauso wie die Äußerung der 15
anderen größten Geber ganz genau zu
lesen wir haben deutlich gemacht dass
wir
wissen die Situation in Gaza ist einfach
die Hölle ich möchte an dieser Stelle
auf ihre Frage aber auch sagen nicht nur
die Situation in Gaza wir haben das
heute morgen glaube ich in der
Gedenkstunde auch noch mal gehört die
Situation für die Menschen deren
liebsten
Angehörige Kinder Eltern nach wie vor
Gefangenschaft der hamasterroristen sind
das ist unerträglich und mir geht der
Satz sei ein Mensch nicht aus dem Kopf
so wie all die Sätze seit dem 7 Oktober
wo es eigentlich nur darum geht dass man
bereit es das Leid von allen Menschen zu
sehen und nicht zu sagen ich möchte nur
das eine Leid sehen und in diesem Sinne
haben wir auch ich komme zurück zu
meiner Rede mit Blick auf die
unerträglichen vor Würfe gegen un
Mitarbeiter jetzt agiert ich kann in so
einer Situation wo es diese Vorwürfe
gibt nicht ignorieren zu sagen da waren
offensichtlich Mitarbeiter von unwra die
sich an diesen barbarischen Taten
beteiligt haben das ist für mich keine
Option und zugleich kann ich auch nicht
ausblenden und das war unsere Diskussion
heute im Auswärtigen Ausschuss dass ich
sage unra muss jetzt reformiert werden
und ignoriere da ist gerade ein Krieg
und einige hatten das ja auch
ausgesprochen jedenfalls in
pressebeiträgen dann soll das jetzt
jemand anders machen Herr laschit und
ich haben ja vorhin auch drüber
diskutiert irgendwie soll das jetzt
jemand anders machen in der jetzigen
Situation ist irgendwie halt keine
Antwort und daher haben wir gegenüber
den Vereinten Nationen deutlich gemacht
sie sind jetzt in der Verantwortung wir
wissen dass 1,9 Millionen Menschen auf
diese humanitäre Hilfe angewiesen sind
wir wissen dass das was derzeit da ist
nur noch vor ein paar Wochen reicht
deswegen haben wir unsere Mittel für das
Rote Kreuz und uniceef erhöht aber diese
Mittel müssen verteilt werden und daher
ist es so essentiell dass die UN jetzt
in den nächsten Aufgaben ihrer
Verantwortung nachkommt und das
Untersuchungsverfahren einleitig und
parallel dazu abgesprochen mit unseren
europäischen Partnern ein unabhängigen
udit von unwra wo auch europäische
Akteure mitbeiligt
sind an der Stelle deutlich das Leid ist
unerträglich aber wegschauen ist für uns
keine Option wir können nicht ignorieren
dass Kinder ohne Narkosemittel derzeit
amputiert werden wir können nicht
ignorieren dass ein einjähriges Kind
nach wie vor in der Gefangenschaft von
Hamas ist deswegen arbeiten wir weiter
daran alles konkrete jeden Tag in diesen
Tagen zu tun verlieren die großen Linien
der Außenpolitik nicht aus den aufen
aber ich glaube unsere humanitäre
Verantwortung in unserem eigenen
Interesse ist es jetzt unser Vertrauen
weiterhin auszubauen verlässlicher
Partner zu sein für die Menschen vor Ort
denn Vertrauen ist in diesen Zeiten kein
nice to have es ist die Grundlage dafür
dass wir in dieser Welt der Zeiten wenn
denn überhaupt noch handeln können
herzlichen
Dank
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Martin
sichert für die AFD
[Applaus]
Fraktion frau Präsidentin meine Damen
und Herren bei Frau berbock fällt ein
Termin aus was macht unsere
bundesaußenministerin sie bestellt sich
für aber tausende Euro Steuergeld extra
einen zweiten regierungsflieger mit
einer zweiten Besatzung nur damit sie
knapp 3 Stunden eher zu Hause ist Frau
berbur ist Ministerin in der Ampel die
im Namen des Klimas unsere Industrie
nach China vertreibt und aber Milliarden
ins Ausland verschenkt die
Bundesregierung hebt extra dieses Jahr
die Steuern aus fliegen für Bürger an
das Ziel ist klar die Menschen sollen
sich fliegen nicht mehr leisten können
währenddessen gönnt Frau berbock sich
selbst jeden Luxus beim Fliegen Frau
berbock beweist mit ihrem Verhalten dass
diese Ampel so schnell wie möglich
abgeschaltet
gehört die gesamte Außenpolitik der
Ampel ist eine einzige Katastrophe im
Namen der humanitären Hilfe betreibt die
Bundesregierung terrorunterstützung 200
Millionen gab die Ampel letztes Jahr an
die unprra aus Anfang Januar wurde diese
Summe noch mal aufgestockt angeblich für
Wasserversorgung dabei war schon im
Herbst letzten Jahres bekannt dass die
Hamas die kontrolliert und aus
Wasserrohren Raketen baut um israelische
Zivilisten zu ermorden den Antrag der
AFD die terrorunterstützung an die unwah
zu streichen lehnten alle anderen
Fraktionen ab erst drei Monate später
weil nun der internationale Druck zu
groß wurde hat diese Woche die
Bundesregierung die Unterstützung der
unwah gestoppt übrigens lehnten auch
alle Fraktionen die Forderung der AFD ab
humanitäre Hilfe in Gaza an die
Bedingung zu knüpfen dass dort nicht
mehr Schulkinder zu Terroristen erzogen
werden sie alle hier im Bundestag mit
Ausnahme der AFD unterstützen unter dem
Deckmantel angeblicher humanitärer Hilfe
die Terroristen der Hamas die jüdische
Zivilisten vergewaltigen versklaven und
ermorden oder um es in der Sprache ihrer
Freunde von Korrektiv zu sagen SPD CDU
Grüne und FDP stellen sich hier immer
wieder auf die Seite antisemitischer
Mörder und das knapp 20 km entfernt vom
Haus der wsekonferenz auf der die Nazi
ist die systematische Vernichtung der
judenkoordinierten schlimmer als sie
kann man die deutsche Geschichte nicht
mit Füßen
treten ja wir sind die einzigen die
jüdisches Leben schützen auch wenn sie
es nicht hören wollen sie schwafel
nämlich immer vom Kampf gegen
Antisemitismus aber ihr politisches
Handeln auf UN-Ebene und hier im
Deutschen Bundestag das ist
antisemitisch die einzige Partei die
wirklich Juden in Deutschland schützen
will ist die AFD und deswegen bin ich
stolz dieser Partei anzugehören
[Applaus]
Frau Werb hören Sie auf das hart
verdiente Geld der deutschen
Steuerzahler in alle Welt zu
verschleudern und hören Sie vor allem
auf Terroristen in Afghanistan oder Gaza
zu finanzieren vielen
Dank Martin sichert war das für die AFD
Fraktion es ist hier ziemlich laut
geworden im Plenum nächster Redner ist
nun NS schm der außenpolitische Sprecher
der SPD
[Applaus]
Fraktion frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verhren Damen und Herren ich will nur
eines feststellen die wiederwärtigen
Ausführung des Kollegen von der AFD
beschreiben nicht die Wirklichkeit die
Antisemiten sitzen hier und nicht in der
Mitte in der Demokratischen Mitte des
Hauses und ich weise für uns alle ich
hoffe Namen aller anderen Fraktionen
diese ekelerregenden Vorwürfe in aller
Form
zurück und ich will no noch eins
hinzufügen eine Partei die für
Deutschland eine Neuauflage der
numunberger Rassegesetze anstrebt um
Millionen von Staatsbürgern aus
Deutschland heraus zu definieren hat
nicht das Recht hier für den Kampf von
Antisemitismus
einzutreten
der Haushalt des einzelsplans 05
spiegelt die strategischen Prioritäten
der deutschen Außenpolitik in
vorbildlicher Weise wieder ich will
nennen den langen Anlauf den wir
genommen haben um die
chinaastategie
umzusetzen es ist uns gelüen eine
institutionelle Förderung von merix in
dem Haushalt zu verankern das ist ein
wichtiger Baustein zur Stärkung der
chinakompetenz der schon längst
überfällig war ich freue mich auch dass
wir trotz leicht rückläufiger zahlen
aber auch dank des Engagements vor allem
auch im Haushaltsausschuss es geschafft
haben dass Deutschland weiterhin
zweitgrößte Geber für humanitäre Hilfe
weltweit ist das spiegelt die
internationale Verantwortung unseres
Landes und auch die Verteidigung unserer
Werte der Mitmenschlichkeit und
Solidarität in der Welt wieder
herzlichen Dank dafür und
diesem und angesichts der aktuellen
Debatte über die Zukunft von unra will
ich festhalten dass dies
selbstverständlich auch bei der
Unterstützung dieses von den Vereinten
Nationen der Generalversammlung der
Vereinten Nationen eingerichteten
Hilfswerks gelten sollte zurecht hat die
Ministerin ausgeführt dass wir die
Aufklärung der unglaublichen Vorgänge
erwarten und auch eine entsprechende
Konsequenz in der Organisation von unra
fordern aber eins ist auch klar Liebe
Kolleginen und Kollegen wir können die
Millionen Menschen in Gazastreifen die
auf die Hilfe von unra angewiesen sind
gerade in dieser dramatischen Situation
nicht im Stich lassen daran wird sich
die Bundesregierung messen
lassen und dieser hausalt legt auch den
Grund dafür dass Deutschlands und
Europas Hilfe für die
Ukraine unverhindert und mit der
gleichbleibenden politischen
Unterstützung fortgesetzt wir kommen in
ein Jahr wo es mehr denn je auf Europa
ankommen wird wie Olaf Scholz heute noch
mal festgestellt hat die Europäer sind
gefordert klar zumachen Putin zu zu
signalisieren dass das erforderliche Maß
an Unterstützung auf lange Zeit gewährt
wird auch finanziell die Militärhilfe
der europäischen Länder für die Ukraine
garantiert ist unabhängig von möglichen
Entwicklungen in Amerika ich würde mal
sagen es ist Zeit die Bazooka
rauszuholen bei der finanziellen
Unterstützung der Militärhilfe für die
Ukraine so ähnlich wie wir es in der
Eurokrise getan haben als die EZB
erklärt hat whatever it takes wir sind
da wir stehen an der Seite der Ukraine
auch mit der Unterstützung von
Waffenlieferung und schließlich will ich
ein bisschen davor warnen lieber Kollege
hart und liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen von
der CDU allzu leichtfertig und mit allzu
leichter Hand radikale Änderungen in der
Iranpolitik oder in der Außenpolitik und
in der Politik gegenüber arabischen
Ländern
anzumachen bei mir bis auf die Listung
von Terror der Terror der der der der
revolutionsgaben als Terrororganisation
und der individuellen Listung nicht so
klar ist worauf das denn hinauslaufen
soll und wir da ja schon einiges getan
haben was die
von iranischen Staatsangehörigen
anbelangt und weil ich auch davor warnen
will die leichte Lösung zu finden nehmen
wir mal das Beispiel der Hut die
Rebellen im Jemen waren die saudischen
Luftschläge sehr erfolgreich war Obamas
dronenkrieg sehr erfolgreich hat die
Fokussierung auf militärische Lösungen
uns nicht die Augen verschlossen vor der
Notwendigkeit diplomatischer Bemühung
und deshalb ist es ja so richtig dass
die Außenministerin jetzt nachdem
Saudi-Arabien diesen vergeblichen
Luftkrieg aufgegeben hat und eingesehen
hat dass es militärisch keine Lösung
gibt dass sie jetzt die Unterstützung
Saudi-Arabiens auch mit
Waffenlieferungen wieder angekündigt hat
denn wir wollen
Saudi-Arabien und die Emirate und alle
anderen Beteiligten darin unterstützen
dass es eine politische Lösung in jedem
gibt mit Militär und mit Luftschlägen
werden wir es ebenfalls nicht lösen das
ist doch die Lehre aus den letzten 20
Jahren aus dem disaster der US-Invasion
im Irak meine sehr veren Damen und
Herren deshalb Vorsicht an der
bahnsteigante wenn man allzu
leicht m sich alles ändernge Kollege ich
bin jetzt hier in einem Zwiespalt
einerseits bin ich für die Rechte ihrer
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der Fraktion
zuständig den sie gerade die Redezeit
wegreden
gleichzeit gleichzeitig meldet sich der
Kollege har
fertig also wegen mir bin ich fertig
aber der hart
bitte her har bitte nee dann
Herr Kollege her Kollege sie haben
angesprochen das ist zukünftig der
Kollege Schmidt sie haben angesprochen
dass es zukünfti auch wieder
militärische Unterstützung für die
Saudi-Arabien geben soll sie meinen
vermutlich die Ankündigung der
Außenministerin dass wir als Deutschland
einwiigen dass Großbritannien
Eurofighter liefert ist das die Meinung
der Außenministerin oder ist es bereits
Beschlusslage des
Bundeskabinetts ich gehe davon aus
nachdem die
sich entsprechend geäußert hat dass
einer möglichen Beschlussfassung im
Bundessicherheitsrat nichts mehr
entgegensteht aber die Beschlussfassung
macht nicht ich sonder
Bundessicherheitsrat wir unterstützen
die Haltung der Bundesaußenminister in
dieser
Frage das Wort hat der Kollege Ulrich
Lechte für die FDP
Fraktion und rich Lechte ist der
außenpolitische Sprecher der
Liberalen
liebe Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin es ist leider
nur drei Minuten heute für mich deswegen
werde ich versuchen mich stichpunktartig
durch die Außenpolitik des letzten
Jahres durchzufrühstücken und ich möchte
als allererstes mal danken nämlich Dank
sagen z.B der bundesaußenministerin die
unermüdlich im Einsatz im Nahostkonflikt
ist um dort die Interessen von uns und
damit auch die Interessen Israels
entsprechend zu
vertreten ich möchte den Soldaten und
Soldaten danken die geräuschlos uns aus
minusma zurückgebracht haben die es
geschafft haben im Sudan als unsere
Botschaft evakuiert werden musste und
deutsche Staatsbürger evakuiert zu
werden entsprechend gehandelt haben und
das Bundes Verteidigungsministerium mit
dem Auswärtigen Amt das auch geräuschlos
hinbekommen hat und keinem deutschen
Staatsbürger irgendetwas passiert ist
ich
möchte danken dass diese Bundesregierung
es geschafft hat erstmals in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik eine
nationale Sicherheit Strategie
vorzulegen eine chinastrategie
vorzulegen wir haben in die Energiekrise
die wir im letzten Winter noch alle
befürchtet haben offensichtlich
überwunden weil diesen Winter spricht
keiner davon auch das ist durch alle
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier im Haus
geschaffen worden ich danke den
Hauseltern die es wirklich geschafft
haben in extrem schwierigen finanziellen
Zeiten für den wirklich wichtigen
Bereich der Außenpolitik der
Entwicklungspolitik der
Verteidigungspolitik im gesamten
vernetzten Ansatz den diese Ampel ja
auch fährt entsprechend weitere Gelder
zur Verfügung zu stellen und es ist
schlicht falsch wenn die Union sich hier
hinstellt und davon spricht dass die
eine Milliarde im vergangenen Jahren aus
dem Einzelplan 60 und das wissen sie
Herr Körber ganz genau und das weiß auch
der Kollege hart die wurde damals von
den Haushältern oben drauf gegeben wegen
der Sondersituation die in 2023 im
Haushalt war und diese eine Milliarde
humanitäre Hilfe beim Auswärtigen Amt
war nie Teil der regierungsentwürfe
sondern Teil dessen was die Haushälter
beschlossen haben und damit aus dem
Einzelplan 60 einmalig eine Milliarde
oben drauf gegeben hat das heißt die 500
Millionen die Sie jetzt an aufwuchs uns
gegeben haben ist eine wunderbare Sache
weil wir damit unserer Verantwortung in
der Welt weiter gerecht werden
können ich danke vor allem auch unseren
gesamten Botschaftspersonal weltweit was
tagtäglich für uns im Einsatz Vorort ist
wir können von Glück sagen dass wir
jetzt z.B es endlich geschafft haben
dass die Kosovo Visa Liberalisierung
geschaffen wurde dadurch können jetzt
100 ortskräfte in Pristina eingespart
werden die wir an anderer Stelle um Visa
zu erteilen dringend brauchen werden und
wir sind alle wie wir da sind als
Demokraten im
Abwehrkampf gegen die Angriffe für
Freiheit und Demokratie und leider
mittlerweile auch in Deutschland von
rechts wie von links und in der Welt und
alle unsere Feinde sind eigentlich
relativ klar definiert und was wir
dieses Jahr alles an Krisen zu erwarten
haben dass wissen wir noch gar nicht wir
wissen aber was wir letztes Jahr mit
Armenien Aserbaidschan mit dem Balkan
mit allen Krisen die wir momentan haben
im der Sahelzone im nahosten und an
allen anderen Stellen dieser Welt was
wir da leisten und da danke ich auch
allen Kolleginnen und Kollegen im
auswärtigen Bereich wir machen einen
verdammt guten Job vielen Dank
Ulrich Lechte für die FDP Fraktion und
ihm folgt jetzt hier am Redner Pult
Michael Brand für die CDU CSU Fraktion
der Sprecher für
Menschenrechte frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich zitiere aus
einem mitgeschnittenen Telefonat vom 7
Oktober das in deutschen Medien
veröffentlicht worden ist und Sie müssen
sich eine freudig erregte Stimme
vorstellen Mutter dein Sohn hat heute
Zeh Juden getötet mit meinen eigenen
Händen habe ich sie getötet ich rufe
Dich vom Telefonat vom Telefon eines
toten Juden an
ich habe zehn Juden getötet zehn sag's
Vater ich habe zehn Juden getötet ihr
Blut ist an meinen Händen Mutter dein
Sohn ist ein Held die Mutter beginnt an
zuu weinen und der Vater ruft töte töte
töte töte viermal unfassbar barbarisch
der pure Horror und nicht weil wir heute
hier der Opfer des Holocaust gedacht
haben sondern weil wir Menschen sind ja
sei Mensch wir müssen alles aber
wirklich alles unternehmen damit so eine
Barberei nie wieder
passiert die Hammers hat im Kern keine
territoriale Agenda sie hat eine
vernichtungsagenda sie will die Juden
vom Erdboden tillden so wie es die da
die Nazis damals Taten gestern waren in
meiner Heimatstadt fulder
100000 Menschen gegen Antisemitismus und
Rechtsextremismus auf der Straße es ging
dort um die Verteidigung von tie und
Grundwerten wir müssen auch
international alles tun um Juden und
Araber in Israel vor dieser Gewalt zu
schützen gerade Deutschland bleibt
besonders dem zielverpflichtet dass
Juden nicht wieder Opfer von Vernichtung
werden die Sicherheit Israels sein Recht
auf Schutz vor Terror gilt zugleich
müssen wir die Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza
s weit wie möglich schützen und
humanitäre Hilfe organisieren und da
sind wir beim Haus ush Halt des
Auswärtigen Amtes wir tun das bereits
über das Rote Kreuz über andere knapp
40% der deutschen Mittel gehen an das
Hilfswerk der UN für die Palästinenser
gut 60% gehen über andere Kanäle das un-
hilfsswerk allerdings und hier kommen
wir zu einem der wichtigen Signale hat
sich als Partner für humanitäre Hilfe
komplett
disqualifiziert an jenen entsetzlichen
Morden vom 7 oktober haben sich auch
Mitarbeiter der UN beteiligt über 1000
Beschäftigte sollen enge Kontakte haben
oder gar Mitglieder sein bei Hammers und
anderen
Terrororganisationen und die unra
kooperiert eng viel zu eng mit der
Hammers in unseren eigenen Kontakten im
Ausschuss für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre Hilfe mit un-vertretern bis
hin zum unrachef Lazzarini ist eins
überdeutlich geworden die unra ist von
der Spitze abwärts deutlich
antiisraelisch auch antisemitisch und
gefangen im DST der Hammers Kollege
Brand seit Jahren Kollege Brand
gestatten Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung
des Abgeordneten Heuchelei nur wirklich
die Gelegenheit zu geben garantiert
nicht garantiert nicht seit Jahren
werden Hass auf Juden und deren
Vernichtung in Schulen der unrah
provagiert Schulkinder geben stolz als
Ziel an später einmal die Ermordung von
Juden mit Autos mit Messern und anderen
schrecklichen Methoden durchführen zu
wollen die Massaker vom 7 Oktober auch
die Anschläge die tausenden Angriffe mit
Raketen auf Israel das ist die Saat die
aufgeht seit Hammers mit Brutalität
Folter und Mord zunächst an Arabern dann
in Gaza das Kommando übernommen hat und
weil wir nicht länger garantieren können
dass das Geld deutscher Steuerzahler
nicht zur Verbreitung der Ideologie zur
Vernichtung von Juden missbraucht wird
oder gar zur Auslöschung von jüdischem
Leben gibt es nur eine Option diese 40%
unserer Hilfe für die Palästinenser muss
anders organisiert werden Frau
Außenministerin dabei reicht es nicht
nur künftige Projekte nicht zu
finanzieren vor allem müssen wir jetzt
andere Partner einbinden es gibt
moderate arabische Akteure wie Ägypten
und Jordanien und auch andere die Hilfe
für palästiner bleibt wichtig aber die
indirekte Hilfe die indirekte
Komplizenschaft mit Hammers muss
aufhören jetzt Deutschland darf nie
wieder Judenhass finanzieren schon gar
nicht eine Hammers die die Auslöschung
aller Juden anstrebt wenn nie wieder
wirklich gilt dann gerade jetzt nie
wieder ist
jetzt aber auch der heute debattierte
Bundeshaushalt braucht eine dringende
Reform dass sie ausgerechnet in diesen
Zeiten humanitäre Hilfe zum Überleben
umfast 30% kürzen und wenn sie von den
den Grünen jetzt noch erklären das sei
alles gar nicht so heute morgen hat die
Beauftragte der Bundesregierung für
Menschenrecht und humanitäre Hilfe doch
selbst erklärt und bedauert ich halte
diese Kürzung und wir als Unionsfraktion
für absolut unverantwortliches schade zu
dem Deutschlands Position und
Glaubwürdigkeit und es ist zynisch das
Gegenteil zu behaupten und am
schlimmsten ist und am schlimmsten ist
sie lassen diejenigen im Stich die Hilfe
zum Überleben benötigen das ist das
Gegenteil von werteorientierter
Außenpolitik wir können dem nicht
zustimmen nicht zustimmen konnte auch
zumindest bei einigen Ausführungen den
Ausführungen von Michael Brand nämlich
die bundesaußenministerin die auf der
Regierungsbank den Kopf geschüttelt hat
jetzt bleibt Michael Brand auch noch
kurz bei stehen bei Annalena berbu und
man tauscht sich noch mal gerade
bilateral aus also waren mehrere
Mitarbeiter des un-pästinenser Hilfswerk
in Terrorangriffe der Hamas am 7 oktober
in Israel ckel diese vorwürf und fragen
die werden natürlich im Moment geprüft
nach anderen Staaten hat auch
Deutschland angekündigt dass sie das
keine neuen Gelder mehr bewilligt für
das unpästinenser Hilfswerk das haben
das Auswärtige Amt und das
Entwicklungsministerium mitgeteilt die
Ministerien die haben aber auch betont
dass die humanitäre Hilfe für
Palästinenser
weiterlaufe und Kriege haben wir
wahrlich aktuell viel zu viele die
russische Aggression in der Ukraine
Hamas Terror in Gaza der Einsatz Israels
brutale Gewalt in Sudan Myanmar jeemen
und so weiter was auch immer Wahrheit in
dieser Zeit bedeutet meine Damen und
Herren eine Erkenntnis besteht
unbebrochen die meisten Opfer des
Krieges sind
Unschuldige zu diesen menschgemachten
kriegen kommen die Folgen der Klimakrise
Dürre Hitze
Flutkatastrophen und so weiter gerade
Länder im globalen Süden sind davon
besonders betroffen schwache staatliche
Strukturen erschweren den Umgang mit
solchen Katastrophen das Internationale
Rote Kreuz hat uns schon im letzten Jahr
berichtet dass von 25 Einsatzorten
bereits 16 einen klimabezug haben ich
bin daher sehr sehr froh dass wir es in
diesem Haushalt geschafft haben die
humanitäre Hilfe deutlich über 2
Milliarden Euro anzusetzen wir machen
damit eine Zusage dass wir hinschauen
wenn Menschen in Not sind dass wir
hinschauen wenn Naturkatastrophen Ernten
vernichten oder Häuser wegspülen mit
diesem Geld zeigen wir unser Bestreben
dass wir einer Welt leben wollen die
sich
[Musik]
hilft und zurecht setzen wir auf
vorausschauende Arbeit in der
humanitären Hilfe jeder Euro den wir in
die Vorbereitung investieren spart im
Katastrophenfall 7 bis 8 € es ist eben
teurer und nicht nachhaltig erst zu
reagieren wenn die Notlage eingetreten
ist es ist gut dass wir die humanitäre
Hilfe zukunftsweisen aufstellen und
nicht nur vorausschauen sondern auch
lokal lokale alle Akteure kennen die
Kontexte und Bedarfe vor Ort am besten
viele unserer
Nichtregierungsorganisationen stehen in
der Zusammenarbeit oft vor
bürokratischen Herausforderungen daher
bin ich ebenfalls froh und der Kollege
Fricker hat es angesprochen dass wir das
Thema zuwendungsrecht in diesem Haushalt
aufgegriffen haben heutige
Einsatzgebiete in denen humanitäre Hilfe
geleistet wird verlangt aber auch
zusätzliche Aufmerksamkeit für die
Sicherheit von Hilfsorganisationen und
ihren Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern
immer mehr setzen autoritäre Regime das
Leid der Menschen ein um uns schäbig zu
erpressen die humanitäre Katastrophe in
Gaza zeigt das eindeutig überdeutlich
eine mögliche
Hungersnot von ca 1,5 Millionen Menschen
scheint der Hamas oder ist der Hamas
völlig gleichgültig das muss uns
aufrütteln und Verbrecher meine Damen
und Herren gehören vor Gericht
hergestellt deswegen bin ich froh dass
wir uns weiter am Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof bezilen beteiligen dass
wir seine Finanzierung verlässlich
sicherstellen die Chance dass wir
Verbrecher im Präsidentenamt vor Gericht
stellen bleibt
gewahrt die Aufgaben sind also bekannt
im Ausschuss wurde uns über die
Entwicklung regelmäßig berichtet auch
dafür vielen Dank an die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in den
Ministerien wir müssen die humanitäre
Hilfe jetzt in einen strategischen
Rahmen packen denn die Zahl der Krisen
steigt stetig das gibt auch den vielen
Hilfsorganisationen eine bessere
Orientierung und dafür haben sie Frau
Ministerin unsere volle Unterstützung
ich möchte zum Abschluss noch mal
betonen wie wichtig ist dass wir diese
Mittel über 2 Milliarden Euro
bereitstellen viele Millionen Menschen
stehen vor der Frage ob die Heimat heute
noch sicher ist oder ob sie sich auf
eine lebensgefährliche Flucht begeben
innerhalb ihres Heimatlandes oder über
Grenzen hinweg es kann uns nicht egal
sein wenn im Sudan 6 bis 7 Millionen
Menschen auf der Flucht vor brutaler
Gewalt und existenziellen gefahren sind
Humanität hil ist
kein sondern eine essentielle Säule für
mehr Stabilität und Sicherheit meine
Damen und Herren möchte gern Marcel RE
von heute morgen zitieren sei ein Mensch
vielen
Dank ja und ein Drittel des etases
Auswärtigen Amtes boris miat hat es
angesprochen ist vorgesehen für
humanitäre Hilfsmaßnahmen im Ausland
2,23 Milliarden Euro Präsidentin Liebe
anderen Liebe Demokraten von der
AFD auf der Website des Außenministerium
steht unser Anspruch Deutschland aus als
außenpolitische Gestaltungskraft
2024 bewaffnet mit gendersternchen und
Steuermilliarden ziehen Sie Frau bbock
durch die Welt sie wollen China zum
Kohleausstieg bewegen sie wollen die
Ukraine wieder aufbauen sie wollen das
Klima und die Menschheit retten
bebildert ist das ganze dann mit Frau
berbock in einem grünen Kleid die barfuß
und verträumt am Strand von Palau
entlang läuft noch nie sah weltenrettung
so entspannt aus meine Damen und
Herren weltweit soll auch endlich das
biologische Geschlecht überwunden werden
85% der Projektmittel sollen
gendersensibel und 8%
gendertransformativ eingesetzt werden
Putin Ching ping und Mohammed bin Salman
die werden wirklich beeindruckt sein
donnerwetter das ist grüne
ampelpolitik Gender Mainstreaming
Diversität Inklusion stadkompetenz
nationales Interesse Stärke und
Diplomatie das gibt es mit den Grünen im
Außenministerium nicht da ist die Frage
ob es nun Kobold oder Kobalt 360° oder
180° wende Bacon oder B
heit nachrangig Hauptsache Bund
Hauptsache wog Hauptsache Grün in der
Praxis steht das sieht das dann so aus
Frauenrechte predigen und den Taliban
Schutzgeld bezahlen Russland
sanktionieren aber alie hieren
Steuerbelastungen für die Bürger und
einen brzpalast für Frau berbock in
Brüssel mit Tennisplatz und
Innenpool sie haben kein Geld für unsere
Bauern aber sie bringen für 10 Millionen
Euro Transsexuellen in Indien das
erikcha Fahren bei meine Damen und
Herren diese wertebasierte und
feministische Außenpolitik ist damit vor
allem eins antideutsch verschwenderisch
und
verlogen wer hier eine 180° Wende
wünscht der wählt die AFD vielen
Dank
das Wort hat die Kollegin eidan ösus für
die
SPD sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wie sehr die
Welt um uns herum in diesen Zeiten in
Aufruhr ist das haben jetzt schon
mehrere Redner auch die Außenministerin
ja sehr gut beschrieben seit der
Zeitenwende blicken wir alles alle ein
ganzes Stück aufmerksamer in die Welt
denn was uns unsere Partner immer wieder
spiegeln ist doch wenn wir Unterstützung
in geopolitischen Fragen auch von den
aufstrebenden Staaten z.B im globalen
Süden erhalten wollen dann müssen wir
uns auch für ihre Prioritäten und
Herausforderungen interessieren und
lieber Jürgen hart ich werde es dann mal
so ausdrücken ich bin in diesem
Zusammenhang wirklich dankbar und sehr
froh dass es uns gelingt die humanitäre
Hilfe weltweit immer noch als zweit
größter Geber hinter den USA für
Deutschland zu
erhalten der indische Außenminister
mahnte vor einiger Zeit zurecht
folgendes an Europa muss sich von der
Einstellung verabschieden dass Europas
Probleme die Probleme der Welt die
Probleme der Welt aber nicht die
Probleme Europas sind und ich bin
unserem Bundeskanzler und auch unserer
Außenministerin wirklich außerordentlich
dankbar dass sie gerade in diesen Zeiten
so unglaublich viel unterwegs sind immer
wieder versuchen neue Partnerschaften zu
festigen und auch für Lösungen all
diesen Konflikten zu werben im
Besonderen in der
Ukraine und auch schon wie es auch
mehrfach genannt wurde im Israel Gaza
Krieg die Hamas bringt als
Terrororganisation derzeit großes Leid
über Israel aber eben auch über die
Palästinenser und das was wir wollen ist
doch Frieden für Israelis und auch für
PalästinenserInnen und Palästinenser sie
brauchen auch einen friedlichen
Lebensraum ohne Terror und auch ohne
Vertreibung und wenn ich gerade über
Indien sprach dann will ich zumindest
noch mal andeuten wir haben ja
mittlerweile fast alle verstanden dass
wir wirklich Fachkräfte und
Arbeitskräfte in Deutschland brauchen
und dass wir jetzt endlich auch eine
notwendige Reform des
fachkräftearbeits einwanderungsgesetzes
beschlossen
haben und dass diese Menschen aber nun
auch um an diesen Arbeitsplätzen
anzukommen nicht Monate oder sogar Jahre
auf eine Visavergabe oder nur einen
Termin für eine Visavergabe warten
dürfen es hilft den Betrieben und
Unternehmen in Deutschland wirklich
wenig wenn die dring gesuchten
Arbeitskräfte eben ewig warten wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass sie hier
schneller ankommen und deswegen ist es
gut dass die neuen Stellen geschaffen
worden die Wiebke papenbruck schon
genannt hat und das eben trotz der
knappen Haushaltslage und dass wir auch
bei der Digitalisierung der Visavergabe
jetzt deutlich Vorankommen diesem
Jahr ich möchte mich an dieser Stelle
wirklich bei allen Haushälterinnen und
Haushältern ganz explizit bedanken dass
sie in einer so schwierigen Lage
wirklich es geschafft haben wichtige
Prioritäten zu setzen gerade um unser
Land voranzubringen und auch im
auswertigen Bereich die wichtigen
Konflikte nicht aus den Augen zu
verlieren für ihnen allen erstmal ganz
ganz herzlichen Dank und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich möchte aber
auch gerade auch wegen meines Vorredners
doch eins sehr deutlich ansprechen und
auch weil heute morgen diese
Gedenkstunde hier stattgefunden hat die
Mitte unserer Gesellschaft geht in in
diesen Wochen auf die Straßen weil sie
weder hier bei uns noch im Ausland ein
Bild Deutschlands als
menschenfeindlichen oder sogar
faschistischen Staat ertragen wollen und
ich will es mal deutlich sagen wenn Herr
höcke als Aushängeschild der AFD sie
schaffen es nicht mal ein Satz zuzuhören
wenn Herr höcke als Aushängeschild der
AFD und verschiedene Gruppen in
Hinterzimmern die Abschiebung von und
ich habe mir diese Filme sehr genau
angeguckt Millionen Menschen in unserem
Land Planen von denen er behauptet dass
sie illegal hier wären dann sind das
Gewaltfantasien die sehr wohl an die
dunkelsten Seiten unserer
Geschichte
Kolleg gestatten Sie eine Frage oder
Bemerkung des Abgeordneten frohmeierer
nein ich werde jetzt erstmal zu Ende
ausführen ja sie schaffen es ja auch
nicht zuzuhören mit Millionen von
Menschen können ja nur diejenigen
gemeint sein die hier aufwachsen leben
arbeiten Steuern zahlen und sich nach
vielen Jahren sogar einbürgern ließen
die sich für dieses Land einsetzen die
sollen irgendwohin abges abgeschoben
außer landesgebracht vielleicht ja sogar
in Anatolien entsorgt werden diese
Hirngespinste sind ja nicht so ganz neu
nein liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
ist eben nicht das Bild Deutschlands es
muss uns alle dankbar machen dass
auf die Straen gehen weil sie ein
deutliches Zeichen gegen die
Herabwürdigung von Menschengruppen
setzen wollen und das können gern noch
mehr werden diesen Menschen sollten wir
sehr
danken das betont noch malö für die SPD
Fraktion sitzt unter anderem im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss ist ja auch
stellvertretender
Bundestags Präsidentin ja heute morgen
gab es hier im Bundestag eine
Gedenkstunde ja an die Opfer des
Nationalsozialismus und daran haben doch
einige Redner jetzt noch mal erinnert
Peter Heid für die fdpäre Hilfe
angewiesen sind ist auf Rekordhöhe neue
Krisen wie im Nahen Osten bringen das
humanitäre System an den Rand des
Kollapses weil die Finanzierung mit der
Not nicht mithalten kann dass die
Kürzung im Bereich der humanitären Hilfe
weh tun ist deshalb verständlich wir
müssen aber sparen dazu zwingt uns jetzt
endlich auch das uril aus karlsrund und
lieber Michael Brand Liebe Union ich
finde das irgendwie unehrlich sie können
dich do nicht in jedem Einzelhaushalt
hinstellen ihr spater das dürf i nicht
tun wo sind eure Vorschläge ihr habt
keinen einzigen Vorschlag gebracht in
keiner Haushaltsberatung das ist
arbeitsverwgerung ich finde das
unredlich und sie sagen das nicht ihr
sagt das nicht weil ihr keine Antworten
habt das ist die Wahrheit und deshalb
deshalb kann kann ich euch auch nicht
mehr ernst sehmen an der stelle ich kann
euch nicht ernst nehmen ich bin mir
sicher all das was wir hier machen
werdet ihr übernehmen werdet ihr
übernehmen das ist überhaupt keine
Frage aber nicht nur der Bedarf an
humanitäre Hilfe steigt in vielen
Ländern Gerät durch autokratische
Entwicklung die Zivilgesellschaft
zunehmt unter Druck oft reicht ein
einziges falsches Wort um Gefängnis zu
landen fakt ist ohne die Anerkennung der
zentralen völkerrechlichen Grundsätze
und der Menschenrechte sind Frieden
prosperierende Wirtschaft und eine
lebenswerte Zukunft nicht möglich es
braucht eine lebendige zivilgesell die
aktuelle Entwicklung hinterfagt um
mstände aufmerksam zu machen und es
braucht mutige Menschen die eben den
Mund aufmachen und unsere Unterstützung
verdient haben deshalb freue ich mich
sehr dass wir die Mittel für die
elisabeth Selbert Initiative die
gefährdeten menschenrechtsverteidigerin
temporäre schutzaufenthalte gewährt
ermöglicht und versteigert verstädigt
haben Existenzrecht und
Selbstverteidigungsrecht Israels ist für
uns Freie Demokraten nicht verhandelbar
wir stehen uneingeschränkt an der Seite
Israels und setzen uns dafür ein dass
auch die EU das auch so macht EU
Hilfsgelder dürfen nicht für Terror und
Antisemitismus missbraucht werden
Personen Personen Organisationen die
Terror gegen Israel verüben oder
unterstützen müssen sanktioniert werden
dazu fordern wir ein globales
Sanktionsregime gegen andere
israelischen Terror unwra Gaza hat nicht
mehr das Vertrauen der Freien
Demokraten ation hat sich erkennbar
überlebt jüste Vorfälle haben gezeigt
dass interne Reformen nicht ausreichen
stessen müssen sich die Vereinten
Nationen in der Region ne aufstellen unw
im Zuge dessen in den bewerrten
Strukturen wie etwa UNHCR World Food
Programm aufgehen lassen ich glaube dass
wir uns da in der Ampel auch völlig
einig sind und dass wir auf diesem Weg
sind dazu liebe Kolleg und
Kollegen jeder Euro der in humanitäre
Hilfe in Entwicklungshilfe
Menschenrechts und in eine gute
außenboltik investiert wird ist für
Deutschland gut investiertes
Geld im übrigen bin ich der Auffassung
dass T sofort freigelassen werden muss
vielen
[Applaus]
Dank das Wort hat der Kollege Thomas
erndel für die CDU CSU Fraktion Thomas
erndel ist der stellvertretende
Vorsitzende des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses vielen Dank sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Kollege Peter Heid an
der groko kann man natürlich viel
kritisieren aber fundamentale Fragen wie
die humanitäre Hilfe dem Parlament
aufbürden das ist letztendlich nicht
aufrichtig ich denke schon dass gute
Außenpolitik
auch im Entwurf eines Haushalts der vom
Ministerium kommt solche gravierenden
sol fundamentalen Fragen von Anfang an
berücksichtigen muss meine Damen und
Herren nach zwei Jahren Ampel bleibt
aber leider festzuhalten dass nicht nur
die humanitäre Hilfe sondern das
Auswärtige Amt in Gänze in der
Bundesregierung eine immer geringere
Rolle
spielt das ist fatal in einer Welt im
Umbruch nie waren die Außen und
sicherheitspolitischen Herausforderungen
so groß wie heute und die ausministerin
muss zum wiederholten Male ein
prozentuales haushaltsminus
hinnehmen es gibt leider weder im
Haushalt noch bei verschiedenen
auspolitischen Fragen eine klare
Richtung da helfen auch die
strategiedokumente nicht wenn dann in
konkreten Fällen doch nicht
das Kanzleramt und das Auswärtige Amt an
einem Strand ziehen sie z.B Position zu
China oft haben wir keine ausreichenden
Antworten keine Antworten auf die
Gefahren die von autoritären Staaten für
unsere liberale Demokratien ausgehen wir
haben keine Antworten auf die
Entwicklung im Iran wir schauen jeden
Tag zu wenn unschuldige Menschen
hingerichtet werden und führen weiter
Hintergrund mit iranischen Führung wir
schaffen es nicht die revolutionsgarten
endlich auf die Terrorliste zu setzen
meine Damen und Herren das muss sich
ändern wir
haben auch keine Antwort auf die
wirklich besorgniserregende
ernstzunehmende
Entwicklung in der Ukraine die Menschen
in der Ukraine sind erschöpft und bei
allem Respekt für das was wir wirklich
im großen Umfang an Hilfe leisten aber
mit der Zögerlichkeit bei Taurus senden
wir wieder ein Signal der Schwäche an
Putin genau wie die Tatsache dass wir es
nun in zwei Jahren nicht geschafft haben
unsere munitionsproduktion signifikant
zu erhöhen wir müssen hier endlich
Vorankommen Signale der Stärke setzen
und senden Signale dass wir den längeren
Atem haben werden meine Damen und
Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben
auch keine Antwort auf die Entwicklung
in USA
donutstrategie lieber Kollege Link ist
es wirklich alles soll es wirklich unser
ernst sein ist natürlich richtig dass
wir Kontakte knüpfen pflegen aber die
grundsätzlichen Hausaufgaben die müssen
gemacht werden unabhängig von der Frage
wie der nächste Präsident heißt und ober
uns gefällt und auspolitik ist natürlich
mehr als der Einzelplan null 5
spätestens mit dieser
Haushaltsaufstellung und dieser
Finanzplanung hätten wir ein klares
Signal für eine starke deutsche und
europäische Säule in der NATO setzen
müssen hätten wir auch ein klares Signal
für langfristige Unterstützung der
Ukraine setzen müssen stattdessen
komplette Fehlanzeige diese
Bundesregierung spielt mit dieser
Haushaltsaufstellung mit unserer
Sicherheit meine Damen und Herren das
ist nicht der richtige Weg
das ist nicht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir haben auch eine besondere
Verantwortung für Israel viele Redner
haben schon angesprochen wir müssen uns
an der Seite Israels für zukunftsfähige
Strukturen in der Region einsetzen ja
eine Zweistaatenlösung ist die Vision
aber ein palästinensischer Staat muss
auch ein verlässlicher demokratischer
Staat sein zukunftsfähige
Strukturen in der Region meines
Erachtens gehört unwra mittelfristig
nicht dazu kurzfristige Zahlungen
einstellen ja das ist das richtige
Signal aber ich glaube wir müssen hier
einen Weg skizzieren wie die Versorgung
im Gasastreifen ohne unwra gelegen unwra
hat jegliches Vertrauen verspielt und
hat neue Generationen an Terroristen
zugelassen hat zu keiner brauchbaren
Entwicklung beigetragen und eine
friedliche Zukunft für Israel geht nicht
mit einer Organisation die an manchen
Stellen somit der Herm verwoben ist wie
unwr ich glaube dass Deutschland hier an
altertiven aktiv arbeiten muss meine
Damen und Herren mehr Führung bitte auch
in der EU der deutsch-französische Motor
ist ein Ausfall
dasim zweimer Dreieck braucht eine
schnelle Wiederbelebung wer von
Mittelmacht spricht muss deutlich mehr
auf den Tisch legen als diese
Bundesregierung es ist an vielen Stellen
zu wenig wir brauchen mehr Verantwortung
als größte europäische Wirtschaft in und
für Europa deutschland kann mehr lassen
Sie uns das gemeinsam beweisen
herzlichen
Dank sagt Thomas erndel für die
Unionsfraktion auch er hat den weiteren
Umgang mit dem un Palästinenser
Hilfswerk
angesprochen heute rufen mehrere
unorganisation zur Wiederaufnahme von
Zahlungen an das un Palästinenser
Hilfswerk auf es sei entsetzlich dass
mehrere Mitarbeiter vorwrfen zufolge in
die schrecklichen Attacken auf Israel
verwickelt gewesen sein erklärte
beispielsweise uniceef und andere
unorganisationen dennoch dürfe man nicht
eine ganze Organisation an der
Wahrnehmung ihres Mandats hindern und
Menschen in verzweifelter Not nicht zu
helfen schrieben die
UN-Organisation wie die Gewalt in der
Sahelzone oder die Situation der Frauen
in Afghanistan und um all diese Krisen
zu lindern brauchen wir Diplomatie und
internationale Kooperation genauso wie
die Leistung von humanitärer Hilfe
und Liebe Union sie haben sich ja jetzt
hier hingestellt und groß kritisiert im
Bezug auf die Beiträge der humanitären
Hilfe ich habe mir mal die Zahlen
angeguckt wie das so in ihrer
Regierungszeit war 2018 1,5 Milliarden
humanitäre Hilfe 2019 1,6
20 2 Milliarden tja haben wir jetzt mehr
und ja die Krisen sind mehr und wir
brauchen auch künftig mehr Mittel und
genau deswegen handelt eben diese
Koalition und das konnten wir eben im
parlamentarischen Verfahren wie meine
Kollegin Jamila Schäfer es auch schon
richtig erwähnt hat und sie falsch
dargestellt haben noch mal
verbessern
im hier nur mit Fake News und Sexismus
probiert ihre nicht vorhandenen
inhaltlichen nicht sinnvollen Beiträge
irgendwie zu kommentieren hat die Union
ja in ihrem Haushalt im
Haushaltsausschuss keinen einzigen
Änderungsantrag gemacht nur
maßgabebeschlüsse Liebe Union sie können
sich doch nicht hier hinstellen und so
tun als ob sie die außenpolitischen
Krisen lösen dann machen Sie doch mal
die Arbeit im Haushaltsausschuss wenn
ihn die humanitäre Hilfe so wichtig
ist liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Menschen in Deutschland und überall auf
der Welt sie brauchen keine
Scheinlösungen und rechte narrative die
Menschen brauchen tatsächliche Lösung
für Ihre Probleme und genau das schaffen
wir mit diesem Haushalt vielen Dank für
diese wunderbaren Beratung von den
Haushältern ich freue mich auf ein Jahr
mit sehr vielen Krisen aber auch sehr
vielen Lösungen die wir hoffentlich
präsentieren
werden
das Wort hat der Kollege Dr Gregor
ges frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen eine Vorbemerkung wer einen
Landes und fraktionsvorsitzen mit dem
Namen höcke duldet der das Denkmal für
die Millionen ermordeten Jüden und Juden
in in als Schande bezeichnet ist so
antisemitisch dass es ihm nicht zusteht
demokratische Kräfte in diesem Parlament
als antisemitisch zu bezeichnen und
Punt liebe Frau
außenministerinicht kann man ihn nicht
absprechen sie fliegen viel durch die
Welt sofern die regierungsflugzeuge
überhaupt fliegen und Sie überfrechte
erhalten aber Außenpolitik lebt von
Glaubwürdigkeit und Verlässlichkeit die
bei ihnen deutlich vermesse sie wollten
eine Außenpolitik nach Werten machen und
haben es selbst widerlegt zur Frage der
Auslieferung von assangeche an die USA
der uns über Kriegsverbrechen aufklärte
schwiegen sie obwohl sie im Wahlkampf
das Gegenteil versprachen und nun wollen
sie plötzlich Eurofighter Kampfflugzeuge
an Saudi-Arabien verkaufen ein Land das
den kritischen Journalisten kchogi
kaltblütig umbrachte das einen
jahrelangen Krieg im Jemen geführt hat
inklusiv einer Hungerblockade die
10tausende Menschen den Tod brachte
indem Frauenrechte auch nach dem Gesetz
erheblich eingeschränkt sind und
Opposition gegen das Königshaus mit
mittelalterlichen Strafen bis hin zum
toded ich habe die Uhr angehalten also
entsteht kein Nachteil aber ich muss sie
fragen ob sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung
des Abgeordneten modorf zulassen um
Gottes
will
hätten sie doch nur ehrlich gesagt dass
es in ihrer Politik um Interessen geht
und Werte nur dann eine Rolle spielen
wenn Sie Ihren Interessen entsprechen
einerseits üben Sie scharfe Kritik am
russischen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine andererseits schweigen sie zu
den Bombardements der türkischen Armee
gegen die Zivilbevölkerung und
lebenswichtige Infrastrukturen in den
kurdischen Gebieten des Irak und Syriens
sie nehmen die militärische Besatzung
durch die Türkei dort kommentarlos hin
die Rüstungsexporte haben drastisch
zugenommen nicht nur wegen der Ukraine
sondern generell die Grünen wollten
früher einmal Frieden schaffen ohne
Waffen und sind inzwischen die treibende
Kraft für immer mehr Waffen und
Aufrüstung ich weiß ja dass sie Frau
Außenministerin und der Bundeskanzler
und der Wirtschaftsminister
ausgesprochene Militärexperten sind
trotzdem richte ich mich nach dem
früheren US generalstabschaff m der
ebenso wie die militärische Führung der
Ukraine von einer m p von einem
Stellungskrieg dort ausgeht soll dieser
Krieg noch 10 noch 20 Jahre dauern wenn
die Ukraine militärisch den Donbass
nicht zurückgewinnen kann muss es in
friedensverhandlung erreicht werden dazu
braucht man zuerst Waffenstillstand kein
einziges natoland hat dies je angeboten
oder von Putin und der Ukraine gefordert
übrigens wenn es einen Waffenstillstand
gäbe wäre das die wirksamste und
humanste Form der Reduzierung der Zahl
der Flüchtlinge in Deutschland weil die
meisten Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer zum
Aufbau ihres Landes zurückkehrten bei
dem viele auch wir zu helfen haben um es
auch deutlich zu sagen ich bin strickt
gegen Flüchtlinge erster zweiter und
dritter Klasse das grundgesatz verlangt
die Gleichstellung vor dem Gesetz
Außenpolitik muss wieder gekennzeichnet
sein durch deutlich mehr Diplomatie
Interessenausgleich und strickte
Beachtung des volkerrechts durch alle
Seiten und endlich auch zu einer
nostkonflikt sagt Gregor GI im Moment
noch fraktionsloser Abgeordneter
Mitglied der Partei die Linken am
Freitag wird der Bundestag hier
entscheiden über den gruppenstatus für
die Mitglieder der linken und auch für
das Bündnis SAR
Wagenknecht wir schätzen sie alle sehr
und ja das ist das ist kein das ist kein
Schatz voren Ding doch über
geschichtliches Wissen verfolgen ich
möchte Ihnen eine Frage stellen sie
haben jetzt gerade den Zusammenhang
zwischen höcke und der Äußerung über ein
Denkmal der Schande genannt ich möchte
ihn die Frage stellen ob Ihnen bekannt
ist dass damals in den 90er Jahren also
zur Zeit ihrer aktiven politischen
Laufbahn es eine Diskussion gab in der
Frankfurter Paulskirche angestoßen von
Martin Walser der diese schandeiskussion
in Deutschland als
völlig überflüssig brandmarkte und ich
darf Ihnen auch sagen dass es kein
anderer war als Rudolf Augstein der
ehemalige Herausgeber des
Nachrichtenmagazins der Spiegel der
gesagt hat in der wiedergewonnenen
Hauptstadt Berlin sollle nun ein Mal mal
an unsere Schande erinnern dieses
Schandmal sei gegen die Hauptstadt und
das in Berlin sich neu formierende
Deutschland
gerichtet Walser nannte das geplante
manm übrigens einen Fußballfeld Gren
altraum im Herzen unserer hauptstad sind
ih diese äuerung bekannt oder behaupten
sie einfach wieder besseres Wissen
diesen Unsinn den sie gerade in Richtung
von gesagt
haben Matias modorf war das für die AFD
Fraktion sie haben die Möglichkeit
erwi abord falsche äuerungen von A und B
refertig niemals Äußerung von Z ihr
Problem ist z nicht A und
B und dafür bekommt Gregor Gesi auch
Applaus aus den Reihen
der
SPD beispielsweise auch aus den Reihen
der Grünen so Frank Schabe spricht jetzt
für die Sozialdemokraten er ist der
Sprecher für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre
[Applaus]
Hilfe frau Präsidentin
verehrte Damen und Herren in einer Welt
die kompliziert ist und in Unordnung ist
macht's keinen Sinn die Augen zu
verschließen sondern das führt am Ende
nur dazu dass wir auch in Deutschland
nicht in Frieden leben können wenn die
Welt in Unfrieden lebt und wer das äh
bestreitet der hängt einer sehr
einseitigen Weltsicht an und ich habe
gerade noch mal drüber nachgedacht
ähm
wel wer eigentlich ihre Freunde sind bei
der AFD ich komme ich komme letzte Woche
war eine europaratsitzung und da gab es
heftige Kritik an Russland am russischen
Präsidenten am präsenten von
Aserbeidschan an der an den
Ministerpräsidenten von Ungarn und alles
das sind ihre Freunde alles das sind
ihre Freunde mit denen sitzen sie
gemeinsam teilweise in einer Fraktion im
Europa sie beschweren sich hier darüber
dass die Meinungsfreiheit eingeschränkt
wäre aber sie unterstützen all diese
Regime all diese Despoten und all diese
Diktaturen deswegen haben sie null
außenpolitische expertise in diesem
Hohen Haus
hier in dieser schwierigen Welt ist es
richtig als Deutschland Verantwortung zu
übernehmen politisch und finanziell und
das tun wir in diesem Bundes Haushalt
auch dadurch dass wir weiterhin
zweitgrößter Geber der humanitären Hilfe
sind aber ich meine wir können ja den
Diskurs hier ordentlich führen und es
bringt gar nichts sich gegenseitig was
vorzuwerfen natürlich ist es nicht so
dass es ein aufwuchs gibt in der
humanitären
Hilfe ja na ja das sage ich aber jetzt
sage ich mal die Konsequenz der
politischen Debatte was nicht
funktioniert ist dass die Union auf der
einen Seite sparhaushalte einfordert
aber dann keine Vorschläge macht wo
eingespart werden kann und wenn irgendwo
eingespart wird dann zu sagen da geht's
auf gar keinen Fall an dieser Stelle
aber lassen Sie uns das konstruktiv
machen weil die nächsten
Haushaltsberatung die stehen schon vor
uns die stehen schon vor uns in einer
Welt in der die USA in der China in der
Indien nicht nur ökonomisch richtig was
raushauen sondern auch außenpolitisch
ist die Frage wie handlungsfähig sind
wir in Deutschland eigentlich wenn wir
uns durch eine Form jedenfalls einer
sehr restriktiven Schuldenbremse selbst
beschränken und am Ende einem Fiskal
Rigorismus hinterherhängen und am Ende
uns Haus und politisch jedenfalls
Handlungsfähigkeiten nehmen vielleicht
können wir uns darüber einig sein und
gemeinsam drüber nachdenken für den
nächsten Haushalt die
Handlungsspielräume auch in der
humanitären Hilfe weiter erhöhen weil
der Bedarf wird natürlich steigen und in
der humanitären Hilfe ist es so dass wir
natürlich über die Höhe der Mittel reden
aber eben auch über den Zugang
humanitärer Hilfe und deswegen ist es
richtig dass wir gemeinsam darüber reden
wie schrecklich das ist was gerade bei
teilen von
unwra passiert schreckliche Vorwürfe und
scheinbar auch Beweise dafür dass
schreckliche Taten verübt worden sind
von Mitarbeitern von unwra und das ist
richtig darüber nachzudenken und darüber
zu reden an einem Tag wie dem heutigen
wo wir dem dem Holocaust gedenken und
trotzdem trotzdem ist es die
Verantwortung von uns gemeinsam
nachzudenken was in dieser Rolle in
dieser Situation zu tun ist und was die
Alternativen wären und ich meine darüber
kann man ja dann diskutieren wie das in
Zukunft mit unwra weitergeht aber zur
Zeit in dieser humanitären Katastrophe
der wir uns gegenüber sehen und der
politischen Katastrophe gibt's doch zu
unwer gar keine Alternative das muss man
doch klar sehen wir würden
doch dramatisch Hunderttausende von
Menschen in den Hungertod treiben und
wir würden auch eine politische
Situation haben wo wir doch Israel
überhaupt nicht zur Seite stehen würden
wenn wir am Ende diese humanitäre Lage
so dramatisch verschlimmern deswegen
gibt es im Moment keine Alter auch mit
unra entsprechend weiterzuarbeiten
Deutschland muss Weltmacht sein in der
humanitären Hilfe und in der
Krisenprävention aber eben auch Garant
für Menschenrechte und Demokratie
weltweit mit klaren Sprachen gegenüber
dispotien mit klarer Verurteilung der
schlimmen Hinrichtung die es gerade
wieder im Iran gegeben hat und der
ganzen Welle dort aber ebenem wir auch
im Haushalt die Strukturen stärken die
für Menschenrechte stehen die Strukturen
zur Unterstützung von Menschen die im
Ausland verfolgt werden sind
angesprochen worden ich will hinzufügen
dass wir im Haushalt auch dafür sorgen
dass wir Deutschen helfen können die wir
aus politischer Gefangenschaft befreien
können in anderen Ländern und die zum
Teil aber darunter massiv ökonomisch und
sozial leiden und denen wir helfen
können entsprechend mit diesem Haushalt
am Ende will ich mich bedanken dafür
dass wir in diesem Haushalt gemeinsam
alles tun können internationale
Organisationen zu stärken die OSZE den
Europarat und andere es wird aber eben
auch darum gehen
zu unterstreichen dass die Regeln dieser
Institution gelten müssen und deswegen
will ich ganz am Ende sagen die Türkei
hat die Verpflichtung sehr sehr sehr
schnell Osmann Kavala freizulassen ich
finde das sollten wir auch in dieser
Haushaltsdebatte als Ganzes hoheshaus
unterstreichen vielen herzlichen
Dank das Wort hat der Kollege Roderich
kiesebetter für die CDU csuaktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren Frau Außenministerin sie Manen
zurecht mehr Handlungsfähigkeit in den
wie sie sagen Zeitenwenden an ich sehe
aber dass etliche Rednerinnen und Redner
der Ampel sich in der Verteidigung in
der Frage der humanitären Hilfe oder in
der Reduzierung der Mittel der
Krisenprävention ergehen und nicht die
Chance nutzen Handlungsfähigkeit der
Ampel in der Zeitenwende zu
demonstrieren ich spreche es bewusst
an am traurigsten stimmt mich dass der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher der
Liberalen über eine mögliche
Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine in der
Europäischen Union spekuliert ich weiß
dass er es anders meint aber warum geht
nicht ein starkes Zeichen von ihnen aus
dass eine EU-Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine
sobald die EU sich reformiert
undverhandelbar ist wo ist das Zeichen
aus der Ampel dass Russland keine
Mitsprache hat an einer möglichen
Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine in der NATO
wo sind die Mittel für Krisenprävention
und strategische Vorausschau in der
Umsetzung der nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie wo sind ihre
Forderungen die nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie endlich zu
priorisieren und Schwerpunkte zu setzen
das geht aus ihrem Haushalt nicht hervor
und das mahnen wir an liebe Kolleginnen
und
Kollegen wir haben die Wahl wir haben
die Wahl durch deutsche Initiative die
sicherlich von der Regierung ausgehen
muss aber unterfüttert werden muss von
Ihnen an uns liegt es nicht den
Amerikanern klar zumachen dass
Lastenteilung auch eine europäische
Frage ist zusammen mit dem Weimarer
Dreieck zusammen mit Italien zusammen
mit Großbritannien warum setzt sich
diese Regierung nicht an die Spitze der
Tallin Initiative die sich gebildet hat
weil Deutschland lange Zeit sehr
zurückhaltenend war warum setzt sich
diese Regierung nicht an die Spitze
einer möglichen Unterstützung mit
weitreichenden Waffen und womöglich auch
mit Kampfjets warum überlässt man ländn
wie Luxemburg dies ein Land das sehr
engagiert daran mitwirkt ich spreche es
an denn wir haben die Wahl ob die
Ukraine eine Perspektive in Europa hat
oder ob Russland weiterhin das
Existenzrecht seiner Nachbarn zerstört
wir müssen doch sehr deutlich machen und
das fehlt mir heute an der Debatte was
auf dem Spiel steht unsere Art zu leben
ist unter drruck wir haben eine
Gleichzeitigkeit von Krisen wo Russland
Iran Nordkorea und China die Hamas
entflammen die huis entflammen die
hisbolla in Reserve halten und einen
abnutzungskrieg führen gegen das
Existenzrecht Israels gegen das
Existenzrecht der Ukraine und gegen den
Zusammenhalt der Europäischen Union ich
erwarte mir mehr wenn sie uns schon ein
machen mehr werf mehr Schwung und
vielleicht auch etwas mehr
Durchsetzungsvermögen von Frau berbock
und von Herr Pistorius im Kanzleramt wir
erwarten mehr Schwung und in diesem
Sinne wünsche ich mir dass wir diese
Wahl die wir haben auch nutzen und
unserer Bevölkerung deutlich machen
danke schön ja fort hier rerich kewetter
für die Unionsfraktion kurz
Intervention aus fdpe Herr Kollege
kiesewter sie haben schon ein Halbsatz
gesagt es anders gemeint habe als sie es
wahrgenommen haben aber weil man ja in
dieser Zeit immer nicht weiß welcher
schnüpsel wo gesendet wird will ich das
dann noch mal deutlich für mich
persönlich sagen ich glaube dass diese
Europäische Union weiterhin das Beste
ist was uns passieren konte es wäre gut
wenn Sie das Mikrofon
Einschalten es war ja an ist es jetzt
besser frau Präsidentin gut dann sage
ich das noch mal weil man ja auch
vermeiden will dass schnips gesehen wden
und weil ich nicht ja auch gar nicht ihn
unterstellen wolle dass sie mir was
bödes will ich noch mal klarstellen für
mich ist die Europäische Union im Streit
darüber wie Sie am besten funktioniert
immer noch die beste Idee die dieser
Kontinent haben konnte und ich sage das
auch deutlich jedes Land das die Idee
hat dass diese Regeln die Fragen wie
Menschenrechte zu werten sind die Frage
wie wir zum Frieden stehen die Frage wie
wir miteinander umgehen jedes Land das
in diese Richtung will sollte man dazu
aufhen und was die Ukraine angeht für
mich ist immer noch der berauschendste
Satz dass die Menschen in der Ukraine
nicht sagen ich will nach Europa sondern
ich bin doch in Europa ich will Teil der
großen Organisation sein ich glaube das
stellt das noch mal klar herzlichen
Dank wir fahren fort in der Debatte das
Wort ach so
Entschuldigung war jetzt schon mit dem
Gedanken voraus ist ja gut dass sie
vorausdenken frau Präsidentin lieber
Kollege Fricke ich bin ihen sehr dankbar
für ihre klaren Worte und es aber
wichtig dass wir im Bundestag deutlich
machen was für uns die europäische Union
bedeutet und das ist nicht eine Frage
das könnte vielleicht oder mit Blick auf
die Ukraine einer sehr schwierigen
bürokratischen Regelung ist wir müssen
von diesem Hause aus ein Zeichen setzen
auch an die ukrainische Bevölkerung dass
sie eine Perspektive hat und dass sie
nicht glaubt im Stich gelassen zu werden
und dann womöglich Millionen von
Menschen mit den Füßen abstimmen es muss
unsere Aufgabe sein uns nicht nur als
die stärkste Unterstützer der Ukraine zu
rühmen wir sind das in der Ankündigung
und wir sind das in der Unterstützung
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger die als
Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland gekommen
sind sondern ich wünschte mir dass wir
mit ehrlichen Zahlen in die
Öffentlichkeit gehen und die
unterstützungszahlen für die Ukraine
nicht summieren mit den Ankündigungen
sondern mit dem was tatsächlich
geliefert ist und dass wir in Europa
endlich dies klein klein in der
Rüstungsindustrie überwinden und
gemeinsame Anstrengungen leisten um auch
nach Amerika das Zeichen zu geben wir
sind in der Lage uns besser aufzustellen
für ein starkes Europa das auch ein
Trump aushält aber vielleicht durch
bessere Koordinierung vorher einen Trump
verhindert weil die Amerikaner sehen die
Europäer haben verstanden und erfüllen
ihre selbstgestellten Hausaufgaben danke
schön soweit also ruderich Kiesewetter
und Otto Fricke hier noch mal im
Austausch jetzt eine weitere
fraktionslose Abgeordnete aus den Reihen
des Bündnis Sara wagenknechts die
Abgeordneten übrigens die fraktionslosen
alle die mal zur Linken gehören sind
derzeit noch fraktionslos sitzen noch in
einem gemeinsamen Block am Freitag wenn
der gruppenstatus anerkannt würde würde
sich das ändern D und Herren was den
vorliegenden Bundeshaushalt angeht
verbeitet die Bundesregierung im
wesentlichen drei Mythen erster Mythus
der Haushalt sichere den Frieden in
Wirklichkeit bringt die Bundesregierung
dieses Jahr mit rund 90 Milliarden Euro
nach natoriterien die höchsten
Militärausgaben Deutschlands seit
1945 auf den Weg und was daran ist
Diplomatie Frau Ministerin einen
sofortigen Waffenstillstand in der
Ukraine und in Gaza abzulehnen was ist
denn eigentlich aus der Verpflichtung
geworden nie wieder Krieg Frau berborg
zweiter Mythos der Haushalt sei sozial
in Wirklichkeit verdoppelt die
ampelregierung das Geld für
waffengeschenke an die Ukraine von 4 auf
8 Milliarden Euro zugleich wird bei der
Bildung in Deutschland massiv gekürzt
während immer mehr Kinder in Deutschland
nicht richtig lesen schreiben oder
rechnen können so meine Damen und Herren
verspielt man die Zukunft kommender
Generationen Dritter Mythos der Haushalt
sei
solide in Wirklichkeit setzt die
Bundesregierung auf zunehmende
Kriegskredite und nächstes Jahr kommt
das nächste Haushaltsloch wurde schon
berichtet und die verherenden folgen die
der Wirtschaftskrieg gegen Russland bei
uns hier in Deutschland anrichtet bei
Bürgern und der Industrie können sie gar
nicht ausgleichen und wenn sie kürzen
dann ausgerechnet bei der humanitären
Hilfe und der Krisenprävention als gäbe
es keine Krisen mehr in diesem Land in
dieser Welt dieser Haushalt meine Damen
und Herren ist ein Produkt eines
Kabinetts der Katastrophen bei dem sich
immer mehr Menschen zurecht fragen wie
lange noch und ich hoffe nicht mehr
allzu lange vielen
dankelin war das für das Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht
und hier sehen sie auch noch einige
andere der Mitglieder des B ist Sarah
Wagenknecht wie gesagt im Moment das
noch nicht geteilt von den
Sitzen erst mit dem gruppenstatus wird
dann die bestulung sozusagen hier im
Plenarsaal dann auch noch mal verändert
werden letz jetzt zum et des Auswärtigen
Amts achelchäfer für die die SPD frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ein Wort
vorab nach der Rede meiner Vorrednerin
und der Reder aus der AFD muss man
wirklich feststellen dass ich manche
extreme berühren und das ist wirklich
schade aber als Demokratin und
Demokraten stehen wir da für unsere
Werte gemeinsam und in dieser Debatte
haben wir das auch
gezeigt ich möchte weil um den Haushalt
geht erst einmal ein ganz kleinen Posten
Anfang aus diesem Jahr und der
Außenministerin danken das war nämlich
eine konkrete
Initiative wie deutsche und französische
ExpertInnen
Wissenschaftler Historiker Vorschläge
machen welche Konsequenzen wir aus der
Konferenz zur Zukunft Europas ziehen
damit wir dieses Europa gemeinsam
voranbringen und da geht es immer um
zwei fundamentale Dinge nämlich um die
Stärkung der Demokratie inklusive eine
Reduzierung der
Mehrheitsentscheidung und die
Möglichkeit dass diese Gemeinschaft auch
erweiterungsfähig ist und dieses
scheinbar kleine hat Großes bereits
bewegt wir haben im Europäischen
Parlament dazu einen klaren Beschluss
wie die Zukunft aussehen soll was wir an
Reform brauchen auch einen Konvent und
es hat auch für heute für diesen Tag
auch eine entscheidende Konsequenz Olaf
Scholz wie alle wissen ist auf dem Weg
nach Brüssel und da geht es um die Frage
Einstimmigkeit Einstimmigkeit für 50
Milliarden für die Ukraine und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
ich bin jetzt so lange dabei ich kenne
so viele von ihnen aus dem Europäischen
Parlament aus dem Bundestag ich habe an
ihrer Integrität überhaupt keinen
Zweifel bei den aller allermeisten aber
akzeptieren Sie doch endlich mal dass
bei dieser entscheidenden Frage Ukraine
Deutschland der Motor ist und der Garant
dass wir da vorankommen und heute Abend
wird es darauf ankommen ob es Olaf
Scholz ein zweites Mal gelingt trotz des
Erfordernisses der Einstimmigkeit gegen
Orban ein Blockierer zu überwinden damit
diese Mittel fließen und damit das Land
genau die europäische Perspektive
braucht bekommt dieses braucht und das
wird glaube ich heute auch gelingen denn
liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen
das haben andere Staats und
Regierungschefs gesagt Olaf war es Olaf
Scholz hat das an entscheidender Stelle
vorangebracht und wenn Sie sich das mal
anschauen was bisher in diesem in dieser
Phase in der außen und Europapolitik
gelungen ist wir haben es geschafft auf
dem D7 Gipfel eine Perspektive zu geben
auch für die Staaten des globalen Südens
wir haben es wir haben es geschafft dass
die
Beitrittsperspektive
für den sogenannten Westbalkan der von
vielen Konservativen und hier auch in
der Union über Jahre verschleppt worden
ist dass es da entscheidende
Fortschritte gibt und Olaf Scholz hat im
Europäischen Parlament wie kein Kanzler
vor ihm jedenfalls letzten 50 Jahre zum
Thema Demokratisierung europäischer
Zukunft sich hingestellt und klare
Versprechen abgegeben klare versprechen
die von dieser Koalition von FDP von
Grünen und von SPD gemeinsam getragen
werden und darauf liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen wird's nämlich ankommen Olaf
Scholz ist jetzt wenn es entschieden
wird last man standing es gibt keinen
Regierungschef es gibt keinen
Regierungschef in großen europäischen
Staaten in wichtigen zusammenarbeiten
der sagen kann ich habe in den
entscheidenden Fragen mein Parlament
hinter mir ich habe in den
entscheidenden Fragen meine Regierung
hinterher schauen Sie welche Probleme
wir auch in Frankreich und in Spanien
Italien und anderswo bekommen wenn es
immer um diese Mehrheiten geht und liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen von der Union
diskutieren sie endlich mal europäisch
reden sie da mal drüber wer bei ihnen in
der EVP mit Rechten koaliert in dieser
in dieser Gemeinschaft reden Sie mal
darüber wer in ihrer internationalen
demokratischen Union mit Donald Trump
und anderen zu ihrer parteifamilie
gehört das ist der Unterschied zu dieser
Koalition und darauf hin sind wir stolz
und danke liebe Kollegin Außenministerin
und danke an unser
Bundeskanzler sagt Axel Schäfer hier für
die SPD letzter Räter zu diesem
Einzelplan ja morgen gibt es den EU
Sondergipfel in Brüssel da soll ein
letzter Versuch unternommen werden den
ungarischen Regierungschef Orban zu
einer Zustimmung zu den Plänen für neue
ukrainehilfen zu bewegen über das Paket
mit Unterstützung für die Ukraine von 50
Milliarden Euro für die Zeit bis Ende
2027 hätte eigentlicher schon im
Dezember entschieden werden sollen aber
damals legte Orban ein Veto ein und
verhinderte damit die Einigung also
morgen ein neuer Anlauf so es gab einen
Wechsel in Bundestagspräsidium die
Sitzung leitet jetzt die
bundestagsvizpräsidentin Katrin Göring
Eckert und sie ruft den nächsten
Einzelplan auf hier in diesen
Haushaltsberatungen und einen
Vorausblick gab es eigentlich jetzt auch
schon beim bei den Beratungen zum
Einzelplan auswärtiges den auswärtiges
und verteidig die hängen natürlich in
Teilen auch zusammen auch wenn das
Verteidigungsministerium einen
wesentlich höheren et hat also
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
der hier schon auf der Regierungsbank
sitzt ist einer der Minister dem in
diesem Haushalt ja zumindest die
Sparpläne am wenigsten zu schaffen
machen neben dem regulären
Verteidigungshaushalt in Höhe von rund
52 Milliarden Euro für 2024 hat er auch
noch das Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr auf das er zurückgreifen kann
damit in diesem Jahr 73 Milliarden Euro
insgesamt für Rüstung so es geht los mit
der Aussprache Ingo gichens für die
Union Präsidentin Liebe Kolleginen und
Kollegen lieber ein Ende mit Schrecken
als ein Schrecken ohne Ende wenn wir
heute nach quälenden Wochen des Streits
in der Ampelkoalition endlich den
Haushalt
2024 beschließen Ende zumindest fürs
erste die
haushaltskernschmelze der vergangenen
Monate für den
Verteidigungshaushalt müssen wir aber
leider feststellen dass die Weichen
falsch gestellt wurden der Zug fährt in
die falsche Richtung das
Schreckensszenario für die Bundeswehr
geht weiter und wird immer
größer 56 Milliarden Euro meine Damen
und Herren 56 Milliarden Euro fehlen der
Bundeswehr nach aktuellen Zahlen aus dem
Verteidigungsministerium im Jahr
8 wenn das Sondervermögen Bundeswehr
aufgebraucht ist spätestens mit diesen
dramatischen Befund sollten Sie Herr
Minister auf den Kabinettstisch haauen
und in aller Deutlichkeit sagen so geht
es nicht weiter stattdessen hören wir
die markigen Durchhalteparolen wie es
werde schon genügend Geld für die
Bundeswehr zur Verfügung stehen nur wo
das Geld herkommen soll wenn keine re
Steigerung des verteidigungsetas
vorgenommen wird kann niemand sagen das
ist alles andere als eine seriöse
Haushaltspolitik besonders bemerkenswert
finde ich in diesem Zusammenhang dass
immer noch zu viele Menschen dem
Bundeskanzler auf dem Leim gehen Scholz
sicher dauerhaft höheren
verteidigungset zu so titelte
beispielsweise die Tagesschau nach der
letzten bundeswehrtagung
es ist der gleiche Bundeskanzler der an
diesem Ort vor z Jahren zugesagt hat von
nun an mehr als 2% für Verteidigung
auszugeben
2022 hat er das Versprechen gebrochen
2023 hat er das Versprechen gebrochen
und 2024 kann das
kanzlerversprechen nur durch tanen
täuschen und trixsereien eingehalten
werden unter anderem in den man
Kreditzinsen Pensionslasten vergangener
Jahre als
Verteidigungsausgaben
deklariert das liebe Kolleginen und
Kollegen durchschaut sogar jeder
Obergefreiter und deshalb schwindet
täglich die Glaubwürdigkeit dieser
rückschrittskoalition das Sprichwort wer
einmal lügt dem glaubt man nicht und
wenn er auch die Wahrheit spricht dieser
Spruch bekommt in diesem Zusammenhang
eine ganz besondere Bedeutung meine
Damen und Herren die Bundeswehr ist in
weiten Teilen ein Spiegelbild der
Gesellschaft viele Probleme die den
truppenaltag erschweren erleben wir auch
in anderen Teilen unseres Zusammenlebens
überbordende Bürokratie viel zu lange
Entscheidungs und Beschaffungsprozesse
überzogenes absicherungsdenken all das
sind Probleme die wir trotz
wohlklingende Ankündigung und
versprechen immer noch nicht energisch
genug
angehen zugleich ist die Bundeswehr aber
auch etwas ganz Besonderes unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten haben ein
eitgeschworen unser Land tapfer zu
verteidigen wer aberim äußersten Fall
Leib und Leben für unser Land einsetzt
braucht ein besonderes Vertrauen in die
Spitze unseres Staates und insbesondere
in den Inhaber der Befehls und
Kommandogewalt und hier müssen wir
leider feststellen dass dieses vertrauen
immer stärker verloren geht über die
desaströse finanzielle Perspektive der
Bundeswehr habe ich bereits mehrfach
gesprochen das Thema ist längst in der
Truppe angekommen und treibt nicht nur
die CDU CSU Fraktion mit großer Sorge um
und während sich viele Soldatinnen und
Soldaten auch die zivilen Mitarbeiter
fragen wie das immer größer werden
Finanzproblem gelöst werden soll gibt es
einen weiteren heftigen Schlag in die
mageng Grube unserer Truppe denn die den
die Ampel heute mit dem Haushalt
beschließen will seitdem die Bundeswehr
Waffensysteme an die Ukraine abgibt das
halten wir für richtig war aber immer
klar die Wiederbeschaffung dieser
Systeme soll gerade nicht aus
bundeswehrmittel bezahlt werden sondern
aus dem Gesamthaushalt um über 500
Millionen einzusparen ist die Ampel aber
auf die wenig sinnvolle Idee gekommen in
diesem Jahr die Wiederbeschaffung aus
dem ohnehin schon hoffnungslos
überplanten sonderschuldenvermögen der
Bundeswehr zu bestreiten das ist ein
massiver Vertrauensbruch gegenüber
unseren soldatinen und Soldaten den man
immer das Gegenteil versprochen hat sie
Herr Minister haben sofort erkannt was
für eine gefährliche Bombe ihnen der
Kanzler Finanzminister oder wer auch
immer ins Nest gelegt hat und darum
haben sie sich in einem Tagesbefehl an
die Truppe gewandt und
Verständnis für die Maßnahme geworden
das war zwar ein netter Versuch es hilft
aber nur begrenzt bei den Soldatin und
Soldaten kommt an dass auch bei der
Bundeswehr eingespart werden soll da
hilft auch ein beschwichtigender
Tagesbefehl nicht meine Damen und Herren
wir alle hier im Haus fast alle sind uns
einig dass wir unsere Bundeswehr stärken
müssen ganz wichtig ist dass unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten Perspektiven
erkennen nur dann werden sie als
Multiplikatoren nur dann wird die Truppe
aus sich heraus für neue Männer und
Frauen werben können und das ist
dringend notwendig dass wir mehr
Personal für die Bundeswehr akquirieren
wir benötigen nicht nur modernes Gerät
das Schwimmen fliegen und fahren kann
sondern wir brauchen auch motivierte
Menschen die unser Land tapfer
verteidigen wollen herzlichen
Dank hier für die Union zum Auftakt der
Debatte zum Einzelplan 14 Verteidigung
und er hat nicht nur auf diesen Haushalt
geschaut sondern auch auf das Jahr
2028 denn der Spiegel meldet
beispielsweise heute dass die Bundeswehr
dass der nach dem Auslaufen des
Sondervermögens im Jahr
2028 eine Milliarden Finanzierungslücke
troh ich beginne mit einem Zitat
FR ist leider gerade nicht da aber er
hat mich inspiriert auch mal bei William
Shakespeare nachzuschauen und der hat
mal gesagt im Falle der Gegenwehr ist es
am besten den Feind für mächtiger zu
halten als er erscheint meine Damen und
Herren die Bedrohung denen wir
ausgesetzt sind die sind mächtig und ich
glaube das ist unstrittig sind wir aber
ehrlich wir alle leben nicht mehr
wirklich in einer friedlichen und
sicheren Zeit ein paar große Mächte
wollen die Welt verändern und hautn
erleben wir gerade in der Ukraine was
Krieg auf europäischen Boden bedeutet
und diese Bundesregierung und unser
Kanzler hat reagiert dass Wort
Zeitenwende wird mit Leben erfüllt auch
wenn es der eine oder die andere nicht
wahrhaben will Putin hat klar erklärt
was er vorhat Russland bedroht die
natomitglieder auch im Baltikum und in
Polen ständig und auch die Chinesen
halten mit ihrer Meinung über Taiwan
nicht hinter dem Berg der Konflikt im
Nahen Osten der Unruhe hert Iran und
nicht zuletzt die Angriffe auf den
weltwirtschaftsverkehr im Roten Meer
sind Zeugnis ein des immer größer
werdenenden Bedrohung und auch unseres
Friedens man muss den Diktatoren unserer
Zeit nur zuhören die sagen ganz klar was
Sie wollen und wo wo die Reise aus ihrer
Sicht hingeht und wir reagieren und wir
reagieren stark und ich glaube solche
Mächte verstehen auch nur eins Stärke
und dieser Haushalt und dieser Etat
vermittelt Stärke meine Damen und Herren
wenn Russland mit seinem Angriff auf die
Ukraine Erfolg haben sollte dann wir uns
alle ausmalen wie es am Ende weitergeht
wenn wir jetzt nicht unsere Gegner für
mächtig halten und unsere Verteidigung
nicht vernünftig aufbauen dann riskieren
wir unsere Art zu leben unsere Freiheit
unsere Demokratie wir riskieren alles
und an dieser Stelle noch mal Dank auch
an unseren Minister Boris Pistorius und
sein Team an das BMVg für das was da
alles geleistet wird
Demokratie Demokratie Frieden und
Freiheit gibt es nicht umsonst deshalb
bin ich froh und deshalb ist es auch
absolut richtig dass wir mit dem
Verteidigungshaushalt 2024 das 2%
natoziel erreichen ja sogar leicht
übertreffen 52 Milliarden für den
Verteidigungshaushalt und nochmals nahe
zuu 20 Milliarden aus dem Sondervermögen
machen also insgesamt knapp 72
Milliarden Euro aus für unsere
Bundeswehr und die sind ein deutliches
Signal an die Truppe an unsere
Bündnispartner innerhalb der NATO dass
wir bereit sind das was von uns erwartet
wird auch zu erfüllen um damit die
Sicherheit in Deutschland in Europa und
in der Welt zu gewährleisten und
demokratireiheit zu schützen Deutschland
und die NATO müssen so stark werden dass
niemand Lust oder gar Mut hat dieses
Bündnis anzugreifen und dazu meine Damen
und Herren müssen wir auch Ausrüstung
auf den Hof unserer kassernen stellen
und zwei Drittel des Sondervermögens
beispielsweise sind auch schon
vertraglich gebunden von diesen 100
Milliarden Euro das wären z.B Ausgaben
für Munition
Raketenabwehrsysteme verschiedene
landwehrsysteme Kampfflugzeuge frigatten
und U-Boote nicht zu vergessen die
persönliche Ausrüstung für unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten und an der
Stelle auch herzlichen Dank an unsere
Truppe die ihren Dienst gewissenhaft
tut Zweck dieser vielfachen leider aber
auch notwendigen Investition ist dass
wir diese Waffen alle nicht einsetzen
wollen und hoffentlich auch nie müssen
aber liebe Kollege und Kollegen wir
müssen potenziellen Gegnern zu verstehen
geben dass sie es auch gar nicht erst
probieren sollen das zu erreichen kostet
nun mal eine Menge Geld und wir sind
bereit dieses Geld auch in die Hand zu
nehmen deshalb bin ich froh dass wir mit
diesem Verteidigungshaushalt unsere
Ziele erreichen können verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen natürlich
können wir uns auf diesem sehr guten
Haushalt nicht ausruhen nach dem
Haushalt ist vor dem Haushalt die
Anforderungen an die zukünftigen
Verteidigungshaushalte sind nun enorm
und das streitet auch hier niemand ab
und spätestens
2028 wird das Sondervermögen der
Bundeswehr aufgebraucht sein und Gott
sei Dank macht man sich in der Koalition
auch Gedanken darüber wie es weitergeht
wir dürfen auch nicht unterschätzen die
Entwicklungen in den USA dort schwindet
die Bereitschaft den Riesen Beitrag der
bisher geleistet wurde für die
Sicherheit Europas auch weiterhin zu
leisten sollte Trump zum nächsten
Präsidenten gewählt werden heißt das
noch mal eine besondere Herausforderung
für die deutsche und europäische
sicherheitsarchitekt
um den um Deutschland Zufalls
zuverlässigen Bündnispartner nicht zu
gefährden ist es deshalb unabdingbar
dass der
verteidigungseta eine verbindliche
Finanzplanung für die Zukunft erhält und
die 2% Zusage des Kanzlers steht dies
muss in den kommenden
finanzplanungs Planungen auch natürlich
hier zum Ausdruck kommen daran wird hier
kräftig gearbeitet sicherlich ist es
keine einfache Aufgabe das wissen wir
alle und damit gehen wir auch ehrlich um
und haben im Moment auch vielleicht noch
nicht die Lösung parat aber sie können
sich auf eine Lösung freuen weil die
wird am Ende des Tages kommommen und wir
haben mit Sicherheit auch keine
Denkverbote um hier Lösungen zu finden
und man kann über ein neues
Sondervermögen man kann über eine Reform
der Schuldenbremse Nachdenken darüber
wird man diskutieren müssen meine
Meinung persönlich dazu ist sicherlich
bekannt wir müssen aber uns natürlich
auch die verschiedenen Kosten im
Haushaltsplan anschauen wie wäre es
beispielsweise mit einem Kernen
Sanierungsprogramm nicht nur ökologisch
können wir wirken wir könnten auch
erheblich Energiekosten einsparen
wichtig ist dass Industrie Bundeswehr
aber auch die NATO wissen wir strahlen
Planungssicherheit aus und wir müssen
auch zukünftig unser Material
ordentlich betreiben können dieser
Verteidigungshaushalt ist ein
elementarer Grundstein hierfür das sind
wir unseren Soldatinnen und Soldaten der
Bundeswehr auchon uldig und ich freue
mich darauf wenn die CDU so im Gegensatz
zum Haushalt
2024 beim Haushalt
2025 sich wieder mit Anträgen beteiligt
und auch inhaltlich hier einbringt danke
an Minister Pistorius an sein Haus für
die viele Arbeit und wir freuen uns auf
die 25 miovorlagen es sind immerhin fast
50 die uns im ersten Quartal erreichen
werden danke
schön sagt andre schwarz für die SPD
Fraktion ist einer der
Berichterstatter für den Einzelplan
innerhalb des Haushaltsausschusses auch
der nächste Redner ist Berichterstatter
für diesen Einzelplan für die AFD
Fraktion Michael
espendilleer sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Kollegen liebe
Zuschauer im Saal und bei Youtube im
Sommer letzten Jahres lief der Film
Oppenheimer in Deutschland an bei dem
Film geht es um Robert Oppenheimer den
Vater der Atombombe dann nach dem
Einsatz seiner Bombe und dem Ende des
Zweiten Weltkriegs zu einem Kritiker des
internationalen Wettrüstens wurde der
Film lockte in Deutschland über 4
Millionen Zuschauer in die Kinos und das
wohl nicht nur deshalb weil es ein
Christopher nolem Film ist sondern auch
deshalb weil viele Menschen im Angesicht
der aktuellen Politik die Befürchtung
hegen dass es auf dieser Welt wieder zu
atomaren Auseinandersetzungen kommen
kann so stellt der Film eine Mahnung da
und regt zum Nachdenken darüber an
welche Folgen einzelne Entscheidungen
haben können und es ist gerade dieses
nach denken über die Möglichkeiten
möglichen Konsequenzen einer jeden
Handlung die viele Menschen in
Deutschland bei dieser aktuellen
Bundesregierung vermissen im Klartext es
ist nicht hilfreich wenn land auf Land
ab die brachialste kriegsretorik
ausgepackt wird während man mit der
eigenen Bundeswehr blank dasteht wie
jeder in Deutschland und in der Welt
weiß es ist ebenso wenig hilfreich seine
eigene Verteidigungsfähigkeit noch mehr
zu schwächen indem man obwohl man blank
daasteht fröhlich weiter Material an die
Ukraine abge wir im Ernstfall hier
selbst in Deutschland gebrauchen können
gerade zu absurd ist es dass man den
deutschen jetzt das narrativ einhämern
möchte dass Putin in 3 5 oder 8 Jahren
vor Berlin steht wo doch eigentlich seit
Z Jahren in der Ukraine angeblich
verliert und es wird noch absurder unser
Verteidigungsminister lässt sich in der
Bildzeitung zitieren mit dem Worten wir
haben zu wenig von allem gleichzeitig
lässt sich im aktuellen Haushalt
nachlesen dass eine Abgabe von Material
auch dann zulässig ist wenn dies zu
einer Tat vorübergehenden
Beeinträchtigung der Einsatzbereitschaft
und Aufgabenerledigung der Bundeswehr
führt na was denn Herr Minister ist die
Lage jetzt so ernst dass wir uns so
schnell wie möglich wappnen müssen oder
ist es doch nicht so schlimm und wir
können fröhlich die Einsatzbereitschaft
der Bundeswehr ruinieren das ergibt doch
alles keinen
Sinn genauso wenig Sinn ergibt es dass
sich eine disolat ausgestattete
Bundeswehr an fragwürdigen
Auslandseinsätzen weltweit beteiligt
deshalb will meine Fraktion die
allermeisten diese Einsätze beenden in
den etas des Verteidigungsministeriums
und des Auswärtigen Amtes haben wir die
Streichung dieser Mittel beantragt und
kämen so auf Einsparung in Höhe von
697,5 Millionen Euro für unnötige
Auslandseinsätze wenn man sich nicht
dauernd im Ausland verzetteln würde
würde die Bundesregierung vielleicht
einmal ganz grundsätzlich über das
eigene Beschaffungswesen nachdenken denn
Hand aufs Herz wirklich hart verhandelt
wird von dieser Bundesregierung nicht
bei Vertragsverhandlung man freut sich
über das Lob des Bündnispartners USA das
Deutschland ein Zitat sehr guter Kunde
sei aber die Verträge mit den
Amerikanern sind regelrechte
Knebelverträge die eigentlich kein
normaler Mensch jemals unterzeichnen
würde noch dazu haben westliche Hightech
Militärgüter hohe Stückpreise die eine
adäquate Ausstattung der Bundeswehr
finanziell für unmöglichen Herr
Pistorius wollte ja gerne den ETA um 10
Milliarden aufstocken und das kann ich
auch sehr nachvollziehen aber
realistisch betrachtet würde eine solche
Erhöhung in der derzeitigen Preislage
nur zu steigenden Aktienkursen der
Rüstungsindustrie führen ohne dass wir
eine nennenswerte Verbesserung bei der
Ausstattung der Bundeswehr haben nun
kann man sich aus wirtschaftspolitischer
Sicht natürlich über volle
Auftragsbücher und steigende Aktienkurse
deutscher Rüstungskonzerne freuen denn
sie erhalten naau und Arbeitsplätze in
Deutschland und das ist wichtig und
deshalb sollte unserer Auffassung nach
alles was in Deutschland produziert
werden kann auch tatsächlich in
Deutschland beschafft werden
Punkt darüber hinaus empfiehlt sich aber
auch ein Blick über den Tellerrand die
jüngst zurücklegenden weltweiten
militärischen Konflikte haben gezeigt
dass unsere Streitkräfte im Ernstfall
sehr viel agiler sein müssen seit dem
ukrainekrieg mussten wir z.B beobachten
dass massenhaft zum einsat gebrachte
billigdrohen konventionelle Armeen
ernsthaft in Bedrängnis bringen können
in der Ukraine wurden sogar Leopard 2
Panzer außer Gefecht gesetzt in Israel
die berühmten merkavas obwohl Experten
diese Entwicklung schon vor Jahren
vorher gesagt haben geht es auf diese
Bedrohung derzeit noch keine
überzeugende Antwort zwar hatte sich die
schwarzrote Bundesregierung 2002 20 mit
der Industrie auf ein Projekt geeinigt
das Drohnen und Raketen im nah und
nächstbereich abwehren können soll doch
die eigentliche Entwicklung dieses
Prototyps beginnt erst jetzt und wird
mit 1,2 Milliarden Euro fünf Mal so
teuer wie ursprünglich geplant der
Bundesrechnungshof hat i zurecht darauf
hingewiesen dass es keine plausible
Begründung seitens des
Verteidigungsministeriums für diese
eklatante Preissteigerung gibt eine
quate preisprüfung ist nicht erfolgt
weshalb unsere Fraktion diesem wichtigen
Projekt aus haushalterischen auch nicht
zustimmen konnte grundsätzlich wird es
in Zukunft immer wichtiger werden mehr
auf Masse und günstige Preise zu setzen
als nur auf wenige teure High-End
Produkte und genau diese wichtige
Weichenstellung nehmen momentan die
Bundesregierung leider nicht in Angriff
da besteht dringend Nachholbedarf vielen
Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit nächste Redner ist der
Kollege Dr Sebastian
scherbündnis9 ist Mitglied im
Haushaltsausschuss aber er ist auch in
einem untergremium des
Haushaltsausschuss stellvertretender
Vorsitzende nämlich in dem Sondergremium
Gremium Sondervermögen Bundeswehr das
eben noch mal die besondere Aufgabe hat
die Bewirtschaftung dieses Sonderfonds
eben zu begleitenag Herr Minister sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen gerade
in diesen Tagen wird leider wieder sehr
deutlich welche schrecklichen Folgen der
brutale und völkerrechtswidrige Angriff
Russland auf das Staatsgebiet der
Ukraine für die Menschen dort hat die
intensiven russischen Luftangriffe auch
auf zivile Einrichtungen wie eine
Geburtsklinik terrorisieren die
ukrainische
Zivilbevölkerung Kinder werden zu weisen
Großeltern verlieren ihre Enkel die
Menschen die Tage und Nächte in den
schutzbunkern oder den Schützengräben
verbringen müssen zahlen einen
unvorstellbaren Preis für die russische
Aggression wir stehen in der Pflicht der
Ukraine weiterhin mit allem zu helfen
was wir liefern
können um den Verteidigung um den
Verteidigungskampf zu stärken benötigt
die Ukraine weitere Ausrüstung
insbesondere Munition die Industrie muss
ihre Produktionskapazitäten in Europa
vergrößern die Munitionsversorgung ist
absolut essentiell es geht aber auch
darum dass die Ukraine die aus Beständen
unsere Bundeswehr gelieferten
Waffensysteme weiterhin und möglichst
dauerhaft benutzen kann deshalb müssen
die instandsetzungs und
wartungskapazitäten für bereits
gelieferte Systeme ausgeweitet werden
gelieferte Kampf und Schützenpanzer
nützen nichts wenn sie nicht
einsatzfähig sind Reparaturen müssen
schneller und am Einsatzort näher am
Einsatzort vorgenommen werden hier steht
die Industrie in der Pflicht und da geht
es auch voran wir müssen aber prüfen was
wir tun können um das weiter zu
beschleunigen der Ukraine läuft die Zeit
davon jenseits aller taktischen
Spielchen hatte die Union mit ihrem
Antrag vor zwei Wochen in der Sache
recht wir müssen unsere Unterstützung
für die Ukraine effektivieren dafür
braucht es die Lieferung von
weitreichenden
taurusmschflugkörpern aus Beständen der
Bundeswehr politisch komplizierten Lage
bleibt Deutschland ein verlässlicher
Unterstützer der Ukraine wir haben 2024
die Hilfen zur Verteidigung gegen den
russischen Angriff aus dem
Bundeshaushalt nahezu verdoppelt auch
dazu hat sich die Union übrigens
enthalten wir stellen fast 8 Milliarden
Euro zur Verfügung damit die Ukraine bei
der Industrie das bestellen kann was sie
am nötigsten braucht und wir liefern
auch immer wieder direkt aus den
Beständen der Bundeswehr zuletzt die
Hubschrauber auch für die nächsten Jahre
stehen Mittel zur Verfügung um der
Ukraine eine gewisse Planungssicherheit
zu geben manchmal hören wir den Vorwurf
dass wir dieses Geld einfach verschenken
würden oder dass damit der Krieg
befeuert werden würde auch hier im Hohen
Haus sind manche dieser Ansicht aber
meine Damen und Herren diese Mittel
schützen auch unsere Freiheit unsere
Demokratie sie schützen unser
Land zu einer ehrlichen Betrachtung
gehört dass das Verteidigungsministerium
angesichts der notwendigen
Sparbemühungen einen
konsolidierungsanteil durch
Umschichtungen zu Lasten des
Sondervermögens Bundeswehr erbringen
muss insgesamt werden nun 520 Millionen
Euro für nachbeschaffungen von an die
Ukraine abgegebenen Waffensystemen aus
dem Sondervermögen
finanziert ich halte das für vertretbar
denn die Bundeswehr bekommt durchweg
moderneres und besseres Gerät als sie
der Ukraine abgegeben hat im vergangenen
Jahr haben wir in Rekordgeschwindigkeit
die Nachbeschaffung der 18 in die
Ukraine abgegebenen Kampfpanzer Leopard
2A6 realisiert als Ersatz werden Systeme
der Baureihe 2a8 angeschafft das ist
technologisch ein großer Schritt und
verbessert die abschreckungsfähigkeit
unserer Armee deutlich Abgaben Schwächen
die Bundeswehr kurzfristig mittelfristig
verstärken nachbeschaffungen unsere
haftigkeit und erlauben uns unsere
natooverpflichtungen umzusetzen ich will
daran erinnern wir erreichen mit dem
Bundeshaushalt
2024 zum ersten Mal seit Jahrzehnten
einen Anteil von mehr als 2% unserer
Wirtschaftsleistung die wir für unsere
Verteidigung investieren das ist ein
Meilenstein den diese Koalition auch in
haushaltspolitisch herausfordernden
Zeiten erreicht das ist die Spiegelung
der Zeitenwende im
Bundeshaushalt
wir haben nach Ende des Sondervermögens
große Aufgaben für un vor uns es geht um
den Schutz unseres Landes und unserer
Bevölkerung nicht nur Verteidigung
auch Hybride Bedrohungen
Cyberattacken müssen wir bekämpfen und
wir stehen da vor großer Herausforderung
und ich appelliere insbesondere an die
Kolleginnen Kollegen von der Union
lassen Sie uns diese elementare und
entscheidende Frage der europäischen
Freiheit und
Sicherheit gemeinsam bearbeiten und
gemeinsam eine Lösung entwickeln
herzlichen
Dank Sebastian Schäfer war das für die
Bündnisgrünen ja die NATO Vorgabe 2% der
Wirtschaftsleistung für Verteidigung
auszugeben wird erstmals eingehalten
allerdings nur dank der Mittel des 100
Milliarden Sondervermögens für die
Bundeswehr
sehgete frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen 2024 wird
Deutschland zum ersten Mal die Zielmarke
der NATO mit 2,1% übersteigen das ist
gelebte
Zeitenwende mit dem Sondervermögen 100
Milliarden Euro für die wiederlangung
der Verteidigungsfähigkeit werden wir zu
zwei Drittel sind schon gebunden und
Ende des Jahres werden wir 100% gebunden
haben das ist gelebte Zeitenwende mit
dem
beschaffungsbeschleunigungsgesetz mit
der entschlankung der Beschaffung im
Ministerium und Beschaffungsamt keine
goldrandlösungen Materialbeschaffung die
den Marktmöglichkeiten
entsprechen das alles ist gelebte
Zeitenwende liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir haben
Rüstungsvorhaben die die 25 Millionen
EUR Schwelle überspringen im
Gesamtvolumen von
47,7 Milliarden Euro im
Haushaltsausschuss auf dem Weg gebracht
das ist fast 1 Milliarden Euro mehr als
die Union 2021 dem ganzen Ministerium
zur Verfügung gestellt hat das ist
gelebte Zeitenwende liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und diese Beispiele zeigen
dass wir dass die Fraktionen von SPD
Grünen und FDP die Zeiten ernst nehmen
und dass diese Bundesregierung die von
diesen Fraktionen getragen wird die
Zeitenwende mit Leben füllt denn uns
geht es darum die Verteidigungsfähigkeit
dieses Landes wieder zuerlangen und ein
abschrckungspotenzial unsereer
Streitkräfte zu erreichen das uns hilft
den Frieden und Freiheit der Menschen in
diesem Land zu
verteidigen und jetzt stellt sich die
Frage ob es einen anderen Weg gibt zum
Frieden ein anderen Weg als Stärke zu
zeigen und da gibt es auf der linken
Seite und auf der rechten Seite dieses
Hauses ja vermeintlich einfachere Wege
die den Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor
allem der AFD aus Moskau eingeflüstert
werden ein vermeintlich ein trügerischer
Frieden der aber nicht zur Freiheit
führt es ist der Weg in die Abhängigkeit
es ist der Weg an dessen Ende Menschen
aus Fenstern fallen vergiftet werden
Flugzeuge abstürzen Menschen weggesperrt
werden und einfach verschwinden am Ende
dieses Weges werden Vätern und Müttern
ihre Kinder weggenommen wie in der
Ukraine und das darf nicht unser Weg
sein und das wird nicht unser Weg sein
liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen denn Frieden und Freiheit
gewinnt man nicht durch Unterwerfung
sondern dadurch dass man gemeinsam in
einem Bündnis stark Aggressoren
Autokraten und Despoten
entgegentritt und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass unsere Freundinnen und Freunde in
der Ukraine diesen Krieg auch gewinnen
und deshalb ist es richtig die starken
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen die die wir als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland aber auch
gemeinsam mit den Partnern auf den Weg
gebracht haben deutschland ist der
größte Partner der Ukraine in
militärischer finanzieller und
humanitärer Sicht in Europa und der
zweitgrößte weltweit und das müssen wir
in den Debatten auch viel stärker und
selbstbewusster betonen in Deutschland
wird gerade so getan wie wenn das ein
kleckerles Betrag ist nein die Freunde
in der Ukraine sind dankbar für unsere
starke Unterstützung die Ihnen hilft
ihren Frieden und und ihre Freiheit aber
auch unsere Werte zu
verteidigen aber liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zur Wahrheit gehört auch dazu
kann Deutschland die Unterstützung der
Ukraine im Alleingang organisieren und
finanzieren diese Antwort ist ziemlich
einfach denn diese Antwort heißt nein
wir brauchen unsere Partner in Europa
und dafür muss in diesem Jahr auch
definitiv deutlicher gestritten werden
denn es ist nicht mehr der Zeitpunkt von
Herr heroischen reden in Europa sondern
von heroischen Taten und das ist in
vielen Hauptstädten der großen
Volkswirtschaften in Europa leider nur
sehr unzureichend
angekommen die Vorstellung dass
Deutschland diese Diskrepanz diese Lücke
zwischen Reden und Handeln im Alleingang
über Neuverschuldung schließen kann
dieser Vorstellung die wird nicht
erfolgreich sein den es geht um Haltung
und es geht um Glaubwürdigkeit des
westlichen werteb es und die werden wir
nur daherstellen wenn wir gemeinsam
kraftvolles Handeln zeigen und das gilt
auch für die innerpolitische
innenpolitische Diskussion liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Verteidigungsfähigkeit ist eine
Daueraufgabe wir haben das
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr 100 Milliarden
Euro mit Verschuldung finanziert in
einer außergewöhnlichen ein akuten
Situation indem wir auf eine Aufholjagd
angesetzt haben in der wir ein starkes
Zeichen an alle Feinde des Friedens und
der Freiheit setzen wollten aber in
Wahrheit ist Verteidigungsfähigkeit eine
Daueraufgabe und daueraufgaben müssen
aufs laufenden Einnahmen finanziert
werden der Anteil der
Verteidigungsausgaben im Bundeshaushalt
weit vor der vor Ende des Kalten Krieges
war fast 20% aktuell sind wir noch bei
fast 11% und das zeigt doch dass wir
Diskussionen führen müssen Diskussionen
die dazu führen dass wir die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit dieses Landes
wieder stärken können denn dann ist das
ist die Grundvoraussetzung um unsere
demokratische Grundordnung unser Freide
und Frieden zu erhalten heute und in
Zukunft vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit Ksten klein war das für
die FDP Fraktion ja es können nicht
alleine an Deutschland hängen das hat
heute Mittag auch Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz gesagt und hat die europäischen
Partner vor dem EU Sondergipfel zu einer
stärkeren militärischen Unterstützung
der Ukraine
aufgefordert relativ spät und befinden
uns damit in direkte Nähe zu zwei
Jubiläen in 27 Tagen wird die
Zeitenwende Rede 2 Jahre alt und Boris
Pistorius kann sein einjähriges
Amtsjubiläum feiern insofern Anlass ein
bisschen ein bisschen Zwischenbilanz zu
ziehen auf das eine oder andere
einzugehen was wir gemeinsam gemacht
haben das war eine historische
zeitenwenderede das muss man sagen in
einer historischen Situation und sie
haben erlebt heute gab's ja jetzt auch
wieder gerade noch mal den Appell an uns
mitzuwirken dass
wir auch all das durchgesetzt haben was
der Bundeskanzler vorgeschlagen hat
insbesondere das Sondervermögen in der
Verfassung verankert haben ich glaube
das war richtig das war gut und zu
dieser gemeinsamen
Aufbauleistung auch
aufbauverpflichtung für unsere
Bundeswehr bekennt sich die CDU CSU
Fraktion ausdrücklich meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und daraus
folgt auch eine fortgehende
Verpflichtung für die zukomt und ich
will nur Herr Kollege Dr Schäfer zwei
Bemerkungen zu den Sätzen sagen die sie
gesagt haben die ich vollumfänglich
unterschreiben kann und das erste ist
die Verwendung des Sondervermögens der
Kollege gedichens hat das
angesprochen natürlich bekommt die
Bundeswehr als Ersatzbeschaffung äh
neueres moderneres auch neuere Leopard 2
Panzer als diejenigen die sie abgegeben
hat an die Ukraine nur die Formulierung
in unserer Verfassung und die Absprachen
mit der CDU CSU Fraktion waren eindeutig
das nämlich das Sondervermögen allein
für eine besser Ausstattung für eine
mehr Ausstattung der Bundeswehr verwandt
werden sollen und insofern handeln sie
kontralem verstoßen gegen das Gesetz und
zerstören vor allen Dingen auch
Vertrauen bei der CDU CSU Fraktion ich
will darauf nur in aller Deutlichkeit
hinweisen das ist nicht in Ordnung und
das ist noch nicht einmal zu irgendeinem
Zeitpunkt mit uns mal besprochen worden
also deswegen wundern Sie sich nicht
wenn die Bereitschaft zur Gemeinsamkeit
in der CDU CSU Fraktion geringer
ausfällt als sie in der Vergangenheit
vorhanden gewesen ist und das zweite
vielle hören Sie es einfach mal an kann
sie auch mal drüber nachdenken das
zweite ist die Sache Taurus und da will
ich dazu sagen die Vorsitz des
Verteidigungsausschusses Frau Kollegin
Dr Marie Agnes Stck Zimmermann die
selbst jetzt als sogenannte
eurofighterin
bezeichnet hat keine Zeit mehr an dieser
Debatte hier teilzunehmen wenn sie nicht
mehr in der Lage oder bereit ist die
Aufgaben als
verteidigungsausschussvorsitzende
wahrzunehmen soll sie uns das wissen
lassen ich finde sowieso dass das etwas
kollidiert mit der Spitzenkandidatur zur
Europawahl aber das mag vielleicht die
freie demokratische Fraktion mal
erörtern nur ich will hier festhalten
dass sie angekündigt hat dass sie
angekündigt hat und Kollege Dr Schef hat
auch noch mal gesagt dass es im Februar
ohne wenn und aber einen
taurusantrag der koalitionsfraktion
geben wird und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich kündige hier für die CDU
CSU Fraktion an dass wir das
unterstützen werden weil wir das schon
lange beantragen an der Stelle muss
jetzt ein Beschluss erfolgen wer den
Mund spitzt muss Pfeifen wir erwarten
diesen taurusantrag von der Ampel
Koalition dass der im Februar kommt da
haben wir nur eine Sitzungswoche und
wenn der nicht kommt werden wir wieder
einen Antrag stellen und meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren an der Stelle
wenn sie es ernst me der mit der Ukraine
dann muss das hier im Deutschen
Bundestag beschlossen
werden ich möchte zum Bundes äh
Verteidigungsminister sagen dass wir
alle mit großer Freude zur Kenntnis
genommen haben wie
er die Themen der Bundeswehr adressiert
die Sprache die er verwendet wie er auch
in die Öffentlichkeit hinein
kommuniziert und deswegen möchte ich
Ihnen lieber Herr pisturius ausdrücklich
gratulieren zu der hohen Anerkennung die
sie öffentlich finden es erfüllt uns
alle mit Stolz auch die CDU CSU Fraktion
wenn der Bundesminister für Verteidigung
der beliebteste Minister in ganz
Deutschland ist das zeigt dass die
Menschen aufgeschlossen sind dass sie
durch glaubwürdige Personen überzeugbar
sind und dass die Themen der
Verteidigung in Deutschland auch eine
Wirkung haben das ist gut und das ist
richtig das möchte ich ausdrücklich
sagen wir verlangen allerdings von ihnen
auch Herr Minister dass Sie das was Sie
ankündigen und das was sie fordern auch
umsetzen und deswegen will ich das
wiederholen was der Kollege gedichens
gesagt hat ich finde es alarmierend
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass wenn
selbst dieser hochanerkannte und am in
der deutschen Bevölkung beliebteste
Minister 10 Milliarden mehr fordert für
die Bundeswehr am Ende herauskommt wegen
der sachfremden Verwendung des
Sondervermögens dass dann am Ende
weniger für die bundeswehre reinkommt
das ist eine Niederlage für Boris
Pistorius das ist eine Niederlage für
die Bundeswehr und das ist eine
bedenkliche Entwicklung wenn selbst
Boris Pistorius es nicht gelingt sie und
den Bundeskanzler davon zu überzeugen
mehr Geld für die Bundeswehr auszugeben
meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren und ich will etwas sagen zu den
zahlreichen Vorschlägen
Herr gemacht haben und viele davon sind
für uns durchaus diskutabel wir haben
keinen einzigen abgelehnt beispielsweise
zu der Fortentwicklung der Bundeswehr
und zur Personallage die prekär ist das
weiß jeder und der Inspekteur der Marine
hat gerade noch mal bezugnehmend auf die
Ausstattung der Fregatten darauf Bezug
genommen und seine höchste Besorgnis
geäußert und sie haben gesagt
wpflicht Dienstpflicht schwedisches
Modell über all das könnte man
diskutieren ausländische Mitbürger und
Mitbürger in der Bundeswehr
in fast allen Fällen haben sie
Widerspruch von ihrer eigenen Partei und
Fraktion bekommen zum Teil auch von den
freiendemokraten wenn es um die
Wehrpflicht geht ich habe nur zwei
Bemerkungen dazu die eine Bemerkung ist
alle die das ablehnen was der
Bundesminister hier vorgeschlagen hat
die mögen bitte andere Vorschläge machen
denn die Bundeswehr kommt mittlerweile
in eine hochkritische Personallage
hinein und wer bessere Ideen hat die
Lücken zu füllen sollen die Bitte
öffentlich sagen ich finde die sind
wirklich notwendig
ansonsten führen wir keine
verantwortliche Debatte und das zweite
ist Herr Minister es ist hohe Zeit dass
etwas getan wird und eBook heißt ja
nicht Ideenbörse und Kreativität sondern
heißt dass Sie der Inhaber der Befehls
und Kommando Gewalt sind und deswegen
Herr Minister erwarten wir jetzt nach
einem Jahr von ihnen endlich auch
konkrete Vorschläge
Gesetzentwürfe definitive Festlegung
welche Struktur soll die Bundeswehr
haben wollen sie die Personallage
verbessern sie finden bei uns offene und
konstruktive Menschen die darüber
diskutieren werden hier im
parlamentarischen Raum aber aber Herr
pestorius nach einem Jahr müssen sie
jetzt konkret werden sie haben selber
gesagt wir haben fün bis 8 Jahre und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt beginnen
herzlichen Dank für die
aufmer da ist es doch ganz passend dass
der Minister das borus genau jetzt auf
der le steht also für die
Bundesregierung sprichorius der
Bundesverteidigungsminister seit 19
Januar 2023 ist er im Amt frau
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren es ist schon gesagt worden es
ist soweit vor 10 Jahren wurde zugesagt
den Rückgang der Verteidigungsausgaben
endlich anzuhalten und zu versuchen uns
innerhalb eines jahrzeh an 2% des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes anzunäheren mit
dem Haushalt 24 meine Damen und Herren
werden wir eine natoquote von 2,1%
erreichen und das erstmals seit
Jahrzehnten meine Damen und
Herren für das Jahr 2024 stehen nach
jetziger Planung allein aus dem
Einzelplan 14 und dem Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr rund 72 Milliarden Euro für
unsere Streitkräfte zur Verfügung das
ist der höchste Wert seit Bestehen der
Bundeswehr und ein deutliches Zeichen
dass wir unsere Sicherheit und
Verteidigung ernst nehmen und hierfür
möchte ich Ihnen meine Damen und Herren
aber auch im vor all auch im Namen
unserer Soldatin und Soldaten
ausdrücklich danken das geht in die
richtige
Richtung und es ist das richtige
Ergebnis und es ist dem Ernst der Lage
angemessen der menschenverachtende
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
jäht sich in wenigen Wochen zum zweiten
Mal und ich bin überzeugt der
imperialistische Anspruch Putins
ist noch lange nicht aus putin wird auch
weiterhin mit allen Mitteln der Gewalt
versuchen den russischen Einfluss zu
vergrößern Grenzen zu verschieben wir
müssen daher unsere ukrainischen
Freundinnen und Freunde weiter
unterstützen meine Damen und Herren und
ich sag's auch sehr deutlich ich bin die
öffentliche Debatte was das Thema angeht
was leistet Deutschland was leistet die
Bundeswehr manchmal leid wir haben es
gehört wir sind seit geraumer Zeit der
zweitgrößte Unterstützer der Ukraine wir
machen in diesem Jahr mehr als die
Hälfte rein schon als Deutschland als
all anderen europäischen Nationen
zusammen wir leisten gewaltiges zur
Unterstützung der Ukraine und was höre
ich in Deutschland ausschließlich nur
noch die Debatte über ein Waffensystem
meine Damen und Herren als wenn es
darauf ankäme ob wir alles liefern was
geht oder ob wir uns auch selber noch
ein Stück Freiheit und Verantwortung
dafür nehmen diese Entscheidung zu
treffen so oder so wir bleiben der
Stärkste der zuverlässigste Unterstützer
der Ukraine Ukraine und dabei bleibt es
meine Damen und her und
gleichzeitig und das ist ein Spagat das
ist eine Herausforderung müssen wir die
Bundeswehr wieder zur zeitgemäßen Landes
und bündnisverteidigung befähigen was
eben 30 Jahre lang nicht nötig war das
ist wieder ihr kernauftrag wir brauchen
eine Bundeswehr die stark ist ja und die
auch abschreckt nur so können wir
verhindern dass es zum Äußersten kommt
Krieg verhindern kann nur wer sich
darauf vorbereitet aber meine Damen und
Herren das alleine reicht nicht wir
sehen uns derzeit weltweit mit einer
Vielzahl von sicherheitspolitischen
Umbrüchen und Konflikten konfrontiert ob
in Israel im Jemen in Syrien auf dem
Balkan im Kaukasus oder im Indopazifik
wir müssen daher auch an anderen Orten
dieser Welt Stellung beziehen können mit
unseren bewrten Maßnahmen aus Diplomatie
und
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit aber wenn
nötig eben auch militärisch und ich will
nichts beschönigen meine Damen und
Herren wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
dass die finanzbedarfe der Bundeswehr
dauerhaft steigen Sicherheit gibt es
nicht zum Nulltarif heute nicht und erst
recht nicht in ein paar Jahren eine
verlässliche Verteidigung braucht einen
verlässlichen nachhaltigen und ja einen
steigenden Haushalt das Sondervermögen
leistet hierfür einen wichtigen ersten
Schritt wir müssen uns aber schon heute
Gedanken darüber machen wie die wie wir
die Bundeswehr auch nach voraorausgabung
des Sondervermögens aus
ausstatten wollen und liebe sie haben so
schön gesagt ich müss mal auf den
tischauen ich erinnere mich gerade an
das tischauen von Herrn Jung Herr von zu
Gutenberg her Frau vonlein und
Anau hat wahnsinnig viel gebracht ich
frag die mal wie die das gemacht haben
aber im Zweifel ma ich das lieber mit
stetiger beharlicher Arbeit damit auf
den Tisch und klar ist auch meine Damen
und Herren wiruchen natürlich ein
planbaren
Finanzierungsrahmen nur ein planbar
aufsteigender Verteidigungshaushalt
macht den Kraftakt des Sondervermögens
wirklich
zukunftsfest wir brauchen dauerhaft
mindestens 2% unseres
Bruttoinlandsproduktes um die Bundeswehr
auf die Anforderung der Zeitenwende
auszurichten und die fähigkeitziele der
NATO zu
erfüllen wir brauchen das sie in
Zwischenfrage aus der Unionsfraktion
zulassen wollen ja sehr gerne bitte
schön
Herr Minister sie haben gerade auf ihre
Vorgängerinnen auch verwiesen können sie
bestätigen dass in dem Zeitraum von
2014 bis zur Regierungsübernahme 2021
der Verteidigungshaushalt angewachsen
ist von etwa 32 Milliarden Euro auf 50
Milliarden Euro und dass es die Leistung
der unionsministerin war das war wohl
eher eine Leistung des
Bundesfinanzministers und des Partners
in der großen Koalition geschuldet im
übrigen wissen wir ja dass diese Beträge
bei weitem nicht ausgereicht haben das
wissen sie besser als wir meine Seen
Damen und Herren es braucht diese
Ausgaben um auch in Zukunft wieder deter
und Defense glaubhaft gewährleisten zu
können und hierfür meine Damen und
Herren möchte ich Sie um Unterstützung
bitten mit Blick auf den vorliegenden
Entwurf des Haushalts 2024 aber auch
schon mit Blick auf diedaten des
Haushaltes 25 und des Finanzplans bis 28
mir ist aber auch bewusst vertrauen ihr
Vertrauen und Ihre Unterstützung dürfen
keine Einbahnstraße sein wenn Sie uns
die Mittel zur Verfügung stellen dann
müssen wir auch liefern und das tun wir
meine Damen und Herren wir haben viel
geschafft im vergangenen Jahr wir haben
dem Haushaltsausschuss 55 25 Millionen
Euro Vorlagen z zugeleitet so viel wie
noch nie in einem Jahr einen großen
Anteil über % des Sondervermögens sind
bereits vertraglich gebunden und 2024
beabsichtigen wir allein aus dem
Sondervermögen knapp 20 Milliarden Euro
zur Finanzierung wichtiger
Beschaffungsvorhaben auszugeben zudem
haben wir in dieser
Legislaturperiode große Rüstungsvorhaben
wie die F35 die überschneefahrzeuge der
neuen Generation die
führungsmittelausstattung für Zugsysteme
infantris der Zukunft weitere
Schützenpanzer Puma schwere
Transporthubschrauber des ch47 und
weitere seefernaufklärer unter Vertrag
genommen alles in kürzester Zeit auch
das Projekt Eurofighter elektronischer
Kampf haben wir gestartet und mit Israel
einen regierungskaufvertrag über die
Beschaffung des flugabwehrsystems Arrow
nepstlenkflugkörpern
abgeschlossen wir können daher mit Fug
und Recht behaupten meine Damen und
Herren wir setzen die Zeitenwende um wir
gehen neue Wege wir werden schneller und
wir ändern das was geändert werden muss
auch in diesem Jahr werden wir die
Zeitenwende mit Leben erfüllen und ich
will auf drei Punkte exemplarisch
eingehen Personal wir haben es gehört
ist ein ganz entscheidender Faktor um
unsere Einsatzbereitschaft und damit die
Sicherheit der Bundesrepublik und ihrer
Partner sicherzustellen und dazu gehört
die Überprüfung unserer personalbedarfe
und natürlich auch die Frage ob eine
allgemeine Dienstpflicht oder eine
werflicht sinnvoll ist oder nicht
gesellschaftlich müssen wir uns nämlich
die Frage stellen wer dieses Land
verteidigen soll wenn es ernst wird und
das heißt wen gewinnen wir für die
Bundeswehr und wie stellen wir die
verbesserte wie gewährleisten wir die
verbesserte Repräsentanz von Frauen klar
ist und das habe ich bereits an anderer
Stelle
gesagt jedes Modell braucht politische
Mehrheiten und eine Gesellschaft die es
trägt aber an der Debatte kommen wir
nicht
vorbei meine Damen und Herren ein
weiterer Punkt den wir uns genau
anschauen sind unsere Strukturen wir
befinden uns und deswegen geht die
Kritik aus der Union vollkommen ins
lehere wir sind längst in der
Umstrukturierung im Ministerium auf der
Ziel gereraden ab morgen nehmen wir die
neuen Strukturen ein mit dem Ziel besser
schneller entscheiden zu können alles
die Fragen die niemand in den letzten 25
Jahren angegangen ist das will ich noch
mal sehr deutlich sagen jetzt folgen
jetzt folgen die Strukturen der
Streitkräfte und der zivilen Bereiche
klarer Maßstab und ich will es noch mal
betonen damit alle wissen worum es geht
klarer Maßstab ist die zukunftsfeste
Ausrichtung der Bundeswehr auf ihre
Aufgaben und das heißt wieder vor allem
Landes und
bündnisverteidigung
ausreichend Personal und gute Strukturen
reichen aber nicht aus die soldatinen
und Soldaten haben einen Anspruch auf
moderne Ausrüstung und voll
ausgestattete Verbände wir arbeiten also
weiter daran die Beschaffung intern wie
extern zu optimieren und zu
beschleunigen wichtig ist dabei dass
alle Elemente der der Beschaffungskette
Zusammenwirken von der Truppe bis zur
Industrie und klar ist auch unsere
sicherheits- und Verteidigungsindustrie
muss ihre Produktionskapazitäten
hochfahren dazu braucht sie aber
Planungssicherheit und
Verlässlichkeit und wir müssen daher
gemeinsam mit der Industrie
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen die eine
schnelle Erhöhung der Kapazitäten
ermöglichen etwa mit langfristigen
verbindlichen Mindestabnahmemengen
international gebündelten Beschaffung
mit unseren Partnern und einer
nachhaltigen Finanzierung meine Damen
und Herren eines ist gewiss die
Zeitenwende wird uns noch lange
begleiten und wir können diesen Weg nur
gemeinsam gehen politisch
gesellschaftlich und wirtschaftlich
dieser Haushaltsentwurf ist ein klares
Zeichen dafür dass wir die Gestaltung
der Zeitenwende sehr sehr ernst nehmen
wir zeigen wir übernehmen Verantwortung
für unsere Sicherheit und wir nehmen
unsere Rolle als großer natoartner wahr
und ich bitte Sie daher unterstützen Sie
diesen Haushaltsentwurf es geht um die
Zukunft unserer whrhaftigkeit und
unserer Verteidigungsfähigkeit und es
geht um unsere Glaubwürdigkeit nach
innen wie nach außen vielen
Dank sagt der
Bundesverteidigungsminister mit Hilfe
des Sondervermögens da hat er in diesem
Jahr für sein et über 72 Milliarden Euro
aber Boris por brauch darauf dauerhaft
mehr Geld für die Bundeswehr zur
Verfügung zu stellen doch wo es
herkommen soll das fragen sich wohl hier
nicht nur die
Haushaltspolitiker frau Präsidentin Frau
werrbeauftragte meine Damen und Herren
wir werden in diesen Wochen Zeuge einer
sehr skurilen Entwicklung die
Bundesregierung bittet die deutsche
Bevölkerung um moralische
Unterstützung weil sie mit dem regieren
hoffnungslos überfordert ist geme ist
freilich dass der deutsche sich jetzt
bitte mit Kritik zurückhalten möge weil
die Lage nun mal so schwierig ist Reihen
schließen in schwieriger Zeit man sitze
ja im selben Boot Tonlage DDR diese
Entwicklung ist nicht neu es ist die
klammheimliche Übertragung der
Verantwortung auf alle die politische
Kaste hat dazu ein eigentliches
eigentlich
harmloses und gutes Wort genommen und es
in ein gefährliches Wort transformiert
ich spreche von dem Wort
wir ich bitte jeden Bürger einmal darauf
zu achten wie häufig Regierungspolitiker
das Wort wir benutzen wir haben ein
Haushaltsloch wir haben ein Schulden
wir haben ein
Ausgabenproblem wir müssen jetzt
zusammenstehen und jetzt überlegen Sie
mal wer hat wirklich ein Haushaltsloch
ein Schuldenproblem einen
verfassungswidrigen Haushalt
zusammengetrixt das waren nicht wir
sondern das waren
die
Verteidigungs
Verteidigungsminister
poriuschibt seinem
Verantwortungsbereich das gleiche
falsche Spiel wir müssen bei der
Beschaffung schneller werden wir müssen
bei der
Personalgewinnung besser werden wir
müssen kriegstüchtig werden aber auch
hier gilt nein Herr Pistorius nicht wir
müssen diese Aufgaben erledigen sondern
sie und es sind auch nicht unsere
Soldaten die dafür ortung tragen sondern
sie Herr Pistorius müssen dafür sorgen
dass die Truppe ausgerüstet ist sie sind
nicht in der Rolle kriegstüchtigkeit
einzufordern sondern sie
herzustellen
meine meine Damen und Herren die
Bundesregierung wird am Freitag den
größten Verteidigungshaushalt in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
verabschieden 52 Milliarden regulär plus
20 Milliarden aus dem Schul aus dem
sonderschuldentopf Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius hat 72 Milliarden Euro zur
Verfügung um die Bundeswehr
einsatzbereit zu machen was hält sie auf
übrigens
bistorius israelischer Kollege joa
Galland kommt mit
16,2 Milliarden aus das ist nur ein
Viertel des deutschen Budgets und damit
befreit er den Gazastreifen von der
heramas nein meine Damen und Herren am
Mangel mangelnden Geld liegt es nicht es
liegt am
Missmanagement der politischen
Leitung dem deutschen
Verteidigungsminister stehen nicht nur
72 Milliarden zur Verfügung er hat
tausende Mitarbeiter die das machen was
er sagt zum zum anderen hat er die
Mehrheit im Parlament auch Union und AFD
unterstützen die Beschaffung von
Material die Presse ist auf seiner Seite
beliebtester Politiker noch dazu
scholzablöser deswegen noch mal die
Frage was hält Herrn bistorius auf die
bundeswert zu ertüchtigen die Antwort
ist klar es ist diese ideologisch
verbohte Regierung in der er drin steckt
und diese Regierung scheitert an den
Gesetzen der Ökonomie scheitert an den
Gesetzen der Mathematik an der Physik
und der Biologie und am Wesen der
Menschen kurz um die
Bundesregierung scheitert an der
Realität und
da und da wird es auch nicht helfen wenn
der
Verteidigungsminister am Wochenende in
Oldenburg zu den Omas gegen Rechts
spricht und gegen die
Opposition in Brück zu den Omas gegen
Rechts spricht und gegen die Opposition
demonstriert denn die
AFD hält sie bestimmt nicht auf die
Bundeswehr einsatzbereit zu machen
darauf gebe ich Ihnen mein Wort danke
schön ein die
Wahheit die Kollegin SAR Nanni hat jetzt
das Wort für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
W anscheinend heute hier in dieser Bette
nicht an Pastor sehr geehrte Präsidentin
sehr geehrte werbeauftragte lieber Herr
Minister liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
war der Kollege gnauk der letzte Woche
noch hier sehr schnittig aufgetreten ist
heute aber nicht zu letzte Sitzung auf
hier aufgetreten ist jetzt aber nicht
mehr zu Wort kommt scheint ihnm doch
peinlich zu sein was sie für Leute in
den Reihen der AFD haben insbesondere
nach den Berichterstattung von
korrektiv.org wo auch noch mal die
Verbindung zu identitären Bewegung so
klar geworden sind trauen sie sich nicht
mehr hier hier in dieser
verteidigungspolitischen Debatte nach
vorne zu stellen auch das spricht
Wände nach dem Überfall Russlands auf
die Ukraine am
242.22 hat der Bundes Kanzler hier an
diesem Platz die Zeitenwende ausgerufen
und im Juni 22 haben wir da mit großer
Mehrheit das Sondervermögen beschlossen
wir haben in Sachen Zeitenwende in
diesen zwei Jahren viel erreicht wir
haben die Rahmenbedingung geändert
bundeswehrbeschaffungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
der Kollege hat schon angesprochen wir
haben 2,4 Milliarden Euro ausgegeben für
Ausrüstung und Bekleidung der Soldate
innen und Soldaten und wir haben die
Beschaffung der F6 35 ähm die dringend
benötigte Tornado ver nachfolggeräte
wir haben in warneemünde das hat mich
sehr gefreut ein historischer Tag für
die Marine die MV Werft eingeweiht
Instandhaltung wird also einfacher für
uns und unsere Verbündete die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben schon
aufgezählt was wir auch uns noch fürs
nächste Jahr vorgenommen haben
Digitalisierung landbasierter Systeme
Entwicklung von eloka beim Eurofighter
wir werden uns mit dem la n Bereich
weiter beschäftigen und intensiver
darüber sprechen und wir werden auch das
dieses Jahr dafür nutzen das Material
was wir in die Ukraine abgegeben haben
wieder
nachzubeschaffen und das sage ich auch
ganz deutlich weil das will ich hier
nicht schön reden die Truppe braucht es
dringend um zu üben und um glaubhaft
abschrecken zu
können aber eine gut ausgestchattete
Bundeswehr ist nur ein Baustein von
vielen auf dem Weg zu einer integrierten
Sicherheitspolitik eine integrierte
Sicherheitspolitik wie sie sich die
Bundesregierung in der nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie vorgenom hat eine
integrierte Sicherheitspolitik wie sie
auch nötig ist in diesen bewegten Zeiten
Ostflanke Balkan Sahel Aserbaidschan
Armenien Israel Gaza rotes Meer
Taiwanstraße aber auch die US-Politik
mit all seinen möglichen Folgen wo
Konflikte Krisen und Kriege ineinander
greifen wo Herausforderung für die
globale Wirtschaft für Flucht und
Migration für Frieden und Stabilität so
groß waren wie lange nicht mehr brauchen
wir eine integrierte Sicherheitspolitik
so nötig wie
nie die Unterstützung der Ukraine ist
für uns vital Europas Sicherheit hängt
von nichts mehr ab als davon wie dieser
Krieg weitergeht oder endet und wir
richten uns neu aus in der Landes und
bündnisverteidigung die Brigade in
litaauen ist essentiell für eine
glaubhafte
Abschreckung wir müssen aber auch und
das zeigen insbesondere die letzte Woche
die letzten Wochen sehr deutlich unsere
Demokratie stärken und sie von innen
resilient machen uns stehen wieder
Einmischung vor in Wahlkämpfe übrigens
auch unterstützt durch sie wir werden
weiter mit Cyberattacken rechnen müssen
russische Agentinnen werden weiter ihr
Unwesen in Deutschland und Europa
treiben und sie werden versuchen die
europäischen Gesellschaften zu spalten
da arbeiten sie ja ständig gut dran mit
sie werden versuchen mit unlauteren
Mitteln weltweit zu destabilisieren und
Russland wird auch weiter zu versuchen
Mehrheiten gegen eine stabile
Friedensordnung in Europa und stabile
europäische Gesellschaften zu
organisieren auf all das müssen wir uns
einstellen das gehört auch zu einer
integrierten Sicherheitspolitik dazu und
das sollte auch dieser Haushalt
ab das sollte auch dieser Haushalt
abbilden er tut es aber nicht genug das
sage ich auch ganz ehrlich ich finde es
zeilich weil dieser Haushalt in einer
sehr schwierigen Lage entstanden ist
nach dem Urteile von karlsruhr musste
die ursprüngliche Planung rasch geändert
werden und ich möchte mich insbesondere
bei den Kolleginnen und Kollegen die das
hier verhandelt haben auch herzlich
bedanken ihr habt das Beste draus
gemacht aber wir leben in historischen
Zeiten die eine Handlungsfähigkeit des
Staates abverlangt wie wir sie alle hier
im Saal nie erlebt haben und der nächste
Haushalt muss das besser abbilden für
diesen bitte ich um ihre Unterstützung
und an die Union noch ein letztes Wort
ich weiß nicht wie oft Sie sich hier
noch hinstellen
wollen und so tun wollen als wenn wir
eine große Lücke hätten in der Zukunft
und sie ein Konzept dafür wie sie
geschlossen wird sie haben heute morgen
mit ihrem Fraktionsvorsitzenden
offiziell alle Angebote zur
Zusammenarbeit ausgeschlagen pauschal
sie machen in der Haushaltsdebatte kein
einzigen Vorschlag wo das Geld nach Ende
des Sondervermögens herkommen soll und
dann stellen Sie sich hier hin und
machen Forderung was was die Ausstattung
der Bundeswehr angeht und können das
kein Stückchen auch das bekommt der
Obergefreite mit dergichen vielen Dank
für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit ja da gab's noch jetzt
noch einige Zwischenrufe und Reaktion
natürlich auf SAR Nani die kann man von
hier aus auch nicht so ganz gut
nachvollziehen mir vorbehalte
Ordnungsmaßnahmen zu ergreifen und das
zweite Herr Brandner vielleicht können
sie unterscheiden zwischen Zwischenrufen
und Pöbelei was ich jetzt hier gehört
habe in den letzten Minuten war Pöbelei
das Wort hat der Kollege ja und das ging
in Richtung der AFD Fraktion und die
bundestagsvizpräsidentin hat es gesagt
das sitzungs des Sitzungsprotokoll kann
sie als amtierende
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin noch einmal
nachlesen und auch im Nachhinein dann
wenn sie beispielsweise Zwischenruf oder
pöbelein nicht direkt gehört hat dann
noch Rügen das ist also durchaus
möglich ja jetzt wieder Konzentration
auf den Redner am Rednerpult Markus
Farber ist das für die FDP Fraktion
Tankstop von hier entfernt und ich war
diesen Monat in der Ukraine und ich habe
mit den ukrainischen Soldaten dort
gesprochen und die können berichten und
die können das auch ihnen berichten wenn
sie fahren würden dass das kein
Vergnügen ist die können ihn berichten
dass sie das machen weil sie für ihre
Familien und sich selbst ein Leben in
Frieden und Freiheit wollen deswegen
kämpfen die dort deswegen sind die dort
in den schützengren die kämpfen dort und
die sind dort in den schützengreben weil
sie wollen dass aus ihrem Heimatland
kein großes Butscher wird und deswegen
sollten wir sie auch dabei unterstützen
meine Damen und
Herren und das ist etwas was deutsche
und Ukrainer übrigens auch gemeinsam
haben dasben nach einem Leben in Frieden
und Freiheit und das ist heutzutage
keine Selbstverständlichkeit mehr wir
beraten ja heute einen
Verteidigungshaushalt und der steigt um
2 Milliarden und es ist auch gut dass
der um 2 Milliarden steigt weil wir uns
gegen Diktatoren wie Putin im Kriel
verteidigen können müssen und dafür ist
dieser Verteidigungshaushalt heute die
Grundlage
2014 hat eine andere
Bundesregierung versprochen in der NATO
dass man 2% des Bruttoinlandsprodukt für
Verteidigung ausgeben will
diese Bundesregierung ist die erste die
dieses Versprechen auch
einhält und zwar nicht nur in diesem
Jahr wir haben im Grundgesetz verankert
dass wir von nun an jedes Jahr 2% des
Bruttoinlandsprodukt in unsere eigene
Sicherheit investieren und das ist auch
gut so und das ist etwas wo man dieser
Koalition dankbar sein kann und wie Herr
Pistorius das auch schon erwähnt hat es
ist auch etwas wo man unserem
Finanzminister dankbar sein kann dass er
das möglich gemacht hat meine Damen und
Herren und das ist auch keine abstrakte
Zahl das ist ein Investment in die
Vollausstattung der Bundeswehr wir
investieren in persönliche Ausrüstung in
Schutzwesten moderne Schutzwesten in
Helme in Schutzbrillen in Funkgeräte für
knapp 200.000 Soldaten und Soldaten und
wir investieren auch in modernste
Technik in nah und nchstbereichschutz
der H heute schon erwähnt wurde wurde
wir investieren daran dass die
Bundeswehr sich zukünftigen verteidigen
kann wenn Putins terrordrohen auf sie
einfliegen wenn fluddienst terrordrohen
hoffentlich nie auf deutschenem
Territorium da sein würden aber wir
investieren daran dass die Bundeswehr
uns dagegen verteidigen kann und das ist
das richtige Investment zur richtigen
Zeit und damit ziehen wir die leeren aus
dem was wir gerade grausam ist in der
Ukraine sehen deswegen fordere ich Sie
auf auch Sie von der Union hier diesem
Verteidigungshaushalt zuzustimmen und
ich bedanke mich für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit das hat sich allerdings
in der bisherigen Aussprache nicht so
angehört und wäre dann doch überraschend
wenn die Union diesem Haushalt zustimmen
würde aber die Union hat jetzt zumindest
noch mal das Wort Reinhard Brandel
spricht er ist Mitglied im
Verteidigungsausschuss Präsidentin
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn
heute den ganzen Tag über die Debatten
verfolgt dann wird eines klar diese
Regierung hat sich vollständig von der
Realität entkoppelt sie lebt in ihrer
eigenen traumampel Traumwelt und wartet
dass ein grünes Wirtschaftswunder
irgendwann alle Probleme löst das wird
nicht
funktionieren und meine Damen und Herren
der einzige wo man das Gefühl hat er ist
noch etwas in der Realität ist der
Verteidigungsminister aber ich habe
manchmal das Gefühl der wird versucht
mit einem 100 Milliarden Euro toopf
ruhig zuell
sonderschulden die aber das grundlegende
Problem nicht lösen die Bedrohung
unserer äußeren Sicherheit ist keine
Sondersituation die man mit einem
Sondervermögen in 5 Jahren lösen kann
die Bedrohung der für die äußere
Sicherheit ist eine
Daueraufgabe und diese Daueraufgabe
müssen wir auch angemessen im Haushalt
entgegnen und mit dieser Daueraufgabe
sind sie offensichtlich
überfordert verhrte Kolleginen und
Kollegen nach dem Kalten Krieg haben wir
doch eines gelernt dass Abschreckung die
effektivste Weise ist einen Krieg zu
verhindern und Abschreckung und
Verteidigung hat in ihrer Regierung
keine Priorität und der Kollege klein
hat vorher die Zahlen genannt und unsere
Zahlen auch zitiert wie der Haushalt in
unserer Regierungsverantwortung war 2020
das war der letzte reguläre Haushalt den
wir voll unter Verantwortung hatten
hatten wir einen Verteidigungshaushalt
hatten wir einen Gesamthaushalt von 362
Milliarden Euro und 45 Milliarden Euro
für Verteidigung sie geben jetzt 114
Milliarden Euro mehr aus da und nur 7
Milliarden Euro mehr für Verteidigung
der Anteil des
Verteidigungshaushalts am Gesamthaushalt
sinkt und jetzt werden sie argumentieren
ja aber wir haben doch das
Sondervermögen aber das
Sondervermögen
sind Schulden und Schulden sind wie
Drogen Herr Kollege sie erleichtern den
Tag aber wenn sie mal weg sind dann wird
der Entzug hart und
2027 wird der Topf leer sein und 2028
fehlen in 850 Milliarden Euro und ich
habe auch heute keine Antwort gehört wie
sie dieses Log 2028 stopfen wollen es
gibt eine Zwischenfrage aus der SPD
Fraktion möchten Sie die zulassen
gerne ja Frau Kollegin bitte
lieber Herr Kollege
Brandel ich war auch den ganzen Tag in
dieser Debatte dabei ich weiß nicht auf
welcher Debatte sie waren aber auf der
hier jedenfalls nicht weil ihre Rede hat
mit dem was hier bisher gesprochen
worden ist nicht so viel zu tun aber ich
möchte zu ihren Zahlen kommen sie haben
ja vorhin schon die Debatte bereichert
durch ihren Beitrag wie der
Verteidigungsetat von 2014 bis heute
gestiegen sei also bis 21 haben sie
gesagt genau genau da möchte ich jetzt
ihre ihr Erinnerungsvermögen mal ein
bisschen auffrischen es war nämlich so
dass unter der CDU FDP Regierung unter
Herrn zuug Gutenberg die ihre Regierung
die sie geführt haben den
verteidigungsit um 8 Milliarden Euro
gekürzt hat das war einmalig in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland
dann war die große Koalition die zweite
und in den ersten vier Jahr
war wfgang Schäuble Finanzminister und
wissen sie das ja wir haben zusammen den
verteidigungsital gesteigert in diesen
vier Jahren mit Wolfgang Schäuble um
sage und schreibe 4 Milliarden Euro pro
Jahr dann wurde Olaf Scholz
Finanzminister und wissen Sie was in den
nächsten vier Jahren geschah wir haben
in der dritten großen Koalition den
verteidigungsitter von 37 Milliarden auf
50 Milliarden pro Jahr erhöht pro Jahr
erhöht und jetzt übrigens steigt er
wieder und damit wenn wir das nicht
gemacht hätten mit dem Finanzminister
Olaf Scholz dann wäre der Trümmerhaufen
vor dem die Bundeswehr steht noch viel
größer als er sowieso schon ist aber der
ampelregierung ausgerechnete
ampelregierung hier vorzuwerfen dass wir
keine Priorität bei der Bundeswehr
setzen das ist wirklich ein Treppenwitz
der
Geschichte für die
SPD Kollegin sie haben doch ihre Frage
jetzt gerade selber beantwortet was wir
geschafft haben auch mit Ihrer
Unterstützung auch übrigens mit der
Unterstützung damals des
Bundesfinanzministers Olaf Scholz ist
dass der Verteidigungshaushalt jedes
Jahr sie haben 4 Milliarden Euro nehmen
wir mal die Zahl an im Schnitt gestiegen
ist und was tut der
Verteidigungshaushalt jetzt er stagniert
er steigt eben nicht sie haben eine
Bereinigungssitzung gehabt letzt vor zi
Wochen haben 30 Milliarden Euro neu
verteilt neue Schulden mehr aufgenommen
und worin haben sie nicht investiert sie
haben nicht investiert in Verteidigung
und dann wird uns immer gesagt ja aber
wir haben das Sondervermögen aber wissen
Sie was das Sondervermögen ist das
Sondervermögen ist
2027 zu Ende und
2027 steuert die Bundeswehr auf einen
Abgrund zu wenn sie die Bundeswehr
weiter richtig finanzieren wollen müsste
sich der Verteidigungshaushalt nach
Berechnungen des bmvgs im Jahr
2028 f verdoppeln das wird nicht
funktionieren es kann nicht
funktionieren und ehrlicherweise kann
man so nur regieren wenn man weiß dass
man dann wenn soweit ist keine
Verantwortung mehr trägt danke sie
dürfen sich
setzen aber ehrlicherweise es ist ja
nicht nur der Haushalt das Problem das
Beschaffungswesen das uns ja schon Jahre
beschäftigt wird auch nicht richtig
reformiert da gibt's keinen Angang dabei
zeigt die Bundeswehr im Moment im BM VG
mit dem beschaffungsstab Ukraine dass
sie gut und effektiv und schnell
beschaffen kann nur Hal nicht fürs eene
Land sondern für die Ukraine wenn wir
für die Bundeswehr selber beschaffen
dann sind wir immer noch im
friedensmodus und es ist dieser Zeit
nicht angemessen und meine Damen und
Herren lieber Herr Pistorius wir haben
jetzt eine Brigade die sie nach Litauen
schicken ich halte das für grundsätzlich
richtig die steht
2027 an der heißen Ostflanke der NATO
ich forder sie auf machen es zumindest
für diese Brigade einen eigenen
beschaffungsstab damit sich der
Kommandeur nicht hinten in koblens
irgendwo anstellen muss was er braucht
sondern dass es so schnell wie möglich
mit dem notwendigen Material versorgt
wird jetzt ist vorher das Thema Taurus
angesprochen ich sage ihnen voraus
irgendwann werden sie wie sie bei allen
anderen Waffensystemen irgendwann auch
reagiert haben irgendwann werden sie den
Taus in die Ukraine liefern oder einen
Ringtausch mit einem anderen Land
durchführen das wird passieren der
Kollege Farber nickt aber wissen Sie was
dann passiert es geht 100% zu Lasten der
Bundeswehr es gibt im Moment keine
tauchesproduktion mehr in Deutschland es
dauert mindestens drei bis 4 Jahre bis
eine neue Produktion aufgesetzt worden
ist und so das heißt wenn die Bundeswehr
jetzt nicht bestellt wenn sie jetzt
nicht in die Beschaffung geht dann wird
die Verteidigungsbereitschaft der
Bundeswehr in den nächsten Jahren auch
bei diesem signifikant wichtigen
Waffensystem sinken und ist genau der
Zeitraum wo Pistorius warnt da könnte
ein Krieg der NATO mit Russland
bevorstehen warnen sie nicht nur sondern
handeln sie auch
dementsprechend so und jetzt also ich
schlage ihn ganz konkret
vor ich schlage
Ihnen fr hat mich gerade gefragt ich
soll was vorschlagen ich schlage ganz
konkret vor dass sie einen Beschluss
fassen die Produktion von Taurus wieder
aufzunehmen und zwar auf einer
niedrigeren Stückzahl auf einer
niedrigeren Stückzahl damit sie wenn es
dann soweit ist die Stückzahlen
jederzeit auch wieder nach oben
schrauben können bis sie die ganzen
Zulieferer wieder zertifiziert haben das
dauert zwei bis dre Jahre die Zeit haben
wir im Ernstfall nicht und das ist die
Lücke die sie jetzt im Moment
reißen so und jetzt kommt noch ein
nächstes Beispiel
drohen der Krieg in der Ukraine zeigt
uns doch wie wichtig die drohen in der
Kriegsführung heute sind die Ukraine ein
Land im Krieg das ständig bombardiert
wird will seine drohenproduktion auf
eine Millionen drohen im Jahr steigern
und was macht Deutschland wir gründen
ein Arbeitskreis eine Taskforce das
bringt uns auch alle nichts wir
diskutieren seit Jahren darum dass wir
bei der Bundeswehr schnell bewaffnete
drohen bra ich habe bisher noch keine
einzige beschaffungsvorlage im BMVg dazu
gesehen bis auf paar her und TP die
nicht unsere sind die wir geliest haben
wo wir Waffen nach Einrüsten damit
werden wir unser Land nicht verteidigen
gehen Sie die Themen an und stellen sie
der Bundeswehr langfristig im Haushalt
das Geld zur Verfügung D sie braucht
denn nur so werden wir auch
verteidigungsfähig werden herzlichen
Dank die Debatte über die Unterstützung
der Ukraine mit Taus March Körpern die
geht ja unvermindert weiter die Ukraine
hatte bereits ja im letzten Mai
offiziell die Bundesregierung um solche
marchkörper gebeten Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz hatte sich vorerst gegen eine
solche Lieferung entschieden gerade
heute haben sich Grüne und FDP wieder
dafür ausgesprochen den Weg frei machen
und den Druck erhöht auf den
Bundeskanzler wir stärken unsere
Sicherheit durch die Unterstützung der
Ukraine wenn wir die militärische
Unterstützung die humanitäre
Unterstützung die finanzielle
Unterstützung zusammennehmen und auch
den deutschen Anteil an den EU-Hilfen
für die Ukraine aderen kommen wir bei
einer unterstützungssumme von 38
Milliarden Euro bisher aus das ist eine
große Leistung das ist auch dann eine
große Leistung wenn wir es vergleichen
z.B mit Frankreich wenn wir bei
Frankreich alles zusammen addieren
kommen wir auf eine Summe von ca 16
Milliarden Euro 38 Milliarden und 16
Milliarden Euro das heißt ja wir
unterstützen die Ukraine stark wir
müssen sie auch weiterin unterstützen
aber unsere europäischen Partner müssen
in Zukunft auch wesentlich mehr für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine
leisten wir stärken unsere Sicherheit
auch durch Klarheit was meine ich damit
wir kommen aus Jahren wo wir drüber
diskutiert haben ob denn der Beruf des
Soldaten der Soldatin im Beruf wie jeder
andere sei die Antwort ist nein der
Beruf des Soldaten der Soldatin
erfordert dass man im Fall der Fälle
bereit ist das eigen Leben zu geben und
das Leben eines anderen Menschen zu
nehmen und wir haben jetzt wieder einen
Nachbarn in Europa der bereit ist mit
Gewalt Grenzen zu verschieben der Kriege
führt um Grenzen zu verschieben und das
heißt dass wir in Europa eine
kriegsüchtige Bundeswehr brauchen um uns
verteidigen zu können um whrhaft zu sein
und sehr geehr Herr Minister vielen Dank
dass Sie den Mut hatten dass dieses
Zeichen in die Truppe zu senden dass sie
den Mut hatten das in die Öffentlichkeit
zu tragen diese Klarheit zu schaffen
dafür vielen Dank Ihnen
und vielen Dank an unsere Soldatinnen
und Soldaten die bereit sind Tag für Tag
uns und unsere Partner zu
[Applaus]
verteidigen wir stärken unsere
Sicherheit in Zukunftsfeldern z.B im
Weltraum die der Weltraum wird immer
wichtiger was Satellitenkommunikation
betrifft was Erdbeobachtung betrifft was
Positionsbestimmung betrifft da ist
wichtig dass wir mit der
raumfahrtstrategie vorangekommen sind da
ist wichtig dass jetzt das nationale
Raumfahrtprogramm in auffuchs erfährt
wir stärken unsere Sicherheit im
cyberraum wir stärken den Cyber
Innovation habub die cyberagentur wir
haben über 20 Milliarden Euro im
Sondervermögen für Führungsfähigkeit
Kommunikationsmittel von Funkgeräten
über Datenlinks Server die die gesamte
Kette und es ist auch wichtig dass die
gesamte Kette weiterhin im
Sondervermögen ist denn wer nicht
digitalisiert wer nicht kommunizieren
kann der verliert
leider wir stärken unsere Sicherheit
doch viele viele Erfolge persönliche
Schutzausstattung ist in Rekordzeit
beschafft worden wir haben das
beschaffungsbeschleunigungsgesetz das
Handgeld für die Kommandeure ist erhöht
wer beim Stichwort Personal wer da
konkrete Anstöße braucht einfach die
Ergebnisse Task Force Personal lesen wer
konkrete Dinge zur Struktur der
Bundeswehr braucht die
verteidigungspolitischen Richtlinien
sind sehr konkret konkret ist was
angestoßen würde was die Brigade Litauen
angeht konkret ist auch dass wir in ab
diesem Jahr die 2% der NATO erfüllen
werden und auch in Zukunft und wenn sie
mir das nicht glauben jeden Juli
veröffentlicht die NATO die Zahlen und
dann wird es auch auf natopapier stehen
dass wir die 2% Quote ab diesem Jahr
erfüllen und damit unsere Verteidigung
stärken und ein Schluss Einsatz noch sch
was für ein Verantwortung übernehmen was
haben denn die folgenden Politikbereiche
gemeinsam innenwirtschaft Energie
Verteidigung Gesundheit Bildung
Landwirtschaft auf Digitalisierung zwei
Gemeinsamkeiten das sind die größten
Herausforderung diese
fortschrittskoalition übernommen hat und
das war davor alles CDU CSU geführt
Stichwort Verantwortung übernimmt wä
schön wenn von ihnen auch Vorschläge in
der Diskussion gekommen wen wir stärken
unsere Sicherheit und da machen wir auch
weiter vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit das Wort hat für Bündnis
90 die Grünen der Kollege Niklas
waggen und Niklas Wagener ist Mitglied
im Verteidigungsausschuss frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Herr
Bundesminister sehr geehrte Frau
werbeauftrachte liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Gedenkstunde heute
Vormittag aus Anlass des Gedenkens an
die Opfer des
Nationalsozialismus hat mich sehr
bedrückt und bewegt
zurückgelassen die Worte die evapeschi
und Marcel Reif an uns gerichtet haben
sind auch für diese Debatte in der wir
uns mit dem Einzelplan 14 der
Finanzierung unserer Bundeswehr
auseinandersetzen entscheidend denn wenn
dieser Tage in in ganz Deutschland
Millionen Menschen auf die Straße gehen
weil sie sich gegen Rechtsextremismus
und für unsere Freiheit für unsere
Demokratie engagieren wollen dann ist
das auch ein Rückenwind für unsere
Arbeit im Verteidigungsausschuss die
Bundeswehr personell und materiell so
auszustatten dass sie gemeinsam mit
unseren Verbündeten in EU und NATO
unsere frei
erheit und unsere Demokratie schützen
kann meine Damen und
Herren fälschlicherweise werden Polizei
Bundeswehr und andere
Sicherheitsbehörden oft unter einen
Generalverdacht des Rechtsextremismus
gestellt das ist falsch
ja es gibt Rechtsextremisten in unseren
Sicherheitsbehörden aber wir haben uns
als Koalition bereits gekümmert dass
diese nun zügiger aus eben jenen
Behörden en werden können nach nun etwas
mehr als zi Jahren im
Verteidigungsausschuss kann ich sagen
mit jedem Besuch einer Kaserne und mit
jedem Gespräch dass ich mit unseren
hochmotivierten und engagierten
Soldatinnen Soldaten führe stehe ich
umso unerschütterlicher hinter unserer
Truppe weil ich mich immer wieder selbst
davon überzeugen kann dass unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten unsere
Demokratie
verteidigen ich bin sehr
dankbar wir Abgeordnete uns in dieser
schwierigen Weltlage auf sie verlassen
können sich aufeinander verlassen zu
können kennt immer zwei Seiten nicht nur
wir müssen uns auf unsere Bundeswehr
verlassen können sondern auch unsere
Soldaten Soldaten auf uns auf uns im
Parlament auf unsere parlamentarische
Unterstützung auf einen Bundeshaushalt
der ausreichend Finanzmittel für unsere
Sicherheit zur Verfügung stellt mit
diesem Haushalt 2024 tragen wir als
Ampelkoalition unserer Verantwortung für
eine nachhaltige Sicherheits und
Verteidigungspolitik Rechnung so
investieren wir z.B in das zweite los
Puma in die Nachfolge des Tigers und
zukünftig in den schweren Waffenträger
Infanterie auch bei der
Munitionsversorgung schließen wir Lücken
mit dem Sondervermögen werden wir 2024
nun fast 3,5 Milliarden Euro für die
Beschaffung von Munition bereitstellen
nach Jahren der unterversorg
können wir auch dafür sorgen dass
zukünftig ausreichend persönliche
Ausstattung der Soldatinnen und Soldaten
mit Gefechtshelm Schutzwesten
kampfbekleidung Stiefeln und Rucksäcken
sichergestellt ist und das ist auch gut
so die
weltweit zunehmenden Konflikte können
nur in einem Zusammenspiel von zivilen
und militärischen Instrumenten gelöst
werden deshalb haben wir als Bündnis 90
die Grünen seit unserer Gründung für
einen breiten und fassenden
Sicherheitsbegriff geworben neben
militärischer Sicherheit müssen wir
Instrumente des zivilen
Krisenmanagements und des prevenentiven
Handelns
Stärken auch die
Zeitenwende auch die Zeitenwende wird
oft vor allem militärisch betrachtet das
ist richtig und ein Teil des notwendigen
Wandels der andere Teil ist aber der
zivile in unser aller Köpfe muss eine
Zeitenwende stattfinden wir müssen als
Gesellschaft mehr über Fragen von
Frieden und Sicherheit diskutieren und
wir müssen auch mehr über unseren
individuellen Beitrag für dieses hohe
gut sprechen denn im Ernstfall wird die
Bundeswehr zur abspreckung und
Verteidigung z.B an der Ostflanke der
NATO gebraucht in Deutschland müssen
dann zivile Akteure kritische
Infrastruktur schützen und auf
Cyberattacken und
Desinformationskampagnen reagieren dafür
müssen sich Bundeswehr
Sicherheitsbehörden
katastrophenschutzorganisationen und
Industrieunternehmen besser vernetzen
genau darum kümmert sich das neu
aufgestellte territoriale
Führungskommando der Bundeswehr dafür
bin ich sehr
dankbar ich persönlich bin sehr froh
dass wir demokratische Fraktion als
politische Mitte Einheit nicht nur für
das Sondervermögen gezeigt haben sondern
auch in Solidarität mit den Menschen in
der Ukraine und den Opfern des
terrorangriffs der Hamas in
Israel ich hoffe dass wir mit dieser
Einheit nun auch den
Verteidigungshaushalt 2024 beschließen
und auch für die Herausforderung in den
kommenden Jahren gemeinsame Lösung
finden herzlichen
Dank Niklas Wagner war das für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen hier zum
Einzelplan 14 Verteidigung und dieser
Einzelplan so viel kann man sagen der
wird nach dieser Debatte die so langsam
zu Ende geht hier abgestimmt werden in
zweiter Beratung so ist es üblich in den
haushaltswochen dann erst am
Freitagmittag das gesamte
Haushaltsgesetz mit allen
Einzelplänen was dann hier noch mal
verabschiedet werden
muss ja das war's sozusagen für heute
hier von dieser Stelle es ist Halbzeit
bei den Haushaltsberatungen zwei Tage
müssen die Abgeordneten hier noch
sozusagen
bewältigen morgen geht es weiter mit dem
größten et im Haushalt das ist der für
Arbeit und Soziales und zunächst aber
steht morgen Vormittag der et für
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz hier auf dem
Programm ab 8:58 ab
8:45 melden wir uns hier dann live von
dieser Stelle wieder für die heute
bedanke ich mich für Ihr Interesse
bleiben sie aber weiter bei
phöniix aktuell engagiert meinungsstark
Impulse für die europäische einigungit
für Krieg und Aufrüstung eingeplant und
das darf nicht
sein 8,6 Milliarden Euro das sage ich
Ihnen ganz deutlich Herr pistorie das
ist das Gegenteil von Nulltarif sie
sprachen in ihrer Rede von Nulltarif das
nehmen wir nicht hin meine Damen und
Herren wir als LINKE sind gegen ein
neues Wettrüsten denn an dem Wettrüsten
verdienen sich die Rüstungskonzerne dumm
und dämlich und die Ampel ist trotzdem
nicht einmal bereit wenigstens die
übergewinne zu besteuern man hat den
Eindruck die Rüstungsindustrie braucht
gar keine Lobbyisten mehr die obisten
sitzen in dieser Regierung das ist nicht
akzeptabel meine Damen und Herren ja die
Menschen wollen mehr Sicherheit und sie
gaukeln ihnen vor dass mehr Geld für die
Bundeswehr mehr Sicherheit bedeutet das
ist falsch unzählige Berichte des
Bundesrechnungshofes sie können das
alles selber nachlesen zeigen die
Bundeswehr schmeißt und zwar ohne
Konsequenzen das Geld zum Fenster heraus
ich erinnere ein Beispiel an die
Bestellung von Funkgeräten für die
bundesw mit einem Volumen von 2,9
Milliarden Euro und Nachlieferung der
Geräte wurde festgestellt die passen gar
nicht in die vorgesehenen Fahrzeuge und
ich sage ihn auch es wäre ein Albtraum
wenn dieser Minister Bundeskanzler würde
und immer weniger Menschen meine Damen
und Herren wollen sich in Kriege
schicken lassen und jetzt will Herr
Pistorius Menschen ohne deutschen Pass
zur Bundeswehr einziehen ich frage sie
wirklich kann es sein dass ein SPD
Politiker bewusst Notlagen von Menschen
ausnutzt wer arm ist und nur
eingestränkte Grundrechte hat der darf
für Deutschland in den Krieg ziehen SAS
können wir nicht akzeptieren meine Damen
und Herren und diese kriegstüchtige
Regierung hat angeblich kein Geld dafür
das Kindergeld zu erhöhen aber 85,6
Milliarden Euro für Aufrüstung ich will
dass unser Land Vorreiter in Sachen
Abrüstung Diplomatie und
Friedensinitiativen wird das wäre der
richtige Weg vielen
Dank
das Wort hat NS Gründer für die FDP
[Applaus]
Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen lieber
Herr Minister liebe Frau
werbeauftragte viel Geld löst nicht
automatisch alle unsere Probleme
aber Sicherheit und Frieden haben nun
mal ihren Preis und daher muss sich auch
jeder ganz persönlich von uns fragen was
ist Ihnen Ihre Sicherheit und ihr
Frieden eigentlich wert wenn ich mir
gerade die Rede der Linkspartei der
ehemaligen Linkspartei angucke dann
stellt man hier ganz schnell fest ihnen
ist das nichtsswerert sie haben nicht
verstanden dass nur wer in die
Bundeswehr investiert dauerhaft einen
Krieg verhindert und dauerhaft den
Frieden sichert in diesem
Land
zur Einordnung die Friedensdividende der
Vergangenheit hat die Mengel von heute
verursacht und aktuell reparieren wir
die Bundeswehr davon unser 2%
Versprechen an unsere NATO
bündnnesspartner darf da auch in Zukunft
eigentlich nur eine Untergrenze sein 10
Jahre lang hat diese Bundesrepublik
dieses Versprechen nicht eingehalten nun
tut sie das zum ersten Mal und das ist
auch richtig
so
die Gründe warum das richtig ist
lute ich ihn jetzt um junge Menschen für
die Bundeswehr zu gewinnen und natürlich
auch zu halten braucht es attraktive
Arbeits und Lebensbedingungen in der
Truppe als Arbeitgeber konkurriert die
Bundeswehr mit dem freien Markt
Attraktivität kostet Geld eine moderne
Kaserne kostet Geld sie ist aber ein
aushängesschild für unsere Bundeswehr in
Nachwuchs und Personal müssen wir also
investieren auch dafür steh ein
aufwachsender
weret es kann auch nicht sein dass die
Soldaten heute zwischen Eltern sein und
Soldat sein entscheiden müssen die
Rahmenbedingungen müssen wir schaffen
auch das hat seinen
Preis in der Sachen Ausstattung haben
wir auch noch einiges aufzuholen lange
Zeit war die Ausstattung veraltet oder
hat auch ganz gefehlt trainieren für ein
Ernstfall war nur unter Umständen
möglich während meiner letzten
truppenbesuche hat sich mein Bild aber
in einem Punkt geändert und zwar im Bild
der persönlichen Ausstattung es geht
jetzt in meinen Gesprächen mit den
Soldatinnen und Soldaten oft nicht mehr
darum dass die Spinte leer sind sondern
es geht eher darum dass man zwei Spinte
braucht um die persönliche Ausstattung
unterzubringen die persönliche
Ausstattung kommt also nach und nach
mehr bei den einzelnen Soldaten an das
Sondervermögen zeigt hier seine
Wirkung zurück zur Frage am Anfang für
mich ist klar Sicherheit und Frieden
sind für uns unbezahlbar wir haben erst
vorgelegt es darf auch erst der Anfang
sein wir haben hier als Parlament eine
Verantwortung für die Sicherheit
Deutschlands wir tragen eine
Verantwortung für unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten die schicken wir nämlich im
Ernstfall an die Front und mein Gewissen
lässt es nur zu dass wir das tun wenn
diese auch vernünftig ausgestattet sind
und ich wünsche mir eines ich wünsche
mir eines dass diese Linkspartei das
endlich mal versteht dass unsere
Soldaten im Ernstfall den Schädel
sie kommen zum Ende bitte Herr Kollege
ja ich schenke die restliche Redezeit
den
Kollegen da war nichts mehr zu
verschenkenz sagen
schuldenvererbt markusübel hat das Wort
für die CDU CSU
Fraktion frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegen
Kollegen Herr Bundesminister ich ein
Generals Zitat V tiche lasmans anders
dieser Satz von General Tiefenbach aus
Schillers Wallenstein steht im deutschen
für nicht eingehaltene Versprechungen
oder Abmachungen für täuschen und
Tricksereien vor Tische lmns anders die
Bundesregierung ist dabei die
zeitenwände gegen die Wand zu fahren
ihre Zusagen nicht einzuhalten bei der
Rede des Bundeskanzlers hier vor zwei
Jahren habe ich noch an der
entscheidenden Stelle Bravo gerufen in
entsetzte Gesichter bei SPD und Grünen
geschaut
und jetzt zwei Jahre später ruft keiner
mehr der was versteht Bravo es ist zu
wenig umgesetzt und vor allem es ist
fast nichts bei der Truppe angekommen
und auch das 2% zel dass sie sich immer
rühmen schauen Sie doch mal in die
Erläuterungen 14 Milliarden werden aus
anderen etas zusammengeglaubt das sind
Dinge die den Kremmel nicht sonderlich
beeindrucken werden und bei dem 2% Ziel
geht's doch drum dass wir gerechte
Lastenteilung innerhalb der NATO für
unsere gemeinsame Sicherheit und
Freiheit haben versprochen und nicht
eingehalten oder beim Sondervermögen
vereinbart war für große bedeutsame
Rüstungsvorhaben diese 100 Milliarden
Euro zu verwenden es wird immer mehr
vwessssert Versprechen nicht
eingehalten der Einzelplan 14 ist zu
niedrig und lauter Finanzplanung steigt
er nicht ein sondern er läuft zur Seite
wird eingefroren sie Minister haben
zurecht und wir unterstützen Sie dabei
mit voller Kraft wir wollen ihren Erfolg
10 Milliarden zusätzlich für den
laufenden Haushalt gefordert richtig gut
so aber sie haben es nicht erreicht und
inflationsbereinigt sinkt der aktuelle
Verteidigungsetat
sogar und jetzt Frau nan sie hatten vor
ein Zwischenruf ja 30 Milliarden auf
Einschlag das wäre auch für die cdoc so
ein
riesenkraftakt wo wir möglicherweise
auch Schwierigkeiten hätten darum muss
man es jetzt stufenweise ansteigen
lassen aber alle Versprechungen die ich
höre der Minister Lindner jüngst der
Verteidigungsminister der Kanzler liegen
nach der nächsten Bundestagswahl und da
tut sich die Ampel leicht mit
Versprechungen und das Versprechen eine
einsatzfähige Panzerbrigade die Brigade
42 nach litaauen zu schicken ab 25 27
Einsatzbereich wird ohne zusätzliches
Personal und Material nicht gehen die
beggade ist bisher finanziell nicht
unter legt auch diese Zusage läuft
Gefahr nicht eingehalten zu werden oder
wir müssen an der Heimat die Einheiten
entblösen wenn jetzt im März im
Eckwertebeschluss und im
Haushaltsplanentwurf im Sommer nichts
entsprechendes steht sind sie auch hier
gescheitert und wir Europäer wissen doch
wir müssen mehr für unsere Freiheit und
Sicherheit tun und können unsere
Sicherheit nicht allein an die USA
delegieren und wir alle wissen und die
abgeörnen der Ampel sagen das ja auch
immer wieder dass der Einzelplan 14
steigen muss aber bis heute ist außer
Sprechblasen nichts hart festgeschrieben
wir brauchen Verlässlichkeit und keine
Strohfeuer auch für unsere
Rüstungsindustrie und es geht nicht den
Präsident Biden oder Trump zufrieden zu
stellen es geht um unsere deutschen
Interessen um unsere nationalen
Interessen um unsere Sicherheit und
jetzt ein Blick zurück wurde ja vorher
gemacht vom Minister und von anderen
Rednern nach 20 14 ist der
verteidigungset angingestiegen nach 2022
läuft er zur Seite oder um es mal
konkret zu machen wir haben damals 100
zusätzliche
leopardpanzer bestellt was hat Minister
Pistorius gemacht 18 bestellt als Ersatz
für 18 abgegebene das ein Null
summenspiel warum nicht 100 damit die
Bundeswehr eine Vollausstattung hat dass
wir eine umlaufreserve haben für Panzer
die in Instandsetzung sind dass wir
Ersatz für beschädigte oder zerstörte
Panzer haben dass unsere Reserve Gerät
hat und wir auffuchsfähig werden dass
man die Ukraine weiter unterstützen
können nein Null summenspiel oder fünf
zusätzliche Corvetten zweites los haben
wir nach 2014 bestellt jetzt ist dritte
los ursprünglich fünf jetzt vielleicht
noch eine wer weiß statt die richtigen
Prioritäten zu setzen für unsere
Freiheit für unsere Sicherheit gibt es
nicht eingehaltene Versprechen das wird
den Kremmel nicht beeindrucken das dient
nicht einer glaubwürdigen Abschreckung
das genügt nicht für unsere Sicherheit
das ist nicht
Verteidigungsfähigkeit und das ist nicht
kriegstüchtigkeit der
Haushaltsplanentwurf genügt den großen
Herausforderung nicht und darum lehnen
wir ab ich fasse zusammen vor Tische l
ich
anders
die Fraktions gynastik hat jetzt das
Wort sehr gehte frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren sparen was das Zeug
hält ist die Devise der Bundesregierung
beim Bundeshaushalt
allerdings mit einer riesigen Ausnahme
die Militärausgaben die sind
mittlerweile auf rekordartige 90
Milliarden angestiegen und das in Zeiten
von Inflation vom selbstverschuldeten
Haushaltsloch in Zeiten von sozialen
Einschnitten und in Zeiten an denen die
Schlangen an den Tafeln immer länger
werden und mit dieser irrsinnigen
Politik wollen wir uns vom Bündnis SAR
wknecht nicht
abfinden gleichzeitig sind sie aber
altruistisch genug um Waffen in
Milliarden Höhe aus dem Bestand der
Bundeswehr zu plündern und zu
verschenken und das für einen Krieg der
seit zwei Jahren dauert und nachweislich
mit Waffenlieferungen nicht zu gewinnen
ist das haben selbst mittlerweile die
obersten Militärs der Ukraine erkannt
aber die Bundesregierung sie möchte die
Legende aufrechterhalten mehr Waffen
Brechten Frieden der
Verteidigungsminister möchte uns
währenddessen kriegstüchtig machen
während eben Millionen von Menschen
nicht wissen wie sie bis zu Monatsende
über die Runden kommen beim Essen beim
Heizen und beim Tanken laut ifo
Konjunkturprognose ist Deutschland
weiterhin schlusslich im weltweiten im
weltweiten Vergleich beim
Wirtschaftswachstum während also der
Wohlstand hier zuulande in Gefahr ist
unter anderen auch durch ihre irrsinigen
Wirtschaftssanktionen haben Sie genügend
Geld für die Militarisierung immerhin
waren sie aber ehrlich genug öffentlich
zu verlautbaren wo ihre Prioritäten
liegen nämlich als sie die
Schuldenbremse zur Bekämpfung von Armut
und Rezession nicht aussetzen wollten
aber gleichzeitig sagten für die Ukraine
würden sie es möglich machen meine Damen
und Herren wir wissen ja dass der
Kanzler zeitweise an Gedächtnislücken
leidet aber ich möchte ihn gerne daran
erinnern was an der Front diesen Hohen
Hauses steht nämlich dem deutschen Volke
und das möchte nachweislich eine an
Diplomatie ausgerichtete
Außenpolitik wirtschaftliche Sicherheit
statt abgehobener und lebensfremder
Politik das Wort hat Christop Schmid für
die SPD
Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen nach dem ersten
russischen Werbeblock von links und dem
vermeintlich folgenden russischen
Werbeblock von rechts darf ich aus der
Mitte des Hauses jetzt zu Ihnen sprechen
und versuche das auch in Gelassenheit zu
tun ich bin sehr froh dass heute niemand
das Wort Friedensdividende benutzt hat
und ich sage Ihnen auch warum weil ich
den Begriff tatsächlich semantisch für
schwierig halte denn
Frieden an sich ist ein so hohes Gut der
muss nicht noch eine Dividende abwerfen
wir alle wissen was gemeint ist wir
haben in den letzten 30 Jahren weniger
für unsere Sicherheit ausgeben müssen
als das erforderlich gewesen wäre aber
Frieden darf auch Geld kosten er muss
nicht wie eine Aktie Gewinn abwerfen
genau das zeigt dieser Haushalt wir
unterstützen die Ukraine in ihrem
heroischen Kampf gegen den russischen
Aggressor wir sind dabei es wurde schon
mehrmals erwähnt nach den USA der
zweitgrößte Geber und gehen in Europa
mit gutem Beispiel
voran ja wir erreichen das 2% Ziel ja
wir erreichen es mit Hilfe des
Sondervermögens aber sowohl der
Bundeskanzler als auch der
Verteidigungsminister vorhin haben
mehrmals betont wie wichtig der Aufwuchs
im regulären Haushalt künftig sein wird
eine nachhaltige Finanzierung uns
Sicherheit und die unsere Partner und
Verbündeten gewährleisten zu können muss
uns das wert sein und Frau Lötsch sie
würden sich wundern wie viele
Krankenhäuser wir brauchen würden wenn
wir nicht wehrhaft
wären für die
Menschen eine nachhaltige Finanzierung
ist aber auch wichtig für die Menschen
die in unseren Streitkräften ihren
Dienst leisten die mit ihrem Leib und
Leben für unsere Sicherheit einstehen
herzlichen Dank dafür dass sie das
tun
und jetzt ist der DR Brandel nicht mehr
da aber seine vermeintlichen oder
hoffentlich nur eingebildeten
Drogenerfahrungen in allen Ehren aber
das was er über Schulden gesagt hat das
ist tatsächlich ein Afro gegenüber jedem
schwäbischen Häuslebauer der sein Haus
Kredit finanziert hat manchmal komme ich
mir bei den Forderungen aus den Reihen
der Union lieber Kollege grübel ein
bisschen so vor wie vor der
Supermarktkasse in der Schlange wenn das
ungeduldige Kind sagt Papa kauf mir was
egal was hauptsache es wird etwas
gekauft so macht man keine vernünftige
Haushaltspolitik so stattet man
Streitkräfte nicht vernünftig aus man
muss sich schon am bedarfsträgeer
orientieren und das tun wir und wenn es
ein marktverfügbares und bewerrtes
Produkt wie 35 odino gibt dann kann ja
dann muss man das auch bei unseren
Verbündeten kaufen aber dieser Haushalt
bildet auch zahlreiche Mittel für
Beschaffungen bei deutschen Firmen der
WHR und Sicherheitsindustrie ab und auch
das ist wichtig nämlich dass wir uns die
Fähigkeiten in den Köpfen erhalten
können wir wissen um die notwendig um
diesfnis dass wir im Verbund mit
europäischen Partnern auch weiterhin in
der Lage sein müssen panzerhubschrauber
Flugzeuge oder Schiffe zu entwickeln und
zu fertigen auch dafür legt dieser
Haushalt die
Grundlage die Herausforderungen für die
Gesamthaushalt 2024 waren groß umso
bemerkenswerter ist es dass es gelungen
ist einen derart ambitionierten
Verteidigungshaushalt aufzustellen an
dessen Umsetzung wir jetzt gemeinsam
arbeiten werden und zum Schluss dann
doch noch nach rechts die Realität in
diesem Land ist zum Glück nicht der
YouTube-Kanal von ein espendiller oder
der AFD die real Realität in diesem Land
ist zum Glück auch nicht der mir
nachfolgende Opa von rechts sonder die
Realität in diesem Land sind die Omas
gegen Rechts egal ob in osnbrück
Oldenburg oder oberbammergau danke
schön
meine Damen und Herren ich komme noch
einmal zurück zu vorhin Herr Brandner
hat die Kollegin Nanni in die Nähe einer
terroristischen Vereinigung gestellt ich
erteile ihm dafür einen
Ordnungsruf und gebe das Wort dem
fraktionslosen Robert
fahle
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
haushaltspolitisch betrachtet sind die
100 Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen ein
schuldenfinanziertes Konjunkturprogramm
für die
usrüstungsindustrie begründet wurde dass
bei uns als Ertüchtigung der Bundeswehr
diese Ertüchtigung hat es aber nicht
gegeben erstens kauft Herr Pistorius nur
das Material nach was er zuvor an Kiev
geliefert hat damit es dort zerschossen
wird und zweitens will er zusammen mit
anderen natostaaten jetzt sogar ein
neues Luftschloss erbauen nämlich eine
eigene
Rüstungsindustrie die Ukraine ist weder
NATO noch ein sonstiger Bündnispartner
und verteidigt schon gar nicht die Werte
von Demokratie und Rechtsstaat denn
alles ist in der Ukraine abgeschalft
selenski braucht diesen Krieg immer
weiter um keine Wahlen abhalten zu
müssen und weitere Millionen Dollar an
schwarzen Verkäufen von Waffen zu
verdienen und Millionen Immobilien im
Ausland zu erwerben in London und
Mailand z.B ich frage Herrn Pistorius
wohin sind die vielen Milliarden in der
Ukraine geflossen die sie an deutschen
Steuergeldern für die Kriegsfinanzierung
bereitgestellt haben können Sie darüber
Rechenschaft legen die Bundeswehr ist
blaner als blank und sie wollen
Deutschland wieder kriegstüchtig machen
sie haben immer noch nicht verstanden 70
bis 80% der Deutschen wollen keinen
Krieg sie wollen ih auch in Zukunft
nicht und sie wollen ihren Kopf nicht
hinhalten für die geopolitischen
Interessen der USA Frieden gibt es nur
in Europa mit
Russland es hat geklappt mit den 2
Minuten diesmal
super
der Kollege Wolfgang Helm ich hat jetzt
das Wort für die SPD
Fraktion frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen wenn die Soldatinnen Soldaten
auf dieser Haushaltsdebatte über den
Einzelplan 14 schauen unsere
Bündnispartner in der NATO in der EU wie
auch unsere bnispartner in der Ukraine
dann werden sie eine Debatte sehen die
an den Enden nicht zusammenzubringen ist
der eine Teil sagt es ist alles disaster
der andere Teil sagt es ist hochgerüstet
ich würde mal sagen bleiben wir bei
einer verlässlichen Politik in der
Zeitenwende wie sie die Bundesregierung
macht weil das ist ein verlässlicher
Kurs der auch nach vorne
weist es ist der höchste Einzelplan in
der Bundesrepublik aller
Zeiten man immer wieder betonen es ist
ein Sondervermögen dass im nächsten Jahr
noch mal mit 19,1 Milliarden Euro
ausgegeben wird ich bin den
Haushaltspolitikern sehr dankbar dass
sie mit dem Thema der
Verpflichtungsermächtigung auch eine
beschaffungsverlässlichkeit bis in das
Jahr 2028 hineineschaffen haben also der
Kurs der da steht ist ein verlässlicher
der da heißt wir werden den Einzelplan
14 steigern wir werden der Bundeswehr
den soldatinen Soldaten das geben was
sie brauchen wir werden unseren Zusagen
an die Ukraine der Unterstützung wir
werden dabei bleiben sie weiter
unterstützen mit dem was wir können was
wir tun und ich bin dem Bundeskanzler
auch dankbar dass er auf der
europäischen Ebene mit dafür gesugt
hat
prgemeinde mit dafür gesorugt hat dass
die bündnisbahner ihre Bemühung steigern
die Ukraine zu
unterstützen leider leider hat heute die
EU feststellen müssen dass dass sie die
Produktion der nötigen Granaten der Atri
Munition für die Ukrainer nicht schaffen
wird und Gott sei Dank in derselben
Situation haben Deutschland Dänemark die
Niederlande andere Staaten eine
Initiative ergriffen die Munition
aufzukaufen die es auf dem Markt gibt um
damit die Ukraine zu unterstützen das
ist konkrete praktische Solidarität für
die Ukraine wie wir sie leisten können
und wie wir sie leisten
müssen wir bleiben solidarisch mit der
Ukraine wir sorgen dafür dass auch in
den langläufigen fahren die
Modernisierung der Bundeswehr
vorangetrieben wird und noch mal ein
Dank an die Haushälter an anderen
Stellen wenn es um die kleinen Details
geht wenn ein ein lzerettsuch beschaff
wird wenn die digitale Gesundheitskarte
zur konkreten praktischen Unterstützung
der Truppe eingeführt wird wenn das
Handgeld für Kommandeure erhöht wird und
wenn eendwie mit zusätzlichen
Verpflichtungsermächtigung
Investitionssicherheit auch für für die
Rüstungsindustrie geschaffen wird dann
sind wir auf dem richtigen einem
konsolidierten auf einem vernünftigen
auf einem verlässlichen Kurs und
letztendlich herzlichen Dank auch als
Mitglied in der cyberagentur dass dort
die Mittel auch hingekommen sind weil
die meisten Startups im Bereich der
cybersicherheit sind in Dresden sind in
Leipzig sind in Brandenburg sind in
Berlin sind in München sind in
badenwürtenberg und das was wir dort
dann Geld ausgeben dient an der Stelle
der Sicherheit unseres Landes indem wir
unsere Fähigkeiten St
vielen Dank dafür guter Kanzler guter
Verteidigungsminister guter 14 zu vielen
Dank ich die Aussprache zu diesem
Einzelplan und wir kommen zur Abstimmung
über Einzelplan 14 Bundesministerium der
Verteidigung und der ausschussfassung
wer stimmt dafür das sind die
koalitionsfraktion wer stimmt dagegen
das sind die
Oppositionsfraktionen und Einzel abordn
tionlos sind gibt es Enthaltungen das
sehe ich nicht dann ist der Einzelplan
angenommen und so kommen wir zum
Einzelplan Nummer 23 des
Bundesministeriums für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung mit den
Beschlussempfehlungen des
Haushaltsausschusses auf den druckschen
8661 und
8662 die Berichterstattung haben
vorgenommen die Kolleginen und Kollegen
Claudia Raffelhüschen Bettina Hagedorn
Ksten Körber Felix bannerch dr
michaelendiller und Viktor
die Aussprache soll 90 Minuten
dauern